SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
TODAY -- WE
ARE HEARING FROM THE PART OF
AGING THE CALIFORNIA SCENE A
LEGISLATURE APARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES AS A SCIENCE IS P..
AND H. S. S. --
TODAY -- WE
HAVE NO VOTES TODAY --
SO WE'RE MAINLY GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM THE FIRST
DEPARTMENTS A STAKEHOLDERS
PROPOSAL.
PROPOSALS --
BASICALLY --
SO THERE'S NO VOTE CALENDAR
WE'RE GONNA TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
AFTER EACH MAJOR SECTIONS SO --
AND THEN WHAT WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO DO IS THAT WE WERE GOING TO
START OFF WITH AN INFORMATIONAL
PANEL ON THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING I APPRECIATE THE THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP.
AND IN HIS STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS ABOUT THIS --
BUT I UNDERSTAND WE ARE MISSING
ONE OF OUR PANELISTS SO WE'RE
TRAIN IS GOING TO GIVE HER A
LITTLE MORE TIME TO SHOW UP
WHITE THAT I DO IS WHEN I TAKE
THINGS A LITTLE OUT OF ORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE OVERVIEW
OF THE PARK AGING FIRST AND SO
I'M GONNA ASK DEPARTMENT AGING
AND RESPECTIVE --
LA -- AND
FINANCE FOLKS COME UP FOR THE
OVER REVIEW AND HOPEFULLY OUR
FINAL PANELIST WILL SHOW UP --
OTHERWISE WE WILL THEN JUST HAVE.
TO KEEP MOVING AND SO A AYE SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
AND WELCOME [inaudible]
SO WELL.
SO I WOULD.
APPRECIATE.
BEING HERE AND YOU NOTING THAT --
CERTAINLY AGING IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE --
HERE AND SEE THE CALIFORNIA
WHERE --
THIS MUCH AS WE MIGHT NOT WANT A
MINUTE OUR POPULATION IS AGING
BUT THAT'S A GOOD THING THAT
MEANS WE'RE LIVING LONGER.
AND SO CERTAINLY --
FISH AT OVER YOUR MAKE NOTE THAT --
WE DO HAVE A GOOD BACKGROUND IN
SO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE AS MUCH AS HEADING
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN THE
DEPARTMENT AND MAJOR INITIATIVES
AND AND A PRIORITIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT --
FOR THIS --
COMING YEAR IN THE PAST YOURSELF
WELCOME AT THIS FIRST --
JUST INTRODUCTIONS FOR THE
RECORD SO WE HAVE THE AGENCY
INTRODUCED MEMBERS INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND HOW THEY OWN
FINANCE SO WELCOME.
SO I'LL START TIME FRIEND MILLER
I AM THE ACTING DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING.
AND I AM AT LONG I AM THE ACTING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE LONG
TERM CARE AND AGING SERVICES
DIVISION THE PROGRAM SIDE OF OUR
DEPARTMENT.
GOOD MORNING I'M JOE RODRIGUEZ
ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
THANK YOU LA YOU.
PRESS HERE WITH THE LA NOW.
GINNY BELLOW WITH THE LA L. YOU
FINANCE WHISPERS WROTE APARTMENT
A FINANCE.
JACOB POOR ALSO WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THANK YOU RIGHT WHEN
WE GO HEAD BEGIN WITH THE SONOMA
WHICH IS THE OVERVIEW THANK YOU
THANK YOU --
SEPARATELY THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON SOME OF THE MAJOR SUCCESSES
AND CHALLENGES.
IN IMPLEMENTING CDA PROGRAMS.
BRIEF BACKGROUND CDA IS THE
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED STATE UNIT
ON AGING AND ADMINISTERS
PROGRAMS SERVING OLDER ADULTS.
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES FAMILY
CARE GIVERS AND RESIDENTS TO
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS
FUNDING ALLOCATED UNDER THE
FEDERAL OLDER AMERICANS ACT THE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT AND
THROUGH THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT CONTRACTS WITH
THE NETWORK OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING KNOWN AS TRIPLE A.'S.
THAT DIRECTLY MANAGE A WIDE
ARRAY OF FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDED SERVICES TO HELP OLDER
ADULTS FIND EMPLOYMENT.
SUPPORT OLDER AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS TO LIVE AS
INDEPENDENTLY AS POSSIBLE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
PROMOTE HEALTHY AGING AND
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT AND ASSIST
FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN THEIR
VITAL KERR GIVING ROLE.
CITY ALSO CONTRACTS WITH THIRTY
EIGHT LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
OPERATE THE MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE MEDI CAL HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED WAIVER FOR THE
ELDERLY.
AND CITY ALSO CERTIFIES
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
PROVIDERS FOR THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE AND
THANK THE TRIPLE A NETWORK AND
THE MANY LOCAL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP IN
ADMINISTERING THESE PROGRAMS
THESE ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE THE
ON THE GROUND DIRECT SERVICES TO
OUR PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
WE COULD NOT DO THIS IMPORTANT
WORK WITHOUT THEM.
SO AS REQUESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENTS RECENT SUCCESSES.
IN MAY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CITY RECEIVED AN INCREASE OF
SEVENTEEN MILLION AND FEDERAL
TITLE THREE GRANT FUNDING.
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON
COMMUNITY LIVING.
THIS INCREASE WAS DUE TO THE
BIPARTISAN BUDGET ACT AGREEMENT
AND RESULTED IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
DISTRIBUTED TO TRIPLE A.'S TO
SUPPORT CONGREGATE NUTRITION
HOME DELIVERED MEALS SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES HEALTH PROMOTION CARE
GIVER SUPPORT.
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN AND
THEN YOU TO PROGRAM.
CDS OFFICE OF THE STATE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN WORKED WITH
THE NATIONAL CONSUMER VOICE FOR
QUALITY LONG TERM CARE TO APPLY
FOR A TWO YEAR EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR FEDERAL GRANT.
THIS FUNDING WOULD PROVIDE
TRAINING TO NURSING HOME STAFF
AN OMBUDSMAN REPRESENTATIVES ON
PERSON CENTERED CARE AND
STRATEGIES TO AVOID THE
INAPPROPRIATE DISCHARGE OF
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS.
THE APPLICATIONS PENDING WITH
CMS AND WE HOPE TO HEAR BACK
SOON.
IN COLLABORATION WITH CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL ALZHEIMER'S
ORGANIZATIONS CITY A HAS APPLIED
FOR A THREE YEAR SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR FEDERAL
DEMONSTRATION GRANT.
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE USED TO
REPLICATE AND EXPAND TO MENTION
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP PLAN CARE
MANAGERS SO THEY CAN BETTER
IDENTIFY AND SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEMENTIA AND THEIR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES CDA HAS EXPANDED
CALPERS OUT REACH TO OLDER
ADULTS VIA FEDERAL SUPPLEMENTAL
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
EDUCATION FUNDING ON A FLAT BED.
WITH THE GOAL OF HELPING OLDER
ADULTS MAKE HEALTHIER FOOD
CHOICES.
AND TO INCREASE THEIR PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN PARTICIPATING TRIPLE
A.'S AND THEIR SUBCONTRACTORS
SERVED OVER FIVE THOUSAND OLDER
ADULTS.
IN ADDITION APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS
RECEIVED NUTRITION EDUCATION
THROUGH PUBLISHED MATERIALS AND
WEBSITE MESSAGING AT SITES WERE
SNAP AT ACTIVITIES ARE DELIVERED.
UNDER THE NEW COMMUNITY BASED
ADULT SERVICES PROGRAM THERE ARE
NOW 200-51 C. BASS PROVIDERS AND
OVER THIRTY SIX THOUSAND SEA
BASS PARTICIPANTS.
THESE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO GROW
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THIRTEEN YOU SEE BASS PROVIDERS
HAVE BEEN CERTIFIED.
AS OF JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CDA HAS RESPONDED TO
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION
REGARDING.
OPENING NEW SEA BASS CENTERS.
IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
CDA DESIGNATD AN ADDITIONAL
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTION. TO SIR PLASTER
COUNTY EXPANDING SERVICES IN
THAT AREA THERE ARE NOW EIGHT
DESIGNATED. EIGHTY OUR SEASON
THE STATE.
CDA CONTINUES TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND OUR TRIPLE A PARTNERS TO
IMPLEMENT THE REVERSAL AT THE SS
I CASH OUT POLICY.
THESE EFFORTS WILL ASSIST NEWLY
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS AGE SIXTY
PLUS WITH APPLYING FOR CALPERS
BENEFITS THEY'RE BY SUPPORTING
IMPROVED NUTRITION FOR OLDER
ADULTS.
IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CITY IS OFFICE OF THESTATE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN RELEASED A
NEW CURRICULUM CHAPTER. FOR
LOCAL OMBUDSMAN CERTIFICATION
TRAINING THIS CHAPTER DISCUSSES
ISSUES ENCOUNTERED BY L. G. B.
T. OLDER PERSONS AND PROVIDES
INFORMATION TO ENABLE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN.
REPRESENTATIVES TO PROVIDE
COMPETENT AND SENSITIVE SERVICES
TO LGBT INDIVIDUALS.
NEXT MONTH WE WILL PUBLISH AN
UPDATE AIR.
THE LAST VERSION WAS PUBLISHED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN SO THIS IS
A WELCOME UPDATE.
WE WILL ALSO BE UPDATING THE
HEALTH INSURANCE COUNSELING AN
ADVOCACY PROGRAM CANCER HANDBOOK
TO INCLUDE THE MOST RECENT
MEDICARE INFORMATION.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT RESOURCES
FOR CONSUMER EDUCATION.
LAST ACCOMPLISHED MAN I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT IS AN ON GOING ONE
CDA CONTINUES TO PARTNER WITH
THE LOCAL TRIPLE A.'S AND THEIR
ASSOCIATION ON VARIOUS
INITIATIVES AND PROGRAMS VIA
WORKGROUPS MEETINGS AND ENHANCE
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS.
THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR US AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE OUR
COLLABORATION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO SUPPORT THE
TRIPLE A IS AN IMPORTANT WORK.
MOVING ON TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES --
FIRST LIMITED DATA TO INFORM
PROGRAM DELIVERY AND TO
DETERMINE NEEDS AND GAPS IN
SERVICES.
THIS IS A BROADER ISSUE
AFFECTING MANY AGENCIES THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO OLDER ADULTS.
AND ADDRESSING IT WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT OMPONENT OF A
COORDINATED PLAN FOR AGING
SERVICES --
ANOTHER CHALLENGES
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR PROGRAMS
THIS CONTRIBUTES TO WORKLOAD
CHALLENGES FOR BOTH THE STATE
AND OUR LOCAL PARTNERS.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE FIND
INNOVATIVE AND STREAMLINE
METHODS TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE SO
WE CAN MORE EFFECTIVELY DELIVER
OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS.
THE FOCUS SHOULD BE ON A FISSION
SERVICE DELIVERY RATHER THAN
BURDENSOME ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES.
RECRUITING AND RETAINING
VOLUNTEER WORKERS AND CITIES
STATE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IS AN ONGOING CHALLENGE
THIS IS PRIMARILY DUE TO THE
SPECIAL SKILLS NEEDED TO BE ABLE
TO CONFRONT.
ABUSE NEGLECT AND EXPLOITATION.
WE LOOK TO CONTINUE TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM AND ENSURING ADEQUATE
SUPPLY OF VOLUNTEERS.
THE LAST CHALLENGE IS TO REPORT
IDENTIFYING.
A MORE EFFECTIVE WAYS TO UTILIZE
THE INFORMATION WE GET FROM CDS
MONITORING OF TRIPLE A.'S WE
NEED TO USE THIS INFORMATION AS
WELL AS FEEDBACK FROM THE TRIP
LAYS TO DEVELOP BETTER TRAINING.
MORE HELPFUL TOOLS AND RESOURCES
THIS SUPPORT OUR PARTNERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
PROGRAM MONITORING IS REQUIRED
ACTIVITY AND IS CURRENTLY VERY
TIME CONSUMING FOR BOTH STATE
AND LOCAL STAFF WE NEED TO FIND
WAYS TO MAKE IT MORE STREAMLINED
TO REDUCE WORKLOAD TIME.
AND COST WE VIEW THESE
CHALLENGES AS OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS IN A
THOUGHTFUL AND INNOVATIVE MANNER.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO
IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS. FOR RIGHT
NOW FOR IMMEDIATE FOCUS IS TO
FILL CRITICAL.
TO POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF OUR
INTERNAL OPERATIONS.
AND MAXIMIZE OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR VITAL
NETWORK OF TRIPLE A.'S LOCAL
PARTNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS. TO
IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF HOW
CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE
ADMINISTERED AND TO BETTER MEET
BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF THOSE
WE SERVE.
OUR SHARED GOAL IS TO DELIVER
SERVICES AND CREATE ENVIRONMENTS
THAT SUPPORT HEALTHY AGING. FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU US ME TO SEE RIGHT
HELLO HOW MUCH [inaudible]
FINANCE.
RIGHT QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO -- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT A REVIEW OF
YOUR AGENCY AND THE THE THE
CHALLENGES AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND CERTAINLY THIS IS AN AGENCY
DOES A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT --
YOU'RE HEAVILY DEPEND ON FEDERAL
FUNDING --
RIGHT SO --
THE GENERAL FUND ABOUT --
BEING PROPOSED ABOUT THIRTY
EIGHT THIRTY SIX I'VE ROUNDED UP
A LITTLE BUT THERE SIX POINT --
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS BUT US A
NOTE THAT --
IN -- WE'RE
EXPECTING A PROXIMALLY --
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR --
DROPPED IN FEDERAL FUNDING --
BETWEEN BLAST FISCAL YEAR AND
THIS FISCAL YEAR CAN YOU SPEAK
TO WHAT WHAT THE REASON FOR THAT
TO BE HAS OUR GRAND ENDING OR
WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A DECREASE
IN FUNDING IT'S THE DISPLAY AND
HOW SOME OF THOSE FEDERAL GRANTS
ARE RECEIVED HOW THEY COME.
IN THROUGH THE BACK TO THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE NORMALLY BRING
THOSE INTEREST SECTION TWENTY
EIGHT OKAY AND THEN THERE ARE
SOME OTHER ADJUSTMENTS WITH SOME
CARRY OVER WE CAN PROVIDE A VERY
SPECIFIC WAY OKAY.
I JUST MIGHT CLARIFY THAT NOT A
SO THAT OVERALL DROP IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS EITHER
UNEXPECTED OR SOMETHING THAT --
JUST SO LIKE A X. SOME CHRIS
SEQUESTRATION A BROAD CROSS THE
BOARD CUTS A AT THE CORRECT IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE WAY WERE
REPORTING GRANT FUNDING OKAY.
ALL RIGHT BECAUSE THAT IS A GOOD
CHUNK OF MONEY SO I'M JUST
LOOKING AT THAT.
POINT AND TO TO MAKE NOTE OF
THAT OKAY.
AND YOU MADE REFERENCE TO BUT IT
I MEAN ARE YOU HAVING SOME ANY
ARE YOU HAVING CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF FILLING YOUR STAFF
POSITIONS AT THE AGENCY WE'VE
JUST HAD SOME ATTRITION THERE
IT'S A HOLLER AGENCY --
FOCUSED ON FILLING THOSE SO OKAY
BUT IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO RECRUIT --
PEOPLE FOR THE POSITIONS YOU'RE
YOU'RE CONFIDENT THAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO FILL THE DEVELOP VERY
PASSIONATE THE WORK THE DESK MAN
WE ARE VERY VERY FORTUNATE WE
HAVE A VERY TALENTED TEAM YES.
WE HAVE VERY TALENTED PASSIONATE
STATE WORKERS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO PAY THEM ENOUGH THAT THEIR
COMPETITIVE SO I WANT TO BE SURE
THAT -- WE
ARE WE ARE ABLE TO RECRUIT THE
THE THE THE THE PEOPLE WE NEEDS
TO DO THE WORK FOR THE PEOPLE
THE STATE SO I I APPRECIATE
PASSION THAT'S ALWAYS GOOD BUT
PEOPLE STILL NEED TO EAT WHEN I
GET HOME FEED A FAMILY SO.
I WANNA BE SURE THAT WERE.
AT THE RIGHT PLACE THERE OKAY.
ARE.
EIGHT NOT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH --
FOR THAT OVERVIEW --
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WHAT WE'LL DO
IS IS THAT I THINK CAN ASSUME
THE OTHER PANELS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA DO
THIS WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON MAYBE WE'LL DO SO I DO ALL
THE SEX AND SO THEY HAVE TO
ITEMS AND THEN WE'LL BRING THAT
PANEL UP I'M JUST TRYING.
TO BE SURE WE COULD CERTAINLY
WANT TO HEAR FROM THE ABOUT THE
MASTER PLAN OKAY SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND THEN MOVE ON WE
HAVE ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
THE B. C. P. --
FOR THE SEA BASS ADDITIONAL
STAFFING FOR MANDY COMPLIANCE --
SO GO AHEAD PRESENT THAT THAN
HER OWN I'LL GO AHEAD AND
ADDRESS THIS AGAIN THIS IS AT
LONG.
YEAH SO RPV PCP REQUEST IS FOR
THE COMMUNITY BASED ADULT
SERVICES PROGRAM WE'RE
REQUESTING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH
WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT. THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND.
AND THREE ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAM ANALYSTS AND ONE NURSE
EVALUATOR POSITION.
THIS REQUEST IS A WORKLOAD PCP
SEA BASS PROVIDERS RE
CERTIFICATION IS OCCURRING
WITHIN THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED
TIME FRAMES.
PROVIDERS ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
NEW FEDERAL HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SETTINGS RULE AND
PROVIDING THEM PROVIDER
SCREENING REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE NEW PROVIDER
APPLICATIONS ARE BEING PROCESSED
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AS OF MARCH --
TWENTY NINETEEN THERE ARE NOW
HOURS TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
C. ABOUT CENTERS AS OPPOSED TO
THE TWO FIFTY THAT WERE
MENTIONED IN THE PC P..
AND OVER THIRTY SIX THOUSAND SEA
BASS PARTICIPANTS.
OF THE NUMBER OF CENTERS IN
PARTISAN PENANCE CONTINUES TO
GROW STEADILY.
AS OF JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN WE
HAD RESPONDED TO THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR REQUESTS FROM
INTERESTED PARTIES.
ABOUT OPENING A NEW CENTER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO OF THOSE
ENTITIES HAD SUBMITTED THE
REQUIRED PROGRAM PLANS.
AND FORTY TWO HAD SUBMITTED
THEIR FORMAL SEA BASS
APPLICATION ON OUR STAGES IN THE
APPROVAL PROCESS.
SO THAT'S A BASIC OVERVIEW OF
THAT PCP OKAY.
THANK YOU LA --
COMMENTS.
THE REVIEW TO BE SPIN REYES NO
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
NOTHING THAT HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU --
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT --
RIGHT NOW I CAN THINK NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON ON THAT ITEM --
SO WE HAVE HIM HERE.
SO WE HAVE THREE OUT PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS --
SPY PART THE WATERS HERE SOUL
SHIFT AROUND AND THEN --
WILL TAKE EACH ONE IN TURN AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THOSE
PRESENTATIONS WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON PART OF AGING.
OKAY FIVE OKAY SCAN SHIFT OVER
THERE.
ALL RIGHT SO FOR THE FIRST THE
PROPOSAL AND FOR INVESTMENT IS --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
AND COME UP --
AND IF.
GIVE YOU. THREE MINUTES BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE ALL THREE YOU
DON'T WISH.
AND THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
ONLY WITHOUT COLLECT.
I DO WANT TO NOT PART OF MY TIME
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
CLARIFICATION ABOUT WITH CDA WAS
TALKING ABOUT WITH THAT
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLAR.
INCREASE IN FEDERAL FUNDS THE
SUPPORT OF SERVICES.
OF THAT SEVENTEEN MILLION THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM YES WERE PART
OF IT BUT WE'RE GETTING A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
ON MONDAY THE WHITE HOUSE MAY
THEIR PROPOSAL FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR BUDGET.
WHICH HAS INCLUDES A ONE MILLION
DOLLAR CUT TO THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM WHICH TO TRANSLATE TO
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
LOSS TO CALIFORNIA.
SO I JUST WANTED TO BE CLEAR
THAT THE SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WHILE WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT IT IT DOES NOT MOVE THE
NEEDLE AND REALLYSHOULDN'T.
I HOPE WILL IMPACT THIS BUDGET
REQUEST.
HI I TOOK IT IS INTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
VERY CLEVER SNEAKING THAT IT.
FOR CLARIFICATION I GOT IT I GOT
IT.
SO BOB.
I HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE LEASE A
COMMON CHALCO I HAVE TESTIFIED
BEFORE I'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW I
DON'T BELIEVE WE NEED TO READ IT
WE DON'T FACILITY VISITS USING
PAID STAFF AND HIGHLY TRAINED
VOLUNTEERS.
THIS BUYS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND ADDITIONAL HOURS
OF OMBUDSMAN EYES AND EARS AND
CARE FACILITIES.
IT BUYS THE STATE EIGHT THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION IT ALLOWS THE
LOCAL PROGRAMS TO USE HIRED
STAFF AS OPPOSED. TO RELYING SO
HEAVILY ON VOLUNTEERS TO DO
ELDER ABUSE INVESTIGATIONS OF
OUR DATA SHOWS THAT LAST YEAR.
ONE IN EVERY FOUR COMPLAINTS
INVESTIGATED FELL UNDER THE
CATEGORY OF ELDER ABUSE.
ACROSS THE STATE WE ARE SO
COMPLAINT DRIVEN NOW WE'RE JUST
NOT GETTING INTO FACILITIES ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
IN IN THE LOS ANGELES PROGRAM
THEY WERE FIVE COMPLETE SHORT OF
HITTING.
ELEVEN THOUSAND COMPLETED
INVESTIGATIONS LAST YEAR.
AND YET ONLY 60% OF ALL THEIR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
ONLY 7% OF THEIR ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES RECEIVED A QUARTERLY
VISITS.
SO WHAT DOES IT MEAN WHEN AN
OMBUDSMAN IS NOT IN THE
FACILITIES ON THE RIGHT ON A
REGULAR BASIS SO I WANT TO
INTRODUCE YOU. TO A REAL LIVE
NINJA WHO ALSO GOES BY THE TITLE
OF LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN --
MICHELLE PLEASE GIVE AND PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF THANK YOU I'M
CHAPARRAL A PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
THE WISE AND HEALTHY AGING LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
SERVING THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES.
MONITORING VISITS ARE CRITICAL
TO FOR FILLING OUR PROMISE TO
PROVIDE SAFE AND QUALITY LONG
TERM CARE SERVICES.
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR OWNER OF
SOME THREE SMALL ASSISTED
LIVINGS WAS ARRESTED ON FELONY
ELDER ABUSE CHARGES.
AFTER ONE OF HIS RESIDENCE A
NINETY ONE YEAR.
MATT DEMENTIA WAS FOUND IN THE
MORNING BY HER CARE GIVER TO
HAVE BEEN BITTEN BY A RAT ON HER
HAND.
THE INJURY WAS SO SEVERE THAT IT
EXPOSED BONE.
WHEN THE CARE GIVER LIFTED THE
BLANKET I ROUTE WAS SEEN JUMPING
FROM THE RESIDENTS BODY BROUGHT
DROPPINGS WERE AROUND HER?
AND THEN WHEN THEY WENT TO
REMOVE THE SOFT --
THAT PROTECTED HER FIGHT ANOTHER
ROUTE WAS SEEN JUMPING FROM THE
RESIDENT AND SHE HAD SUSTAINED
ADDITIONAL BITES TO THE ARCH OF
HER HE'LL.
CARE GIVERS ALLEGE THAT THEY
TOLD THE OWNER IN THE
ADMINISTRATOR REPEATEDLY BEFORE
THIS INCIDENT HAPPENED NOTHING
WAS DONE.
AND THE RESIDENT DIED SHORTLY
AFTER THIS INCIDENT.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE OMBUDSMEN
ONCE THIS FACILITY ONCE.
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE WENT.
NOTE WE DIDN'T VISIT AT ALL.
pVISITED AFTER THIS HORRENDOUS
INCIDENT WAS INFORMED TO LESS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
MAINTAIN AN ONGOING PRESENCE IN
THE FACILITIES IN THE WAY THAT
WE NEED.
TO AND ALSO MANAGE ARE
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX AND
BURGEONING CASELOADS WITH
REGULAR UNANNOUNCED VISITS WE
COULD OF OBSERVE THIS OR AT
LEAST BEEN TOLD CONFIDENTIALLY
BY THE STAFF WHO WORKED THERE.
THE RESIDENT WAS RELYING ON CARE
GIVERS FOR ALL OF OUR CARE NEEDS
ON THE OWNER TO PROVIDE A SAFE
LIVING ENVIRONMENT ON THE ON THE
ON BAZMAN. TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THEM IF WE'RE ABLE TO AND WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO UPHOLD THAT WE
ALL FAILED HER WE ASK FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER THIS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING THIS WITH US --
ANY -- COMES
FROM THE AGENCY THAT'S PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU --
LA OPENING COMMENTS FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALRIGHT SO
APPRECIATE YOU PRESENTING THIS I
THINK YOU KNOWN THAT --
SINCE I'VE BEEN CHAIR WE'VE
WAITED TO ONLY WORK TO TRY TO
GET MORE RESOURCES FOR THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN OFFICE AND
KNOWS WHAT BY THE WORK YOU DO
AND SO -- SO --
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD AND OF COURSE WE WILL BE
CONSIDERING AS THE BUDGET
PROCESS MS FORD SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT LATER ON THIS PROPOSAL
THE OTHER ITEMS THANK YOU.
THE FRENCH.
OKAY NEXT UP IS --
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE ADJUSTMENT FOR
MS US S. P. M. S. S. P. SITES
FROM THE M. S. S. P. SITE
ASSOCIATION --
IT'S COME UP INTRODUCED HERSELF.
THEN AGAIN THE MORNING I'M JANET
HEATH AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE MS HAS DECIDED
SO SHE'S [inaudible]
PLEASE BEGIN.
I SEE NEW.
TO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE THIRTY
EIGHT MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A ONE TIME ONLY
SUPPLEMENTAL INCREASE OF TWENTY
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUNDS. TO BE
DISTRIBUTED OVER THREE YEARS.
AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR POPULATION IS
GROWING RAPIDLY.
AND ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS AGE SIXTY
FIVE OR OLDER.
IS EXPECTED TO INCREASE BY MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION PEOPLE OR
ABOUT 24% OF CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL
POPULATION.
BY.
TWENTY THIRTY OF THOSE ONE
MILLION WILL HAVE LIMITATIONS
WITH SELF CARE OR ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING.
WHICH IS AN 88% INCREASE OVER
THE TWENTY TWELVE POPULATION
LEVELS.
THE MAJORITY THESE OLDER PEOPLE
WILL NOT BE LIVING IN NURSING
HOMES ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S REPORT
OF TWENTY SIXTEEN REPORT ON
DISABILITY AMONG SENIORS
PREDICTS THAT OLDER CALIFORNIA'S
TURNING SIXTY FIVE BETWEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WELL LIVE AN AVERAGE OF
TWENTY THREE POINT SIX YEARS
MORE.
A LOT OF THESE YEARS SO
EXPERIENCE FOUR AND A HALF YEARS
OF DISABILITY.
SO HERE'S HOW IN MISSISSIPPI CAN
HELP.
MS IS P. PROVIDES AND COORDINATE
SERVICES FOR SENIORS.
ON MEDICARE AL WHO HAVE PHYSICAL
AND COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS WHO
LIVE AT HOME.
MRS P. PREVENTS AND DELAYS
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT BY USING
COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS I A TO
ASSESS PARA TRANSIT.
MEALS ON WHEELS AN ADULT DAYCARE.
THE PROFESSIONAL STAFF CONSIST
OF REGISTERED NURSES AND SOCIAL
WORKERS TO EVALUATE THE%
BENEFICIARY'S NEEDS AND HELP
THEM ACCESS A NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY BASED RESOURCE.
THIS IS A REMINDER EMESIS P. HAS
NOT RECEIVED A BUDGET INCREASE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX HAND
DURING THE SAME PERIOD THE
CALIFORNIA PLACE RATE HAS BEEN
23%.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL INCREASE IN
FUNDING THAT EMBASSY IS
REQUESTING MUST BE SPREAD OVER
THREE YEARS.
YOUR ONE FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
INCREASE THE CURRENT RATE FROM
400-020-0852.
FIVE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX DOLLARS PER PERSON PER
YEAR.
WHICH WILL ENABLE SIZE TO
REBUILD AND STABILIZE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE NOT SEEN A
RATE INCREASE IN THIRTEEN YEARS.
IN YEARS TWO AND THREE WE WILL
BE ABLE TO RESTORE THE NUMBER OF
CLIENT SLOTS TO THE MAXIMUM
SLOTS ALLOTTED BY THE WAIVER.
WHICH WILL SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
THE WAIT TIME FOR THOSE
CURRENTLY IN NEED OF SERVICES.
I JUST WANNA CLOSE BY REMINDING
YOU THAT THE COST OF NURSING
HOME CARE IS EXPENSIVE.
A RECENT GENWORTH STUDY FINDS
THAT THE ANNUAL MEDIAN COST FOR
A SEMI PRIVATE ROOM IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOW OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WITH THIS PROPOSED INCREASE
MISSISSIPPI WILL REMAIN A
BARGAIN AT FIVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX DOLLARS PER
PERSON PER YEAR.
IN MISSISSIPPI IS AN ESTABLISHED
MODEL THAT HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR
FORTY YEARS SUCCESSFULLY AND
COST EFFECTIVELY.
MANAGING CARE AND PERSON
CENTERED WAY WITH A FRAIL
FRAGILE AND SOMETIMES OVERLOOK
POPULATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH ANY
COMMENTS FROM --
THE PART OF AGING [inaudible]
OKAY.
SIR HUMPHREY SHEET THAT ARE.
THE LA OPENING COMMENTS FINANCE
ANY COMMENTS OKAY QUESTIONS ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
SO THAT YOU MENTION THAT --
THIS INCREASE WITH THAT ALLOW
YOU TO HAVE THE MAXIMUM NUMBER
OF SLOTS ALLOWED BY THE WAIVER
WHAT HUMM HOW MANY SLOTS IS THAT.
SO WE'RE ALLOWED TO HAVE A NEW
DIVISIONAL TWO THOUSAND FOUR
NINETY SEVEN SLOTS THAT WE HAVE
NOT HAD FUNDED.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS OR IS IT
OUT WITHOUT AN ADDITIONAL TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN ADVICE AND HOW MANY SLOTS
YOU HAVE NOW.
WE ARE CURRENTLY AT ABOUT AND
900-021-1000 SO YOU DID OKAY SO
THEREFORE YOU CAN GET UP TO
ELEVEN THOUSAND OKAY RIGHT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
IT'S VERY HELPFUL AND THIS IS
THE YOU'RE LOOKING AT BASICALLY
THIS IS OVER THREE YEARS OVER
THREE ONE TIME OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY.
QUESTIONS IT'S ENOUGH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR PROPOSAL
OKAY.
FINALLY WE HAVE --
BUT REQUEST FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AREA AGENT.
AGENCIES ON AGING AND MEALS ON
WHEELS --
FOR FOR THE INCREASE FUNDING FOR
SENIOR CHRISTIAN PROGRAMS SO.
THE PRESENTER CAN COME UP OUR
PRESENTERS --
GOOD MORNING.
AND IF YOU CAN JUST.
HAVE WE CAN [inaudible]
SO. THREE MINUTES BETWEEN THE
TWO OF YOU SO FIGURE HOW YOU
ALLOCATE YOUR TIME [inaudible]
MORNING.
ALL I'M DOING --
RIGHT HELLO THE GENTLEMAN GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID MARK
OUR IS IS IS A GENTLEMAN YOU'D
BE SPEAKING AS WELL.
YES SAYS OKAY LET'S LET THEM.
I LOVE ALL INTRODUCED HIM AS HE
COMES FORWARD.
OKAY WELL TO AND GET UP TO THE
TABLE FIRST BEFORE WE BEGIN
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
TOMORROW.
SOME KIND OF THE MICROPHONE OVER.
OKAY THANK YOU BUT NO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DAVID MORE CAL WITH
MEALS ON WHEELS BY ACC IN
SACRAMENTO ALSO CHAIR OF THIS
CALIFORNIA C. NUTRITION NETWORK
AND A MEMBER OF THE MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
I HAD WITH ME CHORUS TOUCH.
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SEVEN
POINT EIGHT I ORDERED THOSE
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF
THE FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND OLDER
ADULTS CREW CURRENTLY RECEIVE ON
THE RIVER MEALS.
GOOD MORNING TO THE PANEL THANK
YOU TO THE GUEST THANK YOU
[inaudible]
PHONE.
MEALS ON WHEELS IS IS.
THE QUICKEST WAY I CAN SAY THIS
LIKE SERVICE WITH A SMILE.
OKAY I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO HAVE BEEN A PARTICIPANT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AND DO
THE SOME SURGERY --
WHEN?
THEY CALLED ME THEY HAVE LIMITED
MOBILITY --
MEALS ON WHEELS ENABLED ME. TO
TO TO STAY IN MY HOME
[inaudible] TO A ALLOW ME WELL
BALANCED MEALS.
THINGS THAT I WOULD NOT HAVE FIX
FOR MYSELF --
THE VOLUNTEER COMBS AND HERE
GOES TO HOW I MAY HAVE FILLED
THAT DAY BEFORE THEY GOT THERE.
THEY GIVE ME A REASON TO SMILE.
OKAY THEY ARE ALWAYS FRIENDLY
THEY'RE ALWAYS COURTEOUS.
PHONE ALSO I GET TO A PHONE CALL
DURING THE WEEK FROM OE OF THE
VOLUNTEERS THE SAYS HEY HOW ARE
YOU THIS MORNING.
YOU KNOW HOW'S YOUR DAY BEEN.
DOES ANYTHING HAPPEN TO YOU
DURING THE WEEK THAT YOU KNOW I
SHOULD BE AWARE OF OR ANYTHING
THAT I CAN PERSONALLY DO OR OR
SOMEONE THAT I CAN CONTACT.
TO THE HEAD OFFER YOU A ANOTHER
SERVICE [inaudible]
I MEAN.
IT'S HARD TO DESCRIBE WHAT A
FRIEND MEANS TO YOU.
AND MEALS ON WHEELS HAS BEEN
MORE THAN JUST A FRIEND
[inaudible]
THEY'VE BEEN.
WELL A LIFESAVER BECAUSE THERE
WAS A TIME THAT I WAS KINDA
DESPONDENT.
AND THEY HELPED ME THROUGH
SEVERAL CRISIS IS SO THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU HAVE DONE.
AND EVEN A BIGGER THANK YOU FOR
WHAT I HOPE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THANK YOU.
I'M DELIVER MEALS AND ARE
CONGREGATE MEAL PROGRAM.
ON THE RIVER MEALS AND
CONGREGATE MEALS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WORK.
THEY MAKE A DAILY IMPACT IN THE
FIGHTING A POOR NUTRITION HUNGER
LONELINESS AND ISOLATION.
OUR REQUEST IS TO PROVIDE
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION TO
HELP PROVIDE ONE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND MEALS --
TO TWELVE THOUSAND NEW CLIENTS
WITHOUT THIS MONEY MEALS ON
WHEELS ORGANIZATIONS.
MAY NEED TO SERVE TEN THOUSAND
LESS MEALS TO OFFSET PERSON NOW
FOOD AND PROGRAM RISING COSTS.
TIMES ARE GETTING EVEN TOUGHER
AS WE TRY TO SERVE THE GROWING
NUMBER OF OLDER ADULTS.
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE AND NOT
LESS DON'T JUST STAND BY A
SUPPORT OUR QUICK SUPPORTER
REQUESTS AS WEAK AS A STATE
BUILD STRONGER NETWORKS IN LONG
TERM CARE AND SUPPORT SERVICES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
A GOOD DAVID EVANS LEARNING HERE
SO YOU KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE
WE CAN'T HAVE --
WE CALL OPEN DEMONSTRATIONS LIKE
CLAPPING AND SHOUTING BUT YOU
CAN DO THIS.
SO THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S A ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT --
COMES FROM THE EIGHT IT INTO THE
AGING.
OKAY EXCELLENT LA --
ANY COMMENTS FINANCE ALL RIGHT
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NOW.
OKAY NO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ABLE TO VISIT
I KNOW THAT IT'S NOT JUST THE
MEALS ALL THE MEALS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT IT'S ALSO THAT.
SOCIAL CONTACT THAT MEALS ON
WHEELS --
PROVIDES AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATE TO ANSWER YOUR
TESTIMONY.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE WILL WE
WILL -- LOW
CONSIDERED AS WE MOVE FOR AND
AND THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT.
OKAY SO I THINK THAT --
CONCLUDES A PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS SO WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE AGING
OVERVIEW THE ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR NATIONAL STAFFING --
REGARDING SEA BASS COMPLIANCE
AND THEN OF COURSE ARE THREE
PROPOSALS OR INVESTMENT.
I WILL ASK THAT --
YOU TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
A MINUTE --
AND AND OF COURSE YOU CAN FREE
TO PROVIDE ANY WRITTEN MATERIAL --
TO OUR STAFF AS WELL IF YOU HAVE
MORE EXTENSIVE MATURE YOU WISH
TO PROVIDE US --
AND IF SOMEONE ELSE IS RAY SAID
WHAT YOU WANT TO SAY ME --
TOO WORKS JUST AS WELL FOR THE
RECORD SO I WILL GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN -- SO
WE'LL START THE MICROPHONE AND
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF NAME
IF YOU'RE REPRESENT ORGANIZATION
TO ORGANIZATION AND THAT OF
COURSE --
YOUR YOUR COMMENT AND THANK YOU
AND WELCOME --
ALL RIGHT WE GOT THE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING RICHARD PAN
ADORNING MY NAME'S JEFF HARDY
GEAR.
I AM AN ADVOCATE I ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SOCIAL
PROGRAM FOR MEALS ON WHEELS ALL
OF THESE PROGRAMS OR USE YOU SEE
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
I AM APPRECIATING WHAT YOUR NEXT
GOING FORWARD SO I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT ALL OVER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EXTRACTOR BENNY S. CAR
ALL OF THE ORGANIZATIONS FEW
PEOPLE BEHIND.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WELCOME.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DENISE LIKE --
I'M SITE DIRECTOR OF MS US P.
SITE ZERO FIVE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AT INDEPENDENCE AT HOME A
COMMUNITY SERVICE OF SCANNED --
ALL OF THE THE SAFETY NET IS
FRAIL IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THERE IN THE COURSE SENIOR
POPULATION IS GROWING THE NEED
IS VAST.
SO ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS I URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER THEM FOR FUNDING
THIS YEAR AT THIS TIME TO HELP
OUR SENIORS BUT A COUPLE FACTS
ON MS SB SINCE THAT IS A PROGRAM
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART --
AT OUR SITE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THE DIFFERENCE THAT WE
MAKE IS THE AVERAGE LENGTH OF
STAY THAT WERE ABLE TO KEEP
SOMEONE IN THE COMMUNITY OUT OF
A NURSING HOME.
IS THREE AND A HALF YEARS THAT'S
THREE AND A HALF YEARS OF NOT.
BE IT NURSING HOMES FEES NOT
BEING CHARGED THE STATE OR TO
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND A
HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT US WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO THEM
SO WE REALLY DO NEED YOU TO
CONSIDER THIS FUNDING AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FRANK MAC EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS AMONG
OTHER THINGS ADMINISTER.
I TO SAYS AN ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES THE THREE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT.
COME FROM THREE REALLY IMPORTANT
PARTNERS THAT WE WORK WITH TO
KEEP SENIORS SAFE AND HEALTHY
AND WE SUPPORT ALL.
THREE THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING A REBEKAH
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ALSO
SUPPORT ALL PROPOSALS THAT WERE
PRESENTED --
TO FOR THIS COMMUNITY ALTHOUGH I
WAS ASKED TO COME HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM IS A CRUCIAL PART
OF THE SYSTEM WE HAVE TO PROTECT
SENIORS AND LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES BUT IT IS BEEN AN
ADEQUATELY FUNDED FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS --
THE TRAGEDY THAT WAS OUTLINED BY
THE SPEAKER --
REALLY ILLUSTRATED THE PROBLEM
AND ALSO IN SACRAMENTO RECENTLY
BE HAS OUTLINED --
SIR HERE IS SOME HORRIFIC CASES
WERE IN A HUNDRED DEGREE WEATHER
FOR HOURS AND HOURS AND AND
SUBSEQUENTLY DIED I THINK IF WE
HAD HAD IT MORE LONG TERM AND
BITES MEN THAT WERE ON THE
GROUND THEY WERE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE.
THESE FACILITIES WE MIGHT HAVE
PREVENTED SOME OF THESE
TRAGEDIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S RICHARD
STRANGE FROM THE SITE DIRECTOR
FOR THE M. S. S. P. SITE FIFTY
SIX WHICH IS NAPA SOLANO PART OF
CHOICE IN AGING [inaudible]
AND I'VE BEEN THE SITE DIRECTOR
THERE FOR FOURTEEN YEARS AND
DURING THOSE FOURTEEN YEARS
ALMOST THE ENTIRE TIME WE'VE
BEEN FLAT FUNDED WHILE COSTS
HAVE INCREASED.
THAT'S BEEN INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT TO RECRUIT AND
MAINTAIN PROFESSIONAL STAFF --
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME --
I STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT FOR FOR
THIS PROPOSAL FOR EMESIS P.
BECAUSE IT DOES TWO REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS ONE IS IT HELPS
TO STABILIZE THE PROGRAM WHICH
HAS BEEN TAKING A BEATING
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASING COSTS
OVER TIME.
IT ALSO FUNDS --
SOME ADDITIONAL SLOTS THAT WILL
MOVE PEOPLE OFF OF THE WAIT LIST
AND INTO SERVICE WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING I MEAN IT'S EVIL
PART WITH JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE
OF LOS ANGELES.
AND AS WITH MY COLLEAGUES I
FULLY SUPPORT ALL THREE OF THESE
PROPOSALS WE PROVIDE A RANGE OF
SERVICES TO OLDER ADULTS.
AS YOU KNOW I'VE STOOD HERE
BEFORE BEFORE SEVERAL TIMES IN
PARTICULAR THOUGH WITH THE
EMPHASIS P. REINVESTMENT.
AS ONE OF THE ORIGINAL PILOT
SITES FOR THE PROGRAM WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THIS
LIFESAVING CARE IF WE CAN AFFORD
TO PROVIDE IT AND WHY ARE
CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT RATES
DON'T COVER OUR COSTS.
ARE COSTS OF ESCALATED IN OUR
WAITING LIST HAS GROWN WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS MINIMAL
INVESTMENT IN LIFESAVING CARE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI I'M JOHN BLUTO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH PROJECTS
CENTER AND ALSO DIRECTOR OF THE
MISSISSIPPI PROGRAMS AND SANTA
CRUZ IN MONTEREY COUNTIES.
AND A LOT OF THE WORK WE DO IS
WORKING WITH --
OLDER ADULTS WHO WERE THE MOST
NEEDY IN THE MOST AT RISK AND I
WANT TO STRONGLY.
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT ALL THREE OF
THE PROPOSAL'S BROUGHT FORWARD
TOGETHER.
TAKE KILLER AS A AND THIS HAS.
A DIRECTOR OVER THE LAST --
EIGHT OR NINE YEARS --
WITH THE SAME FUNDING IS SAY
NEVER PEOPLE THE SERVICE BECOME
A REALLY A REALLY HUGE
CHALLENGES YOU'VE HEARD.
HE AND IN AS A SENATOR PAN HAS
INDICATED A CONCERN FOR ON
RETAINING --
STAFF SERVING OUR OLDER ADULTS
IT'S HARD WHEN YOU HAVE LIKE WE
HAVE HAD TO DO --
ELIMINATE RAISES.
HAVE UNPAID FURLOUGHS.
IN -- CUT
BACK ON OTHER BENEFITS AT A TIME
WHEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
HAVING A SURPLUS IT IS VERY
DISCOURAGING TO FOX AND I'D
REALLY REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
TO EXPAND --
THE THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO WORK
WITH OLDER ADULTS RATHER THAN
I'M DISCOURAGING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME'S THERE AND
DONE AWAY FROM HUMAN SERVICES
ASSOCIATION IN LA COUNTY BOTH AN
EMESIS PEEPER FIGHTER AND A
SENIOR NUTRITION PROVIDER.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE
GROWING AGING POPULATION BUT WE
SEEM YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT TO NOT
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
SO WHERE YOU I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE FUNDING INCREASES FOR SENIOR
NUTRITION AND A MISSISSIPPI
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LEASE A LOT
GOING ON SITE DIRECTOR FOR SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SOURCE TWICE.
AND I AM --
AS MY COLLEAGUES I SUPPORT ALL
THREE PROPOSALS BUT I'M HERE
REPRESENTING NEMESIS BE.
OUT I'M IN THE COUNTY WHERE I OR
STAFF FOR SOCIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
HIGHLY DEDICATED HIGHLY SKILL
AND ALSO NEEDS A TO BE I HAVE A
COMPARABLE INCOMES.
TO THE COUNTY ARE THERE I THEIR
INCOME RIGHT NOW IT'S AT 32%
BELOW WHAT THE AVERAGE SOCIAL
WORKER --
THE SALARY SORRY IN THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE AT SO I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT SAW.
THAT THIS PROPOSAL BE APPROVED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SERRA DEL AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE AND THE SAYS P. SITES SIX
AT THE INSTITUTE ON AGING AND
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR MS US PEACE.
IN MY YEARS AT AMASIS PIAS
BECOME MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT
EVERY YEAR TO PUT TOGETHER A
BUDGET THAT COVERS OUR SALARIES
BENEFITS AND OPERATING COSTS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO WE SERVE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CLIENTS WE MAINTAIN THAT
CENSUS EVERY MONTH.
AND OUR AGENCY HAS DECIDED THAT
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE
WILL BE AT RISK FOR CLOSING THE
SITE IN OURS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THE AGENCY WILL NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PUTTING THOSE SENIORS THAT RESTS
FOR POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND INSTITUTIONALIZE
ASIAN.
PLEASE SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM MISSISSIPPI THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING SENATOR PAN
I'M GEHRY PASSPORT PRESIDENT OF
THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS.
AND I'VE BEEN AT THIS MICROPHONE
STANDING TALKING TO YOU OR YOUR
PEERS FOR ABOUT NINETEEN YEARS
NOW BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
AND THINGS HAVE NOT GOTTEN
BETTER IN FACT I THINK WITH THE
LAST GOVERNOR WE HAVEN'T
PROBABLY RECEIVED ANY INCREASE
OVER THE LAST. EIGHT YEARS THERE
WAS AN ELEMENT OF CONSCIOUS
DISREGARD FOR SENIORS AND THEIR
PROGRAM NEEDS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU SALTS IN
THE ANECDOTES ADMIN SHARED WITH
YOU TODAY.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE UNDER FUNDED LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
DESPITE ALL OF OUR EFFORTS TO
MOVE PEOPLE INTO THE COMMUNITY
OR ALLOW THEM TO REMAIN THERE
ARE STILL PEOPLE OUT WILL NEED
TO BE IN AN INSTITUTION AND THEY
NEED.
UP PROTECTION AND THEY NEED GOOD
CARE.
ALL AND THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT IS TO HAVE PEOPLE
CHECK ON THEM.
OUR NUTRITION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
INADEQUATELY FUNDED AND IT IS A
LIFE SAVER FOR MANY PEOPLE AS
YOU'VE HEARD.
AND FINALLY VAMOS SAYS P.
PROGRAM PLAYS ARE A UNIQUE ROLE.
IN COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES AND
IT HAS BEEN GROSSLY UNDERFUNDED
FOR DECADES.
SO I JUST URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ALL THREE REQUESTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
OF THE CAN DO A LITTLE BETTER
THIS YEAR THAN THE LAST NINETEEN
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING I'M
IN A WHILE THE HEART WELL WITH
A. R. P. CALIFORNIA FIRST OF ALL
LIKE TO STAND WITH THE REMARKS
OF OUR PARTNER GARY.
ON THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
THAT'S ACTUALLY WHY I'M HERE
TODAY.
I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSAL THIS
THIS PROGRAM IS A LARGELY
VOLUNTEER DRIVEN HIGHLY SKILLED
VOLUNTEER DRIVEN.
LIFELINE BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY
AND RESIDENTS OF INSTITUTIONAL
CARE AS YOU KNOW.
WITH SOME OF THE CASES WE'VE
HEARD INAPPROPRIATE USE OF ANTI
PSYCHOTICS ON THE CENTRAL COAST
THEY WERE THE REASON WHY THAT
CAME TO LIGHT.
SO JUST REPEATING A. R. P.
STANCE IN SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
PROPOSAL FOR THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SUSIE
FOR JOE I REPRESENT HUMBLE DEL
NORTE COUNTY SO I RUN THE
PROGRAM FOR THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN --
I REPRESENT ELEVEN ABOUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY'VE
LOST THEIR VOICE.
ALL THESE PROGRAMS ARE VALUABLE
I WANT ENERGY SHOULD THESE
PEOPLE THESE WERE YOUR SCHOOL
TEACHERS YOUR SUNDAY SCHOOL
TEACHER BOY SCOUT YOUR GIRL
SCOUT LEADERS WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THEM NOW WHEN THEY NEED
US THEY WERE HERE FOR US.
WHEN WE NEEDED THEM WE NEED TO
BE THERE FOR THEM NOW?
I'M NOT GONNA DRESS FUNDING
BECAUSE AL THESE FOLKS RE
DRESSING AT ITS CRUCIAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
PETERSON I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
REPRESENTING.
FORTY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES TO ORDER CALIFORNIANS
IN OUR COUNTY WE SUPPORT ALL OF
THE BUDGET REQUESTS THAT ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AND MATHIS P. OMBUDSMAN --
SENIOR NUTRITION I URGE YOU NOT
TO THINK OF THEM AS SEPARATE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS COMPETING
FOR FUNDING THEY ARE PART OF A
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES.
THAT WORKS VERY COLLABORATIVELY
TO ENSURE THAT OLDER.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE SERVICES
THEY NEED TO NAVIGATE THE AGING
PROCESS REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE
HAPPEN TO BE ON THAT CONTINUUM.
ON IT TODAY FUNDING.
FOR GENERAL FUND CALIFORNIA
GENERAL FUND FUNDING IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS LITERALLY
HALF WHAT IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT AND YET WE HAVE. TWO
MILLION MORE OLDER ADULTS BUT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE --
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI AM CHRISTA CHILLING METIS HI
I'M FROM SENIOR ADVOCACY
SERVICES LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN AND MY NAME IS
ACTUALLY KRISTEN NELSON.
I JUST GOT MARRIED.
REGULATION SOMEBODY GET THAT.
SORRY TO ONE IN TWO WEEKS --
I I AM CONFIDENT EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM IS ON THE SAME PAGE ON
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE AND I THINK REALLY
I WOULD TASK US ALL TO MOVE
FORWARD.
TO HELP EVERYONE ELSE TO KNOW
WHO MAKES THESE DECISIONS
EVERYONE HERE TODAY IS IS ON THESAME TEAM SO LET'S --
LET'S GO OUT AND GET THE REST OF
THE PEOPLE THAT BELIEVES IN
THANK YOU CENTER PAN FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU DO.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THE MORNING AND TRACY BARBER I
REPRESENT THAT LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AND LASSEN
MODOC SHASTA SISKIYOU AND
TRINITY COUNTIES I HAD A LITTLE
THING TO SAY.
BUT REALLY TRULY WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO IS JUST DO THOUGH TO
EVERYBODY HERE CALL THE SERVICES
NEED.
ADEQUATE FUNDING AND THEY'RE
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED AND I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY CAN TELL YOU
ANYMORE SO.
DETRIMENTAL SAD STORIES THAT
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY SO I
URGE YOU.
TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING REQUEST
FOR ALL PROGRAMS TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
LIZA COMMON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION IS A
MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION MADE UP
OF THE THIRTY FIVE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS WE STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ALL THREE
THE PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE IN OUR OPINION.
YOUR WHEEL IS ONLY AS STRONG AS
THE WEAKEST SPOKE AND WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT ALL OF THE PARTS OF THE
WHEEL AND THE SENIORS DESERVE IT.
YOUR TEAM.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME MICHELLE PEARL A PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF THE WISE AND HEALTHY
AGING LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM HELLO AGAIN.
AS A AN OMBUDSMAN AND ALSO A
SOCIAL WORKER WHO'S WORKED WITH
ALL OF THESE POPULATIONS OVER
THE COURSE OF MY CAREER.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FUNDING
OF ALL THREE IF TO EACH OTHER
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE GIVING
SENIORS A BETTER LIFE.
AND I REALLY DON'T WANT TO COME
BACK AND HAVE TO TELL YOU SUCH A
HORRIBLE STORY AGAIN.
SO PLEASE WE REALLY REALLY
REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND PROVISION OF
THE SERVICES FOR TO ALL OF US IN
HERE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CAROL SUE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA OLDER JUSTICE
COALITION --
FOR SOMEONE IS THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN FOR THE ATTENTION YOU'VE
GIVEN TO OUR ISSUES OVER THE
PAST MANY YEARS.
AND JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT ALL THREE OF THESE
PROPOSALS THEY ALL SERVE THE
CAUSE OF ELDER JUSTICE BY
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO HAVE
CHOICE AND PROTECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JAMES TO JERRY AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR
SENIORS WERE A TRIPLE A PROVIDER
THAT PROVIDES FREE LEGAL
SERVICES AND HIGH CAP PROGRAM.
NO THOSE --
OUR PROGRAMS ARE UP FOR BUDGET --
THE BUDGET REQUESTS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THESE REQUESTS AS ALL OF
THESE SERVICES --
ARE CRITICALLY NECESSARY FOR
OLDER ADULTS TO COMPLEMENT EACH
OTHER TO MAKE SURE ENSURE THAT
OLDER ADULTS ARE ABLE TO THRIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY --
AS OTHER PROVIDERS AS MENTIONED
I WOULD SAY THAT --
STAFFING IN KEEPING UP WITH NEED
ARE JUST BECOMING MORE AND MORE
DIFFICULT AS THE DEMAND
CONTINUES TO GROW AND I WOULD
STRONGLY SUPPORT ANY INCREASES --
TO AGING SERVICES THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI THERE MY NAME IS THE BATTERY
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LIFE
ELDER CARE AND THE SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
HOMEBOUND SENIORS THAT WE SERVE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY --
REPRESENTING THOSE WHO CANNOT BE
THAT HERE THEMSELVES IN PERSON
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING REQUEST
THAT HAVE BEEN --
PUT BEFORE YOU TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WELCOME WELCOME MISTER CHAIR ON
MONICA MILLER REPRESENTING ALL
TEMAS LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF
UP ALL THREE PROPOSALS WE REALLY
NEED TO INVEST IN OUR SENIORS
AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS.
WE HAVE THE MONEY LET'S DOIT
WE'VE HEARD THEM FOR SO MANY
YEARS SO LET'S MAKE A DIFFERENCE
NOW THAT WE HAVE SOME MONY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THIS TO CHAIRED GIRL CAL TWITTY
HAIR AGENCIES ON AGING.
OBVIOUSLY WHO ARE SUPPORTING THE
VAULT.
THE REQUESTED TO HAVE IN FRONT
PRIMARILY TO THE NUTRITION.
HELLO WHAT A POINT OUT.
STUDIES HAVE TO STUDY SHOWED
THAT WOULD OUT OF SIX OLDER
CALIFORNIANS.
ARE FACED WITH HUNGER.
IN THAT STATE JUST A DEVASTATING
NUMBER.
HEY AND IT SEEMS TO ME SHOULD BE
A POLITICAL EMBARRASSMENT.
HEN A SOCIAL JUSTICE.
TRAGEDY SO WE WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
INCREASING THE NUTRITION FUNDING
MEASURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS ROBERT
COUPLE MAYOR --
VOLUNTEER FOR MEALS ON WHEELS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AT THE
COMSTOCK APARTMENT COMPLEX --
I THINK THE MEAL WILL SERVE IN A
FRACTION OF WHAT'S REALLY NEEDED
WE NEED MORE MONEY FOR MEALS ON
WHEELS.
AND IF THE VOLUNTEERS THAT DO
THE MAIN A LOT OF THE JOB FOR
THE MEALS ON WHEELS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
VOLUNTEERING TO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THERESA AGAIN AND
THE SITE DIRECTOR FOR A TWO IN
MISSISSIPPI STES SERVING
SACRAMENTO PLASTER YOLO AND YUBA
COUNTIES --
AND I'M I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
ALL THREE OF THE ASPEN IN
PARTICULAR MDMS AS P. --
WE ARE YOU KNOW HAVING HIGHLY
QUALIFIED STAFF.
AND AND ABLE TO SERVE THE THE
CLIENTS --
IN OURS TO SITES WE SERVE THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT CLIENTS --
WHO ARE THE THE YOU KNOW MOST?
LOWER INCOME SENIORS IN THE
STATE.
AS YOU CAN SEE THIS ROOM IS
FILLED WITH ALL KINDS OF
PARTICIPANTS FROM OTHER PROGRAMS.
THERE'S NOBODY FROM MS AS P.
HERE BECAUSE THE THE
PARTICIPANTS THAT WE SERVE OUR
TOO FRAIL FOR THE MOST PART TO
BE HERE.
SO THE VOICES YOU HEAR FROM MS
AS P. -- BUT
WE WE HAVE A LOT OF PASSION AND
I I WOULD I BEG YOU --
TO CONSIDER THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS JESSE
WILLIAMS I AM THE ASSISTANT SIDE
DIRECTOR HERE --
IN A SACRAMENTO OFFICE --
WE SERVE YELLOW PLASTER
SACRAMENTO AND YUBA COUNTY.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU GUYS
ABOUT A RECENT PROJECT THAT I
STARTED THAT I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING ON ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO
I WENT INTO THE HOMES OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS TO INTERVIEW THEM.
SO THAT THEY CAN TELL US ON ON
FEAR SAYS P. HAVE BEEN --
AND NOW LIVES AS THEY BEGIN THE
PROGRAM.
WHAT I DID NOT KNOW WHEN I START
DOING THESE INTERVIEWS HOW
EMOTIONAL --
I WAS GOING TO BE ONCE THESE
INTERVIEWS --
STARTED THE FIRST DAY THAT I
INTERVIEW --
THREE PARTICIPANTS I FOUND
MYSELF AT HOME BEING VERY
EMOTIONAL I FOUND MYSELF
THINKING ABOUT THE WORDS OF
THESE FOUR ALE LOW INCOME
SENIORS. ONE ON ONE PARTICULAR --
IN IF YOU JUST STOOD OUT TO ME I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU --
THIS PARTICULAR ARM --
THE LADY BEFORE SHE GOT OUT
PROGRAM --
SHE ENDED UP FALLING IN THE
SHOWER.
SHE IS BLIND AND SHE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH CHALLENGES
BECAUSE THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION HER DAUGHTER ACTUALLY
HAD TO MOVE IN WITH HER TO
ASSIST HER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS --
DON'T HAPPEN AGAIN WELL OUT TO
DR ONE ONE DAY AND SHE HAD TO
LEAVE HER MOM AGAIN IN HER HOME
AND IT HAPPENED AGAIN.
SO SINCE THIS LADY HAD BEEN IN
M. S. S. P. R. PARTICIPAR --
WE WAS ABLE TO GET HER A LIFE
ALERT SYSTEM TO PREVENT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WERE
HAPPENING.
SO I WANT YOU GUYS TO REALLY
CONSIDER WHAT --
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT BEFORE YOU
TODAY BECAUSE IT IS REALLY
REALLY MAKING A LIFE CHANGING --
FOR THESE PROTESTS WAS IT WITHIN
A AND THAT'S THIS.
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS DYLAN WHAT LOW AND
I'M A SOCIAL WORKER WITH THE MS
HAS P. PROGRAM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I'M IN THE TRENCHES
EVERYDAY WITH THE CLIENTS THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR SUPPORT. TO
INCREASE --
THE NUMBER OF CLIENTS WE
CONSERVE I'M ON THE PHONE WITH
THE WAIT LIST --
PEOPLE THAT WE WAIT LISTED
BECAUSE WE CANNOT SUPPORT THEM
AND HAVING TO TELL THEM I'M
SORRY THERE ISN'T ANY SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES FOR YOU.
SO I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF MS
HAS P. AND ALL OF ASK BECAUSE WE
INTERFACE WITH ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS SO THAT WE CAN STOP
TELLING PEOPLE I'M SORRY THERE'S
NOTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING THERESA ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARC IN UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE LONG TERM
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR OF THE
SAFETY NET PROTECTING SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
FIFTH APART THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'M BEVERLY SEAL I GO TO THE
SENIOR CENTER AND DO EXERCISE IN
WHICH IS --
PREVENTATIVE CARE MY PARENTS
BENEFITTED WITH FOR MEALS ON
WHEELS CAN THEY COULDN'T DO IT
AND SOLVE SONORA NASCAR THE
OTHER END OF THE SPECTRUM.
BUT I THINK THE WHOLE THING IS
IMPORTANT TO FIND ALL SERVICES
THANK YOU.
OKAY MY NAME IS JAN HOLES KELLY --
I'M A SENIOR CITIZEN AND
HOPEFULLY ALL OF YOU WILL BECOME
SENIOR CITIZENS.
AND OF I AVAILED MYSELF OF IN A
SENIOR CENTER OF A BRAIN FITNESS
CLASS.
WHICH A NOT ONLY IS IT HELPS YOU --
TO GET COGNITIVE SKILLS BUT ALSO
IT'S THE SOCIALIZATION THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE --
SO I REALLY ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
ALL THESE PROGRAMS FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS AT THIS STAGE IN LIFE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL OKAY THE I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF MERCY BROWN
BAG PROGRAM WE GET GROCERIES TO
LOW INCOME SENIORS I'M ALSO ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK.
AND WE ARE OF COURSE BECAUSE WE
LOVE THE SENIORS THAT WE SERVE
WEARING A IN SUPPORT OF ALL OF
THEM -- BUT
I WANTED TO SAY THAT IT'S A VERY
COST EFFECTIVE WAY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO HELP GIVE A
NUTRITION DOLLARS THEN IT PEOPLE
DON'T END UP IN CARE CENTERS
WHICH COSTS SO MUCH MORE --
THE FEEDING AMERICA IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HAVE A SENIOR HUNGER
STUDY THAT SAID THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY IF YOUR FOOD IN SECURE TO
THESE 78% MORE LIKELY TO BE
DEPRESSED --
THE STRESS IS REAL AND WE'RE
ASKING YOU TO HELP RELIEVE THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
GOOD AFTERNOON AND ARE MY NAME
IS AMIR MONTHLY A COME FROM
OAKLAND.
AN ALLY HELLO --
THIS IS A INVISIBLE DISABILITY
OUT.
ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES I TING IT FINALLY
AND FOLLOWING DAY ARTICLE TWENTY
FIFTH OF THE COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RIGHTS OF THE UNITED NATIONS.
WHICH EVERYBODY TO HAVE A
STANDARD OF LIVING ADEQUATE FOR
TO DO IN CIRCUMSTANCES HOUSING
NEW CATION HILT.
I'M GLAD TO CALIFORNIA THE ONLY
STATE THAT THE IN PROVIDE FOOD
STAMPS OLE.
CARTRIDGE THE GUARDED NOW. TWO
PEOPLE RECEIVE THE NECESSARY
THIS IS WHERE YOU NEED.
TO SURVIVE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE HIGH COST OF LIVING.
NOW IF YOU KNOW AND SO THAT HE
SAID THEY DON'T KNOW THAT HE'S
VERY [inaudible]
PRIMITIVE MARY IS MY CARE GEAR.
NOW I'LL TO COULD NOT LEAVE WITH
ME BECAUSE HE TO LIVE WITH ME
CHIU MAKES MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
I LOSE MY BENEFITS DOES THIS
RESET FOR ME I WENT TO A STOP --
FOR FOR TENNIS EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS WILL BE EASY ENOUGH SO I
CAN AFFORD THAT SHE HAS TO BE
POOR AND LIVE UNDER FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SO.
I HOPE THESE ARE NICE AVAILABLE
BUT FOR US TO LEAVE TO GET THERE.
UNDER HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IS WE ARE PUNISHER RATES OF
PEOPLE ARE FORCED TO LEAVE
SEPARATE OR THEM GET MARRIED YOU
KNEW THEY LOVE EACH OTHER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
THINK WE'RE GONNA BE ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE A LITTLE LATER
HERSELF I THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS CAROL CROOKS I'M FROM
OAKLAND.
AND FIVE YEARS AGO [inaudible]
I HAD.
I GOT FOOD FROM THE FOOD FROM
THE FOOD AT THE FOOD BANK THE
FOR MEALS ON WHEELS.
AND THEN --
I GOT APPROVED FOR AYE HSSAND I
HAVE SOMEONE THAT COOKS AND
CLEANS FOR ME NOW.
I HAVE ARTHRITIS AND THEN I HAD
BACK SURGERY TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO [inaudible]
AND IT'S MADE ALL THE DIFFERENCE
TO ME THAT HAVE THE SOCIAL
PROGRAMS AND TO HAVE THEM.
SO THAT THEY WERE FUNDED SO THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO WAIT WHEN I
NEEDED THEM BECAUSE I WAS
DESPERATE BY THE TIME I FOUND MY
WAY TO WHERE.
I COULD GET SOME HELP --
ANOTHER THING IS THAT I CAN HEAR
WITH UNITED SENIORS AND WE WANT
TO REMIND YOU.
TO FULLY FUND EVERYONE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT THIS BEING
REQUESTED TODAY.
THANK YOU.
MARTY EMOTO CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNICATION
NETWORKS HE CAN --
ALSO A FAMILY MEMBER MY OLDER
SISTER HAD DEVELOPMENT --
AND PHYSICAL DISABILITIES PASSED
AWAY IN TWO THOUSAND THREE BUT
I'M STILL HERE FOR HER --
JUST PERSONAL THANK YOU TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND TO THE STAFF
FOR PUTTING THIS ON THE AGENDA
AND ALSO FOR LISTENING TO US
THANK YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR
BEING GOOD PARTNERS.
ESPECIALLY TOO DIFFICULT TIMES
IN INCHES OF TIME STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ALL THREE PROPOSALS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS BUT THREE
SEVERAL MIDDLE AUG WAS PHOEBUS
AND I RECENTLY STARTED RECEIVING
MY SOCIAL SECURITY RETIREMENT
WHICH OP CAUSE ME TO LOSE UGH GO
DOWN IN MY CAL FRESH DOWN TO
FIFTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH.
HI I LOST MY MEDI CAL SO NOW ON
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE --
WHICH IS REALLY HAD HASN'T MADE
A HARDSHIP ON MYSELF SO I
UTILIZED THROUGHOUT THE SERVICES
ENOUGH SENIOR CITIZEN FOOD
GIVEAWAY PROGRAMS AND I URGE
THAT YOU SUPPORT --
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO FUND ALL
THE SENIOR PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CLEARLY KEEP ON
AND I'M WITH SENIOR SERVICES
COALITION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY.
I THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE DEPARTMENT.
FOR LISTENING TO EVERYONE TODAY.
MY INSTINCT IS TO JUST SAY
DIGITAL FOR EVERYONE IT'S COME
UP HERE BECAUSE I THINK THAT IT
EMPHASIZES WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE TO FIND ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS --
THE COME THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT --
AND ALSO I THINK THAT FOLKS HAVE
DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
EXHIBITING HOW IMPORTANT IS TO
RECOGNIZE IT AS THE ECOSYSTEM.
THE PEOPLE ARE DEPENDENT ON ALL
OF THE PROGRAM SO I THANK YOU
FOR THAT CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME MORE IN EVERYONE MY NAME
IS ALVIN FLOYD I'M FROM THE CITY
OF MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA UP ON THE
COUNTER CONTRA COSTA.
AND I'M COME TO BE A SENIOR NEXT
MONTH.
I'M THE YOUNGEST ONE WILL COME
TO BE ONE THAT ANYWAY --
I DO IS I'M A VOLUNTEER AS WELL
IN THE COUNTY OF CONTRA COSTA
AND I I SUPPORT TO SENIORS --
WE HAVE A TAKE CARE BYE TWENTY
EIGHT SENIORS IN IS KIND OF HARD
TO DO THAT SPECIALLY WHEN THEY
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE FUNDS IN
THE COMPLAIN ABOUT THE FOOD THEY
COMPLAIN ABOUT EVERYTHING.
SO I'M I KIND OF LIKE --
THEY YEAH WILL BECOME SENIOR AS
SOMEBODY HAD TO COME OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING I'M SHANTI PRASAD I
REPRESENT ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK WE SERVE ONE
IN FIVE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTY AND
SENIORS REMAIN ONE OF THE TOP
POPULATIONS THAT WE SERVE --
AND WE FULLY SUPPORT ALL OF THE
FUNDING IT'S VITAL FOR THE WELL
BEING OF SENIORS --
INCLUDING NUTRITION SERVICES WE
KNOW THAT WITH THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE THE FOOD BANK THAT WE'RE
NOT REACHING EVERYBODY SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO FUND THESE
SERVE.
AS WELL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING TWO POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING
WITH OR CARING FOR A LOVED ONE
WITH ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE ALL
THREE OF THESE PROGRAMS BENEFIT
THAT POPULATION THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WELCOME I'M AT THE FABER ON FROM.
SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE THIS
WEEK MAINLY ON I. XSS BECAUSE IT
IS HELP ME KEEP MY HOUSING YEAH
BATES AYE MAJOR DEPRESSIVE
DISORDER AND A LITTLE HOARDING
PROBLEM.
AND SO MY AGE S. WORKER COMES IN
AND SHE HELPS ME.
HELP HELP ME DEAL WITH THINGS
AND I KEEP THINGS STRAIGHTENED
UP ENOUGH SO THAT THE LANDLORD
DOESN'T TRY TO VIC ME AGAIN.
AND THAT IS A NICE THING.
PLEASE CONTINUE SUPPORTING AYE
HSS.
THANK YOU WE WILL BE ADDRESSING
THAT A LITTLE LATER THANK YOU.
OKAY ME SANTA BE GOOD TERRORISTS
FOR TWENTY YEARS I WORKED THREE
JOBS OR TO JOB.
OUR THREE JOB MOSTLY.
ARE MOST OF THE TIME I WORK ONE
JOB.
ELENA.
I CAME TO THE POINT THAT I
BECAME DISABLED.
ELENA ALLLOTTO PROGRAMS HAVE
HELPED ME TO BE HERE.
NOWADAYS I VOLUNTEERING PROGRAMS.
AND THE I WORK A LITTLE BIT.
AND I CAN NOT A OFF.
THE NEED FOR ALL THIS PROGRAM
YOU ARE IN THE POWER WE HOPE
THAT YOU LOOKING TO OUR NEEDS.
ELENA.
KEEP THOSE PROGRAMS GOING
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT KEEPS US
GOING LOOK AT ME NOW.
I WAS IN A BAND I WAS ISOLATED.
I HAD IT THAT I HAD GO IN ALONE
AND GUESS WHAT THEM HERE.
I THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO I AM RUSSELL RAWLINGS
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY IT
RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER
SERVING OLDER ADULTS THE AND
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES WITH
DISABILITIES IN.
SACRAMENTO AND YOLO COUNTY AND
WE FULLY SUPPORT FUNDING ALL
THREE PROPOSED PROGRAMS AND
ESPECIALLY WOULD LIKE CALL
ATTENTION THE M. S. P. PROGRAM.
THAT ALLOWS --
OLDER ADULTS TO REMAIN IN THEIR
COMMUNITY WHICH WE FEEL IS
IMPAIRED THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CALLING CHRISTY
PUTNAM.
AND I AM GOING TO BE SIXTY THREE
IN APRIL.
SS HATE AND SOCIAL SECURITY IS
NOT ENOUGH TO LIVE ON RIGHT NOW
MY RENT IS MORE THAN THE MONEY
THAT I RECEIVE EVERY MONTH.
WHICH MEANS THAT I'M LIVING OFF
THE REMAINDER OF MY SAVINGS.
THAT I GOT FROM WORKING FOR AYE
HSS TAKING CARE OF SOMEONE ELSE
IN THE IRONY IS MY DOCTOR
ORDERED AYE HSS FOR ME AND I GOT
REFUSED I THINK BECAUSE I DON'T
LOOK MY AGE.
AND I'M CHEERFUL AND INTELLIGENT
AND TALKATIVE AND THE PERSON
THAT CAME TO REVIEW.
AND MEET WITH ME DECIDED I
DIDN'T NEED IT MY FAMILY WAS
LIKE I GUESS YOU DIDN'T DROOL
ENOUGH.
WHICH FRANKLY IS THE TRUTH IF
YOU PRESENT AS WELL SPOKEN AND
INTELLIGENT AND YOUR AND YOUR
DISABILITY IS INVISIBLE.
YOU OFTEN DON'T GET HURT
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE A RARE
DISORDER THAT MOST DOCTORS DON'T
EVEN KNOW AS MUCH AS I KNOW
ABOUT -- MY
WHOLE FAMILY HAS THE SAME THING
AND MY DAUGHTER RECEIVED AS A
SITE EVERY SHE FIGHTS TO STAY
ALIVE AND SHE HAS TWO KIDS
STRAIGHT --
SSI IS NOT ENOUGH MONEY TO LIVE
ON AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE SO
MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING IN
TENTS AND IF I WERE TO GO LIVE
IN A TOWN WHICH I'VE BEEN VERY
CLOSE TO IT TIMES --
I WOULD LITERALLY DIE BECAUSE I
WOULD PROBABLY STROKE OUT
BECAUSE I WOULDN'T HAVE A SEAT
THERE.
SO YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE THERE'S A
LOT OF DESPERATE PEOPLE OUT
THERE AND WE JUST LIVE QUIETLY
AND WE TRY TO HANG IN.
AND WE DO WHATEVER WE CAN PART
OF HOW I EAT IS THAT I'VE BEEN
VOLUNTEERING FOR YEARS AT A FOOD
PANTRY IN ORDER TO FEED MYSELF
AND MY FAMILY.
SO WE NEED ALL THESE PROGRAMS --
I'M HERE BECAUSE I'M DEFINITELY
AN ADVOCATE I WAS THE MOM WHO
SUED THE OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN FEDERAL COURT IN THE
NINETIES TO MAKE THEM
ARCHITECTURALLY ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL DISABILITIES.
WHICH THEY THEN HAD TO SPEND.
A MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
FIVE DIFFERENT SCHOOLS AND NOW
MY GRANDDAUGHTER WE FIND OUT AND
MY GRANDSON BOTH HAVE THE SAME
DISABILITY AND THE THOSE.
THOSE FUNDS ARE HELPING REMODEL
THE SCHOOLS THEY ARE NOW
ATTENDEE.
SO THIS KIND OF THING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF INVISIBLE PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT ARE JUST QUIETLY LIVING AND
DYING.
ON THE STREETS.
YOU KNOW I SEE SO MANY PEOPLE
LIKE WHEN I WAS GOING TO MY JOB
FOR AYE HSS I WOULD HAND OUT
FOOD FROM THE FOOD PANTRY FROM
MY CAR.
GETTING OFF THE FREEWAY IN SAN
FRANCISCO EVERY SINGLE TIME I
WENT TO WORK BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WITH NO LEGS
THAT ARE WEARING PROSTHESIS.
THERE IN WHEELCHAIRS THERE AND
WALKERS.
IT'S LIKE MOST OF THE TIME I
DON'T EVEN USE MY WALKER I NEED
IT SIT SIT BECAUSE I CAN'T STAND
FOR A LONG TIME BECAUSE ALL MY
JOINTS DISLOCATE.
IT'S LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF US
OUT THERE THAT CAN'T EVEN COME
HERE TO SPEAK.
LIKE THANK YOU THOUSANDS.
THANK THANK YOU AND WILL BE
ADDRESSING AYE TO ASSESS THE
LATER TODAY AS WELL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HI SENATOR.
HI SENATORS.
I THINK YOU CRISTINA BOSS
HAMILTON WITH UT W. OF
REPRESENTING I JUST AS WORKERS
AND WE ARE SUPPORTING ALL THE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'M JUDITH MOWER FROM CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY MULTI FAITH ACTION
COALITION AND WE SUPPORT THIS
FUNDING THAT IS UP FOR NOW.
AND IF THIS FUNDING IS CUT IN
ANY WAY SENIORS LIVES WILL BE
DRASTICALLY REDUCED.
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD THESE
ARE FIND OUT TO FUND THEM THEM
SELVES.
AND WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR
SENIORS THEY WORKED HARD ALL
THESE YEARS TO GET US WHERE WE
ARE.
AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL CAN SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
TO THANK YOU MY ARMS MY NAME IS
STEVEN TO RALLY AND I AM AND I
HSS PROVIDER FOR THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS BUT I'M COMING TO YOU
TODAY AS A CITIZEN.
WHO -- HAVE
HAS BEEN EXPOSED TO SENIORS WHO
HAS THESE PROGRAMS.
I ASKED THE JUNE REMEMBER THAT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE PAST WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
BUDGET ITEMS THE SENIORS ARE
THERE FUNDING IS THE FIRST ONE
THAT GETS CUT.
FROM THE TOP.
THIS TIME LET'S DO IT
DIFFERENTLY LET THE MEN FUNDED
AT THE TOP INSTEAD OF FIRST CUT
AT THE TOP.
BECAUSE THESE PROGRAMS SAVE
LIVES AND KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES MS AS P. I KNOW IN OUR
AREA -- I
COME FROM LAKE COUNTY I'M IN
CLEAR LAKE WE'RE IN A RURAL AREA
WHERE THERE'S BEEN FIRE AFTER
FIRE AFTER FIRE AND THE MSF P.
PROGRAM CAN ALSO REPLACE --
MEDICAL --
LIKE WHEEL CHAIRS --
THE PARTIES AND WALKERS AND I'VE
EVEN HAD ONE OF MY WORKERS WHEN
THE PEOPLE I WORK FORGET A
WALKER BECAUSE THEY COULD YOU
GET IT ANYWHERE ELSE.
SO THAT PROGRAM OF WAS NOT THERE
THAT PERSON WILL TO WET WITHOUT
A WALKER.
SO JUST PLEASE KEEP THAT IN MIND
AND LETTER SENIORS BE ON TOP
THIS TIME INSTEAD OF ON BOTTOM
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
SENATE PANEL KEEP THIS UP BRIEF
FIVE TRONG POINTER CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
WE SUPPORT ALL THREE PROPOSALS
ARE THEY'RE ALL WORTHY.
AND TOWN AGAIN THAT'S OUR FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI. ONE OTHER.
OKAY MARK OKAY.
WHAT IS JUDY JACKSON I REPRESENT
OVER THE? ONE MILLION SENIORS
AND DISABLED EOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT BELONG TO OUR
ORGANIZATION.
I CAME TODAY TO TELL YOU ABOUT
MY FRIEND CAROL.
CAROL WAS BORN.
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
IT ALBANY RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO
BERKELEY SHE HAS LIVED ALL OF
HER SEVENTY NINE YEARS IN
BERKELEY.
AND SHE WAS TOLD WHEN SHE BROKE
HER HIP AND NEEDED.
A BOARDING CARE THAT THERE
AREN'T ANY IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
THAT WILL TAKE.
HER MEDI CAL AND MEDICARE MONEY.
SHE NEEDS A PROGRAM IN HER
COUNTY SHE DIDN'T WANT TO MOVE
AWAY SOMEWHERE ELSE WHERE SHE
HAS.
LIVED ALL OF HER LIFE.
AND SO FAR WE HAVE HER INTO THE
ALZHEIMER'S CENTER FOR A DAY
PROGRAM.
AND I HSS AT NIGHT.
BUT SHE SPENDS MANY HOURS ON THE
WEEKEND BY HERSELF BECAUSE THERE
IS NOTHING ELSE.
AVAILABLE SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS
NEED TO BE FUNDED BETTER.
AND SOME KIND OF PROGRAM I AND
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO LIVE IN THEIR
OWN HOME.
PLEASE SHIELDS TO LIVE THERE FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS AND NEEDS TO STAY
IN HER HOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CLICK HERE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SENIORS COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING FOR THE CO
CHAIRS SO.
ODD SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ALL
THREE OF THESE PROPOSALS TWO
THINGS THAT I REALLY WANT TO ADD --
AND APPRECIATE YOUR ON GOING
SUPPORT BUT M. S. S. P. SAVES
THE STATE DOLLARS WITH EVERY
PERSON IN SERVICE.
AND IN THAT CAPACITY IT'S
RIDICULOUS BUT THE PROGRAM IS
NOT AVAILABLE STATEWIDE BUT ONLY
IN CERTAIN REGIONS.
AND IT'S RIDICULOUS SENATE'S
CAPT SO I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE.
KNOWING THAT IT'S ACTUALLY
REVENUE POSITIVE FOR THE STATE
THAT NOT ONLY THE AUGMENTATION
BE --
ALLOCATED BY LOOKING AT GROWING
STATE AND MAKE YOUR BROWN GOING
TO PROGRAM AND MAKING SURE.
EVERYONE CAN GET INCLUDING THOSE
LIVING IN RURAL COMMUNITIES.
FOR THE MEAL PROGRAM I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE THING LOCALLY.
ARE TRIPLE WAY IS ALL FOR EIGHTY
FIVE FUNDING LEVELS.
AND THAT'S INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING FOR US TO CONTINUE
TO DO ANY REASONABLE.
ARMS BE REASONABLY SUCCESSFUL IN
MEETING NEEDS SO I'M I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO SHARE --
WE HAVE WELVE STAFF PEOPLE.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
VOLUNTEERS.
SO EVEN WITH THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO OPERATE IN THE SAME LEVEL WE
DID THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO IT
CAN'T CONTINUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CONMIGO FLOYD
I'M I JUSTICE WORKER ALSO AND I
BILL SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN
SO I DO CAP WITH HIM AND I OR
ORGANIZING --
SO I HAVE A ISSUE WITH THE
FUNDING PART --
I HAVE A IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE IS.
BECAUSE THEY LOSE CARE THEY NEED
THE CARE SOMETIMES THEY LOSE THE
CARE -- SOME
THINGS SOME HOURS SOME PEOPLE
NEED MORE HOUR THAN WHAT
THEY'RE GAINING.
AND IS NOT ENOUGH --
MY QUESTION IS IS LIKE WE HAVE
THE FUNDING SO WE SAY WELL WHERE
IS THE FUNDING GOING IF IT'S NOT
GOING TOWARDS THE PEOPLE THAT
THE THINGS THAT WE NEED.
ALSO I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
SHEER COST FOR OUR SENIORS THIS
YEAR COSTS FOR SENIORS IS I HAD
A CLIENT ONE TIME SHE ONLY MADE
TWO DOLLARS OVER.
HER INCOME AND THEY THOUGHT THEY
MADE AND SHE WAS STILL ON A
FIXED INCOME SHE ONLY MADE TWO
DOLLARS OVER AND THEY MADE HER
PAY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS OUT OF
HER.
INCOME CHECK THAT SHE DEMAND
HALF [inaudible]
THAT'S SO THERE'S A ABOUT ABOUT
THAT.
AND BUT IF YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT
AYE HSS MURMURED TAKING TACKLING
THAT LATER ON IN THE HEARING
WILL TALK ABOUT THE PART OF
AGING SO I WAS ACTUALLY QUESTION
WAS ADDRESSING.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WELCOME.
I I'M LARA CALVERT I'M THE
DIRECTOR SPECTRUM COMMUNITY
SERVICES IN ALAMEDA COUNTY --
WE PROVIDES SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS FALL PREVENTION
PROGRAMS --
AS WELL AS A LIKE HE FROM OTHERS
ATION.
WE ABSOLUTELY DELIVER MORE THAN
A MEAL EVERY DAY AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
RECOMMENDATIONS BEFORE YOU --
TO TRY TO MAKE THAT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE ON THE SENIOR
CENTER COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW I THINK EVERYONE TO AG
A PUBLIC COMMENTS --
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
QUICKLY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
HI MY NAME IS JOE SO CHAU
FORSAKE COUNTY.
AND MY MOM --
SHE PARTICIPATES IN THE IN IN
WHAT IS IT AMNESTY PROGRAM.
AND IT'S A FANTASTIC PROGRAM
BECAUSE SHE'S TO FALL LIKE
WEEKLY ENDED UP IN THE HOSPITAL
IN IN IN THE REHAB SO WHEN SHE
GOT ON THE PROGRAM.
THEY GAVE THE LITTLE MONITOR SO
SHE CAN GET THE HELP LINE RIGHT
AWAY -- I'M
JUST STRESSING HOW IMPORTANT
PROGRAM EARLIER.
IN THE VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY'RE KEEPING MY MOM HOME SAFE.
AND I GET TO SEE YOUR DAILY SO I
REALLY ENCOURAGED TO KEEP THE MS
SB PROGRAM GOING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
INDIAN OKAY.
OKAY THIRTY SECONDS COUNTY
ARNOLD IN SUPPORT OF THE SENIOR
PROGRAMS --
AND ALSO MY NEIGHBOR A BARBER
ENOS PARTICIPATES IN PROVIDING
MEALS ON WHEELS TO PEOPLE AND
SHE ALWAYS SAYS.
THERE'S A A CRITICAL NEED
PARTICULARLY EVEN IN ELK GROVE
FOR MORE VOLUNTEERS AND SHE'S
FROM CANADA.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
OKAY WELL --
SO ACTUALLY AT THE THAT'S
BECAUSE IN TERMS OF SO WE WE
HAVE THREE PROPOSALS BY A IN
TERMS OF AN SS HE OF THE
TESTIMONY WAS IS THAT --
THAT FIRST OF ALL WE'RE NOT UP
TO I GUESS IS FROM A WAIVER SO
THERE'S A CAP ON THE TOTAL
NUMBER BUT WE'RE NOT UP TO
MAXIMUM CAP --
BUT ALSO THAT IT AVOIDS.
INSTITUTIONALIZATION --
SO -- AND
FROM -- FIVE
AGING ARE LA YELLOWS THERE AS IS
RUN SOME EVALUATION AS TO WHAT --
WHAT DEGREE THEY SP PROGRAM THAT
DOES --
REDUCE --
BASICALLY INSTITUTIONALIZATION
OF PEOPLE HAVING TO AND TO MOVE
TO NURSING HOMES WHICH BY THE
WAY WE ALSO PAYS A STATE THE
EVEN MORE SO CAN YOU JUST CAN
YOU DRESSED AS ONE LOOKED AT
THAT ISSUE.
WE DO KNOW --
THAT AT LONG CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING WE DO KNOW
THAT EMESIS P..
DOES PREVENT OR DELAY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF PERSONS
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD BE --
QUALIFIED TO BE IN A HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE --
I DIDN'T COME PREPARED WITH HER
THE THE THE FAX WE'D --
THE INFORMATION WE DO HAVE.
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY PULL THAT
TOGETHER THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
AND GET THAT TO THE COMMITTEE --
AND LA LA --
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THAT ISSUE AT
ALL.
SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE YEAR ROUND.
WERE NOT FAMILIAR WITH ANY
PARTICULAR CITY BUT HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THE DEPARTMENT IN
AND ALSO I'M THE EMESIS BESIDE
ASSOCIATION TO SEE IF FUND THEY
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ON THAT BUT SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT MADE IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT INDIVIDUALS
THAT RECEIVE EMESIS P. --
ESSENTIALLY ARE ELIGIBLE AND IT --
AND OUR FRIEL ENOUGH TO BE IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY SO I'M.
HAPPY TO SEE WHATEVER
INFORMATION WE COULD GET TO GET --
HOPE YOU ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
AND THEN I GUESS FOR FINANCE --
TO ME WE HAVE THE DATA THAT
SHOWS THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE --
WA TO SAVE MONEY.
SO ANY THOUGHTS FROM FINANCE
ABOUT LOOKING AT THIS DATA IN
TERMS OF I KNOW WHEN YOU.
FINALLY CRUNCH EVERYTHING FROM A
REVISED.
I MEAN WE WE CAN WORK WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE DEMOGRAPHICS
IN FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT BUT RIGHT NOW I DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING --
CATCHER NIGHT DAY I RECOGNIZE
THAT -- SO
BUT I HOPE THAT YOU WILL LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT
WAS A SAID THAT.
AS I UNDERSTANDTHAT --
WE EAT UP THERE'S BOTH A RATE
INCREASE ARE ASKING FOR BU ALSO
EVEN IN TERMS OF NUMBER OF
POSITIONS IN THE WAIVER I
RECOGNIZE THERE'S A CAP BUT IF
IT.
PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM GOING TO
NURSING HOME CARE WE CAN THAT
NOT EVERYTHING IS ABOUT THE
MONEY BUT IF YOU DO AN ACTUARY
ANALYSIS AND METER THAT SAVES US
MONEY TO DO THAT.
SO I HOPE THAT WE CAN DO THOSE
KIND OF CALCULATIONS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THINK FINANCE
CAN LOOK AT WE WE CAN'T DO AN
ACTUARIAL ANALYSIS ARE OUR STAFF
HOLDS BUT WELL TO THE SIDE I'M
HOPING THAT HAPPY. TO LOOK AT
THE DAY OKAY --
YES THAT --
THE DEPARTMENT HAS OKAY.
WILL DEFINITELY PROVIDE
TECHNICAL SYSTEM OKAY WELL I I
THINK I THINK THE IDEA IS THE OF
THAT --
BROUGHT UP IN MULTIPLE HEARINGS
BEFORE EIGHT WE WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE ITEMS WE THINK OKAY V. PUT
MONEY INTO SOMETHING WE ALWAYS
SCORE ACOSTA THAT RIGHT.
BUT WE SHOULD ALSO LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS WE DON'T DO IT WHAT
HAPPENS RIGHT SO --
I DON'T THINK THE SENIORS WHO
WOULD TAKE UP THE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS.
ARE GOING TO BE NOT.
DOWN THE AND NOT GOING TO TO
DELTA THE THING IS IS THAT IF WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW IN
NURSING HOMES ARE TO COULD HAVE
AND WOULD HAVE BEEN AT THE
NURSING HOME SUIT DOWN.
TO MY GUESS IS A SOMEONE RAN THE
NUMBERS THAT FIGHT CHEAPER TO
HAVE THEM S. S. P. THAT AND
HAVING A NURSING HOME CARE SO.
ASIDE FROM THE QUALITY ISSUES
AND SO FORTH YOU KNOW I MEAN
EVEN JUST A NUMBERS STANDPOINT --
AND AND MAYBE I REALIZE THE FEDS
PAY HALF FOR NURSING HOME UNDER
MEDI CAL ABOUT THE EVEN IF EVEN
AT THAT RATE.
SO I JUST I JUST HOPE YOU LOOK
AT THAT SO WHEN WE COST
EFFECTIVE AS IT CROSSES IN
EVERYTHING WE ALSO LOOK AT OTHER
FACTORS BUT EVEN FROM A COST
STANDPOINT NOW WE SHOULD
HOPEFULLY.
HOPEFULLY CAN WORK TOGETHER AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT'S THE BEST
WAY TO GO THERE [inaudible]
YES -- SOME
OF THE INFORMATION WE DO HAVE
LIMóN WE RENEWS THE WAIVER FOR
MSN WE HAVE TO TO REPORTING TO
THE FEDS RIGHT.
IS THE COST OF EMESIS P. TO WHAT
THE COST OF OF A HIGHER LEVEL OF
KERR WOULD BE SO WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT SORT OF NATION.
PULL TOGETHER AND WE COULD WORK
WITH FINANCE TO SHARE THEM WITH
YOU ALL RIGHT I FIGURED BETWEEN
NOW AND MAY WE CAN PUT OUR HEADS
TOGETHER FORGET SOUTH.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL --
I THINK WITH THAT --
THAT --
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD OPEN --
THOSE ITEMS --
ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH THE B. C.
P. ON CBS --
AND THEN ALSO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
EACH.
SO I WANT THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH --
FOR PRESENTATION THE BARDEN
AGING AND SO WHAT WE CAN DO NOW
IS GOING --
TO MOVE ON TO OUR BACK TO THE
FIRST ITEM WHICH IS THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE ALL THE SPEAKERS HERE NOW.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK AND AT
APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE OF ALL
THE OTHERS SPEAKERS WHO WERE
HERE -- AT
THE BEGINNING OF OUR HEARING --
FOR FOR WAITING SO WE HAVE --
FOR OUR PANELISTS FOR
INFORMATIONAL PANEL AND
CONSIDERATIONS DEVELOPMENT OF
BASS CLIN FOR AUSSIE OVER FROM
THE LA -- AT
DOCTOR KATHLEEN WILBUR --
PROFESSOR GERONTOLOGY FROM THE
RECEIPT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ALLEGE JONES --
SENIOR ADVOCATE CLAY CAMPS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
SENIORS COUNCIL.
OF SANTA CRUZ AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES AND MARCO --
MUSIC OVER PRONOUNCE IT
CORRECTLY ACTING DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR PROGRAM FISCAL
FAIRS CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
SELF PEOPLE WANNA SAID ALONG THE
PLEASE COME UP [inaudible]
AND ALL RIGHT WE GOT.
WE GOT CHAIRS FOR EVERYONE HERE
[inaudible]
YASSER [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO --
WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND --
PERHAPS --
WE'LL JUST GO IN THAT ORDER AND
START OFF WITH --
ROSSIO FROM THE LA --
I'M GOING TO ASK IF WE CAN TRY
TO I KNOW I USUAL THREE MINUTES --
THAT BECAUSE BUT THEY'LL BE I'M
SURE TO BE QUESTIONS AND SO
FORTH SO AND AGAIN THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE AND REALLY GET
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S --
LEADERSHIP AND ASKING FOR MASTER
PLAN WE'VE BEEN TRYING.
TO THANKS AND LOOK FORWARD ON
THAT AND I APPRECIATE WE HAD
HEARING LOOKING AT DEMOGRAPHIC
PROJECTIONS I APPRECIATE THE A
LA IS --
HELP AND SUPPORT --
TO WITH --
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF AND
DOING THAT HEARING SO WE WANT TO
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE AND SO.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND
SHARING WITH US YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHAT ARE SOME THE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED AND ADD
THINGS TO BE LOOKED AT IN A
MASTER PLAN ON AGING SO.
AGAIN BEGIN WITH THOUGHT THIS
BROSSIER FAMILIAL THANK YOU
WELCOME.
OUR OFFICE WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE
JUST A STATUS UPDATE IN TERMS OF
WHERE THE STATE IS AT WHEN IT
COMES TO PLANNING FOR THE AGING
POPULATION AND ON THIS QUESTION
IS DEFINITELY COME UP --
AND SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR OFFICE.
THINGS THAT WE HAVE DONE JUST TO
GET A BETTER CENTER STARTING
POINT ON THIS CONVERSATION AS
YOU MENTIONED WE DID DO --
SOME WORK ON LOOKING AT
DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS SPECIFIC TO
THE AGING POPULATION BUT THEN
ALSO PROJECTING OUT DISABILITY
RATES --
WHICH THEN ARE SET THE TONE OF
DOUBLE BY TWENTY SIXTY BUT THEN
ALSO WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A HIGHER SHARE OF THE AGING
POPULATION --
WITH DISABILITIES --
AS MEASURED BY JUST LIMITATIONS
WITH ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING
WHICH IS AN INDICATOR OF A NEED
FOR THAN THESE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORT PROGRAMS
AND THAT THE STATE.
OPERATES I'M SORRY THESE BIG
PICTURE QUESTIONS --
JUST TO TAKE A STEP BACK THINGS
THAT HAPPENED RESEARCH OVER THE
RECENT YEARS THAT HAVE MADE SOME
MOVEMENT IN TERMS OF THIS.
BLOCK LARGE BIG PICTURE PLANNING
FOR THE AGING POPULATION IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AS A PART OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
TO PROVIDE --
SOME FUNDING TO INCLUDE
QUESTIONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INTERVIEW SURVEY AND
THESE QUESTIONS IT WAS EXPECTED
THAT THEY WOULD HELP THE STATE
GATHER MORE INFORMATION NOT ONLY
ON THE PREVALENCE OF
DISABILITIES.
BUT ALSO COGNITIVE AND
FUNCTIONAL IMPAIRMENTS NEED AND
USE OF L. T. S. AS CURRENTLY.
ARE THERE --
LEVELS OF UNMET NEEDS.
AND ALSO FACTORS THAT CAN
MITIGATE OR OFFSET ON THE NEED
FOR L. TSS.
OF THESE QUESTIONS --
THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF BEING
INCLUDED IN THE SURVEY AND IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT --
THEY WILL BE ANALYZED --
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY BUT
AGAIN IT'S IT'S MORE OF THAT
LIKE LONG TERM NEAR TERM
PLANNING OF A JUST GATHERING
DATA WHICH IS KEY --
ADDITIONALLY THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED --
HAS BEEN.
AS YOU MENTIONED THE NOVEMBER
HEARING IN WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
CONVENED A PANEL NOT ONLY TO GET
A BETTER SENSE OF THE
DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS BUT THENALSO
THEN.
A SENSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON
OF THE PROGRAM ONLY WATER WHAT
ARE THE EFFORTS AND FUTURE
PLANNING.
WITH THAT.
IN THIS GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NOT
ALL OF NOT ONLY AS THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO EXPRESS
INTEREST BUT THE GOVERNOR
HIMSELF HAS EXPRESSED INTEREST
IN THIS CONCEPT OF DEVELOPING A
MASTER PLAN.
AND ALTHOUGH THE DETAILS --
ARE FORTHCOMING --
THIS DEFINITELY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO NOT ONLY DEFINE THE SCOPE OF
THE MASTER PLAN BUT ALSO TO COME
UP WITH A TIME LINE AND THESE
KEY QUESTIONS THAT WILL BE USED
TO INFORM THE MASTER PLAN.
IN OUR NOVEMBER HEARING WE JUST
PRESENTED A SAMPLE OF SOME OF
THOSE POTENTIAL QUESTIONS THAT
COULD BE --
USED ON AS A POINT OF
CONSIDERATION.
SOME OF THOSE INCLUDE.
I'M GETTING A BETTER SENSE OF
THE CURRENT L. TSS SYSTEM AND
THEN ALSO HOW IS THAT MEETING
THE CURRENT NEEDS OF SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES --
PROJECTING OUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
DO EXPECT IN THE FUTURE WILL BE
NEEDING SOME FORM OF L. TSS
SERVICES --
WHAT TYPES OF SERVICES WHAT THEY
NEED?
AND THEN ALSO THINKING WE HAVE
OUR CURRENT BUCKET OF LTE SAYS
PROGRAMS BUT THEN THAT IN THIS
CONCEPT OF FUTURE PLANNING DOES
THAT THE NECESSITATE THE
CONVERSATION UP ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL TSS PROGRAMS THAT WE
THAT MAY NEED TO BE INTRODUCED
INTO THE MIX --
LASTLY THINGS THAT WE ALSO
MENTIONED IS HOW WILL THE FUTURE
ALTI ASSIST UTILIZATION AND
PACKED THE FINANCING OF THE
STATE FUNDED LTO SUCH PROGRAMS
AS WELL.
THOSE ARE FEW QUESTIONS THAT WE
LAID OUT AND I KNOW THE
PANELISTS WILL SPEAK MORE
BROADLY IN TOUCH ON OTHER
DIMENSIONS OF THIS CONCEPT OF A
MASTER PLAN.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT DR WEBER [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING --
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC --
I WORK WITH GERONTOLOGIST AND
DEMOGRAPHER'S AND A LONGEVITY
EXPERTS AND WE'VE SEEN
TREMENDOUS STRIDES AS YOU KNOW
AND WE'RE ALL HAPPY ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE ARE AN AGING
SOCIETY LIVING INTO OUR EIGHTIES
AND NINETIES.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE I DON'T
THINK WE DO THE BEST JOB WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
OLDER AGES OF QUALITY OF LIFE
AND THAT IT'S A SECURE OLD AGE.
IN PREPARING FOR THIS I KIND OF
LOOK BACK AND I HAVE TO SAY I'VE
BEEN COMING UP HERE FOR A VERY
LONG TIME I'VE WORKED ON FIVE
MAJOR PROJECTS WITH THE STATE.
STARTING IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AND AS I LOOKED IT WAS
EVERY ABOUT EVERY DECADE AND
THEN IT'S TIGHTENED UP WITH SOME
OF THE PROJECTS WE'VE DONE ONE
WAS --
CALLED THE LONG TERM CARE
INTEGRATION.
WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO INTEGRATE
MEDICARE AD MEDICAID AND LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS DATA?
ACROSS TWENTY COUNTIES AND
ANSWER SOME VERY INTERESTING
QUESTIONS BEFORE THAT WAS SHUT
DOWN WE ALSO WORKED ON A PROJECT.
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A
DATA WAREHOUSE --
BECAUSE OF HIGH.
I WAS ASKED TO TALK ABOUT KIND
OF WHAT WE KNOWN WHAT DATA ARE
AVAILABLE AND THE THE PROBLEM IS
THAT I DON'T THINK WE KNOW
NEARLY ENOUGH BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE DATA --
MOST RECENTLY WE WORKED AND MOST
OF THESE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
BETWEEN UCLA AND USC SO WE'RE
ABLE TO COORDINATE ACROSS THOSE
ENTITIES --
BUT THE MOST RECENT ONE WAS
LOOKING AT A UNIVERSAL
ASSESSMENT INSTRUMENT AND LOTS
OF STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WITH
THAT PROJECT.
A AND I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF
INFORMATION THAT'S STILL OUT
THERE FOR ALL THESE PROJECTS. TO
BUILD ON AND THE SORT OF
THINKING ABOUT THE KEY TAKEAWAYS
SOME OF WHICH YOU'VE HEARD.
REPEATEDLY ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WERE AN AGING SOCIETY PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT PEOPLE ONE AGENT
PLACE.
AND TO DO THAT THEY NEED HOUSING
AND THEY NEED SERVICES AND THEY
NEED SUPPORTS COMING INTO THEIR
HOMES --
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THAT COULD
BE PULLED IN --
FROM CO HOUSING TO THE CAPABLE
PROGRAM WHICH BRINGS HANDYMAN
INTO PEOPLE'S HOMES TO
INTENTIONAL COMMUNITIES --
I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD THIS OVER
AND OVER AND CARE GIVERS FAMILY
CARE GIVERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
THE CURRENT LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS.
BETWEEN FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
BILLION BILLION DOLLARS WHICH
ACCORDING TO MY CALCULATIONS
ABOUT DOUBLE CALIFORNIA'S MEDI
CAL.
CONTRIBUTION SO THAT'S HUGE BUT
AT THE SAME TIME AS YOU'VE HEARD
OVER AND OVER FROM PEOPLE.
MAKING PUBLIC COMMENT WE'VE SEEN
SERVICES KAT.
AND TERMINATED SO THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS COME BEEN CUT
BACK DRAMATICALLY.
AT A TIME WHEN WE NEED IT AND I
HAVE TO SAY HAVE BEEN COMING UP
HERE TO TESTIFY FOR THESE THIRTY
YEARS SAYING.
WE'RE GOING TO BE AN AGING
SOCIETY WE NEED TO GET READY.
LOOKS LIKE I DIDN'T DO THAT
COMPELLING A JOB BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T GET READY AND NOW --
NOW WE EED --
TO WE STILL HAVE SILO DATA I
THINK THE CHEST QUESTIONS WILL
BE REALLY HELPFUL --
BUT WE REALLY NEED DATA TO HELP
US.
ANSWER SOME OF THE CORE
QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF SERVICE
PATTERNS AND DUPLICATION --
WHAT WHAT DOES CREATE RISK FOR
NURSING FACILITY PLACEMENT AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT WITH MONEY FOLLOWS THE
PERSON?
WHO'S ACTUALLY ABLE TO COME OUT
AND WE KNOW THAT MANY PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN FACILITIES THAT HAVE KIND
OF RECOVERED SUFFICIENTLY TO GO
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY DON'T.
EXIT THE FACILITY BECAUSE
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR THEM IN THE
COMMUNITY SO THOSE KINDS OF
QUESTIONS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT --
SO I I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER.
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A FEW MORE COMMENTS
ACROSS THESE FIVE STUDIES IN
THESE THIRTY YEARS.
SO FIRST CALIFORNIA HAS SOME
VERY INNOVATIVE AND REALLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS AND YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT THEM AND THE AMASIS
P. I. TO SAYS --
BUT WHAT WE'VE LACKED IS A
COHERENT VISION.
OF FOR PEOPLE TO AGING PLACE TO
HAVE OF PERSON CENTERED CARE.
BECAUSE WE FLEXIBLE POLITICAL
WILL AND SO I THINK NOW WE'RE AT
THE JUNCTURE WHERE THE AGING
POPULATION IS HERE.
AND IT'S REALLY TIME TO MOVE
AHEAD WITH THE MASTER PLAN TO
PUT THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
ON THE TASK AND SEE IF
CALIFORNIA CAN --
GO TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
THANK YOU.
I'LL JONES JONES WELCOME.
THERE IS A DOT THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME THIS MORNING THEY
GIVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF SENIORS ALL OVER
AND SHARE WITH YOU MY PERSONAL
JOURNEY.
I'M A PERSON IN THE EAST COAST
TO NEW JERSEY I MOVED HERE.
JUST PRIOR TO RETIRING IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE SO THAT POINT I
DIDN'T KNOW.
ANY RESOURCES HOW TO GO ABOUT TO
WIN MEDICARE OR WHAT BENEFITS I
HAD.
SO -- I WAS
BLESSED.
THAT REPORTED THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL ON AGING IN CONTRA COSTA.
THAT GROUP IN TRIPLE A A VERY
VITAL.
TO SENIORS UNDERSTANDING.
HOWEVER AT THAT POINT.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE INFORMATION
ASSISTANCE.
CALL CENTER AND I DON'T KNOW THE
DATA ON OTHER COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA MAYBE YOU DO THAT
HAVE THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW.
WHERE TO GO TO GET AN ANSWER AND
THEN GO FORTH BECAUSE YOU'RE
FAMILIES GENERALLY DON'T KNOW
NEIGHBORS OR CHURCH MEMBERS?
SOUL I WAS BLESSED TO MEET THEM
AND I GOT --
TO AFFILIATE WITH SOME
[inaudible]
THE ARM [inaudible] TO BANK.
AND THE MANAGED CARE COMMISSION
AT CONTRA COSTA HEALTH PLAN.
WHICH GAVE ME A LITTLE UP ON
SPECIALLY COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE BECAUSE I HAD NO.
CONNECTIONS AND MY PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN WAS VERY VITAL.
I PICKED ONE THAT WAS ON OUT OF
THE PHONE BOOK.
THAT WAS.
A VERY VERY HELPFUL IN IN MY
HEALTH CARE IN THE QUALITY OF ON
THAT I GET IS A SENIOR.
OKAY MY MY PRIORITIES AS A
SENIOR.
IN THINGS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD ON HELP MAKE HAPPEN
NUMBER ONE IS HOUSING.
AND THIS YEAR HOUSING CONCEPT IS
VERY GOOD THAT THE WHOLE HOUSING
OR HAVING SOMEONE IN FOR PEOPLE
LIKE WHO HAVE A ONE IS THE IN
HOME.
AND THEY HAVE EXTRA ROOM THERE'S
A PROJECT GOING ON I THINK IN ON
CONCORD A GROUP THAT I THINK
SOMEONE'S HERE FROM THERE DID ON
THE INTERVIEW PEOPLE TO COME IN.
AND LIVE WITH.
ENGLISH HERE THE COURSE THAT'S A
VERY GOOD CONCEPT.
BUT THE MAIN THING I EXPERIENCE
WAS.
HOW DO I KNOW WHAT FACILITY
TAKES IN SENIORS WHAT AGE THAT
THE FIFTY FIVE YOU GET THE SIXTY
TWO AND THEN YOU AFFORDABILITY?
OF COURSE IT'S THE NUMBER.
ONE HUD HAS --
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF HOUSING THAT
THEY HELP PEOPLE WITH.
SO WHAT I DID I WILL TO SIGN IN
SACRAMENTO.
I'M IN SAN FRANCISCO AND THEY
SENT ME A LIST INDICATING.
IT'S THE TO RUN ACROSS THAT
NEEDS THAT HUD HAS A LISTING OF
OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN.
AND THAT THEREFORE YOU CAN HELP
PEOPLE WITH THAT.
FOOD THE FOOD BANK THIS SENIOR
GIVE OUT THE CHURCH IS DIFFERENT
THE SENIOR SENATORS.
A GREAT RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED.
MONEY FOR OUR FOOD.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE ON SSI I'M
RETIRED SO SECURITY WHICH IS A
LITTLE BETTER.
BUT ON THE THEIR GREAT SOURCE
FOR HELPING PEOPLE OUT AS WE SEE
NOWADAYS HOWEVER ONCE.
THE COST OF THINGS HERE FROM
WHEN I FIRST GOT HERE IN TWO
THOUSAND TILL NOW IS.
IS ASTRONOMICAL SO I KNOW WE'RE
ALL IN TROUBLE HEALTHCARE IS THE
NEXT THING.
OKAY PART D. TELL ME MY DAUGHTER
MY MY DOCTOR ORDERED A
PRESCRIPTION FOR ME.
AND WALGREENS ON FILLED IT.
AND THEN THEY TOLD ME THAT
BECAUSE I WAS OVER SEVENTY YEARS
OLD.
THAT THEY HAD TO HAVE THE DOCTOR
OR TO RISE TO PRESCRIPTION.
THAT WAS TOTALLY NEW I DON'T I'M
JUST THROWING IT OUT ON IT BUT
I'M GONNA FIND OUT MAYBE YOU
KNOW THE ANSWER DR PAT.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT IS
ACTUALLY IN THE FORMULA WE BOOK
IF YOU WILL WAS.
SEVENTY THE DOCTOR HAS TO LOOK
IF I WAS UNDER SEVENTY DAY WHEN
A QUESTION ABOUT SCRIPTED AND
THEY DON'T WANT TO FILL IT.
I GOT IT BUT YOU KNOW I I DON'T
KNOW WHERE THAT.
OKAY TRANSPORTATION IS ANOTHER
THING IS THAT THAT'S HOW DO WE
GET TO WHERE WE DON'T HOW DO YOU
MOVE AROUND.
AND THE LAST THING I AM
CONCERNED WITH HIS ADULT DAYCARE
THERE'S A LOT OF LEVELS OF AG.
DECIDE TO TAKE YOUR BABY TO THE
NURSERY.
YOU CAN TAKE YOUR MOTHER YOUR
GRANDMA.
AND WHY YOU GO TO WORK.
THEY'LL BE ON GIVEN YOUR
MEDICINE FED AND ENTERTAINED
SOCIALLY IT'S GOOD FOR THEM TO
GET OUT.
AND HANG OUT WITH OTHER SENIORS.
IT'S LIKE YOU GUYS HANG OUT AT
THE WELL.
FOR THE WAY --
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING
OF A FACILITY IN PLEASANT HILL
THEY DO A TREMENDOUS JOB.
DATE -- BUT
THEY HAVE SOME LOW INCOME SLOT
WITHIN YEARS SO I THINK THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD ALSO CONSIDER
THAT IN THE BUDGET WHEN YOU TALK --
TO OUR GOVERNOR IN AMONG
YOURSELVES.
TO MAKE AVAILABLE.
ADULT DAYCARE CENTERS FOR PEOPLE
IN IN SCREEN OUT PEOPLE THAT
WOULD HELP THE FAMILY HAVE A
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE
EVERYBODY'S HAPPY. FOR THE CARE
TAKING CAN TAKE A NAP FOR A
COUPLE OF HOURS AND AND YOU KNOW
TAKE IT ON THAT LEVEL TO GO TO A
DAYCARE CENTER.
BY THE DAY SITTING HOME WATCHING
FOUR WALLS AND A TV.
OKAY SO -- I
APPRECIATE YOU I THANK YOU FOR
THE AS A SIDE BENEFIT TO TO PUT
IN THAT WE LOBBY FOR LAST YEAR
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF IT.
CELL THANK YOU AGAIN AND KEEP ON
DOING AND ALWAYS SUPPORT ALL
THESE PROGRAMS AS WELL YOU'RE
GOING TO BE THERE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS CAMP WELCOME.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME HERE IT'S
REALLY A PLEASURE [inaudible]
AND I'VE BEEN ASKED TO KIND OF
TALK ABOUT.
PEOPLE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND AND DOCUMENTING NEEDS
AND AND IT'S SUCH A BROAD
CATEGORY THAT I DON'T THINK.
I CAN DO ANY OF THAT JUSTICE IN
THE TIME WE HAVE HERE --
AS ARE THE SOLUTIONS THEY'RE
EXTREMELY COMPLEX AND TAKE A
DETAILED LINK THE I TACK ON THE
THE VERY DIFFERENT PROBLEMS WE
FACE BUT A COUPLE THINGS THAT I
WANT TO SHARE ABOUT.
DOCUMENTING THE I JUST THINK
THAT SHEER NUMBERS OF OUR
POPULATION DOES THAT.
RIGHT NOW THE SIXTY PLUS
POPULATION IS AT EIGHT POINT TWO
MILLION IN THE STATE. TEN OF
THOSE. ONE OUT OF SIX LIVE ALONE.
AND LONELINESS AND ISOLATION IS
A TOPIC THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING A LOT ABOUT IN THE-COMING YEARS.
IT'S KIND OF BEEN IGNORED WE
KIND OF HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
MAINTAIN.
THE CORE SERVICES THAT WE HALF
BUT IT'S BEEN STUDY THAT LIVING
ALONE --
BEING ISOLATED IS THE EQUIVALENT
OF SPOKE SMOKING HALF A PACK A
DAY OF CIGARETTES ON ON YOUR
HEALTH CARE.
SO THE PROGRAMS THAT WE DESIGN
IN THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE.
NEED TO COMBAT THAT IN MANY OF
THEM OFTEN IT'S ONE OF THE PUT
THAT PIECE INTO THE MAX. ONE OUT
OF EVERY.
FIVE OTHERS SIXTY PLUS
POPULATION IS MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE.
SO I THINK THAT'LL LOAN
DOCUMENTS THE NEED.
JUST POVERTY WE ALL KNOW THE
CAUSES AND CHALLENGES AND
RESULTS OF POVERTY AND IF WE
HAVE ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
SENIORS LIVING IN POVERTY WE
HAVE MAJOR PROBLEMS.
IF YOU ASK ME THREE YEARS AGO
ABOUT WHAT I WOULD THINK WE
WOULD NEED.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN SAYING TWO
THINGS WE NEED TO ELEVATE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE OLDER
ADULT POPULATION.
CHAMPIONS.
AND I'M REALLY THRILLED THAT WE
KIND OF DONE THAT YOU KNOW I'M
LOOKING AT LEGISLATIVE CHAMPIONS
RIGHT NOW.
AND THE WHOLE FACT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A MASTER PLAN AN
AGING SHOWS WITH ELEVATED THAT
CONVERSATION.
SO THE CHALLENGE NOW BECOMES
WELL NOW THAT IT'S HAPPENED WHAT
DO WE DO ABOUT IT.
HOW TO REMOVE THIS YOU'VE ISSUE
FORWARD --
THERE'S A COUPLE KEY THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING.
ON THE BAD NEWS YOU HEARD ONE OF
OUR PRESENTERS EARLIER.
STATE THAT THE STATE GENERAL
FUND CONTRIBUTION TO OUR CORE
OLDER ADULT PROGRAMS HAS DROPPED
BY THIRTY MILLION.
OVER THE LAST DECADE IN TWO
SIXTY TWO SIXTY THREE MILLION.
AND THAT DROPPED ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THIRTY TWO MILLION.
AND THE LAST FEW YEARS THERE'S
BEEN A CONCERTED EFFORT TO GET
SOME OF THAT MONEY BACK AND WE
GOT TWO TO THREE MILLION BACK
WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW HER RAY WERE REALLY
HAPPY ABOUT THAT BUT CLEARLY WE
HAVE THIRTY MILLION TO MAKE UP
JUST TO GET WHERE WE WERE EN
YEARS AGO.
AND THAT WAS WITH A MUCH SMALLER
POPULATION.
AND NOT NECESSARILY ONE THAT WAS
ACT AS ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED
AS TODAY.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE CHANNELS
THAT I WOULD THROUGHOUT THEIR
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT WORK.
WE JUST NEED TO INVEST IN THEM.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
RECREATE THE WHEEL WE NEED TO RE
CREATE HOW THE INTERFACE WITH
EACH OTHER.
AND THAT'S WHY THINGS LIKE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT IS BEING LOOKED
AT TO DEVELOP A CALIFORNIA A
COMMUNITY LIVING HOT. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE REALLY COMBINING
SERVICES AND MAKING SURE THAT
WHAT'S NEEDED IS GETTING TO
PEOPLE IN THE MOST COST
EFFICIENT WAY.
BUT THAT COMMITMENTS. TO WHAT
ALREADY WORKS TO WHAT WE KNOW
WORKS.
IT'S CRITICAL NOW COURTS WE NEED
TO INNOVATE WE NEED NEW PROGRAMS
THAT'S ALWAYS PART OF WHATEVER
CHALLENGES.
BUT WE WHEN WE HAVE EXISTING
SERVICES THAT WORK WELL.
AND WE JUST DECIDED NOT TO FIND
THEM WE DON'T HAVE A CRISIS IN
POLICY WE HAVE A CRISIS IN
FUNDING.
AND WE DON'T JUST NEED AN MASTER
PLAN ON AGING WEEDING UP MASTER
PLAN ON PAYING FOR AGING.
AND JUST TO WRAP UP I I KNOW MY
TIMES JUST TO BRING THAT PIECE
TOGETHER.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HEALTH CARE
COSTS IN THE LAST 20% OF YOUR
LIFE CONSTITUTE ABOUT 80% OF ALL
OUR HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES.
SO IF WE DO NOTHING WE'RE STILL
GOING TO HAVE A BUDGET CRISIS
DEALING WITH OLDER ADULTS WE'RE
GOING TO BE SPENDING ALL THESE
DOLLARS. TO DEAL WITH EMERGING
HEALTH CARE.
AND THAT'S THE MOST EXPENSIVE
INTERVENTION WE CAN TAKE.
YOU KNOW IT'S A LOT EASIER TO
PUT A GRAB BAR AND A BATHROOM.
THE END IS TO REPLACE A HIP WHEN
SOMEBODY'S FALLEN AND BROKEN
THAT.
SO.
I BELIEVE OUR CHALLENGE AND WHAT
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING SHOULD
FOCUS ON IS NOT HOW MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND BECAUSE THAT'S A
GIVEN.
THE MASS SAYS WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND A LOT.
BUT LET'S LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
SPEND THOSE DOLLARS EFFECTIVELY.
COMPASSIONATELY AND IN A WAY
THAT ACTUALLY REDUCES THE
EXPENDITURES THAT THE STATE HAS.
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER THE
EXPENDITURES ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
BUT TO SPEND THE DOLLARS RIGHT
AND MAKE EVERYBODY'S LIFE
PATTERN MAKER BUDGET LOOK BETTER.
AND WE HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY NOW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MISTER MITCH THE PRESS
SECRETARY YEAH YOU DATA CENTER
PAN CENTER TANTO IN CENTER STONE
THANKS FOR THE INVITATION TO BE
HERE.
BEFORE I BEGIN I JUST WANNA
KNOWLEDGE THAT OTHER FOLKS ON
THE PANEL I THINK IT'S REALLY
GREAT TO HEAR THEIR PERSPECTIVES
IDEAS AND RECOMMENDATIONS --
AND SPECIFICALLY TO MRS MRS
JONES I THINK WE CAN DO MUCH
BETTER AND WE MUST DO MUCH
BETTER FOR INDIVIDUALS LIKE YOU
AND THOSE THAT ARE SITTING IN
HE AUDIENCE.
AND SO THAT'S I THINK OUR TASK
MOVING FORWARD --
AS YOU NOTED MY NAME IS MARKHAM
EACH I'M THE ACTING DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR PROGRAM IN FISCAL
AFFAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
OVERSEES TWELVE DEPARTMENTS AND
FIVE OFFICE AS WE SERVE AT WE
PROVIDE A RANGE OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SOCIAL SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES INCOME
ASSISTANCE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES. TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPECIFICALLY
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING.
AND AS A GOVERNOR NOTED INSTEAD
OF THE STATE OF DRESS IT'S TIME
FOR US ALL TO COME TOGETHER AND
REALLY TACKLE THIS HAD ON IT
MUST ADDRESS PERSON CENTER CARE
THE PATCHWORK OF PUBLIC PROGRAM
PROGRAMS.
SOCIAL ISOLATION BED LOCK
SENIORS IN NEED OF
TRANSPORTATION IN ADDITION TO
MANY OTHER THINGS.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT HAS NO BOUNDARIES AGING
DOESN'T CARE WHAT RACE YOU ARE
WHAT ECONOMIC STATUS YOU ARE OR
IF YOU'RE SINGLE WITH NO OTHER
FAMILY SUPPORT.
AND AS MY OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO
WORKS ON THE PANEL AT DESCRIBED
YOU ALL ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT THAT WILL FACE
IN THE COMING DECADE.
NOT ONLY WILL WE SEE A
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN THE NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIANS.
THAT ARE GONNA BE OLDER BUT
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO SEE A SHIFT
IN THE COMPOSITION OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THE COHORT OF OLDER ADULTS IS
MORE LIKELY TO BE SINGLE.
CHILDLESS MORE ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE LIVE ALONE AND LIVE IN
POVERTY.
THERE IS NO SINGLE PROGRAMMER
POLICY THAT'S GONNA PREPARES FOR
THE SHIFT I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE A COMBINATION OF PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES.
AND WE MUST WORK TOGETHER BOTH
YOUNG AND OLD AND PRIVATE SECTOR
AND PUBLIC SECTOR.
AND EVEN INDIVIDUALS LIKE MYSELF
MILLNNIALS WE HAVE TO COME TO
THIS TABLE.
A ONE THIRD OF US OUR CURRENT
CARE GIVERS ANOTHER THIRD WILL
BE CARE GIVERS IN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS AND AS MANY PEOPLE ALLUDED
TO WE ALSO WILL AGE SO WE HAVE
TO BE AT THIS TABLE.
AS PART OF OUR WORK ON THE
MASTER PLAN AN AGING WE HAVE TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT HOW WE
DELIVER OUR PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES.
I THINK THIS IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO RECOMMIT
OURSELVES TO ENSURE THAT THE
DELIVERY OF OUR PUBLIC PROGRAMS.
ARE CENTERED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE OUR CLIENTS.
FOR DECADES PUBLIC PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES HAVE BEEN DESIGNED TO
DELIVER TO SUPPORT THE STRUCTURE
OF GOVERNMENT.
HOWEVER INDIVIDUALS LIKE MRS
JONES.
THEY DON'T LIVE THEIR LIVES IN
SILOS.
OUR VISION FOR THE MASTER PLAN
ON AGING IS THAT IT WILL SERVE
AS A BLUEPRINT THAT CAN BE USED
BY STATE GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BY PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS AND
PHILANTHROPY TO BUILT
ENVIRONMENTS A PROPOSED HEALTHY
AGING.
AND I WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT CAN'T DO THIS ALONE
WE MUST DO THIS TOGETHER.
WE CAN ONLY DO THIS COLLECTIVELY
PRESSURING IDEAS AND CONNECTING
PEOPLE STORIES AND DATA WE ALL
HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY ENSURING
THAT OLDER CALIFORNIANS CAN
AGENT PLACE AND WITH THE DIGNITY.
SO THE QUESTION BEFORE US TRULY
IS HOW CAN WE CREATE AN AGING
FRIENDLY COMMUNITIES FOR ALL ALL
OLDER ADULTS.
THIS MEANS THAT OUR WORK MUST GO
BEYOND JUST THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT UNDERLYING SOCIAL FACTORS
LIKE SO THANK HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION AND FOOD.
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
INDIVIDUALS WELL BEING AND AND
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND THIS IS TRUE
FOR CHILDREN AS MUCH AS IT IS
FOR ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS AS
WELL.
ADDITIONALLY THE MASTER PLAN
MUST NOT ONLY FOCUS ON PUBLIC
PROGRAMS WE ADMINISTER IN MUST
BE INCLUSIVE OF ALL OLDER
CALIFORNIANS.
THERE ARE MANY OLDER
CALIFORNIANS THAT DON'T UTILIZE
OUR PUBLIC PROGRAMS AND WE MUST
ENCOMPASS THEM AS WELL.
FINALLY THE MASTER PLAN MUST BE
ACTIONABLE WE HAVE TO HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE.
AND WE MUST DEVELOP CONCISE
METRICS THAT WILL HELP US
EVALUATE OUR PROGRESS.
SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE TO
ACT WITH URGENCY HOWEVER THERE
ARE NUMBER STEPS THAT WE CAN
TAKE AND HAVE TAKEN TO SET THE
FOUNDATION TO ACCELERATE THIS
WORK AT THE AGENCY.
FIRST WERE BETTER LEVERAGING
PUBLIC DATA WE'RE DATA RICH BUT
INFORMATION POOR WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN WE COLLECT A LOT OF DATA
BUT WE DO A POOR JOB USING IT
TURN FORMER.
PROGRAM DELIVERY DATA MUST
INFORM THE MASTER PLAN AND IT
CAN HELP IMPROVE PROGRAM OUT
REACH SERVICE DELIVERY AND
ULTIMATELY CLIENT LIVES.
SECOND WE'RE CHANGING THE
CULTURE AND WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION WE MUST FOCUS ON
HOW WE BETTER DELIVER PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE. TOO
OFTEN WERE FOCUSED ON THE
DEVELOPING PROGRAMS BASED ON
WHAT'S CONVENIENT WITHIN THE
SILO STRUCTURE OF GOVERNMENT.
THE MASTER PLAN MUST ENVISION A
SYSTEM OF PUBLIC PROGRAMS THAT'S
EASY TO NAVIGATE FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE CONSUMER.
AND AS GOVERNMENT IT'S OUR DUTY
TO ENSURE THAT WE WRAP THESE
PROGRAMS AROUND THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE.
FINALLY WE'RE DEVELOPING
PROGRAMS WITH OUR CLIENTS NOT
FOR THEM THIS MEANS THAT WE HAVE
TO ENGAGE OUR CLIENTS MEETING
FLEET IN THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
SO THAT THEY ARE PART OF IT SO
THE MASTER ENGAGE INDIVIDUALS
LIKE MRS JONES.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
WE ARE ULTIMATELY BUILDING THE
PLAN FOR SO IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION WILL ENGAGE
CLIENTS STAKEHOLDERS AND
CERTAINLY YOU AS THE LEGISLATURE.
ON THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONNECTING YOUR
IDEAS.
THOUGHTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS I'D
LIKE TO FINISH BY UNDERSCORING
THE GOVERNMENT'S VISION FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THIS IS OUR
SOCIAL CONTRACT THIS IS OUR
COMMITMENT TO OUR PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS THAT WE BUILD A
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN H. WITH
INDIGNITY.
MANY LEGISLATORS INCLUDING
YOURSELF DOCTOR PAN HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR MASTER PLAN AN
AGING WE THANK YOU IT'S TIME FOR
US TO ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES AND
GET TO WORK TOGETHER I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY AND I'M.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE ALL THE
PANELISTS PRESENTATION --
I HAVE TO STEP OUT JUST FOR A
FEW MOMENTS I'M GONNA PASS GAVEL
TO CENTER STONE BUT I'M SURE
BOTH CENTER STONE HER TADO HAVE
QUESTIONS AND BY THE TIME I GET
BACK I CAN GET IN MY QUESTIONS
THAT.
THREATENS THEIR STUFF.
THANK YOU DOCTOR BROWN --
CENTER RICARDO WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO START WITH MY QUESTIONS OR DO
YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WE'LL
START WITH OKAY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INFORMATIVE --
A PRESENTATIONS --
IN APPRECIATE --
SO MANY MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE
THAT ARE HERE TODAY THAT SHOW OF
CONCERN.
FOR BUT I I THOUGHT I WOULD
OFTEN CALLED THE THE SILVER
TSUNAMI WITH --
WITH THIS IS LANDED IT LANDED
RIGHT.
AND WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS IT --
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE LA --
IN MY ROOM IN THE SENIOR
POPULATION OF THOSE SIXTY FIVE
YEARS AND OLDER AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU.
THAT MEANS I HAVE TWO MORE YEARS
OF USE BEFORE --
I BECOME OFFICIALLY PART OF OF
THE GROUP.
SO -- YOU
KNOW.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IN HAVING THIS MASTER PLAN.
IS -- TO DO
WHAT WASN'T DONE --
DECADES AGO IN PREPARING FOR
THIS EVENTUALITY --
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP MY MY
GRANDPARENTS WERE GETTING SOCIAL
SECURITY AND MY PARENTS AND THE
FINANCIAL SECURITY OF COURSE
WHEN SOCIAL SECURITY --
FIRST CAME OUT AND WOMEN MY
GRANDPARENTS WERE THE
BENEFICIARIES OF IT ACTUALLY YOU
CASH YOU LIVE ON IT.
HE ACTUALLY PAY RENT YOU COULD
ACTUALLY FEED YOURSELF AND GO TO
THE DOCTOR AND NOW YOU'LL FAST
TRACK TODAY YOU LOOK AT THE VERY
MODEST INCREASES THAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS --
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT AND VERY
CHALLENGING FOR ANYONE. TO TO
HONESTLY SAY THAT THEY CAN LIVE
ON JUST --
SO SECURITY ALONE THAT SAYS IT
IS APPALLING SO --
SO WITH THAT SAID.
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THIS REAL
MASTER PLAN --
I THINK A PART OF THAT IS --
REACHING OUT TO OUR MILLENNIALS
REACHING OUT TO OUR OUR OUR
YOUNGSTERS ARE MIDDLE CLASS.
AND AND HIGHLIGHTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF EMBRACING PROGRAMS
THAT WILL NOT ALLOW THEM TO BE
IN THE POSITION --
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES
[inaudible]
IN TODAY.
AND SO.
ARE A NOTICE ONE OF THE THE
SHOCKING STATISTICS FOR ME WAS
THAT.
OF ALL THE PEOPLE THAT GET --
L. T. S. HELP --
ONLY 5% OF THEM.
HAVE BOUGHT LONG TERM LONG TERM
INSURANCE 5% I MEAN --
SO TO THE TO MAYBE THE EIGHTH --
PANEL IN PARTICULAR DR ROBERT --
IT'S IT'S VERY VERY WONDERFUL
HAVING YOU HERE FROM A VERY
PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITY THEY WERE
VERY LUCKY THAT WE HAVE SOMEBODY
YOUR CALIBER HERE TODAY SO --
AS AS A FELLOW TROJAN I'M I'M
DELIGHTED TO HEAR I WAS.
WHAT WHITE WHY IS IT THAT --
THERE ARE BARRIERS FOR FOR
MEDICAL LAST CALIFORNIANS TODAY --
TO PLANNED THIS THIS EVENTUAL
FUTURE --
AND AND AND WHY DO YOU THINK.
THAT -- WE
ONLY SEE 5% OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
BOTTLE AS LONG TERM INSURANCE --
REFLECT THE THE OVERWHELMING
NEED THAT WE'RE GONNA BE SAYING
IN THE FUTURE.
SO I THINK THERE'S SEVERAL
ANSWERS TO THAT --
ONE IS THAT WHEN IT'S
INEXPENSIVE TO BUY IT IS WHEN
YOU'RE YOUNG YEAH BUT WHEN
YOU'RE YOUNG YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT EDUCATING YOURSELF.
OF MORTGAGE MAY BE --
SAVING FOR RETIREMENT GETTING
YOUR KIDS THROUGH COLLEGE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
ARE HIGHER PRIORITIES IF YOU IN
FACT.
HAVE ANY DISCRETIONARY INCOME TO
PUT TOWARDS THOSE THINGS.
BUT AS YOU REACH RETIREMENT AGE
AND BEYOND WHEN YOU REALLY START
THINKING YOU NEED LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE.
IT'S PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE IMAGE THE INSURERS SNOW
THAT IT'S AN INSURED EVENTS THAT
IS UP ALSO IT'S DIFFICULT TO
COST IT OUT FAR AWAY.
AND SO AND SO I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH THIS IS AN
INSURANCE PRODUCTS --
THERE HAVE BEEN.
EFFORTS TO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT
BUT PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING TO AS
YOU KNOW TO EVEN SAVE FOR
RETIREMENT BEYOND CELS SECURITY.
SO LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
SEEMS LIKE.
OF SOMETHING THAT'S DOWN THE
ROAD IN TERMS OF A PRIORITY FOR
MANY PEOPLE AND THEN I'LL JUST
SAY ONE OTHER THING --
THE PRODUCT ITSELF.
IS NOT ALL THAT GREAT OFTEN AND
SO DOES IT INCLUDE INFLATION --
WE'VE SEEN SOME PEOPLE PURCHASE
IT AND THEN THE PRODUCT IS NO
LONGER THERE SO WE NEED A LOT OF
SAFEGUARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOES WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO AS
WELL.
WOULD YOU SEE WOULD YOU SEE IS
GOVERNMENT'S ROLE SHOULD
GOVERNMENT --
ESTABLISH SOME TYPE OF A FUND.
THAT OUR CITIZENS CAN CONTRIBUTE.
VOLUNTARILY --
TO INSURE THAT THEY HAVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT HELP AND RESOURCES
WHEN THEY RETIRE SO.
I I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF WE
STILL HAVE THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP AND WHAT HAPPENED TO
THAT THAT SEEMED LIKE.
A MODEL THAT PEOPLE COULD
PARTICIPATE IN.
SO A CALIFORNIA AND THREE OTHER
STATES HAVE A PROGRAM WHERE YOU
COULD INSURE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
ASSETS --
YOU COULD DECIDE AND THEN WHEN
YOU HAD SPENT DOWN TO THOSE
ASSETS.
THEN YOU COULD GO ON STATE
MATTER CAL AND SO IT WAS A WAY
TO TO KIND OF OFFER A PROTECTION
AND MAYBE --
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE AT THE
HEARING NOW IF THIS IN FACT AND
MAYBE AT LONG WOULD HAVE KNOWN.
IT DOES THIS EXIST --
THIS WAS A THIS WAS A BIG IDEA
AND THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WAS A LEADER --
SO.
I I THINK THERE ARE SOME MODELS
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT A LOT OF
VERY SMART PEOPLE HAVE WORKED ON
THIS FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
AND HAVEN'T COME UP WITH ANY
KIND OF PANACEA FOR IT
[inaudible]
OKAY. ONE THING IT'S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT IS CREATING A LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE STATE PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO DISABILITY INSURANCE.
WHICH BOTH THE INDIVIDUAL AND
EMPLOYER POSSIBLY THE STATE
COULD COULD PAIN.
TOO AND I THINK THE PLACE TO
LOOK AT THE FEASIBILITY OF THAT
WOULD BE SOMEHOW CALCULATE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING
TO SPEND DOWN.
THEIR SAVINGS AND USE MEDI CAL
MEDICAID TO PAY FOR THEIR LONG
TERM CARE.
WHEN A WHEN THEY GO INTO A
NURSING HOME AND SEE YOU KNOW DO
A COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS ON?
HOW MUCH DOES COST COULD BE
DIVERTED BY CREATING THIS STATE
LONG TERM INSURANCE PLAN WITH
THE INDIVIDUAL CONTRIBUTION ARE
YOU AWARE OF ANY OTHER STATES
SORT OF --
TAKEN ON AN INNOVATIVE PROGRAM
LIKE THIS I DON'T KNOW IT SEEMS
LIKE SOMEBODY MUST HAVE BUT I IN
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IT I HAVEN'T
HEARD.
THOSE EXAMS DOCTOR WILBUR MY NO
THAT'LL BE AFFORDED WHICH WAS A
WAY TO FUND LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE.
IT WAS THE FIRST THING TO GO
BECAUSE THE THE NUMBERS DIDN'T
WORK AL THAT WELL.
SO AGAIN I THINK THIS.
THIS IS A HUGE CHALLENGE AND ONE
OTHER THING IS THAT.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO ENSURE
AGAINST FACILITY PLACEMENT OF SO
THE PRODUCT NEEDS.
TO INCLUDE HOME COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES BUT HOW MUCH DO THOSE
COSTS IN HALF HOW DO YOU MANAGE
THAT SO I WISH I COULD.
BE MORE HOPEFUL AND SAY YEP --
MINNESOTA DOESN'T HERE'S HOW IT
IS IT WORKS GREAT BUT WELL WE
LIVE THE GOLDEN STATE AND I
THINK OUR OUR OUR OUR CITIZENS
WHEN THEY REACH THEIR GOLDEN AGE.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO LIVE IN
DIGNITY AND IN CASE OF AND AND
NOT HAVE TO TO WORRY --
WHERE THE RENT CHECKS AND COME
FROM WHERE THEY'RE?
WERE THERE OTHER MONEY FOR THE
MEDICATIONS GOING TO COME FROM
THEIR FOOD --
SO YOU KNOW.
I'M I'M SOME TYPE OF A MASTER
PLAN THEY THEY GIVE SAID
ASSURANCES SO --
CEDARS CAN LIVE IN PEACE.
AND THEY'RE AND THEY'RE IN THEIR
AND THEIR GOAL AND THEIR GOOD
YEARS WHEN EXPOSED TO BE
ENJOYING THEIR LIVES.
I WILL TAKE THIS BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND SEE I'M SURE
THERE ARE THINGS THAT I'VE
MISSED AND IF I FIND SOMETHING
THAT'S PROMISING I'LL MAKE IT
AVAILABLE THANK YOU --
SO I WOULD JUST MAKE NOTE --
HEARING THAT LINE OF QUESTIONING
THAT ACTUALLY --
FIRST OF ALL I HAVE A BILL --
TO LOOK AT IN ACTUAL ANALYSIS IN
FACT AND WE ALSO HAVE A BUDGET
PROPOSAL INVESTMENT WE'RE GONNA
HERE LATER ON TODAY.
THAT LOOKS AT THIS VERY ISSUE SO
IT'S ASKING FOR A BUT A JAZZ
ALLOCATION TO DO A FEASIBILITY
ACTUAR ANALYSIS OF BASICALLY
FINING FINANCE YOU'LL TO SUPPORT
FINANCING SERVICES OPTIONS
AROUND A LONG TERM CARE.
AND SO FORTH SO --
I REALIZE IT'S A TOUGH NOT IT'S
ONE THAT WE WANT TO TRY TAKE ON
SO THAT --
WE CAN HELP THE THEIR SUPPORT --
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THIS BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW OUR CURRENT OPTION IS
SPEND DOWN ON MEDI CAL AIMED AT
THAT THAT SAID AND TWITTER.
ESSENTIALLY THE STATE IS PAYING
YOU KNOW FOR AT A GOOD JOHNNY ON
THE HALF IN THE FEDERAL AND ITS
IT'S AND BASICALLY.
WE EXPECT FAMILIES TO DRIVE
HIMSELF IN THE POVERTY FIRST.
AND THEN --
AND AND THAT AND THEN WE BUT IN
AN INSTITUTION SO --
WHEN WE WERE TRYING --
TO GROW STRAIGHT CREEL OPTIONS
SO IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THIS IS
ATION SO ANYTHING WE LOOK THE
MASTER PLAN WILL LOOK AT THESE
WELL LOOK SAID FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE VISION IS AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION SAYING.
RIGHT SO WHAT WHAT IS A WHAT WE
WHAT WE WANT TO DO AND THEN
THINK ABOUT HOW WE GO ABOUT
GETTING THERE CERTAINLY THIS IS
ONE THE STEPS WHILE LOOK AT IS
HOW CAN WE HELP.
BETTER --
FINANCING OPTIONS THAT --
WORK FOR OKAY S. FAN YOU CAN
HAVE SELF SELECTION AT EIGHT
IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE TO SAY WE CAN
ONLY DEPEND ON THE PEOPLE WHO
THINK THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO
THEM SO.
FAR WE HAVE TO LOOK AT NINE ONE
ONE MORE THING.
SO -- IT
USED TO BE THAT YOU HAVE A CUTE
PRIMARY CARE AND LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AND YOU
SEE THOSE COMING TOGETHER AND WE
SEE WAYS THAT WE CAN SAVE ON THE
ACUTE CARE SIDE OF COURSE.
THAT'S MEDICARE --
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S SOME
REALLY GOOD WORK COMING OUT OF
BROWN THAT SHOWS THAT.
HOME DELIVER NUTRITION PROGRAMS
SAVE HOSPITALIZATIONS.
SO IT'S SORT OF THINKING ABOUT
WHERE ARE THE DOLLARS THAT COULD
BE DEVOTED IF WE HAD.
A BETTER INTEGRATION OF FUNDING
TO SUPPORT OF LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS.
QUESTION SENATOR TADA YES MISTER
CHAIR.
SO A MISMATCH I WAS JUST TRYING
TO GET A CENTER NAY MENTION THE
THREE STEPS --
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON DO YOU
HAVE A SENSE OF TIME OF WHEN YOU.
CAN PLAN ON COMPLETING THIS OR
IF IT'S JUST AN ONGOING THING
JUST WANT TO GET MORE OF AN
UNDERSTANDING OF OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE AND I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I THINK THE THE
THINGS THAT I OUTLINED OR THINGS
THAT ARE IN.
PROGRESS NOW WE HAVE TO MOVE
QUICKLY THE GOVERNOR HAS --
HAS MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT WE
HAVE THIS IS NOT ACT.
THE MULTI YEAR EFFORT THIS HAS
TO HAPPEN VERY QUICKLY SO I
THINK WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS AND MONTHS WE WILL BE
ENGAGING BOTH STAKEHOLDERS
LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS. TO
REALLY THINK THOUGHTFULLY ABOUT
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE IT LOOKS
LIKE AND IT CAN BE A DRAWN OUT
PROCESS THAT TAKES YEARS IT HAS
TO BE WE HAVE TO MOVE QUICKLY ON
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU FOR BEING HERE I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND MAKE NOTE OF THE
WORK THAT --
FORMER SERIK CAROL LOU DID --
SHE HAS SELECT COMMITTEE ON
AGING I THINK SHE PRODUCED THIS
CHART WHICH SHOWED ALL THE
VARIOUS DIFFERENT PROGRAMS OUT
ONE HAND YOU GO LOOK AT IT YOU
SEE ALL THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
AT THE OTHER HAND.
THERE'S A LOT MISSING ELEMENTS
RIGHT.
AS WELL AND SO --
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE THE BILL
DEVELOP A VISION AND THEN FIGURE
OUT HOW IT'S THAT SITTING THERE
SAYING WHAT SILOS DO WE HAVE AND
I THINK WE HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
THE CONVERSATION WE TALK ABOUT
FARM AGING WE ARE BY AN S..
P. AND RESIZE WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
THIS PIECE BUT THERE'S A MEDI
CAL PIECE WHICH WILL BE HEARING
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE LATER ON AND
AND THOSE.
TO MEET RIGHT AND BUT THEY'RE
BEING HEARD DIFFERENT TIMES AND
SO FORTH SO --
ISN'T ACTUALLY DISPOSSESSED A
MASTER PLAN THAT'S GOOD --
THAT'S AND I APPRECIATE WE NEED
TO MOVE SPEEDILY ON THIS --
SO HOW HOW.
HOW DO YOU TREAT THIS VISION FOR
IT IS EVIDENCE BASED VISION --
FOR FOR AGING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I MEAN IS THERE A
PARTICULAR --
DEAL IS THERE A PARTICULAR STATE
OR OTHER NATION THAT WE LOOK AT
THAT IT'S DONE THAT BEFORE WE
PLOWING WE GOT TO BUILD THIS
WE'RE PLOWING NEW GROUND FOR
CELLS I WAS WE HAVE UNITARY
CALIFORNIA CHARACTERISTICS AS
WELL.
HOW HOW HOW DO YOU ENVISION THE
PROCESS FOR DOING THAT I
APPRECIATE THE SPEED PART BUT WE
ALSO HEARD ABOUT WE NEED TO
ENGAGE?
THE THAT.
THEY ON SENIORS WE NEED TO DO
REACHED THERE'S A PART THE STATE
IT CETERA.
ALL THAT TAKES SOME TIME SO I
I'VE USED THE FINAL LAB RATE ON
WHETHER THERE'S EXISTING WORK
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING TO BUILD ON
AS WELL AS WHAT KIND OF THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND THAT
FROM.
YEAH SO MAYBE I CAN START CENTER
I THINK YOU MAKE A REALLY GOOD
POINT I THINK THAT.
YOU REALLY --
OUR PROGRAMS ARE SILO IT BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO DO THAT AT A
NECESSITY BECAUSE GOVERNMENT
THAT'S HOW GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS
BY.
LIKE I NOTED THAT'S NOT HOW
PEOPLE'S LIVES WORK AND SO WE
HAVE TO REALLY THINK
HOLISTICALLY ABOUT.
IF PEOPLE ARE COMING TO OUR
AGENCY AND COMING THROUGH FIVE
DIFFERENT OORS AND PROVIDING
THE SAME INFORMATION FIVE
DIFFERENT TIMES AS OUR MORE
INNOVATIVE WAY FOR US TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE DELIVER THOSE
SERVICES --
AND I THINK THAT THAT WE NEED TO
PUT ON STEROIDS THAT
CONVERSATION WE HAVE TO PUT ON
STEROIDS AND THINK REALLY
THOUGHTFULLY ABOUT WHAT WE DO
THERE -- IN
TERMS OF THE MASTER PLAN I THINK
THERE IS BOTH STUFF THAT HAS
HAPPENED OR A WORK THAT HAS
HAPPENED BOTH WITHIN GOVERNMENT
AND OUTSIDE OF GOVERNMENT.
DR WILBUR'S WORK ON CARE GIVING
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
DONE PHENOMENAL WORK ON THIS WE
HAVE TO BUILD ON TOP OF IT
THERE'S NO NEED TO RECREATE THE
WHEEL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I THINK WE
HAVE TO ESTABLISH METRICS THIS
ISN'T GONNA HAPPEN OVERNIGHT WE
HAVE TO ESTABLISH METRICS AROUND.
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO ACHIEVE
PERHAPS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
AND REALLY HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE BOTH.
BROUGHT ON THE PRIVATE SIDE AND
THE PUBLIC SIDE TO SAY HOW ARE
WE MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS US
METRICS --
AND SO I THINK PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN IS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT WHAT DOES --
HEALTHY AGING LOOK LIKE IN THE
STATE AND IT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO THE
COAST.
BUT WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT A
MORE HOLISTICALLY AND THEN SET
THOSE PARAMETERS SO THAT WE CAN
BE MEASURING TOWARDS THEM OVER
TIME.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT LONG TERM CARE BE
SOMEHOW.
PUT IN WITH MEDI CAL IS PART OF
THE IF THEY SIT DOWN AT THE
TABLE AND YOU KNOW UP.
PUT IT IS PART OF THE MEDI CAL
BENEFITS SORE HOWEVER WASTE THE
GOVERNMENT DOES IT.
IF NEEDED.
EVERYBODY'S NOT GONNA LIVE AND
WHEN YOU PAY INTO A LONG I HAD A
LONG TERM CARE POLICY WHEN I WAS
YOUNG.
BUT YOU CAN'T COULD TOO BECAUSE
I HAD THREE KIDS RIGHT.
AND MYSELF THE HOUSE TO COLLIDE
IN.
IN TIME IN LIFE SELL IT I'D I
DIDN'T CONTINUE IT SO ALL THE
MONEY YOU PUT INTO A LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE.
WHO IS A GO IS HIS GUN RIGHT?
RIGHT [inaudible]
NOT.
GONE.
YES WELL AT THE AGE THAT STOCK
TO ENSURE ANY GOES INTO A POOL
WHICH THEN RIGHT --
SOME OF IT NAY VI YOU NEVER USE
IT.
RIGHT IF YOU DIE.
WHICH WE KNOW WILL YOU FEET IF
YOU DON'T NEED TO GO INTO A LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY THEN.
THAT IS THAT RIGHT WELL AT THE
THE WITHOUT GOING TO BED TO THE
BACK AND FORTH SO FIRST OF ALL --
THE AND ACTUALLY --
MEDI CAL THOSE GRAYSON WITH
MEDICARE THAT WE WANT TO THINK
ABOUT.
BECAUSE FOR SENIORS MEDICARE
STARTS OPINION IS BEING THE MAIN
PAYER FOR HEALTH CARE --
AND THEN WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT INSURANCE.
YOU DO COUNT ON THE FACT THAT IF
YOU DO THAT IN AN INSURANCE POOL
THAT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
HAVE GREATER NEEDS EL AND SOME
PEOPLE OF LESSER NEEDS.
RIGHT AND WE DON'T KNOW AND AND
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHO IT'S
GOING TO BE BUT THAT YES I MEAN
YOU DO NEED A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE
OF PEOPLE LEE DON'T NEED IT BUT
THEY BOUGHT IT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
NEED IT --
AND THERE'S A PEOPLE WHO END UP
NEEDING AND THAT'S HOW YOU
AVERAGE THAT'S HOW YOU SOCIALIZE
AVERAGE OUT THE COSTS AMONGST
EVERYONE.
RIGHT SO FOR EXAMPLE SO SECURITY
PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT LENGTHS OF
TIME IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
YEAH THAT IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW YOU
LEFT HE LIVES.
YET EVEN LIVE AS LONG THAT.
THERE BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO PAY
FOR THE PEOPLE LIVE LONGER SO SO
ANYTIME WE TALK ABOUT INSURANCE
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT WE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW TO
WHAT DEGREE DO WE LIMIT THE
AMOUNT OF PROFITS OR OTHER TYPE
THING TO GET THE WORD OUT THE
POOL.
BUT YOU DO NEED TO PULL IN ORDER
TO MAKE IT SUSTAINABLE OTHERWISE
OTHERWISE EVERYONE'S BACK TO
PAYING FOR THEMSELVES RATE SO
LOW I NEED DOCTOR IF YOU HAVE TO
PAY FOR IT I DON'T NEED AT ALL
THEY DON'T PAY FOR IT AND THEN.
THE PROBLEM THERE IS THAT PEOPLE
CAN'T AFFORD.
YEAH MOST PEOPLE AREN'T
MINNESOTA FINANCIAL POSITION TO
PAY FOR ALL THEIR LONG TERM CARE
THEMSELVES WE DON'T FIND A WAY
TO CREATE A POOL.
SORRY FOR THE LONG TALKED BUT
NOW YOU SAY.
LONG TERM CARE IS IT IT IS PART
OF MEDI CAL WE THAT'S CERTAINLY
A SUBSTANTIAL PART OF OUR MEDI
CAL BUDGETS PAYING FOR LONG TERM
CARE AND ALSO OF COURSE WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT AYE HSS
TODAY AND OTHER.
SO WE DO HAVE WE DO PAY THROUGH
MEDIC HOW FOR DIFFERENT SERVICES
HOPEFULLY MANY OF THEM WE
ACTUALLY WANT TO SUPPORT MORE
BECAUSE THEY KEEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES AND OUT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS WHICH ARE MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE.
YES.
QUESTION ABOUT HOW DO WE GET TO
THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING I THINK
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY IS OUTLINED
SOME REALLY NICE STEPS AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE IS COMPONENT TO
THAT.
MAKING SURE WE HAVE STAKEHOLDERS
AT THE TABLE.
AND WE NEED TO THINK OF THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO PRIVATE PUBLIC
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BUT ALSO THE
FEDERAL FUNDING SIDE THE STATE
FUNDING SIDE AND LOCAL FUNDING
SITE WHICH IS A HUGE PIECE OF IT.
SO THAT SHOULD BE PART OF IT --
I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT.
THIS NEEDS TO BE A LIVING PLAN
AND EVOLVING PLAN BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET IT RIGHT IN A
YEAR.
OR EVEN TWO YEARS IT'S WAY TOO
HARD TO DO THAT.
AND SO MANY TIMES I'VE SEEN
GREAT PROJECTS THAT NEVER LAUNCH
BECAUSE WE SPEND ALL THIS TIME
TRYING TO GET IT RIGHT.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE DO MAKE TIME OF THE ESSENCE
AND PUT SOMETHING IN PLACE WITH
THE ADMISSION UP FRONT THAT THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE TO CHANGE BUT
WE NEED TO START TAKING ACTION.
IF WE MAKE IT ACCOUNTABLE THEN
THOSE CORRECTIONS AND THAT
EVOLUTION WILL NATURALLY BE
BUILT INTO IT SO RELEASE A
SIMPLE TO DO THAT BUT I JUST
WANT TO URGE THAT THE IMPORTANT
THING IS WE DO SOMETHING.
NOT WAIT FOR PERFECTION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY WELL I'D AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE --
EVERYONE PRESENT HERE THIS IS --
WE'RE TRYING TO WATCH IT IS ONE
THING I WOULD MAKE NOTE --
IS IS THAT --
I APPRECIATE YOU SAID THAT THIS
INVOLVES FEDERAL STATE LOCAL AND
FOR EXAMPLE --
JUST RAISE YOUR TO BUDGET SUB
HEARING YOU KNOW AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AN S. S. P..
THAT'S COMING FROM A DIFFERENT
PART OF MONEY MONEY THAT FROM
THE FED START COMING THROUGH
RIGHT AND SO --
SO WE ALSO TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WHAT WE HAVE FEDERAL SILOS
FUNDING SILOS THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH AND WILL.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T.
YEAH OF COURSE FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BRIDGE THOSE THAT WILL GET THINK
HOW IS A STATE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO MANTA AND THEN ALSO
PERHAPS LEAN ON SOME OF OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO GIVE US THE
KIND OF FLEXIBILITY. TO BE ABLE
TO PROCESS SALAS TO MAKE MORE
EFFECTIVE USE OF OUR FUNDS AS
WELL SO.
I THINK I APPRECIATE THAT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE THE GOVERNOR
IN THIS --
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH SAID ADMINISTRATION
CERTAINLY HERE IN THE SENATE
THIS IS A HIGH PRIORITY I KNOW --
CENTER TODD DOES CHAIR OF THE
HUMAN SERVICES --
I UNDERSTAND IT'S A PRIORITY THE
OTHER SPEAK FOR HERSELF IT'S SO --
AND AND AND A IS THAT NO THAT
THE CENTER STONE --
IS OUR VERY GOOD FRIEND FROM
ACROSS THE ISLAND.
SO THIS IS A BIPARTISAN OF
PRIORITY WITH ALL OF YOU --
AND AND AND BE SURE WE TAKE CARE
OF PEOPLE THAT IS FOR THEM SAID
MANY TIMES BEFORE WE'RE ALL
GOING TO BE IN THE SAME POSITION.
HOPEFULLY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
OKAY SO NEXT ITEM WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO NOW IS THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE --
SO [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO WE CAN BRING UP PLAIN OF
SERVER HERE.
RIGHT HE IS PRESENTING HAIR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ACTUALLY ISSUES IS PRESENTING
HERE A NAME PERSON HERE.
OKAY YES SO --
THE BRING UP THE SEE LEGISLATURE
OF THE LA OWN FINANCE STAFF OKAY
AND SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
HAVE EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES THE RECORD AND THEN
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
THE PRESENTATION THE OVERVIEW
PRESENTATION.
SO IF YOU LIKE. TO FOR THE
RECORD --
FOR YOUR MACHINE ABOUT JUSTICE
THANK YOU HELLO.
THANK YOU JACKIE BRAZIL ILIO.
JANIE BELL LA --
THANK YOU FINANCE WHISPERS WROTE
APARTMENT FINANCE YOU.
PLEASE BEGIN.
PARTICIPATE IN THE LONG TERM
CARE.
IT'S A CHALLENGE TO STAY.
IN LONG TERM CARE SO I'VE HAD TO
RESORT.
TO OUR COMPRESSING THE INFLATION
FACTOR.
IN ORDER TO STAY IN THAT PLAN MY
CONCERN IS I'M NOT SURE THE
PLANS CAN BE AROUND.
BY THE TIME BECAUSE I THINK THE
POOL JUST CAN CONTINUALLY SHRINK
AS PEOPLE NO LONGER CAN AFFORD
IT SO IT'S IT'S AWFULLY SCARY.
IN TERMS OF THAT SO I JUST SORRY
I WANTED TO DEVIATE FOR JUST A
MINUTE YEAH WELL THAT THAT'S
THAT'S WHY WE WANT TO DO A STUDY
IN THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE HAVE
A POOL THAT'S LARGE ENOUGH AND
KEEP IT LARGE ENOUGH RIGHT
EXACTLY.
EXACTLY TO POOL SIZES KEY YES
ALL RIGHT SENIOR LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN PAN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
THE U..
YOUR COMMITTEE TODAY.
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE A
STATE AGENCY CELEBRATING ITS
THIRTY EIGHTH YEAR ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS.
AN AGENCY THAT HAS OVER TWO
HUNDRED LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
SIGNED INTO LAW.
OVER THE SAME THIRTY EIGHT YEAR
PERIOD.
I'D LIKE TO START.
WITH A REMINDER THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE PRESENTED TO THIS
COMMITTEE A THREE YEAR FINANCING
PLAN.
AS PART OF A REFERENCE TO
CONTINUOUSLY CONTINUOUSLY FUN
CSL.
AIR AND REQUESTED TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
AS YOU RECALL.
OUR REQUEST FOR CONTINUES FUNNY
TO NOT MAKE IT OUT OF CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
SINCE THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
LEGISLATIVE SESSION CSL
SUBMITTED A PCP. FOR CONTINUOUS
FUNDING FOR INCLUSION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET.
BUT WE WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET.
WE HAVE CONTINUED OUR PURSUIT OF
CONTINUOUS FUNDING.
THROUGH THE FUNDING LETTER WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
CHAMPIONING OUR REQUEST. THREE
YEAR FINANCING PLAN.
THE PLAN NOTED ABOVE WITH THE
RESULT OF A TWENTY SEVENTEEN
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
THE ASSEMBLY CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET THE NUMBER ONE
REQUESTED DEAL WITH CSL IN LA
YOU KNOW WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO
FIND A SOLUTION TO THE FUNDING
OF CSL.
AS A RESULT OF THESE DISCUSSIONS
HE ALSO RESPONDED.
BY CURTAILING EXPENSES IN THE
ERROR IS A PRINTING POSTAGE.
AND HOUSE CSL CONDUCTS ITS
ANNUAL SESSION.
THE PLAN ALSO NOTED THAT THE
SEAL SO WAS TO IDENTIFY LARGER
DEPARTMENTS OR AGENCIES THAT
WOULD POTENTIALLY UP SORT.
CSL ACCOUNTING AND OTHER TGS
CONTRACTED WORKLOAD.
WELL THE CSO MET WITH OTHER
AGENCIES NO SOLUTIONS BEEN FOUND
TODAY.
THIS IS QUESTIONS CONCLUDED WITH
THE LEGISLATURE REQUESTING AT
CSL PROVIDE AN UPDATE TO THEM IN
JANUARY. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REGARDING A LONG TERM FINANCING
PLAN.
THAT'S WHAT I REFER TO AS THE
THREE YEAR FINANCING PLAN.
AT THIS DOCUMENTS ABOUT TEN
PAGES IN LENGTH.
ARE IN THE PLANTS HERE SO
REFERENCE TO CONTINUE TO RISE IN
SALARY AND BENEFITS AND FIXED
COSTS LIKE STATE FEES.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
THESE COSTS REPRESENTED 36%
TOTAL EXPENSES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE
TOTAL EIGHTY AND 69%.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WERE
PROJECTING THEY WILL TOTAL 76%.
THE JOB IS THE RESULT OF A A
RECENT VISIT BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
CONDUCTED A CYBER SECURITY AUDIT --
IN A LEARNING THIS THAT WILL BE
AUDITED IN THE FUTURE EVERY TWO
AND FOUR YEARS.
THAT'S THE THREE YEAR FINANCING
PLAN.
OUR AND PREPARE TO SPEAK TO THE
INCREASE FUNDING OUR ISSUE NOTED
IN THE AGENDA AS WELL OR TAKE
QUESTIONS YOUR RUN.
WHICHEVER YOU PREFER GERMAN OKAY
WELL -- WHEN
WE -- TO
START -- ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM ALEJO
ON THE OVERVIEW AND A THREE YEAR
PLAN.
JUST AS WAS MENTIONED --
AND SEE ESOS OPENING COMMENTS WE
WERE ASKED --
TO TWO YEARS AGO IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH TO LOOK INTO THE BUDGETING
AND THINGS THAT CAME UP DURING
THAT CONVERSATION WAR --
A PORT A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THE BUDGET WAS TIED TO THE SPECS
COSTS THEN CAME THIS
CONVERSATION OF WELCOME OTHER
DEPARTMENTS ABSORB THOSE FIXED
COSTS TO REDUCE COST PRESSURES
NCSL.
CONCERN --
STANDING ABOUT THAT OPTION WAS
EXPLORED BUT ISSUES OF A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WITH CSL
BEING A LOBBYING INSTITUTION AND
HOW -- FOR
FOR THAT ORGANIZATION TO BE
INCORPORATED ADMINISTRATION
COULD RAISE SOME ISSUES OF
CONFLICT OF INTEREST --
BUT WITH REGARDS TO THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL --
WELL IT'S NOT IT INCLUDED IN
JANUARY'S BUDGET AND JANUARY
BUDGET.
BASED ON THE COMMENTS IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE IS SOME PROPOSAL
BEING MADE. FOR POSSIBLE
CONTINUATION GENERAL FUND IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET IT IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY COMING IN FROM THE
TAX.
ACCOUNT --
TO FIND THEIR SOURCES BUT WE SAW
ON PREVIOUS YEARS THAT THAT
HASN'T NECESSARILY BEEN THE CASE
SO THIS CALL THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT ONGOING GENERAL FUND IT
WOULD JUST BE A MATTER OF
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES
[inaudible]
OKAY FINANCE.
YEAH JUST TWO QUICK THINGS ABOUT
JUST FOR THE RECORD AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SENIOR LEGISLATURE
SAFELY MAINTAINED ITS TAX CHECK
OFF STATUS.
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR CITIZEN VOLUNTARY TAX
CONTRIBUTION FUND.
AND AS NOTING THE ATTENDANCE
ABOUT NINETY ONE THOUSAND AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO WE'RE STILL
WAITING TO SEE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THAT HAS --
IT WAS FORWARD AND THE BILL
ITSELF MADE MANDATED 10% OF THE
REVENUES BE USED FOR MARKETING
CAMPAIGN I BELIEVE.
CSL HAS ALREADY SECURED --
SOMEONE TO DO THAT SO THERE'S
THAT ISSUE TO CONSIDER
AND THEN JUST FOR THE RECORD IN
APPROPRIATED FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
AND ALSO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ANOTHER ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION OF
TURN TO SEVNTY FIVE THOUSAND
THESE HAVE BEEN RE APPROPRIATED
AND IT'S ESTIMATED THAT --
FOR CURRENT YEAR FOR SO FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS
GENERAL FUND MONEY THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN APPROPRIATED SHOULD
COVER [inaudible]
YOUR EXPENDITURES [inaudible]
IN IN.
NOT TO GET TOO MUCH INTO THE
WEEDS SO EXACTLY.
WHAT DO YOU SPEND YOUR MONEY ON
TO HOW MUCH IS STAFF AND SO WE
HAVE THESE --
PRORATED FEES AND SALARIES AND
BENEFITS AND SO FORTH I'M JUST A
SELECT.
THERE WAS A YOUNG IT SO I MEAN
THAT IN TERMS OF HATS I'LL BE
STAFF HOW ME TELL ME PAID STAFF
MEMBERS EIGHT STAFF SO WE HAVE
OKAY SO WE HAVE SO BASICALLY
ISSUES OF ONE PAID STAFF RIGHT.
TO OF COURSE AS SALARY BENEFITS
AND THE OVERHEAD RELATE TO
HAVING A STAFF PERSON
[inaudible]
AND AND WHAT PORTION OF THE
BUDGET IS THOUGH.
WHEN PAID STAFF PERSON?
SO.
IN ROUND NUMBERS AT
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
OKAY SO THAT'S A HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR THE SALARY AND
BENEFITS QUESTION RIGHT AND THEN
THERE'S I ASSUME THERE'S MORE
BECAUSETHERE'S ALL THIS CONTEST.
THE CPS SERVICES RIGHT BECAUSE
ALL I PROFESSIONALS CC NPS
SERVICES.
IS.
SO.
I HAVE A TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET --
THAT.
I CAN WALK YOU THROUGH THAT OR
YOU MAY WANT TO VIEW IT YEAH SO
SO SO SO I GUESS I GUESS THE
COURT I AM SURE YET PAD FOR APPS
WITHOUT GAIN. TOO MUCH INTO THE
WEEDS BECAUSE OF OF IS IS THAT.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS THE FIXED COSTS
RELATED TO CENTURY THIS THE
CONSOLIDATED PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES STRAIGHT.
PORTION OF THE BUDGET RIGHT AND
THAT PARTS GROWING CORRECT
BECAUSE THE RED CAR.
AND SO I GUESS WITH.
AND I REALIZE THAT THEY ALSO WAS
ONE STAFF PERSON.
IT IS SO IT SO LICENSE THAT'S AN
AVERAGE STEPS --
THAT THERE'S YOU KNOW SOMEONE
CALCULATED AND SERVE AVERAGES
ACROSS THESE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
DEPENDING ON HOW BIG THEY ARTS
ADDRESS HOW DO YOU DETERMINE
THIS.
THIS RATE THE C. AND P. S. RATE
FOR FOR THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE
IN HOUSE AT CONTRAST WITH
SETTING IT.
FOR OTHER OTHER AGENCIES AND SO
FORTH.
SO THIS IS --
A UNIT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ALL THE
CONTRACTED FISCAL UNIT AND THE
SMALLER ENTITIES LIKE THE SENIOR
LEGISLATURE RIGHT EXPENSIVE THEY
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES AND I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH EXACTLY HOW THOSE
RATES ARE SET SO I HAVE TO WORK
WITH MY TGS COLLEAGUES ON
FINANCE --
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN INCREASING
FACTUALLY SPEAKING OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS.
AND SO THAT THE HAS BEEN A
PRESSURE AND THEN JUST THE STAFF
PERSON I THINK MAINLY FOCUSES ON
JUST DAY TO DAY TASKS AND ALSO
THE MODEL LEGISLATIVE SESSION SO
I DON'T KNOW IF.
IF HE PERSON IS THE EXPERIENCE
WITH THE TIME TO ALSO TAKE ON
THE ACCOUNTING FUNCTIONS IN THE
BUDGETARY FUNCTION VIA IN A GOOD
AND NOT SO MUCH SAYING THAT
THOSE FUNCTIONS SHOULD BE
SHIFTED TO THE ONE STAFF PERSON
BECAUSE AFTER THEY REQUIRE
MULTIPLE SKILL SETS.
I GUESS THE QUESTION I'D HAVE
AND IT AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND DETAILS CHALLENGE FOR
DTS KISSER THE TO TO ASSESS EACH
INDIVIDUAL SMALL AGENCY AND SEE
WHAT I MEAN LEGAL SERVICES DOES
THAT AGENCY REALLY NEEDS I'M
JUST THINKING LIKE.
THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE TYPE OF
ACTIVITIES ENGAGE IN OBVIOUSLY
YOU NEED SOME BASIC A COUNTY YOU
NEED SOME BASICALLY YOU'LL
SERVICES BUT I MEAN ARE THEY IN
A POSITION WHERE THEY GET SUED
ALIVE -- THE
A LOT OF LEGAL SERVICES IT'S
ADDRESS I'M JUST AND AND AND I
IT CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT DEL
AT THAT THAT'S WORK FOR D. G. S.
M. INTERNET THEY MAY NOT WHAT IT
MAY BE MORE EXPENSIVE TO GO
THROUGH AGENCY BY AGENCY AGENCY
TO FIGURE OUT WHILE.
THEY MAY VARY FROM ONE THE ONE
SO THEY JUST SAY OKAY WELL THIS
IS YOU KNOW THIS IS THE POOL WE
SPEND WE JUST DIVVIED UP.
FOUND SOME PROPORTION BASED ON
HOW BIG THEY ARE BUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT THERE'S
SOME WAY.
TO GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE WORK
THEY DO TO GET. TO DEAL WITH THE
C. AND P. S. A LOT OF THE
SERVICING ITSELF.
NOW THE ACCOUNT AND A LAWYER AND
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT AT SO I KNOW
THERE'S SOME.
WAY WE COULD WORK WITH THAT OR
NOT WELL MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
MAJORITY OF EXPENSES UNDER
ACCOUNTING AND SO FOR EXAMPLE
ALL THE MEMBERS WHEN THEY FLY
OKAY SO THAT'S ALL THEY DO ALL
THE REIMBURSEMENTS AND IT'S I
THINK THAT'S THE MAJORITY OF THE
WORK LOAD BUT THE SPECIFIC.
CALCULATIONS AT TGS YOU CHARGE
I'M NOT PERSONALLY FAMILIAR WITH.
AND DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANY
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO THINK ABOUT THAT AND I
REALIZE THIS VERY CONVERSATION
WITH THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE
MEMBERS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS.
TO ADDRESS OF THIS COSTS IN A
WAY THAT MIGHT REDUCE THE COUNTY
OVERHEAD LIKE I DON'T KNOW I
MEAN I I I I I DON'T WANT TO
TELL YOU HOW TO RUN YOUR
ORGANIZATION BUT IT'S KIND OF
LIKE OKAY WE JUST DO PER DIEM IS
WE DON'T DO REIMBURSEMENT.
SO THEREFORE IT'S IT OUT WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO PROJECT REVIEW ALL
THESE RECEIPTS AND SO FORTH I
HAVE NO IDEA SO.
I THINK THAT THE DIFFICULTY THAT
WE WE WE RUN INTO WITH THIS IS
THAT I MEAN THEY'RE STILL WALK.
RIGHT RIGHT SO SO TO THE EXTENT.
WE YOU KNOW IF IF IF THIS THE
THE CFS WASN'T YOU KNOW SERVICES
WEREN'T CHARGED.
TO THE AGENCIES THAT UTILIZE
THOSE SERVICES SO AS A RIGHT SO
SO IT'S REALLY JUST YOU KNOW
YOU'RE TAKING FROM ONE IN BUT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO.
PUT THE MONEY SOMEWHERE ELSE SO
IT IT BECOMES AND THEN WHEN
YOU'RE YOU KNOW.
CELLS DEFINITELY NOT THE ONLY
AGENCY THEY ARE SMALL --
AGENCY BUT WE WE CAN LOOK INTO
HOW THE DETERMINATION IS MADE
WHAT THOSE CFOS.
ARE HOW THOSE COSTS ARE
ALLOCATED AMONGST THE TO
AGENCIES THAT USE THOSE SERVICES.
I WILL GO OUT ON A LIMB AND SAY
I'M I'M PRETTY CERTAIN IT'S
THERE'S LIKE.
A IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
AMOUNT OF OF WORKLOAD THAT --
THAT TGS TAKES ON BUT WE CAN GET
YOU SOME --
SOME MORE INFORMATION
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HOW THAT
WORKS UNFORTUNATELY --
YEAH WE WOULD HAVE TO TALK TO
OUR D. G. S. CAR DOT COM PARTS
AT FINANCE OKAY WELL IN IN WE'VE
BEEN DOWN THAT ROAD WE WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH.
THE ORGANIZATIONS TERMS HOW THE
CALCULATION.
IS AND WHETHER THERE ARE
ADJUSTMENTS IN.
MY POINT IS.
THAT IT SEEMS LIKE [inaudible]
IT'S JUST.
EACH YEAR SOMETHING ELSE COMES
UP SO FOR EXAMPLE THIS YEAR.
OF CYBER AUDITS HAVE NOW BECOME
A PART OF OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
COST SO HERE WE HAVE. ONE ONE
OUR DESKTOP COMPUTER.
A ROUTER.
AIR AND WE'RE INVOLVED IN A
MAJOR.
CYBER ON IT THAT'S GOING TO NOW
BE OCCURRING EVERY. TWO AND FOUR
YEARS.
AT A COST IT'S CLEARLY GOING.
TO BE THE SIX FIGURE.
CATEGORY ARE SO.
EVEN IF I WAS THE GREATEST
PROMOTER.
I PT BARNUM AND I WAS ABLE TO
GENERATE MASSIVE INCREASES IN
TAX CHECK OFF I CAN'T STAY AHEAD
OF THE CONSTANT INCREASES THAT
OCCUR -- AS
A RESULT OF NEW PROGRAMS THAT
INTRODUCED OR SOMEBODY DISCOVERS
WHAT THEIR CSL WHERE YOU BEEN
ALL THESE YEARS IN TERMS OF FAR
CYBERSECURITY SO I I I'M NOT
SURE I MISTER CHAIR I'M EVER
GOING TO GET A HEAD OF IT AND
THEN THE CHALLENGES IS ALSO.
AS THE TAX LAWS CHANGE WHAT'S
GOING TO BE HAPPENING TO THE TAX
CHECKOFF PROGRAM AND THAT KIND
OF THING AS WELL SO I'M
CONSTANTLY --
AWAKE WITH WITH NEW CHALLENGES
IT SEEMS.
OKAY WELL --
YEAH I THINK I THINK THE OTHER
PART I KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS PART --
AS WELL AS IT IS PART OF ITS
LIKE YOU KNOW --
I KNOW AND WE'RE GONNA GET IT'S
A VERY QUICKLY TO YEAR --
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT BUT SOME
DOUBT THIS SO IT'S GOING TO ASK
AND RIGHT NOW.
EVENTUALLY IN SPECIALLY IF THE
CLINIC IF THE COUNTY TURNS DOWN
THE FUTURE LIKE OKAY WELL YOU
HOW HOW HOCKEY RAISE MONEY TO
SUPPORT YOURSELF THIS IS THAT
THE PEOPLE SEE VALUE IN THE
STATE NEED TO BE.
IT SAID THERE MEMBERS A SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
FUNDRAISING EIGHT ON AND HOW THE
HOW THE MEMBERS ARE ENGAGED IN
AND THEN SOME OF THAT THE TIES
OF STANDARDIZATION AND ALSO --
FOR FRANKLY --
WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE TO BE.
PART OF THE STATE WITH THE KIND
OF STATE OVERHEAD DOORS IT MAKE
MORE SENSE.
TO BE LIKE CREATE A SEPARATE
NONPROFIT AND PEOPLE CAN GIVE
AND GET RIGHT OFTEN MAYBE YOU
GET A LITTLE STATE SUBSIDY BUT
THEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT SEE TO READ THAT MEANS
YOU'D HAVE TO TAKE ON THIS TASK
YOURSELF AND CONTRACT WITH
WHOEVER YOU KNOW.
ACCOUNTANTS AND LAWYERS CITY
NECESSARY BUT DEBT WHETHER
THAT'S A A OF CHEAPER COST
STRUCTURE YEAR CYBERSECURITY
WILL BE THAT.
WILL BE AT YOUR OWN RISK INSTEAD
OF HAVING YOU KNOW THE REPORT
STATES STATE OF COURSE US DO
SOMETHING ACROSS THE BOARD SO.
I JUST NOT PROPOSING YOU DO THAT
RIGHT NOW I'M JUST THROWING THAT
OUT THERE BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A CHRONIC ISSUE THAT COMES
UP.
NOW EVERY YEAR EVERY TIME WE SO
THAT ALLOWS ME TO SEGUE TO THE
NICELY YES THAT'S SOMETHING I
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
TWO BILLS OF INVESTMENT YES.
TO THE REQUEST FOR A CONTINUOUS
FUNDING --
THE THREE YEAR PLAN NOT ONLY
IDENTIFY THE CHALLENGES FACING
CSL AND OUTLINED A SOLUTION AS
WELL.
IT INVOLVED A TWO PRONGED FUNDED
APPROACH THAT INVOLVED FUNDING
OF THE ADVOCACY EFFORTS AND WE
REFER TO IT AS ADVOCACY NOT
LOBBYING.
K. ARE LOBBYING REQUIRES
REGISTRATION ALL THAT KIND OF
EFFORT --
AND IT CAN FOR TAX PURPOSES IF
WE WERE A NON PROFIT --
WE'D BE IN A DIFFERENT CATEGORY.
AS WELL SO ANYWAY.
AND ALSO THEN FUNDING COSTS
INVOLVING ADMINISTRATION OF THE
STATE AGENCY.
USING GENERAL FUND THIS.
SO YOU HAVE A TWO TIERED FUNDING
PROGRAMMING YOU'VE BASICALLY.
FIRE WALL IF YOU WANT TO CALL IT
THE OF THE MINISTRY OF PEACE AND
THE AND THE ADVOCACY PIECE.
OF THE REQUEST FOR AN ONGOING
APPROPRIATIONS FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND THAT JUMPED
FROM OUR PREVIOUS YEAR BUDGET IS
TO TRIP IT MAINLY. TO THE CYBER
AUDIT EXPENSE.
AND AS OUR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET NOTES 76% OF OUR
COSTS.
INVOLVED SOVEREIGN BENEFITS
STATE FEES.
AND CITY T. AUDIT EXPERTS.
AS A FIRM REMINDER.
THE SALARY AND BENEFITS INVOLVED.
A STATE EMPLOYEE BEING ASKED TO
THEIR SALARY BENEFITS TO BE
FUNDED OUT OF DONATIONS.
IN MY MIND THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THAT.
OKAY -- THE
PROBABLY THE SAVING GRACE AT
THIS POINT IS THAT AN EMPLOYEE
IS NOT A UNION.
PERSON THERE ARE MANAGEMENT.
INDIVIDUAL SO BUT STILL THE
QUESTION IN MY MIND IS AND I
THINK A NUMBER OF PEOPLE ASK HOW
DO YOU FUND.
A STATE EMPLOYEE OUT OF
DONATIONS [inaudible]
OUR SO [inaudible]
IN CLOSING.
I THINK THE THREE YEAR PLAN HAS
IDENTIFIED A FUNDING APPROACH.
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE A STATE
AGENCY. TO FIND OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND CERTAIN
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE STATE THAT ARE CHARGED
TO BASICALLY.
MOST AGENCIES OF NOT ALL AGES
LIKE OUR OWN.
AND THEN FOR THE ADVOCACY PIECE
INVOLVING OUR LEGISLATOR VISITS
OUR ANNUAL SESSION SENT. TO BE
FUNDED OUT OF IT HAS BEEN
TRADITIONALLY FUNDED OUT OF THE
TAX CHECK OFF.
AND THEREFORE I AM REQUESTING
YOUR SUPPORT. FOR I REQUEST FOR
APPROPRIATE CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION IN THE AMOUNT OF
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
RIGHT ANY COMMENTS ON FROM LA --
ON THE PROPOSAL FINANCE PROPOSAL
OKAY --
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
IT'S COME UP THE MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH BURGER I AM
MOST CALIFORNIA'S SENIOR
LEGISLATOR I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I REPRESENT SACRAMENTO AND SIX
SURROUNDING RURAL AREAS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHEN I
WAS A SENATE FELLOW I GOT TO
MEET ASSEMBLY MEMBER HENRY
MELLOW.
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF THE CSL
LEGISLATION.
HE WAS A VISIONARY.
HE THOUGHT THAT THE PEOPLE THAT
LIVED THE PROBLEMS SHOULD SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS.
AND THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
CSL EXISTS. TO LET SENIORS HAVE
A VOICE BECAUSE SENATOR PAN
THERE'S A LOT OF AGEISM IN THIS
BUILDING AND STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND IN OUR CULTURE IN GENERAL
AND I'M SPEAKING FROM SOMEONE
WHO WORKED HERE FROM SEVENTY
FIVE ENDED A CAREER.
IN GOVERNMENT AND HEALTH POLICY
CONSULTANT.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WAS GOING
EXPERIENCE AGEISM BUT I'M ALMOST
SEVENTY AND I HAVE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT A FEW GOOD
THINGS IT SEE A CELLS DOWN THERE
ARE MANY.
NUMBER --
ONE AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED BILLS
HAVE BECOME LAW BECAUSE OF CO
CELLS PROPOSALS LET ME GIVE YOU
A CURRENT.
ONE HOW ABOUT THAT SILVER ALERT
THAT'S HOW STERN CHP WHEREVER
THERE IS THE A SENIOR WHO GOES
MISSING FOR SUSPICIOUS OR
UNEXPLAINED REASONS.
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL THAT'S JUST
ONE PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
SEE A CELLS DONE.
VERY QUICKLY --
I WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE ALWAYS WORKED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE --
ONE OF OUR SENIOR LEGISLATORS
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR GETTING THE
JOIN AUDIT LETTER THAT LOOKED AT
THE TUBS IN CAMPS FIRE BECAUSE
SO MANY SENIORS DIED IN IT WE
WANT TO HAVE FOCUS ON DISABILITY.
AN OLDER ADULTS IN THAT.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE DONE IN THIS TIME WHEN THE
SENIOR VOICES BEEN DIMINISHED
AND IS STARTING TO GET MORE
ATTENTION AND WE'RE THANKFUL FOR
THAT WE CANNOT LOSE ONE MORE
SENIOR ADVOCATE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TRY TO ASK PEOPLE TO KEEP THEIR
COMMENTS TO A MINUTE THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO SENATOR THANK YOU
WELL I'M SURE BECAUSE FIREWORKS
AND STATE INDEPENDENT LIVING
COUNCIL.
AND WE'RE AN ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS POLICY WORK THEM
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
OF ALL AGES ACROSS THE STATE WE
SUPPORT THE CSL AND IN THIS --
ASK AND WE PARTNER SKEWS ME
WHERE PARTNER CSL AND SUPPORT
THEIR OWN WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THE LARGE TEAM OF
VOLUNTEERS AND ONE EMPLOYEE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WELL A R. P. CALIFORNIA I JUST
WANT TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF OUR
PARTNERS O THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
MANY OF THE VOLUNTEERS HAVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT HAVE CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH LEGISLATORS.
ON WE MAY HAVE OUR OWN IDEAS WE
BRING BUT WE ALSO LOOK AT THE
THE GREAT BILL PROPOSALS A DAY --
BRING FORTH AS WELL SO WE URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT HIS BUDGET
PROPOSALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI CLAY CAM SENIOR COUNSEL --
I JUST ON THE HEELS OF OUR LAST
CONVERSATION JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT SENIOR ENGAGEMENT IN
ADVOCACY NEEDS TO BE PART OF THE
COMPONENT OF THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING SO I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING.
THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER NOT
PROCESS AS WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
JEFF TURNER GEAR APPLICANT OLDER
WOMEN'S LEAGUE.
SUPPORT OF THE SAME LITTLE
OUTSIDE THE BOX THAT BRINGS YOU
IDEAS THAT YOU STILL NEED TO
HEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE --
I THINK SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS --
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THE THIS --
I DON'T WANNA HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND US AS WE GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND I APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
SENIOR LEGISLATURE AND ALWAYS
ENJOYED --
MEETING WITH --
MY COUNTERPARTS --
IT IS WE THANKS VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD JUST
MAKE ONE CLOSING STATEMENT.
JR CSL WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THE FACT
EARLIER.
ARE WE HAVE A SOLUTION I THINK.
IN THIS THREE YEAR PLAN IN THIS
TWO PRONGED.
FUNDING APPROPRIATION SO --
I LOOK FORWARD TO SPEAKING AGAIN
TO IT END OF YOUR SUPPORT AND
FINDING A SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS
US TO ADVOCATE.
AND CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
SENIORS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH [inaudible]
BUT BOTH.
OKAY SO THE NEXT THE ITEM WILL
BE FROM SOCIAL SERVICES ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
THE NAMES DIFFERENCE FIRES THAT
TO HELP PEOPLE.
SO WE CAN HAVE THE PURPOSE
SOCIAL SERVICES HERE FROM A
DOCTOR SERVICES [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO EVERYONE CAN INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES THE RECORD OF START
WITH THE AGENCY FIRST WELCOME.
A FIGURE IT OUT EVENTUALLY THE
RED BUTTONS ON IT'S GOOD
[inaudible]
WE GO.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU HAVE
PETER MAKE A CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
I ON BEHALF OF OUR ACTING
DIRECTOR PAT LEARY IS WITH US
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO TALK
THROUGH THAN.
A REMAINING PROGRAMS IN YOUR
AGENDA TODAY THERE OBVIOUSLY OF
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT OF PEOPLE AS
YOU CAN TELL FROM --
THE CROWD BEHIND US SO WE'RE
GONNA DO THE INTRODUCTIONS FIRST
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE YOU GO HEAD
TO GET THE TESTIMONY.
DEBBIE THOMPSON --
DEPUTY DIRECTOR IT'LL PROGRAMS
FOR DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
RALLY CERTAIN HOUSING HOME
ASSISTANCE ALL RIGHTS BRANCH
CHIEF AT CDSS [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
JACKIE BRASILIA.
JANIE BELL L. L..
AND IT'S AN HMO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
YEAH ONLY THE VERY FINANCE.
THANK YOU WELCOME BEGIN.
THANKS I AM RATHER THAN REPEAT
WHAT I JUST SAID.
HI ALL JUST HANDED OVER TO
DEBBIE THOMPSON THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR VITAL PROGRAMS DIVISION
AND AGAIN THANK YOU.
AGAIN GOOD MORNING ARE ALMOST
AFTERNOON HERE --
I BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE HANDED
OUT -- UP
HER POINT THAT GIVES SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM --
UP I CAN.
DID YOU NOT GET IT.
YEAH ACTUALLY DO YOU HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE THE HANDLED THIS.
GET THEM ALL RIGHT OKAY --
I CAN BRIEFLY GO THROUGH WHAT'S
IN IT AND THEN RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS I WILL TAKE MUCH --
YEAH IF YOU CAN JUST BARELY HIT
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF STUFF WE DO
HAVE A GOOD WRITE UP IN OUR OUR
MATERIAL HERE THANK YOU.
AND WILL HAVE SEARCHES TESTS OF
THE UPPER WHICH GO AHEAD BEGIN.
HEY SO I'M JUST GONNA TELL YOU
WHAT'S IN IT AND THEN ANYTHING
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HAPPY TO
RESPOND.
TO SO BASICALLY THAT BEGINNING
GOES OVER.
AND HOW IT WAS AN ACTIVE.
AND THEN MOVES INTO A LITTLE BIT
OF INFORMATION ABOUT IT THE
REALIGNMENT OF APS FUNDING.
WHICH OCCURRED IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
EXPENDITURES THIS LAST YEAR WERE
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE POINT
NINE MILLION.
COMING UP FROM THE BEGINNING OF
REALIGNMENT WHEN THEY WERE AT
ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN POINT SEVEN
SO ABOUT A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE OVER THAT TIME PERIOD.
APS REPORTS THIS LAST YEAR
HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND
REPORTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR --
UP FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOR THE PRIOR YEAR.
THE NEXT GIVES YOU SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT REPORTS
RECEIVED CASES OPEN CASES
RESOLVED --
CHANGES SINCE THE LAST EAR.
THERE WAS A SLIGHT DIP AND THE
NUMBER OF CLIENTS WERE FOUND --
CONFIRMED --
VICTIMS.
A SLIGHT DIP SO THAT STATE
PRETTY STABLE FINANCIAL ABUSE
CONTINUES TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WE GET MORE MORE REPORTS ON
CASELOADS SLIGHTLY UP.
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PER WORKER --
LAST YEAR UP TO ABOUT TWENTY
SEVEN THE I STAFFING WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A SINGLE APS
LIAISON THAT.
IS --
HANDLES THE APS ACTIVITIES THAT
STILL REMAIN AT THE STATE AFTER
REALIGNMENT --
FOCUSED ON A REGULATIONS DATA
COLLECTION AND THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE TRAINING ACTIVITIES --
KNOWN WE PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION ON THE TRAINING
CONTRACTS THAT WERE DEVELOPED AS
A PART OF THE ONE TIME THREE
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING THAT WAS.
ON THE DONE IT BACK IT'S
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN ALONG WITH ALL
OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT WERE DONE
WITHOUT FUNDING WHICH WILL AND
OF THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR --
AND THEN IT.
GOES INTO THE ACL GRANT THAT WE
HAD GOTTEN BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THAT ALSO WILL END THIS
YEAR AND IT WAS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SOME NEW DATA
COLLECTION.
SO THAT HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED AND
THE COUNTIES ARE NOW COLLECTING
THAT DATA BEGINNINGJANUARY OF
THIS YEAR.
AND THEN A NEW ACL GRANT THAT WE
JUST GOT THIS YEAR THAT WILL BE
DOING TO ACTIVITIES ONE DOING
SOME DEVELOPMENT OF LEADERS
WITHIN THE APS PROGRAM TO DO
MORE.
ADVOCACY AROUND THAT PROGRAM AS
WELL AS TO INITIATE A PILOT.
OF A STIPEND PROGRAM FOR
INDIVIDUALS --
GETTING THEIR MASTERS IN SOCIAL
WORK TO FOCUS IN A PS AND THEN
DO A REPRINT READ PAYMENT BY
WORKING IN THAT PROGRAM FOR TWO
YEARS SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENS
WITH CHILD WELFARE.
SO THE THAT'S WHAT'S COVERED IN
HERE AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU
WANT MORE DETAIL ON I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANKS FROM ALEJO.
AND FINANCE NO.
QUESTIONS NO OKAY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MEET ALL RIGHT --
SO ACTUALLY SO WHERE THINGS.
A MAKE NOTE THAT YOU DO --
YOU HAVE THIS IMPROVE THE DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEM THE NATIONAL
ADULT MALTREATMENT REPORTING
SYSTEM.
AND IS SO THAT THAT'S ONLINE NOW
RIGHT SAID IN RUNNING NOW THAT
COUNTIES BEGAN COLLECTING DATA
IT WITH THIS FORMAT IN JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR OKAY.
AND THIS IS THIS --
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS LETS
YOU DEVELOP SOME.
SOME DE IDENTIFIED REPORTS TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RESIDENT OUT IS DO YOU SEE HOW
THIS THAT THE STATE IS GOING TO
BETTER INFORM --
FUTURE ACTIVITIES OF OF OF THE
AGENCY YES IS GOING TO GIVE US
SOME MORE DETAILED AND AN
AGGREGATE LEVEL GIVE US MORE
DETAIL PARTICULARLY ABOUT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR INDIVIDUALS
WHO THE IDENTIFIED VICTIM AS
WELL AS THE OUR IDENTIFIED.
SO NEXT THE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
MORE INFORMATION THAN WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO IN THE PAST IN IN IN A
STANDARD.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IN TERMS
OF THE TYPE OF SERVICES.
I MEAN YOU'RE SORT OF MORE DOING
LIKE THE BACK AND IN THE
OVERSIGHT PARKER IS IT MAINLY
HAPPENING AT THE COUNTY LEVEL OR
I GUESS SO IT WAS REALIGNED THE
COUNTIES ARE DOING MOST OF THE
ACTIVITIES THE THINGS THAT
REMAIN AT THE STATE OR KIND OF
THE GREATER.
POLICY OVERSIGHT REGULATION
DEVELOPMENT KINDS OF THINGS AS
WELL AS DATA COLLECTION
COORDINATING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT ARE MORE BROUGHT TO THE
STATE AS WELL AS WE DO CONTINUE
TO OVERSEE THE TRAINING
CONTRACTS AND GREAT SO I GUESS
IN TERMS OF ASSESSING HOW
COUNTIES ARE PERFORMING I'M SURE
MAY COUNTIES ARE DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB BUT A ARE YOU ABLE
TO ASSESS WHETHER JURORS --
THAT.
WERE EQUALLY MEETING STANDS
ACROSS THE COUNTY IS --
VERY AT THE DEGREE VARIATION --
IS FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY I
REALIZE COUNTIES ARE DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT SIZES WE HAVE LA WHICH
IS BIGGER MOST STATES TO HELP
COUNTIES THAT ARE.
FAIRLY A FAIRLY LOW SMALL
POPULATIONS THERE IS THERE'S
WHAT KIND OF WORK DO YOU DO. TO
TO TRY TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STATE GIVEN THE
UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS OF
DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
WELL WE GET THE DATA THAT TIED
IN ON A MONTHLY BASIS FROM ALL
OF THEM KIND OF SEE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND WHAT HAPPENING WITH
THOSE CASES SO THOSE OUTCOMES --
CERTAINLY THE TRAINING
ACTIVITIES --
THOSE BEING --
STATEWIDE AND PROVIDES FORMATION
AS WELL AS WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES AROUND.
ANY REGULATION AREAS THAT MIGHT
NEED.
UPDATING TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
THAT CONSISTENCY STATE WHY AND
AND YOU SEE IN TERMS OF
PARTICIPATION A TRAINING GUIDE --
FAIRLY EQUAL PROCESS.
THE IN TERMS OF THE
PARTICIPATION A TRAINING
GALLAGHER CONSISTENTLY ACROSS
THE STATE I MEAN YEAH --
SOME STATE AREAS AT THE TO SEE
MORE AND OTHERS ARE RIGHT AND
YET AND YET SO I DON'T LIKE IS
WHEN THE THINGS THEY JUST WANT
TO I'M CHECKING ON HIS ARM SEE
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT SERVICE --
THE UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WE HAVE
LOCAL CONTROL DIFFERENT COUNTIES
ARE DIFFERENT AT THE SAME TIME
WILL BE SURE THAT SENIORS NO
MATTER WHERE THEY LIVE IN THE
STATE.
ARE FOR THIS DEAL SIMILAR
PROTECTIONS RATE AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU DO SO --
ITSELF THERE ARE COUNTIES WHERE
THERE WERE FOR SOME REASON THEY
MADE A LESSER PRIORITY.
YOU KNOW THOSE THAT THERE THESE
ARE CERTAIN --
LEVEL PERFORMANCE THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING ON CERTAIN --
CERTAIN LEVEL STAFFING GIVEN THE
AGENT THE SIZE OF THE POPULATION
THEY HAVE THAT THAT'S HAPPENING
IN THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING.
THE TRAINEES AND SO FORTH AND A
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW SO IT'S
THE HARD TO GET FROM CERTAIN
PLACES THE STATE TO OTHERS.
AS WELL THE PAIN OR TRAINING
LOCATIONS ARE BY JUST IN TERMS
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION THE STATE'S
PERFORMING TOO SURE OF THAT --
SENIORS NO MATTER WHERE THEY
LIVE IN THE STATE EFFECTIVE
SERVICES --
THAT THEY NEED I WOULD CERTAINLY
SAY THAT THERE IS BEEN A GREAT
INTEREST AND PARTICIPATION IN
THE TRAINING STATEWIDE AND THAT
IT IS ALSO AVAILABLE MANY OF THE
ACTIVITIES OR A COURSES HAVE
ALSO AN ONLINE OPTIONS SO THAT.
FOR THOSE COUNTIES THAT MAYBE
MORE REMOTE THERE STILL IS THOSE
ACTIVITIES --
AND WE'VE SEEN A VERY POSITIVE --
DESIRE FOR THE COUNTIES TO
CONTINUE.
FINANCING THAT TRAINING AND ON
INTEREST IN PROVIDING THESE
SERVICES CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE
STATE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY AND ALL RIGHT SO --
I THINK --
WE DO HAVE --
ONE PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT --
SO I SHE WORLD.
AND I HAVE A SPEAKERS ARTISTS
THAT WE DO HAVE AN EMPTY CHAIR
HERE -- IF
THERE'S SO LET'S SEE WE HAVE A
SO ISSUE TO YEP PHOTO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
YOU HEAR.
OKAY IS HOW HOW MANY OF YOU ARE
GOING TO BE PRESENTING. TO OKAY
SO I'M GONNA MAYBE WE CAN A YOU
GUYS COULD SHIFT OVER JUST ONE
SHARE OUR OF WE CAN SEE IF
THERE'S A WE HAVE TO TEARS THAT
OKAY IT WAS JUST OVER BY.
ONE OKAY WELCOME IF PLEASE FIRST
OF ALL INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD AND BETWEEN THE TWO
VIEWS THREE MINUTES AND THEN WE
MAY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS WE GIVE
YOU MORE TIME TO TALK
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS VALERIE SMITH I MAY --
PROGRAM MANAGER WITH ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M SCARLET HUGHES I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION.
OF PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC
GUARDIANS IN PUBLIC CONSERVATORS.
DO I PRESENT A PROPOSAL AND OKAY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT TO CONTINUE TO GROW THE
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR A PS SOCIAL
WORKERS AND THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR GUARDIAN
CONSERVATORS.
OUR BROAD COALITION IS
REQUESTING FIVE POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS
OVER THREE YEARS.
THIS WORKS OUT TO BE JUST UNDER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
BUT IT LEVERAGES ANOTHER FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION IN FEDERAL
DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL INVESTMENT
OF TEN POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
UNTIL THREE YEARS AGO THE APS
TRAINING PROGRAM WAS SUPPORTED
BY A MERE EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IN STATE FUNDS.
THIS WAS NOT ENOUGH TO MEET --
NOT ONLY MY OWN STAFF TRAINING
NEEDS -- LET
ALONE ALL THE NEEDS OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY APS WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THERE WAS NO CON --
SKEWS ME THERE IS NO TRAINING TO
ONBOARD NEW SOCIAL WORKERS OR
NEW SUPERVISORS.
AND NO ADVANCE TRAINING TO
ADDRESS THE VERY COMPLEX AND
DIVERSE TYPES OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT THAT WE RESPOND TO ON A
DAILY BASIS.
WITH THE ONE TIME THREE MILLION
APS TRAINING INVESTMENT WHICH
GREW TO SIX MILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE FEDERAL MATCH OVER THESE
PAST THREE YEARS.
WE WERE ABLE TO TRAINER SOCIAL
WORK STAFF TO BETTER PROTECT
OLDER ADULTS.
AND VICTIMS OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
LADIES. FOR EXAMPLE MY STAFF NOW
HAVE INCREASED KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS TO CONDUCT INITIAL
INVESTIGATIONS ASSIST CLIENTS.
FOR DECISION MAKING CAPACITY
COMPLETE FINANCIAL ABUSE
INVESTIGATIONS ANSWER VICTIMS
WHO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE NEEDS.
WE BELIEVE THE TRAINING IS
CRITICAL TO PREPARING OUR APS
WORK FORCE TO PROTECT AND SERVE
OLDER ADULTS AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AS DEMAND FOR SERVICES CONTINUE
TO RISE WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OUR ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS THE
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR GUARDING
THINK CONSERVATIVES IN THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES AND WE'RE THE
CERTIFYING BODY LEGALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
ACCREDITATION.
OUR MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPERIOR COURTS TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MOST
IMPAIRED ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THERE IS STATES.
I TOO AM REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT
TO CONTINUE THESE FUNDS PRIOR TO
THREE YEARS AGO OUR MEMBERS
NEVER RECEIVED ANY TYPES OF
TRAINING FUNDS EVEN THOUGH
CERTIFICATION IS LEGALLY
MANDATED FOR THEM.
TRAINING WAS LIMITED TO ONE
THREE AND A HALF DAY CONFERENCE
HE YEAR AND MANY MEMBERS COULD
NOT AFFORD TO ATTEND REGULARLY.
THE TRAINING FUNDS ALLOWED US TO
DELIVER THIRTY ADDITIONAL
TRAININGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND PROVIDED OUR MEMBERS WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATION HOURS DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVING THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
ABILITY TO MANAGE THE RISE.
AND REALLY DIFFICULT CASES OUR
MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED TO TAKE
OVER THE PERSONAL DECISION
MAKING OF OUR CLIENTS WHOSE
RIGHTS. FOR TO SELF
DETERMINATION HAVE BEEN REMOVED
BY THE COURTS.
AS A RESULT OUR MEMBERS MUST BE
TRAINED IN A WIDE RANGE OF
TOPICS COVERING ALL ASPECTS OF
LIFE.
INCLUDING DECISIONS CONCERNING
CEMENT MEDICATION END OF LIFE
DECISIONS AND OUR MEMBERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING CLIENTS
PERSONAL INCOME AND ALL OF THEIR
FINANCIAL AFFAIRS.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH ANY
COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS FROM THE
AGENCY ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL.
NOW OKAY LA --
ANY.
FINANCE.
OKAY -- SO
ACTUALLY JUST TO CLARIFY I
UNDERSTAND THAT --
AND THERE'S SOME FUNNY PROVIDE
FOR TRAINING IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
DEBTS EXPIRING AND SO.
WORD TO WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THAT AND AND YEAH PLEASE.
THAT'S CORRECT A SO TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN IT WAS A THREE YEAR ONE
TIME AND RIGHT BUYERS THIS YEAR.
AND IN YOUR POWER POINT IT
COVERS ALL THE DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES AND AS RIGHT IT'S
DESERVE PROPOSAL TO CONTINUING
OF THAT TRAINING OR NOT.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS EXACTLY THE TIME SAYS.
I GUESS THAT'S ON POSING THE
QUESTION IS ARE LIKE WELL THE I
MEAN IT WAS USEFUL I MEAN I
HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT EIGHT THIS
IS WONDERFUL RIGHT NOW LIKE WELL
THEN WE I'D ASSUME THAT WE'RE
STILL HAVING YOU SOCIAL WORKERS
RIGHT.
YEAH OKAY SO SO IS I I REALIZE
THAT IT'S IT'S NOT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YOU CAN'T SAY
YEAH I'M FOR IT OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BUT I DISLIKE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAD A TRAINING
PROGRAM IT WAS VERY.
SUCCESSFUL RIGHT.
PEOPLE SAID IT WAS GOOD RIGHT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT FELT WAS
USEFUL RIGHT.
OKAY THAT'S GOOD SO SO WE SHOULD
GIVE CONSIDERATION TO CONTINUING
IT PERHAPS OKAY.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO PROPOSAL TO
CONTINUE IT CORRECT AT THE
MOMENT OKAY ALL RIGHT.
YOUR COMMENT ON THAT.
JUST GOING TO POINT OUT YOU
MIGHT HAVE AN INFO GRAPHIC
PRINTS THAT TAUGHT US ABOUT SOME
OF THE TRAININGS --
WITH THE THREE MILLION IN --
TRAINING FUNDS THAT WE HAD WE
ARE ABLE TO DO BOTH ONLINE AND
IN PERSON TRAININGS --
AND THE THE ONLINE HELPFUL
BECAUSE IT REDUCE THE TRAVEL
EXPENSES FOR PEOPLE SO --
AT WE ALSO --
WERE ABLE TO CREATE A CORE
CURRICULUM THAT MEANT CRITERIA --
FOR NATIONAL ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES CERTIFICATE --
AND THOSE TRAININGS WERE --
THAT NEEDED IN ORDER TO MEET
THAT CRITERIA AND SO WE'VE BEEN
ABLE -- TO
CERTIFY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE A PAST WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE --
SINCE THOSE FUNDS OKAY
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL THE AND DO
YOU DEBT AT AND HOW MANY I MEAN
GIVEN.
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW THE
ANSWER ME GIVEN THE NATURE OF
TURN OVER EXPANSION IRENE YOU
PEOPLE AT CENTER --
I MEAN HOW HOW MANY PEOPLE OUT
THERE DO YOU THINK THAT THEY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE TRAINING
YET THE FIRST THREE YEARS THAT
WOULD NOW NEED THE TRAINING IF
THIS WAS AVAILABLE.
IT'S HARD TO SAY BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED EVERY COUNTY IS
DIFFERENT HOWEVER --
WE HAVE THE NUMBER THAT THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY APS SOCIAL WORKER OR
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE.
SO IF ONLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
OR A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
WERE ACTUALLY MEANT THE DID ALL
THE COURSE CURRICULUM FOR THE
CERTIFICATION YOU CAN SEE THAT --
OTHER WORKERS MAY HAVE DONE.
SOME OF THE TRAININGS BUT MAYBE
NOT AS MANY AS THE CERTIFICATION
OKAY THEIR CERTIFICATE EXCUSE ME
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS ALL
RIGHT WELL WITH THAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BOTH THE OVERVIEW AND
AS WELL AS THE PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT --
WELCOME AGAIN TRY TO KEEP TO A
MINUTES AND THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR --
MONICA MILLER REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY ALAMEDA MORE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS OP INVESTMENT WE THINK
IT REALLY WE SEE IT WORKING IN
OUR COUNTY WE THINK IT'S REALLY
BENEFICIAL WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE ON PROVIDE THIS FUNDING
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO BE CENTERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AS WELL AS
SEIU STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE PROPOSAL TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR A P. AS SOCIAL WORKER
TRAINING THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THESE TRAINING
FUNDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
KELLY BROOK SOME BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE TO SUPPORT ON
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
TRAINING AND HAPPY TO SEE THE
ADDITION OF PUBLIC GUARDIAN
PUBLIC CONCERT OR SOME PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
DOESN'T GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES COUNTIES
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN SERVING
OUR GROWING AGING POPULATION AND
PREVENT TEEN --
ABUSE AND NEGLECT IN THIS
TRAINING FUNDS HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY USEFUL AND VALUABLE
AND SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
CONTINUING EXPANDING THEM SO
THAT --
COUNTIES BOTH THREE PS INTO
PUBLIC GUARDIANS CAN PREVENT
ABUSE AMONG THE SLUMBER
POPULATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CAROL SCHOOL REPRESENTING THE TO
CO SPONSOR ORGANIZATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
AND THE CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION --
A FACTOR THAT IS OFTEN
OVERLOOKED IN THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT FUNDING A PS IS THAT MANY
OF THE SOCIAL WORKERS WHOSE
STAFF FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
DID NOT GET GERONTOLOGY
EDUCATION WHILE THEY WERE GOING
THROUGH COLLEGE OR EVEN GRADUATE
SCHOOL --
THERE ARE STIPENDS TO DO CHILD
WELFARE SERVICE BUT THERE ISN'T
THAT BENEFIT FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO GO INTO AGING.
SO MANY PEOPLE DON'T AND THEY
FALL INTO THAT FIELD LATER.
MAYBE GOING FROM CHILD%
PROTECTIVE SERVICES INTO A PS
LATER THIS TRAINING IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE WORKING WITH THE ELDERLY
AND WORKING WITH AUTONOMOUS
POPULATIONS.
WHO HAVE A CHOICE AND WHO HAVE
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT THING --
ADDITIONALLY THE FACT THAT --
APS ALSO DEALS WITH AND
FINANCIAL CRIMES CHANGE AND
EVOLVE DALY.
SO TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
CURRENT ONGOING TRAINING IS
ESSENTIAL.
AND TO THINK THAT WE WOULD LET
THAT GO AFTER WE'VE DEVELOPED
THIS AMAZING CREDIT CURRICULUM
WOULD JUST BE HEARTBREAKING I
BELIEVE SO.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT ALSO CSE
FULLY SUPPORT THE PUBLIC
GUARDIAN PUBLIC AUTHORITY PUBLIC
CONSERVATIVE --
AND THEIR INTEGRAL ROLE IN THIS
PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THESE ARE COMMON ON CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION WE STAND A VERY
STRONG SUPPORT I DEPENDING ON
HOW THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IS
SITUATED --
WE COULD BE.
IN THE SPHERE WITH APS WORKERS
AND APS TRAINING WAS VERY
GENEROUSLY OFFERED TO OMBUDSMAN
AS SO I BELIEVE THIS IS ART
ANOTHEREXAMPLE OF THAT
REINFORCING OF A SPOKE IN THE
WHEEL.
AND THE PUBLIC GUARDIAN PROGRAMS
ARE ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL NEED
ROBUST SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
WELCOME FIND IN A WHILE THE HER
WELL A. R. P. CALIFORNIA AND
JUST WANT TO SAY WE STAND IN
SUPPORT WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITIONTHE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN IN SUPPORT
OF THE APS.
TRAINING ASK THANK YOU THANK YOU
WELCOME.
AS MORE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS --
WE SUPPORT THIS AND THE
WITNESSES THANKS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
AB MARTHA GREW A REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTED THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES --
TRADING PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
JEFF TURNER KIA.
PUBLIC ABDICATE.
HALL GIVES A HOOT AND KERO
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE RETIREMENT
RECKONS GIVE A HOOT THAT THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT THING DO
SUPPORT AND KEEP GOING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S EVIL BUT THE
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE IN LOS
ANGELES WE SERVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS IN YEARS EACH YEAR AND
WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIVE POINT SEVEN
FIVE MILLION.
APS TRAINING FUNDS.
THANK YOU THANK OFFICER CHAIR
FRANK MAKE ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES DIRECTORS
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT REQUEST
[inaudible]
Q..
I LIVE TO FOLLOW FRANK MEDICAL --
MARTY HIM HOW DOES HE CITY CAN
CALIFORNIA JUST REALLY YOU CAN
ACTION NETWORK SUPPORT THE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT THANK.
OKAY THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION THE COMMENTS SO --
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS --
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD OPEN THE
REQUEST FOR INVESTMENTS AND MAKE
WITH THAT --
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR AND ON THE
A PS SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS IF YOU DON'T MIND IT'S
TWELVE FORTY TWO WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FOR OF THAT SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE STRETCH
BREAK SO WE CAN ALL STRETCH A
LITTLE AND THEN WILL.
THEN MOVE ON TO COULD GET NICK
FOR USE A LITTLE BREAK BEFORE
YOU MOVE DIVE AND AS A SCIENCE
SP SO.
WE'LL DO A FIVE MINUTE BREAK AND
WE GET THE RESTROOM WHATEVER
ELSE
COME BACK FROM RESTROOM AND
EVERYTHING [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THE SEARCH IS ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
THREE OKAY --
THAT'S ONE TO SO IT'S REALLY
THREE ISSUES ON IN THIS CATEGORY.
OKAY SO ALL RIGHT SO WHEN WE GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED ON THE
PARMA SOCIAL SERVICES ACCESS.
SCIENCES P..
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE AN OVERVIEW
AND THEN --
AFTER THAT --
THEY WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE --
FOR AS AN EXERCISE SPEAK OUT
FRESH AND THEN THE HOUSING
DISPLAY ABSENT PROGRAM THEY'LL
HAVE PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT IN
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON ALL THOSE ITEMS SO LET'S GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH THE
OVERVIEW BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT I
KNOW SOME OF YOU WERE HERE
BEFORE BUT WITH EACH NEW THING
WE DO THE INTRO AGAINST EVERYONE
CAN INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD PLEASE STARTING WITH THE
AGENCY.
DEBBIE THOMPSON DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
FEDERAL PROGRAMS SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU.
FEATURING CO CHIEF DEPUTY AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
GIVE THEM A QUICK WAY CDSS CAL
FRESH.
HI SET AND HOUSING ASSISTANCE
ALRIGHT CSS YOU'VE LU ACCURACY --
ELIA.
GINNY BELLA ALEJO FINANCE.
THE NAY TAMA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
HE BARELY DIFFERENT FINE.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO WE GO
HEAD BEGIN WITH THE OVERVIEW OF
SS I ASSIST SIMILARLY TO WHAT I
DID WITH US --
APS YOU SHOULD HAVE A POWER
POINT ON THE AS A SCIENTIST HE
AND TELLS YOU BASICALLY WHAT IT
IS IT DOES ADDRESS ON THE THIRD
SLIDE.
SOME INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DECLINE THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WITH --
AS A SCIENCE IS P. CASELOAD
IDENTIFYING SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT CAN --
WE BELIEVE ARE.
IMPACTING THAT THE FINANCE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF THOSE
MORE FINANCIALLY STABLE OF THE
BABY BOOMERS --
SO HAVE HIGHER INCOMES MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY AND IMPROVEMENTS
HEALTHIER BEHAVIORS THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS HAVING AN IMPACT ON
DOCTOR KLEIN.
ARE YOU TELLING WE ACTUALLY GET
A RETURN ON HEALTHY BEHAVIOR
[inaudible]
MAYBE.
OKAY I DISLIKE --
WELL WE ACTUALLY HAVE OUTCOME
RESULTS HERE [inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT'S A REMINDER OF THE LOOK AT
INVESTMENTS IN HEALTHY BEHAVIOR
FOR FINANCE AND LA ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE SOME RESULTS THE PROOF THAT
WE ACTUALLY DECREASED ACOSTA
THAT BACK IN AND LATER ON OKAY
THANK YOU.
SORRY -- UP
THESE CONTINUE.
THAT IT GOES OVER THE ACTUAL HAM
CASELOAD THE END NEXT YEAR AGAIN
PROJECTION OF THE TEN BILLION --
THE PAYMENT STANDARDS RIGHT NOW
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL --
KIND OF THE MOST COMMONLY USED
STANDARD NINETY THREE NINE OR
THIRTY ONE A MONTH.
INCREASING ANTICIPATED TO BE
NINE FIFTY BASED ON THE COLA ON
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE
COUPLE'S CURRENTLY FIFTEEN SIXTY
FOUR AGAIN ANTICIPATED FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE WITHOUT COLA --
GIVES YOU A KIND OF COAL THE
HISTORY OF EACH OF THE
CATEGORIES --
COMPARES IT TO THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL --
HE INDIVIDUAL RATE IS ABOUT.
A 90% CURRENTLY SLIGHTLY UNDER
PROJECTED FOR NEXT YEAR --
HUNDRED ELEVEN OF FOR THE
COUPLE'S --
AND THAT KIND OF TELLS YOU
WHAT'S IN.
THE POWER POINT AND THEN WE MOVE
INTO THE ITEM AROUND TO THE CASH
OUT REVERSAL AND ALL RIGHT OKAY
ANYTHING ELSE ON THE OVERVIEW
HERE OKAY LA --
COMMENT ON THE OVERVIEW.
FINANCE COMMITTEE OVERVIEW OKAY
I THINK I SAID MY COMMENT ON THE
OVERVIEW OF RIGHT SO LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO THE THE
CASH OUT THE SOCIETY S. P. FOR
COVERAGE EXPAND.
AS AS YOU WELL REMEMBER LAST
pPOLICY KNOWN AS THE END OF CASH
OUT IN CALIFORNIA'S WE'VE MOVED
IMPLEMENTATION YOU HAVE A TWO
PAGE SUMMARY I BELIEVE IN YOUR
PACKET.
ARE WE REALLY BE TALKING MORE
ABOUT IT AS AN EXPANSION OF
CALIFORNIA TO **** AYE
PARTICIPANTS --
A KICK OFF IS JUNE FIRST
BEGINNING ABOUT ENROLLMENT
PERIOD BEGINS JUNE FIRST --
AND SO THE PAST YEAR SINCE THE
BUDGET TO JUNE FIRST WE'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH A POLICY GUIDANCE
AND OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
PARTICULARLY FOR COUNTIES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM TO GET
READY -- AND
THEN OUR SHOULD BE KICKING OFF
LATE APRIL THROUGH MAY TO SPREAD
THE WORD TO RECIPIENTS THAT THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY BEGINNING
JUNE FIRST MAKING SURE WE
EMPHASIZE IT'S ABOUT HOW FRESH --
THEY'LL BE NO CHANGE TO AS A
SCIENTIST P. GROUNDS AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE HOLD
HARMLESS INTENTION PROGRAMS --
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION AND
TRANSITIONAL NUTRITION BENEFITS.
THE BIG ISSUE FOR US IS JUST THE
VOLUME IT'S A ONE TIME ON
BOARDING.
OF MANY MANY PEOPLE SIMILAR TO A
CA SO GETTING READY FOR ALL THE
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY SERVE A
WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE.
EXCELLENT SO WE'RE GOING --
TO ACTUALLY --
THANK YOU YOU HAVE SOME
PANELISTS RIGHT SO --
ACTUALLY FIRST OF ALL ANY
COMMENTS FROM LA --
ABOUT THE INVITATION AND WE HAVE
A PANEL AFTER WE GET COMING FROM
LA --
FINANCE YES.
I'M JUST GENERAL BROADER
COMMENTS ABOUT --
WE WE JUST RAISE SOME.
QUESTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
ONGOING MONITORING OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION ONCE WE GET TO
THAT PHASE I THINK A LOT OF WORK
HAS BEEN DONE IN PREPARATION BUT
ONCE JUNE FIRST HEADS WHICH IS
THE EXPECTED TIME IN WHICH THE
POLICY CHANGE WOULD OCCUR --
HOW WILL THE DEPARTMENT BE
MONITORING PROGRESS --
WHAT METRICS WILL THEY BE USING
HOW THEY GO ABOUT NOT ONLY
IDENTIFYING SUCCESSES IN SOME OF
THESE IMPLEMENTATION PLANS BUT
THEN ALSO UNEXPECTED AND
UNFORESEEN CHALLENGES ARE
BARRIERS?
AND THEN HOW WILL THAT BE
COMMUNICATED TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN A TIMELY MANNER AND WHAT ARE
THOSE CONTINGENCY PLANS WHAT DO
THEY LOOK LIKE [inaudible]
FINANCE.
NO OKAY AND ACTUALLY JUST GIVEN
THE LA AS QUESTION DID YOU HAVE
SOME MAYBE SOME ANSWERS TO SOME
OF THIS QUESTION IN TERMS OF
THAT REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
LUNCH BUT NO THE THE PLANS FOR
MONITORING THE VERY HOT TOPIC OR
FORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE A CAL
FRESH DATA.
DASHBOARD IN PLACE SO WE ARE
UPDATING THAT TO HAVE SOME MORE
AS A SITE SPECIFIC METRICS THAT
THE INITIAL ONES OF COURSE WILL
BE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE APPLIED AND HOW
MANY WERE PROVED MAKING SURE
BOTH GOT THE WORD OUT AND HELP
PEOPLE SUCCESSFULLY IN ROLE WILL
ALSO BE WATCHING VERY CLOSELY
THE FIRST FEW MONTHS TIMELINESS
WE DO HAVE?
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS AND AGAIN WITH THE
VOLUME THAT'S GONNA BE A
CHALLENGE FOR OUR SYSTEM AT
LEAST IN THE SHORT TO MEDIUM
TERM -- AND
GOING FORWARD WE HAVE A LOT MORE --
REPORTING WITH YOU SEE A SEVEN
OTHER RESEARCH LOOK AT THE
IMPACT OF BRINGING NUTRITION
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT PIECE.
TO OKAY EXCELLENT SERVER EXCITED
ABOUT THAT --
SO LONG AND IS WE HAVE THREE
PANELISTS WHO ARE GOING TO USE
OR SPEAK ABOUT THEIR PERSPECTIVE
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION SO WE CAN
SORT OF MOVE OVER WE NEED THREE
SEATS OVER HERE SO --
SHIFT OVER SO WE HAVE ANDREW
CHAIN FRANK A MECCA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WILL FOR DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND TRAIN FAN
JUSTICE AN AGING IF YOU CAN COME
UP -- AND
GIVE US YOUR THREE MINUTES OR
LESS TAKE --
AND HOW THIS --
THIS WE'RE GETTING CLOSE TO
LUNCH HOW THIS IS BEEN GOING AND
DAY IN THE AS CONCERNS YOU HAVE --
IS THE PROCESS IS MOVING FORWARD --
AND ALSO I MEAN WE DON'T WE
DON'T SALAS AT THE NEGATIVE BUT
ALSO THE THINGS THAT WORKED THAT
SEEM TO WORK REALLY WELL AS WELL
SO.
I WILL GET START WITH --
MISTER CHENEY WELCOME THANKS
INTERCHANGE FROM CALIFORNIANS
DECIDE --
DIDN'T SPENDING IS MAKING SENSE --
FROM ADVOCATE --
COALITION THANK SEVENTEEN TO
SPEAK AND I JUST WANT HISTORIC
EXPANSION AND REALLY RECOGNIZE
THE WORK OF YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE --
FOR THE TOUR IS WORKING LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AGREEMENT --
IT'S BEEN A TREAT OF MINE --
TO BE ABLE TO GO AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO CONFERENCES ETCETERA
AND JUST REALLY SEE THE NATIONAL
RECOGNITION OBVIOUSLY WE WERE
THE LAST DAY FOR SEVERAL YEARS --
WITH THIS POLICY IN PLACE AND
BUT ALSO TO DEAL WITH A HOLD
HARMLESS WHICH WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT AND REALLY HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS AN IMPORTANT THAT
IT HAS.
AND SIMILARLY I WANT TO THANK
THE DEPARTMENT --
THE COUNTIES WHO SINCE THAT
POINT I MEAN ALMOST NOT AFTER --
JULY ONE HAVE WORKING KILEY HARD
DAY IN DAY OUT WITH THE
COALITION ENGAGE FULLY AS AS KEY
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
HONESTLY I'VE NEVER FELT A YEAR
OF MY LIFE TO BE SO SHORT --
AND TO IRAQ WE'RE ALMOST THERE
SO PIC UPDATE IS AT THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS HAS PRODUCED
A CLEAR GOAL TO ENROLL 75% --
BY LOOKING AT OTHER STATES IN
AND WHAT'S REASONABLE AND AT
SOME THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND TO CALIFORNIANS AS
CHEMICAL WE JUST MENTIONED AND
THAT'S EXCITING AND THERE'S ALSO
A CLEAR ROADMAP TO GET THERE --
AS YOU CAN SEE AN APARTMENT
WEBSITE THAT THERE IS A
FRAMEWORK OF SOLUTIONS OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE ENHANCEMENTS
THAT WE KNOW WILL WORK NOT JUST
FOR FOLKS RUN AS A SIGH --
BUT FOR EVERYONE --
RESULT WILL FOR CONFIRMATION
ACTUAL INTERVIEWS.
SOME OF THESE I DO TAKE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
TIME IS IS OF THE ESSENCE --
SOME TAKE RESOURCES AND AND
OTHERS TO WE'VE HEARD FROM
EXCITING --
COUNTIES LIKE WINTER ABOUT HOW
THE ADOPTED CULTURE ELIGIBILITY
WITHOUT --
MUCH FINANCIAL RESOURCES BUT
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT THE TIME IS
OF THE ESSENCE ESPECIALLY WITH
THE TWO FULL TIME AS PROGRAMS
THAT WERE SO VITAL AND AND I WAS
HE THE COALITION MADE THAT AS AS
A COURSE IN THE AGREEMENT AND WE
KNOW THAT THE COUNTIES ARE
WORKING EXTREMELY.
HARD TO STAND UP TO BRAND NEW
PROGRAMS TO AUTOMATE THEM AS
ETCETERA --
AND AS WE JUST HEARD BRIEFLY WE
KNOW THAT JUST THE ON THE
CALPERS SIDE THE ENROLLMENT
GOALS ARE ARE ARE YOU KNOW I
NEVER MAGNITUDE LIKE WE'VE WE'VE
REALLY SEEN RIGHT WE'VE NEARLY
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
PROGRAM AND THE COOL CENTRAL
BETWEEN OR SEVENTY THOUSAND AND
SO WE KNOW.
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
TIME TO GET THERE --
AND SO WE FIND SOME SOME
QUESTIONS AND AND LIKE SOME
POTENTIAL CONCERNS FOR YOU --
SIMILAR TO THE THE LA --
I MEAN YOU CAN SEE IN OUR LETTER
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE STATE OF MONITORING METRICS
AND ALSO LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
PARTICULAR BARRIERS AND I THINK
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM SOME
PEOPLE WHO CAN SPEAK TO BETTER
THAN I CAN.
I WANNA GET TO PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT CERTAINLY ISSUES ARE
LANGUAGE ACCESS THAT IS THAT IN
THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW BUT WITH
SENIORS PEOPLE DISABILITIES
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING POVERTY
PEOPLE POTENTIALLY HAD SOME
CHALLENGES WITH THE SS I
BENEFITS.
THAT'S ALL GONNA COME INTO PLAY --
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THAT THEY THE COUNTY SINCE
YOU'RE LOOKING TO DO BUT THERE'S
GONNA BE A ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REMAIN ENGAGED TO
COMMIT TO STEP IN HAVE OVERSIGHT
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO STEP UP
AND FIX THINGS AS AS THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IT'S OKAY ON HOLD HARMLESS AND
THANK YOU TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THIS. ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
CAUSES FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
WAS PROTECTING FAMILIES FROM
LOSING CAL FRESH WHEN.
THE SS I RECIPIENTS ARE INCLUDED
IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD --
WERE PLEASE AT THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET INCLUDES A
COMMITMENT TO MAKE PROTECTING
THESE FAMILIES PERMANENT.
AND WE'RE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
STATUTE.
THAT WOULD MAKE THE SUPPLEMENTAL
NUTRITION BENEFIT AND
TRANSITIONAL NUTRITION BENEFIT
PERMANENT.
BUT PROGRAMS PERMANENT --
AND IN LIGHT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
KIND OF INTENTION TO MAKE THOSE
PROGRAMS PERMANENT AND TO
ADDRESS SOME ISSUES --
THAT WERE NOT LIKE FULLY VETTED
IN THE CLICK CLICK OF DRAFTING
OF THE LANGUAGE LAST YEAR.
WE'RE ASKING FOR SOME
ADJUSTMENTS. TO TO MODIFY RULES
RELATED TO EXIST FOR THE TO
PROGRAM SO THAT BOTH PROGRAM
PROGRAMS USE THE ROLE THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN PLACE FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION BENEFIT --
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO RESTORE THE
BENEFIT IT WAS TERMINATED FOR
REASONS OTHER THAN MISSING EVERY
DISCRIMINATION.
AND ARE DEADLINE AND ALSO TO
ALLOW FOR PROSPECTIVE ENROLLMENT --
AND FINALLY WE'RE PLEASED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ELIMINATED THE
OF THE TEN DOLLAR GAP BETWEEN
THE CAPPY BENEFIT AND THIS IS I
GUESS IS P. BENEFIT --
HOWEVER WERE ASKING THAT THE
SECTION THAT MAKES THE INCREASE
IN THE CAP THE BENEFIT SUBJECT
TO A BUDGET APPROPRIATION BE
STRICKEN.
THANKS MEGA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FRANK MECCA WITH THE
COUNTY PERSPECTIVE --
SEATED READING A AND ARE
COUNTIES BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE SS AND MANY ADVOCATE
PARTNERS LIKE THE FOOD BANKS
ASSOCIATION IN THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY --
THE PARTNERSHIP IS SPEND BAND
TASTIC IN THE STATE'S LEADERSHIP
HAS BEEN REALLY TOP RATE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP OF ALL THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS.
ALSO WORKING REALLY CLOSELY WITH
THE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM SO THAT WE HAVE
AUTOMATION IN PLACE --
BY JUNE ONE TO IMPLEMENT THE
BENEFIT WE'RE HAPPY TO REPORT SO
FAR THAT IMPLEMENTATION IS GOING
WELL.
AND THAT WE'VE ENCOUNTERED NO
MAJOR PROBLEMS ARE BARRIERS.
AND THE CURRENTLY WORK GROUPS
DISCUSSING HOW READ --
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE STATE IS
GOING TO BROADLY REACH OUT TO
ANY --
POTENTIAL --
BENEFICIARY AND THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S A SMART APPROACH THE
BROUGHT OUT REACH --
IS IT IS GREAT FOR MOWING SSI
RECIPIENTS IT ALSO SORT OF LEADS
TO BASICALLY ARE SORT OF MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN.
AND THAT IS --
MISS MCCOY WAIT INDICATED IS
JUST VOLUME --
WE LEARNED MANY LESSONS FROM
IMPLEMENTING THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT -- SOME
OF WHICH WE'VE ANTICIPATED THAT
WON'T HAPPEN --
AUTOMATION IS IN PLACE THE STATE
RULES HAVE BEEN CLEAR AND HAVE
COME TO US WITH SUFFICIENT LEAD
TIME -- BUT
WE ALSO REALIZE FROM THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THAT WHEN
YOU HAVE A VOLUME THAT FAR
EXCEEDS WHAT YOU ANTICIPATE --
IT CAN BE REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
CLIENTS AND IN THIS CASE OR SOME
OF THE MOST WONDERFUL PEOPLE IN
THE AND SOCIETY.
THAT LEADS --
TO A CW WE'RE REQUESTING FIFTEEN
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
WHICH IS AND SORT OF TWO
COMPONENTS.
THE FIRST IS FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION ON A ONE TIME BASIS FOR
APPLICATION VOLUME.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
NEW CASES.
THE BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING --
FOR THE ESTIMATED THREE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE FOR ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY CASES --
WE EXPECT THE VOLUME OF
APPLICANTS WILL BE MUCH HIGHER
THAN THAT COULD BE TRIPLE --
AND WE ARE REQUESTING ONE TIME
FUNDING SO WE CAN PROCESSES
APPLICATIONS AND WE DON'T HAVE
VERY VULNERABLE PEOPLE WAITING
LONG PERIODS OF TIME MORE HAVING
LONG LINES.
OUT OUT THE DOOR OF THE WELFARE
OFFICE.
THE SECOND PART OF THE REQUEST
IS TEN POINT ONE MILLION FOR
ONGOING FUNDING.
THE STATE IN THE COUNTIES DID
AGREE LAST YEAR TO AN ASSUMPTION
ABOUT WORKLOAD FOR THE NEW CASES.
THEIR NEW WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE BUT FOR
BETTER OR FOR WORSE WE CAME TO A
A GOOD.
A GOOD UNDERSTANDING --
THE BUDGET HOWEVER FUNDS THAT
WORKLOAD AT TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND ONE COSTS.
SO THAT THE UNIT COST THE COST
OF THE WORKER THE COST OF THE
BUILDING THE OVER HAD.
IN THE CALPERS PROGRAM HAS NOT
BEEN UPDATED SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
AND SO INFLATION AND HAS
PROBABLY ERODED MAYBE 40% OF
THAT SO THE BUDGET ACTUALLY ONLY
FUND 60% OF THE WORK THAT WE
AGREED.
COUNTIES NEED TO DO AND AND
THAT'S A VAST SESSION ERA.
A YOU KNOW A BY GONE ERA OF HOW
THE STATE MANAGED ITS BUDGET IN
A KIND OF A STATE COUNTY --
ENGAGEMENT IT REALLY DOESN'T
REFLECT WHERE WE ALL ARE IN
TERMS OF PARTNERSHIP.
I'VE BEEN WANTING TO GET THIS
THIS IMPLEMENTED AND SO WE'D
REQUEST THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
UPDATE THE UNIT COST. TO CURRENT
COST SINCE IT IS
INCONTROVERTIBLE A NOT TOO
THOUSAND TODAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- ANY
COMMENTS FROM AGENCY ABOUT WHAT
SAID BEEN PRESENTED [inaudible]
OKAY ALEJO [inaudible]
FINANCE --
WORDS PER MINUTE FINANCE I THINK
WE WOULD JUST SAY FOR A COUPLE
OF THESE ISSUES WERE OBVIOUSLY
WILLING TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE LEGISLATURE
THE EXTENT THESE BECOME
PRIORITIES --
AND WE'RE OPEN ONGOING
DISCUSSION HOWEVER NOW THESE
WERE INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OKAY BUT I WOULD PRESUME
THOUGH THAT IMPLEMENTING CASH
OUT IS A PRIORITY OF THE BUDGET
RIGHT BECAUSE IT DOES.
SO THAT.
THE SUGGESTION IS IF IT'S IF
IT'S A NICE THING THAT WE MIGHT
WANT TO DO.
THAT ENTERTAIN THE CONVERSATION
BUT OTHERWISE NOT THAT WOULD NOT
SEEM CONSISTENT.
WITH THAT THE PARTNERSHIP AROUND
A PROPOSAL THAT IS CURRENT LAW.
THE CURRENT FINANCED HER WORDS I
THINK WE WOULD CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT WE WANT THIS TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE AND SMOOTH AND
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION AND
THAT'S WHY WE'D BE WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN FURTHER CONVERSATION.
ALL RIGHT A FREE **** MAY V. CAN
LOOK AT THE THE FINDINGS BASED
ON OLD NUMBERS MAYBE WE CAN LOOK
AT THE WEATHER WE HAVE MORE
ACCURATE INFORMATION.
TO BETTER DISHER THAT.
THANK COUNTY PARTNERS THE HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO MAKE
IT SUCCESSFUL CENSORED THE SIR
THE OPERATIONAL AND OF THIS
RIGHT OKAY.
RIGHT OF A CERTIFIED THIS ONE IS
THE THIS IS MY THANK EVERYONE
AND WHO HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS --
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR A VERY
LONG TIME I HEARD FOR ME MY
COLLEAGUES AND LEGISLATURE WHY
ARE WE NOT DOING THIS RIGHT AND
IT AND I THINK LAST YEAR I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AND THE
FACT THAT.
CENTER FOR US --
Là PROPERTIES AT OKAY THIS IS
SOMETHING WE CAN DO WE JUST
HAVEN'T DONE IT AND WE HAVEN'T
DONE IT FOR A VERY LONG TIME
LIKE WELL WHY CAN'T WE DO IT.
RIGHT AND THAT WE WERE ABLE.
TO COME TOGETHER I KNOW THERE IS --
YOU KNOW TURN THAT THE END OF
WORKING OUT ACTUALLY IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT ROLLING PEOPLE INTO
CAL FRESH IT'S ALSO ABOUT DOING
THE HOLD HARMLESS PIECE WHICH IS.
COMPLICATED A THEY THINK YOU
KNOW YOU THE TRICKERY THAT PIECE
OUT AND SO FORTH AND SO AND I'M
GLAD WE WERE ABLE TO COME TO
AGREEMENT GET IN THE BUDGET AND
LIVE VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD
TO THIS LAUNCHING ON ON JUNE
FIRST AND BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE.
THAT --
HOPEFULLY --
IT WE ALWAYS AT THE LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE IN THE NEXT RECESSION
MIGHT HIT WE ONLY PUT IN VARIOUS
BUFFERS BETWEEN RAINY DAY FUND
AND AND SO FORTH BUT ALSO THAT.
HOPEFULLY THE CALPERS BENEFIT
ITSELF IS ONE THAT WILL BE
ITSELF --
POLICE A SMALL BUT BUT IMPORTANT
BUFFER -- TO
STRESSES THAT HAPPEN ON THE
STATE BUDGET AS WELL THE FACT
THAT WE NOW CAN GET PEOPLE ON
CAL FRESH'S.
SO GIVEN THE VOLATILITY OF STATE
FUNDING REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK --
EVERYONE IS DONE ON AND LOOKING
FOR TO BOTH THE SUCCESSFUL
LAUNCH ON JUNE FIRST --
BUT ALSO THE FOLLOW THROUGH
RIGHT AND AND AND I APPRECIATE
THAT WERE LIKE THE CA RIGHT
WE'RE GOING.
TO THE CIVIC VOLUME WE'RE ALL
GOING TO BE MOVING PEOPLE INTO A
CELL [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY WELL I THINK --
WE'LL WE'LL BE --
SO IT ACTUALLY IS THE QUESTION I
FOR FOR FOR THE PARTS OF
SERVICES IN TERMS OF ARE YOU
PLANNING TO KEEP THE LEGISLATURE.
I IS THIS HOW THIS IS ROLLING
OUT -- SO
JUNE FIRST WE LUNCH --
YOU KNOW WE GIVE YOU VOTING ON
BUDGET JUNE FIFTEENTH SO THIS
THAT BUT IN TERMS OF ON GOING
STUFF RECENTLY.
YEAH WELL AND AND AND THIS IS
BEYOND JUST JUMP BUDGET I MEAN I
THINK IN TERMS OF OVERSIGHT --
WHEN TO EXPECT US SOME FEEDBACK
ON HOW THE HOW THE ROLLOUT IS
HAPPENING BUT WE WE ARE THE
CURRENT CYCLE WHERE AND WITH
WITH EVERYONE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS?
IS A MONTHLY UPDATE THAT'S
PROPOSAL PUBLICLY AT THE END OF
EVERY MONTH --
WE WILL HAVE OUR TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A BY MONTH --
AND WE ALSO HAVE DATED ASH
PORTAL START --
JUNE DATA WILL SHOW UP LATER IN
JULY SO I OUT WE WOULD HAVE.
YOU KNOW WILL HAVE SOME REAL
TIME.
THINGS TO SAY IN JUNE BUT IN
TERMS OF ACTUAL STATEWIDE DATA
WILL BE A MONTH IN AND THEN EVEN
THAT WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO SORT
OUT -- BUT
WE YOU KNOW ANYTIME WE CAN --
POSTER WISHING PUBLICLY ON A
MONTHLY AND QUARTERLY BASIS AND
THEN OF COURSE HAPPY TO DO MORE
BRIEFINGS FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ANY TIME OKAY SO PLEASE
GIVE BERNIE TO SOMETHING TO DO
AFTER TO BUDGETS.
OKAY SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING ABOUT HOW HOW THIS ALL
OF THIS NOW THIS RULES OUT AND
LET'S SEE A WILL FIGURE OUT FOR
MAY HELP YOU SURE PEOPLE HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE WE DO
THIS SUCCESSFULLY SO BASED ON
MORE CURRENT.
NUMBERS CELL THAN WAS AT NINETY
ONE AND WHICH WHICH YEAR WAS
THAT.
THROUGHOUT.
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
ALL RIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO --
SHE WAS REPEAT CPO.
OKAY THEY MENTION ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT RIGHT OKAY SO JUST TO
CONFIRM --
SINCE THERE'S ALSO PCP PORTION
THAT THERE WAS A REQUEST SINCE I
KNOW YOU DON'T EXPLICITLY SAY I
NOTES INTO WRITTEN MATERIAL --
SO LIVE TURF LIMITED TERM
FUNDING FOR ELEVEN A HIGHER
CASELOAD ALRIGHT THAT'LL NATURE
OF THIS CASE LOW THE ELDERLY AND
PEOPLE DISABILITIES AND THE NEW
STATE PROGRAMS OKAY EXCELLENT
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE HOUSING THIS BILLY
ACSI PROGRAM.
OKAY I THINK EVERYONE AROUND THE
TABLE STILL THE SAME OKAY ALL
RIGHT GOOD ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL.
RIGHTS OF MY GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
YES SIR ALEX HADN'T CSS OUR
HOUSING ASSISTANCE FOR ITS
BRANCH -- SO
JUST A LITTLE BIT IN TERMS OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION SINCE WE WERE
LAST YEAR --
YOUR OVERVIEW DOES A REALLY GOOD
JOB OF IT SO I'LL JUST QUICKLY
TOUCHING A FEW PIECES BUT AS A
REMINDER THIS IS THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR OVER A THREE YEAR --
PROGRAM THAT WAS FUNDING COMING
DUE NEXT NEXT YEAR --
THERE IS A THERE IS A COUNTY
MATCH -- AND
THIRTY NINE COUNTIES ARE ARE
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING THAT
THOSE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED TO
COUNTIES --
SORT OF ON A ROLLING BASIS
BETWEEN NOVEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN JANUARY --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH A SECOND
ROUND SORT OF COMPLETING AND
ROUNDING OFF THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS --
IN APRIL OF OF LAST YEAR --
SINCE THEN WE HAVE HOSTED AT
THREE IN PERSON LEARNING FORUMS
YOU'VE BEEN DOING QUITE A FEW
WEBINARS OUGHT TO TRY TO GET
FOLKS UP TO SPEED ON HOW TO
SECURE HOUSING FOR THIS
POPULATION THAT HAS BEEN A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE.
HOW TO GO ABOUT BUDGETING IT'S A
PRETTY COMPLEX --
PROGRAM AND THEN ENSURING THAT
THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
HOUSING FIRST WHICH WILL BE A
REQUIREMENT AS OF JULY OF THIS
YEAR -- SO
THERE'S I'VE I'VE ALSO GONE OUT
AND DONE QUITE A BIT BUT IF SITE
VISITS --
UNTIL WE SEE FOLKS YOU KNOW IT
IT DID TAKE AT COUNTIES QUITE A
BIT OF TIME TO GET ALL THE
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS OF THIS
PROGRAM TOGETHER --
IT'S THAT PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING POPULATION TO SERVE --
TO TRY TO DO OUR REACH FOR A TO
MAINTAIN THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH --
IT'S ALSO BEEN A PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING POPULATION TO FIND
HOUSING FOR EVEN WITH AN SSI
CHECK I THINK SOME COUNTIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THAT MIGHT WORK --
WE ARE JUST IN THE MIDST OF SORT
OF SEEING THE DATA THAT YOU ALL
SEE -- FROM
IS FROM NOVEMBER WE ACTUALLY
HAVE HAD UPDATED DATA AS OF
JANUARY SEEING ALMOST A DOUBLING
DISABILITY BENEFITS APPLICATION
SUBMITTED TO US SINCE WE LAST OF
THIS THE WERE ALMOST AT SEVEN
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED
AS OF JANUARY --
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
PARTICIPANTS PERMANENTLY HOUSE
YOU ARE SEEING THAT GAP BETWEEN --
THOSE --
DISABILITY BENEFIT ABLE TO FIND
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR IT THUS
FAR -- TO A
STOP THERE WAS SORT OF THE OVER
VIEW -- I
KNOW YOU A COUPLE QUESTIONS ANNA.
AGENDA THAT I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS
AS WELL AS HELPFUL WHAT WHAT --
WHAT YOU GO AND ANSWER THOSE?
QUESTIONS THAT ARE SO YEAH SO I
MEAN IN TERMS OF MEASURING THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM ON LIKE A
COUPLE OF OUR OTHER --
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM DOESN'T HAVE AN
EVALUATION COMPONENT TIED TO IT
SO WE UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE
AN EXTERNAL EVALUATOR FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
THAT SAID WE ARE TRYING TO DO
SOME THINGS INTERNALLY --
AS THE PROGRAM GETS UP AND
RUNNING AND MAINLY THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS IN THE STATUTE
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO BE
COLLECTED --
THERE'S SOME QUALITATIVE DATA
THAT WE'RE REALLY GOING TO BE
INTERESTED IN SEEING FROM
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
SORT OF EVEN TEMPORARY HOUSING
ON GETTING AS AS OUR WHILE
GETTING APPLICATION PUT TOGETHER --
SORT OF HOW THAT HELP THE
APPLICATION BE SUBMITTED MORE
QUICKLY HOPEFULLY SO THERE'S
SOME QUALITATIVE DATA WILL BE
GETTING FROM THERE WE ARE ALSO
WORKING WITH A FEW COUNTIES --
THAT HAVE ACCESS TO THE SOME TO
SEE IF DOWN THE ROAD WE CAN
TRACK RETURNS TO HOMELESSNESS --
IT IS NOT A DATA SYSTEM THAT WE
OWN OUR MOST COUNTIES --
SO IT HAS BEEN A BIT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH THE
COUNTY TO TRY TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET THERE DOWN THE ROAD BUT THAT --
THAT RETURN TO HOMELESSNESS
NUMBERS A BIT TRICKY FOR US TO
GET TO BUT WE'RE WE'RE WORKING
ON IT FOR THIRTEEN COUNTY SORT
OF HAVE GOOD ACCESS NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO TO BUMP THAT NUMBER UP
AS WE GO.
AND THAT SORT OF IN TERMS OF
SUCCESS --
ALSO LOOKING SORT OF IT AS WE
GET FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD AND
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF APPROVAL
RATES FOR SS I APPLICATIONS WILL
BE LOOKING AT THOSE COMPARED TO
OTHER MODELS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BUT WE JUST DON'T HAVE
QUITE AS MUCH EIGHT ON THAT YET
BECAUSE IT.
TAKES A BIT OF TIME TO GET THOSE
APPROVED --
AND THEN YOUR LAST QUESTION HERE
ON THE ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
MILLION THAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WERE EXPECTING
THAT TO BE GIVEN A PRETTY
SIMILAR WAY THAT WE ALLOCATED
THE LAST ROUND THING YOU KNOW
THAT THERE WILL BE A MATCH --
IT WILL BE COMPETITIVE WE HAVE
SEEN A FEW COUNTIES THAT GOT I
LOS UP FIVE LESS FUNDING IN THE
FIRST ROUND SORT OF ALREADY
SLOWING DOWN.
THERE --
THEIR OUR REFERRALS AND AND
APPROVAL SO THERE AND WE WE
EXPECT THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
NAY BUT IT WILL BE GIVEN OUT A
PRETTY SIMILAR FASHION AS AS THE
FIRST FORTY FIVE MILLION WAS.
OKAY THANK YOU --
COMES FROM OHIO.
WE'VE REVIEWED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
MONEY REYES NO CONCERNS WITH THE
CONCEPT OF AGE THAT BEING AN
ONGOING PROGRAM WE JUST --
WOULD KNOW JUST SOME GENERAL
IMPLEMENTATION OR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AROUND WHEN AGED UP
WAS PROPOSES A PILOT PROGRAM
THEY WERE SPECIFIC --
DATA --
COMPONENTS THAT WERE OUTLINED
BEING THAT IT'S BEEN MORE
DIFFICULT TO CAPTURE SOME OF
THOSE DATA COMPONENTS THAN
OTHERS -- SO
WITH THE ONGOING NATURE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL GETTING A
BETTER SENSE OF MOVING FORWARD
HOW ARE WE CAN IMPROVE THE DATA
QUALITY THAT WE'RE GETTING --
FROM COUNTIES TO BETTER ASSESS
THE OUTCOMES WITH AN H. TOP
ITSELF --
BUT IN ALSO BROADER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE INITIAL
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED ABOUT
THREE YEARS AGO UNDERSTANDING
THAT -- IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT WOULD BE
THE LAST YEAR IN WHICH THAT
FIRST --
INITIAL FUNDING CAN BE SPENT
DOWNS GETTING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WILL --
LATER ON ON TOP OF THAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE AS WELL --
BUT HAPPY TO CONTINUE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
SEEMS LIKE THIS IS AN EVOLVING
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW HOW THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED.
THANK YOU FINANCE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
UP SO.
THE IDEA I UNDERSTAND THAT --
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY.
TO MEASURE THE RETURN TO
HOMELESSNESS A YEAR SO YOU'RE
COUNTY AND THESE AT THIRTEEN
COUNTIES HAVE SOME.
MECHANISM IN PLACE.
TO MEASURE THAT I GUESS WHEN IT
COMES -- NOW
THIS THIRTEEN COUNTIES
REPRESENTATIVE OF ALL OF THE
STATE OR THE HOURS JUST A THIRTY
BIGGEST COUNTIES PERHAPS BECAUSE
THEY USUALLY HAVE MORE RESOURCES.
I'M JUST TRYING TO THINK ABOUT
LIKE WELL.
WHEN IT COMES TO DOING
EVALUATION --
AND SINCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NO
I'M GOING FUNDING AT MOVING MORE
TOWARD THAT AND I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE THIS IS --
YOU KNOW VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM --
THAT -- WE
LOOKING AT SOME OTHER OF AND OR
EXPANDED CAPACITIES OF COUNTIES
THAT THAT DOWN MAYBE PARTNERING
OF COUNTIES THAT DO SO THEY CAN
NOW LEVERAGE OFF EACH OTHER IN
TERMS OF EXISTING SYSTEM SO.
HE SPEAK TO WHAT MIGHT BE FUTURE
PLANS FOR FEMALE TO BE SURE WE
CAN GET THE KIND OF INFORMATION
WE NEED TO SHOW THAT WERE --
THAT WILL GAIN CAM RESULTS WERE
EXPECTING YEAH SO I I THINK A
LITTLE BIT OF THIS IS THERE'S
ALSO DISCUSIONS HAPPENING AT
THE STATE LEVEL AROUND SORT OF A
STATEWIDE DATA WAREHOUSE FOR
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IF THAT WERE
TO COME. TO PLAY WE'D BE ABLE TO
SORT OF MATCH TO THAT DATA SET
AND BE ABLE TO SEE THAT
SOMETHING IS STATEWIDE LEVEL --
I EXPECT THAT TO BE QUITE A FEW
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD THOUGH SO I
I MEAN I THINK FOR THE THIRTEEN
COUNTIES THAT ARE ARE CURRENTLY.
I WOULD SAY ACTIVELY ABLE TO GET
DATA OUT OF THE H. I. S. SYSTEM
IT'S IT'S A VERY GROUP --
OUR HOPE IS THOUGH THAT JUST
FROM A A SYSTEMS OUR
COLLABORATION STANDPOINT THAT WE
CAN BRING MORE COUNTIES INTO
THAT SPACE --
AND IT WOULD IT WOULD TAKE MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ARE OTHER
BUT WE'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN OR
OTHER --
PROGRAM BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT WITH AN
EXTERNAL EVALUATOR SORT OF ON
THE GROUND HELPING THEM FIGURE
OUT.
THAT THE DATA PRIVACY PIECES OF
OF SOME OF THAT SO THE HOPE
WOULD BE THAT --
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND AND
SOME OF AND AND WITH THE ONGOING
NATURE THAT THERE'S MORE
INCENTIVE TO ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE LONG TERM IT IN THAT --
MODEL IN THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTH SAYS IT
DOESN'T STATUTES.
OKAY THE OBVIOUS THING I AT
LEAST IN THE BEGINNING IF
THERE'S A WAY.
TO MAYBE A SAMPLE RIGHT.
OF COURSE THIS IS AT THE
THIRTEEN MAY NOT BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE INTERSTATE
BUT THE AND AND THINKING ABOUT
LIKE WILDER PARTICULAR COUNTY SO
MIGHT BE MORE WILLING THAT THEY
HAD SOME ASSISTANCE FROM MY
COUNTY THAT THREE DOING YET THEY
CAN LEVERAGE OFF THEIR SYSTEM OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
ARE THAT WRITING THEM ASSISTANCE
IN THAT REGARD SO FORTUNATELY
ALL OF THE HMS SYSTEMS ARE OWNED
BY --
SEPARATE ENTITIES ACROSS AND
THEY SORT OF HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
DATA PRIVACY RULES AND SO WE'VE
DONE A LITTLE BIT OF PEER
SHARING OF AT LEAST THIS IS HOW
WE WERE ABLE TO GET.
ACCESS TO IN OUR COUNTY AND YOU
CAN GO AND TALK TO YOUR A TO MY
AS CORNY OR IN YOUR COUNTY SOME
OF THAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING I
WOULD SAY THAT WITH THE THIRTEEN
THAT WE HAVE WOULD BE ABLE.
TO SAY SOMETHING DOWN THE ROAD
JUST SORT OF NOTING THOUGH THAT
EVEN IF THEY GET THEIR A SOCIETY
YOU KNOW THIS IS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED FOR ABOUT A YEAR NOW
THEY GET THEIR **** SIDE WE
DON'T NECESSARILY ACCEPT THEM
RIGHT OFF.
AND THEN IT WOULD TAKE A SIX
MONTH AT MINIMUM FROM THERE SO
EVEN THERE'S GOING TO BE A BIT
OF A LAG AND AND EVEN LIVE TIME
DATA SO WHILE WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF WAITING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WE HAVE SOME OPPORTUNITY TO TRY.
TO GET BETTER ENGAGEMENT INTO
THOSE SYSTEMS OKAY ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
SO -- WHAT
WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX
IS A PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT AND --
WE HAVE SOMEONE IS SEE WHO'S
PRESENTING CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI.
THE REQUESTED --
ACTUALLY IS THAT OKAY FROM
WESTERN STAR Là POVERTY YOUR
SERVICE IS THE PERFECT WHO IS
THE PRESENTER FOR THIS.
WELCOME ALL RIGHT SEE LAST TIME
WHAT YOU DID LAST YEAR OKAY ALL
THE TROUBLE WE CAUSED YES THANK
YOU FOR CALLING US OUT ON THAT --
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MY
CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY --
AND I'VE JUST IF I JOB MOMENT
PRIVILEGE TO SAID --
THANK THAT APARTMENT IN THE
COUNTIES --
FOR THE GREAT WORK THAT THEY
HAVE DONE OVER THE LAST YEAR
ROUND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALPERS EXPANSION.
MEAN -- WE
ARE REALLY WE'VE BEEN VERY
PLEASE WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
INVOLVEMENT I THINK FRANKLY IT'S
AS GOOD AS I'VE EVER SEEN --
IN IF THEY'VE REALLY WORKED VERY
HARD AT THIS AND I'M
ANTICIPATING A A REALLY ROBUST
RESPONSE IN JUNE IN FACT I WHEN
I TALK TO CLIENTS MAY NAY.
THE CAN'T WAIT MORE THAT WILL BE
OVERWHELMED.
AND WE'RE GONNA E UNDER ALL SO --
THAT'S A GOOD THING AND
HOPEFULLY THAT'S A PROBLEM WE
CAN MANAGE AND WE WILL AS WE GO
FORWARD BUT I JUST DID WANT.
TO SAY THAT ON THE RECORD THAT
OF THE ASTOUNDING JOBS
OUTSTANDING JOB THAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
ON THIS WORK ON THE SEPARATE SO --
SO -- I'M
HERE TODAY THOUGH ACTUALLY TO
PRESENT ON AND A SEPARATE ISSUE
BUT RELATED WHICH IS THE THAT'S
THE ESSENCE I GRANT LEVELS --
AND I WAS LISTENING EARLIER IN
THE DAY OUT --
SENATOR STONE --
HAD MADE A COMMENT ABOUT SORT OF
THE STATE OF BE YOU KNOW OF EVEN
[inaudible]
SOME SECURITY CHECK CAN'T LIVE --
OUT OF OUTSIDE OF POVERTY
ANYMORE IN OUR STATE THAT COSTS
OF RIBBONS RISEN SO QUICKLY --
THAT THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO DO
THAT WELL WE HAVE --
ROUGHLY WE HAVE THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF OVER SIXTY FIVE SS I
RECIPIENTS OF ANY STATE IN THE
COUNTRY SO AS CENTER STONE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS JUST STRUCK
ME THAT.
EVERYTHING HE'S DESCRIBING
APPLIES TO THAT AS THE SITE
POPULATION BUT EVEN MORE BECAUSE
THEIR MAXIMUM GRANT IS NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
SO PEOPLE WHO ARE ON SOCIAL
SECURITY ARE GETTING OLD
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT ABOVE THAT
I'M STILL NOT ADEQUATE I
COMPLETELY GROUP CENTER STONE ON
THAT POINT --
BUT I I THINK IT AGAIN BEARS
REPEATING THAT WE STILL HAVE
CUTS IN PLACE THAT WE TOOK --
DURING THE TIME OF GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER --
THAT REDUCE THE STATE'S
CONTRIBUTION TO THE GRANT TO THE
POINT WERE WERE ONLY I THINK
FOUR DOLLARS ABOVE THE ABSOLUTE.
BOTTOM THAT WE CAN PROVIDE UNDER
FEDERAL LAW HUNDRED SIXTY
DOLLARS A MONTH THE MINIMUM IS --
ONE FIFTY SIX AND SO AGAIN AS
EACH YEAR THAT WE GO ALONG WE
SEE THAT.
THE POVERTY LEVEL FOR THAT
CREATES --
AGAIN WE DROPPED OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE TIME THAT WAS OUR ACTS
THAT WE DID HERE AND THAT NUMBER
KEEPS GOING DOWN I THINK WE'RE
DOWN TO ABOUT 90% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL NOW --
NOW IT WAS GREAT THAT WE ARE
DOING THE CALPERS EXPANSION AND
THAT'S GOING TO HELP A LOT OF
FOLKS.
BUT WHEN YOU DO THE MATH AND
EVEN IF WERE WILDLY SUCCESSFUL
LET'S SAY WE GOT A HALF OF HALF
A MILLION AS A SLIGHT RECIPIENTS
IN ROLLED AND CAL FOR US.
THAT WOULD STILL LEAVE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND CASES WHO DO
NOT BENEFIT FROM THE CALPERS
EXPANSION MEANING THAT THEY
AREN'T GOING TO BE GETTING ANY
INCREASE IN THEIR BENEFIT AT ALL.
IT'S A WIN FOR THE TNTH
CONSECUTIVE YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR ANNUALLY FROM THAT
POPULATION.
NOT PROVIDING IT TO THEM AND I'M
WOULD SUGGEST THAT OVER TIME
THIS IS HAVING TO MAKE-SIGNIFICANT DETRIMENTAL EFFECT.
ON THE THE PEOPLE ON THE US
ASIDE IN THE US AYE CASELOAD --
I THINK WE'RE SEEM HIGHER LEVELS
OF HOMELESSNESS --
HIGHER LEVELS OF ILLNESS.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY REALLY
STRUGGLING TO GET BY AND SO WE
ARE BACK AGAIN ASKING.
FOR AUGMENTATIONS TO THE BUDGET
THAT WOULD MAKE.
SURE THAT THE GRANT LEVELS FOR
SSI RECIPIENTS HITS THE 1100%
LEVEL OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL NOW WE DON'T THINK THAT'S
A PANACEA WE DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S PROBABLY EVEN COMPLETELY
ADEQUATE.
BUT WE THINK IS A STARTING POINT
FOR THE LEDGE --
INTO WE'VE COME FORTH AND
SUGGESTED THAT WE DO THIS OVER.
A COUPLE BUDGETS I THINK WE
WOULD STILL BE OPEN TO APPROACH
LIKE THAT AND WE'RE HOPING THAT
THE TIME WILL COME THIS YEAR
WHERE WE CAN PUT THAT PLAN IN
EFFECT AND GET IT DONE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TIME
MY TIME OKAY THANK YOU THANKS
VERY MUCH ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
FORCES OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
ALL RIGHT LA --
OF FINANCE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY WELL.
HELLO TEACHERS A WHOLE LOT
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
ABOUT THE ATV TWO CASES --
SO.
YEAH I THINK IT'S IT'S GOING TO
BE A BUDGET PROCESS.
ISSUE SO --
NO THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT --
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO.
NOW IS --
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA TAKE PUBLIC
THE THE ENTIRETY OF THE SS I SS
P. SO WE HAVE --
THE OVERVIEW THE THE P. C. P. AN
UPDATE ON THE COVERAGE EXPANSION --
THE H. STEP PROGRAM --
INSTITUTIONAL FUNDING IN THE AND
THE PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT SO.
OYSTER MICROPHONE AND AGAIN
REMIND PEOPLE WE CAN TRY TO KEEP
IT TO A MINUTE AND IF SOMEONE
SAID SOMETHING EVERY TWO WORKS --
THERE'S ONLY TWO OF US UP HERE
WE WE DO HEAR YOU AND APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE SELF THANK YOU
WELCOME AND PLEASE SAY YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION IF THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HELEN O'CONNELL AND
I'M [inaudible]
CHAIR OF DISABILITY ORGANIZING
GROUP FOR INITIATING TOTAL
EQUALITY OR DOG FIGHT.
WE SUPPORT --
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL REYES
TO SSI A COLA.
AND CAL FRESH EXPANSION BECAUSE
IF YOU.
ON HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS FOR
DIETARY IS AS YOU AGE.
CONFERENCE WOULD BE VERY VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI GERMAN --
RICHARD PAN --
WHAT I WILL OFFER RIGHT DON'T
OFTEN TURN AROUND IN?
SHOULD WE SAY EMPHASIZE BUT WILL
SAY AS HAVING PARTICIPATED THE
LAST SIX MONTHS AS A CALIFORNIA
FOR COALITION FOR SSI.
I THINK IT'S BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVELY WORKING WITH HUMAN
SERVICES IT'S BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE IN WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
LISTENING TO WHAT THE A AS
PROVIDED SO FULL SUPPORT OF ALL
THE RAGES THROUGH THERE AND YES
ARNOLD TOOK IT DOWN THERE IT
WOULD BE NICE IF HE SHOULD WE
SEE GRANT WOULD BE RESTORED
BROUGHT UP TO AT LEAST THE
FEDERAL.
YOU DEAL WITH HOUSING YOU SOONER
NOT LATER AND PLEASE YOU KNOW I
MEAN THIS MATTER IN THE
COALITION GETTING BACK IN A YEAR
WHAT KNOCKED THE CHECKUP BUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS VERY ALSO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES AT FIRST
JUST WANT TO START BY SAYING
WE'VE ALWAYS EXTREMELY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR RAISING THE GRANT
LEVELS AT LEAST TO THE POVERTY
LEVEL -- AND
WANT TO JUST FOCUS MY COMMENTS
ON THE CAMERA COVERAGE EXPANSION --
AN ECHO EVERYTHING PEOPLE SAID
ABOUT THIS START PARTNERSHIP AND
HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE FOR ALL THE
INCLUSION THERE AND THAT THIS
FUNDING WILL ALLOW US TO HIT THE
GOAL OF 75% ROMAN.
BY SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY AS
THE ASSUMPTIONS IN THE BUDGET
OUTLINE.
ON BECAUSE THIS FUNDING IS GOING
TO BE REALLY KEY TO THE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION ON
GOING ON WE HAVE THIS REALLY
GREAT COLLABORATIVE FRAMEWORK
THAT EVERYONE WORKED ON WITH THE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE IN
ADVOCATES TOGETHER --
BUT AS YOU MENTIONED WITH ISSUE
TO WITH ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE STATEWIDE CONSISTENCY.
I'M FOR ALL OF THE IS --
ACROSS THE COUNTIES AND SO AS WE
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO CALL I'M
ONLY A HANDFUL OF COUNTIES
ACTUALLY ALLOW PEOPLE TO
COMPLETE AN INTAKE ENROLLMENT BY
PHONE AND WE NEED TO HAVE EAST
SIGNATURE BY FEDERAL LAW SO
THERE FEDERAL COMPLICATIONS HERE --
SACRAMENTO YOLO COUNTY DON'T%
HAVE THAT FUNCTIONALITY --
SO ONLY ABOUT 50% OF THE SS I
CASELOAD HOW'S THAT
FUNCTIONALITY TO ENROLL BY PHONE --
SAME IS BY CLICKING ON LINE IF
YOU APPLY ON AND WHEN YOU COME
IN TO GET SAME DAY SERVICE LIKE
PRINTER HAS --
SO WE'RE JUST THRILLED THAT THE
INVESTMENTS ARE BEING MADE
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF AN REALLY
ENCOURAGING OF THE PROGRESS
BEING MADE TODAY AND OUTSIDE OF
THIS ROOM AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THE NAME IS KERRY ON THE
SS I AN S. S. P. RECEPTOR.
I WOULD SAY MIRRORS HOPING
JUSTICE -- I
LIKE TO FOR THE GRANT TO BE
RESTORED.
THE BOOK PROPERTY LEVEL --
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WERE FAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MR CHECKER CHILD THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO
PILE ON WITH THOSE THAT ARE
RECOGNIZING THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE COUNTIES FOR ALL OF THE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO THE
OUTSTANDING EFFORT THAT THEY'VE
DONE THUS FAR. TO MOVE THIS
TOWARD GREATER SUCCESS IN A A
SUCCESSFUL JUNE ROLL OUT --
I'LL JUST SAY AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S
PROBABLY NOT BEEN AN ISSUE THAT
HAS GARNERED AS MUCH --
INTEREST IN EXCITEMENT AS THIS
COW FRESH --
ROLL OUT AND SO WE WOULD WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
WORKING AS PART OF THIS
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS TO MAKE IT
AS SUCCESSFUL WE DO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S --
PCP WE DO SUPPORT AS WELL THE
REQUEST BY --
CW DA ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
RESOURCE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS JUDY JACKSON AYE MEN
SSI RECIPIENT.
AND I THINK THAT BOTH THE CAL
FRESH IMPROVEMENT AND AN
IMPROVEMENT IN THE STATE'S
CONTRIBUTION WOULD REALLY BE
HELPFUL ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE A
TWO TIME CANCER SURVIVOR.
AND A DIABETIC WHERE YOU NEED
SPECIAL FOOD SAID YOU CAN ALWAYS
GET THOSE FROM THE FOOD BANK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR SHARING
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE --
AS OF TODAY'S DATE --
MY NAME IS JOSEPH BERRY --
A STUDENT AT ADVOCATE ON HERE WE
HAVE A DOG FIGHT AND
CALIFORNIA'S RECESS I IT'S BEEN
A LONG TIME SO SO SO IT'S
REFRESHING TO GET THE FOOD
STAMPS -- I
HOPE THAT THAT DOESN'T TURN INTO
A BATES WHICH IF YOU WILL WHEN
IT COMES TO THE RICK RESTORING
THE GRANT AMOUNTS I THINK THAT
THAT'S A MAJOR MAJOR --
YOU KNOW SOURCE OF ANGUISH FOR
MANY PEOPLE THAT THAT THAT THEN
AND IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR A RAISE RECESSED FOR A
RETURN OF A GRANT THAT WAS A
PORTION OF THE GRANT THAT WAS.
IN ESSENCE BORROWED DURING A
TIME OF RECESSION SO PLEASE
CONTINUE THE YOU KNOW AT TO WHAT
YOU THE THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO AGAIN CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RUSSELL RAWLINGS --
DIRECTOR MAD BECAUSE HE
RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
AND THAT WE ARE --
THRILLED THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
WORKED SO CLOSELY.
AND ON IT WITH SUCH DEDICATION
TO IMPLEMENT THE EXPANSION
EXPANSION OF CONFERENCE TO ****
AYE RECIPIENTS WE ARE GLAD THAT
WE ARE A PART OF THIS PROCESS AS
WELL.
AND WILL BE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT
CAL FOR US IN THE FUTURE SO --
I JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE --
A LOT OF THE HISTORIC WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING TODAY IN STARTING A
LOT OF THESE CONVERSATIONS AND
THAT A LOT OF THIS IS ROOTED IN
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING MOVEMENT
THAT WAS STARTED SO LONG AGO --
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM INDIVIDUALS
LIVING ON SSI THE COMBINE SS I
SS P. GRANT IS SIMPLY --
UNTENABLE --
WE SEE CONSUMERS HOUSING AND
OTHER LIVING NEEDS MET ON THE
GROUND LEVEL SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE.
THAT THAT BE RESTORED TO FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I JUST SING AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES --
IN SUPPORT OF THE CW A REQUEST
FOR FIFTEEN POINT MILLION.
INCREASE FOR A COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION COSTS FOR THE S.
I CASH OUT --
IT'S VITAL THIS IMPORTANT IT
SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE AND THIS
FUNDING WILL ENSURE THE COUNTY'S
COMPLETE THE CRITICAL ROLE THAT
WE PLAY AND THEN IMPLEMENTATION.
ALSO SUPPORT OF BEING INCREASE
FOR THE H. THAT PROGRAM I
COUNTIES ARE CONFRONTING
HOMELESSNESS IN EVERY COUNTY IN
THE STATE THIS IS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM.
THIS IS ONE WAY THAT WERE --
WORKING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE CENTERS ON BEHALF
OF SEIU STATE COUNCIL
REPRESENTING ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
WHO ARE TASKED WITH THIS
ENORMOUS CAL FROM.
UNDERTAKING FOR ENROLLMENT
PURPOSES I WANT TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR C. W. D. A.'S
REQUEST FOR BUDGET AUGMENTATION
TO ACHIEVE THAT AND ALSO WANT TO
REGISTER ON BEHALF OF KAPPA FOR
AYE HSS.
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE S. S.
P. COLA 80% OF AYE HSS CONSUMERS
ARE SS I SS P. RECIPIENTS AND
THIS WILL HELP A LOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOINT IRVINE I
LIVE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
UNFORESEEN EVENTS OCCUR WELL LET
LET ME LOSS MY HOME AND I BECAME
HOMELESS.
I AM NOW READY TO MOVE I AM NOW
RENTING A ROOM UNDER MY SS I
GRANT. FOR SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS I DEEPLY AS FOR INCREASE
IN THE GRANT AND I TRULY THANK
YOU FOR THE FOOD STAMP THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMIE TOMATO
YEAH.
IN A LIFE I I LOVE THESE CONCERT
BOOKS AND THAT COMES FROM THE
TIME FOR ROAMING BE SEN.
THANK YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
FINALLY WE H. O. THAT WE HAD A
CIVILIZATION THAT AT THE LEVEL
OF THE TIMES.
AND WE HAVE COVERAGE FOR PEOPLE
THAT LEAVES UNDER THE POVERTY
LINE LIVING ON HAS TO SAY.
SO I HOPE THAT YOU CAN MAKE A IS
THE SITE OF SEQUENCE.
IN THAT CASE A I'M AN ADVOCATE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING A. B. SO
SAD TO SEE EVERYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO MANY.
PEOPLE WITHOUT A HOME.
AND YO CAN SEE AND READ TO HOW
MANY PEOPLE HE'S GETTING
DIFFERENT KIND OF SICKNESSES.
CONTAGIOUS SICKNESSES FOR
LEADING OUTSIDE.
SO IN THESE TO CLOSE A LOT THIS
EVERY.
ONE HAS THE RIGHT TO A STANDARD
OF LIVING ADEQUATE FOR THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
THEMSELVES.
AN OLDER FAMILY INCLUDING FOOD
CLOTHING HOUSING AND MEDICAL
CARE AND NECESSARY SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THEIR RIGHT TO
SECURITY AND IN THE EVENT OF
UNEMPLOYMEN.
SICKNESS DISABILITY WIDOWHOOD
OLD AGE.
OR OLDER LACK OF LIVELIHOOD IN
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES BEYOND THEIR
CONTROL ARTICLE TO REFUSE THE
UNITED NATIONS --
THE GLAZER HUMAN RIGHTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANKS MUCH OF MARTY
MOTO CALIFORNIA DISABILITY YOU
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK'S YOU
CAN ALSO FAMILY MEMBER MY SISTER
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE.
AT DEVELOPMENT ON PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES AND ALSO WAS
UNNECESSARY RECIPIENT.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO US
SENATOR PAN AND PROPOSAL FOR THE
THIS IS PICCOLA DEPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK OF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRESS ASIDE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
PROPOSAL --
THAT'S DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
WELL TO DO WHEN A SHOT OUT A
STRONG SHOT OUT TO THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
ITS REMARKABLE WORK WITH WITH
ALL OF US WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS I'VE BEEN IN EVERY
STAKEHOLDER MEETING AT LEAST THE
PUBLIC CYCLE --
MEETINGS SINCE AUGUST THEY'RE
OUT REACH HAS BEEN REMARKABLE --
AND REALLY PRODUCTIVE IN WORKING
IT'S A VERY COMPLICATED --
ROLLOUT AND IT'S BEEN REALLY --
PRODUCTIVE THANK YOU.
CONNIE ARNOLD AGAIN I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF PETERMAN DOES
IT.
OFFER MARIN CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING HE HAD TO
LEAVE EARLY WANTED TO I THANK
THE PROPOSALS THANK YOU. TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND FOR EVERYBODY
WORKING ON MAKING IMPROVEMENTS
TO SS I SS PICCOLA.
AND TO IMPROVING IT WITH CAL
FRESH BUT ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MIKE --
HERALD IS THAT RIGHT.
THE WESTERN.
LAWCENTER AND POVERTY.
REGARDING THOSE PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T GOING.
TO ACTUALLY GET SEE THE TO SEE
MORE IMPROVEMENTS HAPPENED IN
THAT AREA ALSO AND BRING UP AS
AS I UP TO AT LEAST THE POVERTY
LEVEL.
AND ALSO --
HE WANTED ME TO SAY.
THAT HE SUPPORTS THE RESTORATION
OF THE 7%.
I HSS WHICH I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
DOING NOW BUT I'M TRYING TO WRAP
IT UP ALL ONCE.
NOT ONCE AND AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT PERMANENT I MEAN FOR I
AGES AS RESTORATION AND ALSO --
THE EARLIER.
ISSUES REGARDING SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES --
THAT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST AGENDA
ITEMS.
MAKING SURE PEOPLE CAN CONTINUE
TO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND ONE LAST COMMENT SINCE I'M
BASICALLY DOING HIS COMMENTS AS
WELL IS WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS WE HEAR A LOT
ON THE NEWS ABOUT THE TINY HOMES.
AND YOU MAY NOT REALIZE THIS BUT
THERE ARE NO ACCESS REGULATIONS
AROUND.
HOUSING.
AND SMALL HOUSES IN TINY HOMES.
AND SO THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
ADDRESS THE TO ENSURE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR THOSE.
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WHEELCHAIR USERS BECAUSE THERE
ARE SPECIFIC SPACE REQUIREMENTS
FOR MANEUVERABILITY IF YOU'RE IN
A WHEELCHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL KEEP IN
MIND AS I TEXAS COMMENTS TO MAKE
IT [inaudible]
WELCOME.
VERY PASSED MORE THE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
I SIMPLY WANT TO SAY HOW
APPROPRIATE IT FEELS.
THAT WHEN WE ARE FINALLY IN A
CONDITION OF SURPLUS AS OPPOSED
TO DEFICIT FOR DECADES.
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
IN THE STATE ARE FINALLY
BEGINNING TO FEEL A LITTLE BIT
OF PROGRESS.
BOTH WITH THE UP.
THE STAFF PROPOSAL AND THE THE
OP THE HOUSING.
IT'S REALLY REFRESHING TO SEE
THE LEGISLATURE AND OUR NEW
GOVERNOR.
PUT TO MANTISES IN THESE AREAS
AND I AND I APPLAUD THE ADVOCATE
SAID HAVE SUPPORTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
BACK A GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
SOCIAL WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE HEARING TODAY
AND ALL THE GREAT PROPOSALS WERE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF MONEY IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE CALIFORNIA SIX
BRANCH AND THE AGED.
OUT PROGRAM BUT WE ALSO HAVE
BEEN SSI COALITION --
IN CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE --
THE GRANTS TO AT LEAST A 100% OF
POVERTY LEVEL AND ALSO TO HAVE
THE COOLEST START EARLIER IT'S
LONG OVERDUE AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
OUR JUDITH MORE WITH THE MULTI
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FOOD
SECURITY.
FIRST WE ARE SO THRILLED THAT
FINALLY --
SSI RECIPIENTS CAN ENROLL FOR
CAL FOR ASH.
WE WERE THE ONLY STATE IN THE
UNION THAT DID NOT ALLOW.
SSI RECIPIENTS TO ENROLL IN
CALIFORNIA ASH OR FOOD STAMP
PROGRAM.
I VOLUNTEER WITH THE FOOD BANK
AND WE SUPPORT.
THE RESTORATION OF SSI NFS P.
GRANT LEVELS.
THE ECONOMIC AND SECURITY.
IN THAT IS THE MOST SINGLE.
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO THE
STABILITY OF LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME OF OLDER ADULTS AND
DISABLED AND OUR COMMUNITY TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS WARREN
CUSHMAN AND PERSONAL I JUST
WANNA THANK THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALL OF THE ADVOCATES.
FOR MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
CALPERS PROPOSAL SO THAT NOW SSI
RECIPIENTS CAN RECEIVE CAL FRESH.
I ALSO WANT TO CITIZENS BY BUS
IS LEAVING SOON I ONE OF OUR
FULLY SUPPORT.
FUNDING I HSS AND RESTORING THE
CUTS.
AND BUT ON WITH REGARD SSI I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT 70%
OF BLIND AND DISABLED PEOPLE ARE
UNEMPLOYED.
SO WE ALL LIVE IN MOST OF US.
OUR ON SSI.
DUE TO NECESSITY AND I WOULD SAY
THAT I LIVE IN THE BAY AREA.
AND MY RENT IS ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND OF MY EXERCISE IN THE NINE
HUNDRED SO OBVIOUSLY WE GOT A
PROBLEM THERE --
AND SO I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SEE --
THE GRANT --
INCREASED AND THE AND I'D LIKE
TO SEE ALL FUNDING ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS.
IN A AND ALL THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
[inaudible]
HE EARLY IN GOAL WITH THE FOOD
BANK OF CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO --
WE DID A A LARGE HUNGER STUDY OF
THE FOLKS THAT WE SERVE LAST
YEAR AND WE FOUND THAT ALTHOUGH
SS I RECIPIENTS ARE ABOUT YOU
KNOW 2% OF THE POPULATION IN
CONTRA COSTA FOR EXAMPLE.
A QUARTER OF ALL THE HOUSEHOLDS
THAT WE SERVE HAD AS A TIRE
SABAEANS IN THEM AND SO WE ARE
SO VASTLY DISPROPORTIONATELY
SERVING AS A TIRE IS A B. AND
BECAUSE THE GRANT LEVELS ARE SO
LOW AND EVEN WITH THE ADDITION
OF CALIFORNIA'S FOR THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WILL QUALIFY --
THEY'RE STILL GONNA BE A VERY
DEEP LEVEL OF NEED AND SOMEWHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF GRANT
RESTORATIONS ON THE PERMANENT
FUNDING FOR A HOLD HARMLESS
THANKS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK WELCOME.
HI -- MY
NAME'S MARIANA TRUJILLO MSX
STATE STUDENT ALSO INTERNING
WITHOUT FOOD THINK OF CONTRA
COSTA AND SOLANO --
I'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
AYE AYE SINCE I RECIPIENTS AND
SEEING HOW THIS COW FRESH
EXPANSION WOULD DEFINITELY HELP
THEM.
I SEE THAT THIS IS A TWO YEAR
PROPOSAL I WOULD LIKE FOR IT TO
SEE TO BE BECOME AN ONGOING
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FOR WELCOME. TO GET HIGH ELLA
JONES --
SENIOR CONSUMER ADVOCATE --
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE SSI.
BENEFIT BACK INTO THE BUDGET.
I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT COMING FROM
ANOTHER STATE DID THIS.
LIKE STATE SO ACTIVE IN IN SO
PROTESTS FAMILY THAT THAT WAS
THAT NINA [inaudible]
AND SO.
I'VE BEEN INVITED TO BE ON A
PANEL WITH THE FOOD BANK
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS.
THE PROBLEM I SEE IS GOING TO BE
YOUR ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS
AND THAT'S WHERE IT'S GOING TO
BE A PROBLEM DO YOU GUYS AGREE.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH STAFF.
ALAN OF ELIGIBILITY WORKERS IN
I'M JUST.
TO THE CONSUMERS SENIOR.
BUT THE BUDGET NEEDS TO PUT
MONEY OUT THERE FOR THE PEOPLE
WORKING IN THE COUNTIES.
AND THERE'S A PARTNERSHIP THAT'S
BEEN FORMED WHERE THE COUNTY AND
THE ARM.
FOOD CAL FRESH PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO PUT TOGETHER A PROCESS AND
AND A COMPUTER PROGRAM TO GET
THE INFORMATION IN A DETERMINE.
WHO AND THE PRIORITIZE PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE THIS IS WHO IS GOING TO
BOB DOWN?
I BELIEVE YOU GUYS KNOW MORE
ABOUT IT THAN I DO BUT IT SEEMS --
TO NOT BE A ANSWER BUT YOUR
BUDGETING WILL BE THE MAIN CALL
A REASON FOR IT TO GO FORCE ONLY
BECAUSE IT TAKES MONEY TO HIRE
MORE AND THEN YOU HAVE IT'S
GONNA --
DETERMINE WHETHER PEOPLE ARE
ELIGIBLE.
TO ON BE ON THE PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME. THREE THE ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARC IN IN --
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION --
I'M FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD WHERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SS I SS P.
RESTORATION --
CAL PRICE EXPANSION AND THE IT'S
NOT PROGRAM I REALLY DO WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY THAT'S COME
TOGETHER TO WORK SO HARD ON THIS
AND GET US WHERE WE ARE. ONE
LAST THOUGHT BEFORE I STEP AWAY
IS THAT THIS LET'S ALL REMEMBER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOOD AND
HOUSING WHICH ARE BASIC HUMAN
NEEDS AND WE ALL NEED TO BE
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT.
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WELCOME CENTER PAM IT'S ALWAYS
AN HONOR SYRIA.
AND BEEN FOR ANY UP.
I WAS HERE LAST YEAR SO YOU'RE
PROBABLY PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH MY
STORY IT HASN'T CHANGED.
AWESOME BACK UP HERE TALKING
AGAIN.
I AM A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
I AM ALSO A DOMESTIC WORKER.
OUR WITH OUR UNION UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS THIRTY NINE
THIRTY NOT A PLEDGE COUNTY.
AND I TAKE CARE OF AN ELDERLY
VETERAN.
AND I AM VERY BLUSTER HERE BUT
YOU GUYS WANNA RAISE YOU ALSO
SIDE SHE NEEDS A SURE COULD USE
UP.
MYSELF.
I AM STILL WORKING TRYING TO GET
ON SSI.
AS WELL AS TAKE CARE MY VETERANS
RIGHTS ON FORTUNE BECAUSE BOTH
OF MY INJURIES BUT ONLY MILITARY
AS WELL ALSO VOLUME.
SO I'VE BEEN FORCED TO GO TO
BOTH SIDES OF THE HOUSE.
AND PLAY CARDS.
THE GAMBLING GAME IS GETTING
FONG EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I'M ALSO ON YOUR CAL FRESH
PROGRAM.
I AM VERY PROUD AND VERY HONORED
TO BE ON IT.
BUT I STARTED OUT WITH THE MAX
AMOUNT THAT THEY COULD GIVE ME
ONE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR DOLLARS
A MONTH.
NOW I'M DOWN TO SIXTY SEVEN
DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND WITH WHAT I MAKE FOR MY AS I
GET IS A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
SEVENTY EIGHT HOURS AND FIFTY
FIVE MINUTES. FOR ONLY TAKEN
HOME EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR DOLLARS A MONTH DO THE MATH.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
CHAU THIS IS A PROGRAM I'M GLAD
YOU GUYS ARE LOOKING OUT.
I HOPE WE CAN BE REPAIRED AND
HELP YOU CAN REPAIR ALL
INCLUDING MYSELF AND MY ROOMMATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON PANEL FIRST OF
ALL LIKE STATE THAT I'M ADVOCATE
FOR SAINT MARY'S CENTER AND
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT I AM [inaudible]
PERMITTED DISABLED.
I LOST MY HOME TO THE BACON
ISSUES BACK IN.
NINETY SIX ALSO LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE PANEL FOR THE
INCREASED AND OWN FOR SOULS SSI
FOR CHAIR NUMBER.
ONE BUT ALSO I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT ALSO WITH VERY.
BILL FOR THE CURRENT IN JUNE THE
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM IS STILL BE
IS.
BE APPROVED BUT HOWEVER YOU CAN
PAY A BILL WITH WITH FOOD STAMPS.
OKAY AND I'M JUST THERE --
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY AND
YOU ALL KNOW THE HOMELESS TO
SITUATION THAT IS INCOME HELP WE
ASKING FOR YOUR HELP AND I'M
ASKING YOU AND REQUESTED THAT
YOU HELP US.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO SAID KNOWING MY
NINETY DUE TO MY ANNA --
LATELY WITH MY DENTAL BECAUSE
THEY CAN PAY FOR MY OWN
APARTMENT.
THING I WHO OF THE BUSINESS SITE
IS INCREASE.
NOT A YOU RIGHT NOW THESE.
DAYS THE PEOPLE THE SAME PEOPLE
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE IN THE
SAME SITUATION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
KEEP IN MIND THAT I KNOW A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT CANNOT BE HERE
FOR ONE REASON OR ANOTHER.
SO I FEEL IKE I AM A HUGE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF PLEASE FIRST
FOR THE RECORD THAT'S WHAT I WAS
GOING TO RIGHT NOW.
MY NAME IS SAM THAT BE GOOD
THEORIES I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I WORK THREE JOBS FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
ALL OR MOST OF THE TWENTY YEARS
MOSTLY I HOLD ONE JOBS ON NAM
TALKING FRITTATA FULL TIME JOBS.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO
STRONGLY ORGIA. TO COME.
THE COMMITTEE TO FULLY FUNDING
IT'S THE SIDE.
AN OLD AGING ADORNMENTS I'M OVER
TWENTY ONE OKAY.
AND SERVICES PROGRAM THESE
PROGRAMS ARE IMPORTANT. TO MY
DAILY LIVING ON TO FOUR DAYS
LEAD LEAVING THIS OUR LIVES LISA
RE YOUR PEOPLE.
BECAUSE OF THIS PROGRAM ON THE
ABLE TO BE HERE.
THERE WAS A TIME THAT I WAS IN
BED BATH READING AT AN ISOLATED
I'M VERY SEEK BUT THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE HELPED ME.
S. ASIDE HAVE HELPED ME TO GO
THROUGH ALL MY TRIALS.
ARE WITH DIGNITY.
PLEASE.
KEEP IT GOING.
I ALSO LIKE TO TELL YOU SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS AND SOCIAL SECURITY
ALLOW ME TO GET WELL WITH
DIGNITY.
I STILL NEED THEIR HELP
[inaudible]
WITHOUT THESE.
SB SIX I WILL EXPERIENCE HELD
DECADENCE AND I WILL BE BACK.
NOT HERE FOR SURE.
I WLL NOT BE HERE.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD NEED THE
SELLER BASIS OR THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NEVER NEVER THOUGHT.
I COME TO THESE HEARINGS BECAUSE
I WANT TO CONTINUE I HAVE THE
FATE.
THAT THINGS CAN GET BETTER IF WE
SPEAK UP.
AND I WANT TO CONTINUE THE
BENEFITS FROM SAID AND BASIS I
DEPEND ON MANY OF THE PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW.
THE BAND ON IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL THAT YOU DO.
THANK YOU THANKS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WITH EVEN LESS VOICE GOOD
AFTERNOON IT'S THE IT'S EVIL
CARD FROM JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE
WHAT'S LEFT OF MY VOICE OF LOS
ANGELES REALLY I WANT TO ECHO.
LEAVE IT TO THE RECIPIENTS TO
TELL THEIR STORY.
BUT THANK YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND TO ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP WE NEED THE CONTINUED
INVESTMENT.
THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME A CRYSTAL CASEY WITH
MERCY BROWN BAG PROGRAM AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK -- JUST
ME [inaudible]
TOO THANK YOU.
WELCOME MY NAME IS LUCIA LITTLE --
I'D PREVIOUSLY HAVE BEEN ON SSI
MYSELF SO.
AND WITH CHILDREN SO I KNOW THAT
IT'S VERY HARD TO LIVE WITH
CHILDREN.
AND MAINTAIN A PLACE SO I BOUGHT
A MOBILE HOME.
SO WHEN I BECAME OLDER I KNOW
I'D BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT EVEN
NOW WITH.
HAVING A MOBILE HOME ONLY HAPPEN
TO PAY THE SPACE.
IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH YOU HAVE
TO HAVE EXTRA JOBS [inaudible]
SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NINE
APPROVED.
HELP YOU DO APPROVED THE SS I SS
P. AND THE FOOD STAMPS INCREASED
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HOW YOU DOING MY NAME IS
SHARON MCINTOSH --
FROM SAINT MARY'S CENTER.
OF HOPE AND JUSTICE OF WEST
OAKLAND.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO STE --
TO COMMITTEE STRONGLY
[inaudible] TO GIVE BACK THE
GRANT FOR THE FOR THE SSI THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS DAN BRADLEY I'M
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I AM AN
ADVOCATE FOR HOPE AND JUSTICE
FOR SAINT MERRI SOONER.
AND I'M HERE ADVOCATING FOR MY
NEIGHBORS AND MY FRIENDS BECAUSE
I SEE THAT THEY HAVE FOOD AND
SECURITY.
AND THEY THEY HAVE A NETWORK
WHERE THEY GO TO DIFFERENT
CHURCHES AND GET FREE FREE BAGS
OF FOOD ALSO SAYING MERRY CENTER
PROVIDES MERCY BROWN BAG.
ON SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING SS CYANOSIS P. AND I
HOPE YOU'LL INCREASE THE AMOUNTS
ABOVE THE POVERTY LEVEL LEVEL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI SHANTI PRASAD WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN
THE CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI
COALITION --
WE'RE GRATEFUL AND EXCITED TO BE
ABLE TO ENROLL SO MANY NEW FOLKS
ON TO A CAL FRESHMAN SUS I
RECIPIENTS --
VERY SOON AND WE SUPPORT CW DO
T. A.'S REQUEST FOR FUNDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
BE AS SEAMLESS A PROCESS AS
POSSIBLE AND TO ENROLL AS MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE ON TO HELP
FRESH -- WE
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT AN
INCREASE TO SSI ABOVE THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS THE NEED A
WILLIAMS.
AND I'M HERE WITH HOPE AND
JUSTICE AT SAINT MARY'S.
AND I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
INCREASE THE SS I BENEFITS IN
THE COW FRESH FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA OUR SENIORS
AS WELL AS MYSELF WE DESERVE TO
LIVE IN DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
THINGS WE PUT IN SO MANY YEARS
OF HARD WORK AND LABOR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE DESERVE AN
INCREASE IN SSI.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO CARS I NEVER THIRTY
JOHNSON.
A REPRESENTATIVE FOR SAY MERS
[inaudible]
APPLICANTS [inaudible]
OKAY -- I
THANK YOU OFFER AS A SIDE WHICH
ARE GIVEN US RIGHT NOW.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
NOT ENOUGH FOR US TO LIVE ON
HOMELESS AND NOT I'VE BEEN HOMES
ON THE STREETS.
FINALLY SEVEN YEARS.
NOW I LOOK GOOD BUT STILL GOT
ADDRESS.
I NEED TO EAT TWO FULL STOPS
[inaudible]
WE NEED.
YOU VERY MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE THE JOB GIVEN
JUSTICE CHEST TO SPEAK ABOUT IT.
I WOULD TAKE OUT FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
BUT WE WHICH ARE HAPLESS.
MORE THAN ANYTHING.
THIS ALLOWED TO SERVE RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A BET
WITH CENTRAL CALIFORNIA FOOD
BANK CAL FRESH OUT REACH TEAM
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MORE OF
THE SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE --
FOR SSI MEMBERS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHO COULD NOT BE WITH US
TODAY BUT WE STRONGLY ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CAL FRESH
EXPANSION AS WELL AS RAISING THE
SSI BENEFIT AMOUNTS TO THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. ONE OF
OUR CLIENTS WHO UNFORTUNATELY
HAD TO CANCEL LAST MINUTE BUT
SHE PUT IT PERFECTLY SHE SAID
IT'S A STRUGGLE. TO LIVE.
AND BARELY MAKE ENDS MEET FEED
MYSELF AND KEEP MY DIGNITY AT
THE END OF THE MONTH SO I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
ALL THE PROPOSITIONS --
AND PROPOSALS BROUGHT UP TO YOU
TODAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE
CABLES ALSO REPRESENTING CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA FOOD BANK JUST WANT
TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
AND SAYING THAT.
OF THE FIVE COUNTY SERVICE AREA
THAT WE REPRESENT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SERVING TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND CLIENTS EACH
MONTH WE DO SERVE A LARGE AMOUNT
OF SS I RECIPIENTS AND SO WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF AND THE RESTORATION OF GRANT
AMOUNTS AND ALSO SO VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE WORK THAT.
THAT AND THE STATE IS DOING AND
AT THE CAO FRESH EXPANSION SO
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS CAROLYN
SENTENCE I'M.
WITH THE US A MARRIAGE PROGRAM --
ALSO ALSO SENIOR I'M DISABLE AND
I'M HOMELESS.
I'M TRYING IT I HAVE BURKE HAD
AS MUCH.
I HAVE A DIVIDE IS AN IS LIGHT I
HAVE.
TO TRY TO KEEP MYSELF IN A PLACE
WHERE I CAN.
YOU KNOW THE BACK IT'S HARD TO
LIVE ON THE STREET.
EIGHT YOU'RE ON THE SIDE YOU CAN
COOK THERE'S A PLACE YOU CAN
COOK.
SO YOU HAVE TO USE WHAT LITTLE
BIT MONEY TO HAVE.
AND EVEN THOUGH WE'RE HOMELESS
WITH THAT THEY'LL STOP THE OTHER
BILLS THAT WE HAD BEFORE WE GOT
HOMELESS.
BASED ECONOMY IT.
IS THEY HAVE TO BE PAID.
AND WEBER IF WE HAVE TO PAY
THOSE BILLS BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
EAT WE HAVE TO LEAVE.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OF
INCREASING IN IS ASIDE I THANK
YOU FOR THE FOOD STAMPS --
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GET OUT OF NEWS YES LAYS JIM --
MY NAME IS ALVIN FOR AND YOU
DECEIVE ME LAST YEAR.
HE SEE ME THE THIS ONE A CM IN
THAT AGAIN --
RECEPTION OF SSI --
I WAS CUT.
I'LL CUT SO MANY OF THIS IS THAT
BECAUSE I'M A VETERAN.
I DON'T GET VERY MUCH A MESSAGE
FROM VA. FOR THE MONEY THAT GATT.
S. IS THAT CUT ME RIO DE.
A CUT ME DOWN TWENTY SEVEN
DOLLARS [inaudible]
EIGHTY EIGHT OKAY.
I AM.
ELEVEN BY MY GRACE.
I KNOW HOW TO SURVIVE.
BUT ON OUR OWN OTHER HAND IF THE
WAITING FOR A I KNOW I DON'T
HAVE WHO STANDS [inaudible]
OKAY.
ON THE OTHER HAND I GOT --
HOUSING BUT IN HAVE HOUSING I BE
LIKE A ON THE STREET.
AND IF I WAS ON THE STREET
EVERYBODY HER.
I DO NOT A HURRY I JUST DON'T
WANT HER.
I DON'T LIKE JAIL AND THAT SURE
THE ONLY INSTITUTION.
AND JEFF I KNOW ONE DAY I MAKE
IT ONE DAY BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT.
WHEN HE CALLED ME --
WHOEVER CALLED YOU.
SO -- EIGHT
YOU'LL --
I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU DID SOME
OF BY OUR OUR FOOD STAMP PROBLEM.
ALLOWS SO THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
FOOD STAMPS TO GIVE THEM. ELEVEN
A IF YOU ALLOW ME TO GET A GET
BIGGER THAN WHAT I AM BUT I'M
NOTING.
HOW WORKING ONLY YOU KNOW --
ARE YOU HAPPY THEY SAID I HAD
OVER.
A HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS THE
PAY BACK I PAID BACK.
THIS IS I CAN'T SEEM TO FIND HIS
HUNGER FOR THE HOUSE THIS MEANT
THREE MONTHS AGO.
THANK YOU GIVE ME A RUN AROUND
SEVEN ME HOW I GOT THE WAY SOME
OF TIME.
I WILL HAVE TO MONTH.
PICKED A GUY KANNAMMA MONEY.
CAN I HAVE MY MONEY BACK
[inaudible]
ANYWAY.
PLEASE CONTINUE TO GIVE MY
PEOPLE.
DEBATE MORE MONEY SO THEY CAN
SURVIVE.
WE NEED TO STOP HOME JUSTICE I'M
NOT HOMELESS.
I HAVE APARTMENT THANK YOU I
HAVE A CAR.
I GET WHAT I NEED.
AND I'M NOT GONNA LET NOBODY
TAKE IT AWAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE THANK YOU.
I HI I'M CALLING CHRISTY PUTNAM
I'M TRYING TO THINK OF WHAT I
CAN ADDRESS THAT PEOPLE HAVEN'T
MENTIONED THANK YOU FOR THE FOOD
STAMPS LIKE THE ONE MAN SAID I
HOPE IT DOESN'T BECOME A BAIT
AND SWITCH WHICH OFTEN SEEMS TO
HAPPEN WITH THINGS LIKE SOCIAL
SECURITY --
THEY SAY OH WELL YOU HAVE THIS
TO YOU CAN TAKE LESS HERE.
YOU KNOW THAT HAPPENS --
I ACTUALLY DEAD IT FOR A WHILE
WHEN I BECAME VERY CLOSE TO
HOMELESS --
I USED TO HAVE A PAID OFF HOUSE
IN THE HILLS WHEN I WAS MARRIED
AND I LOST EVERYTHING IN A
REALLY NASTY DIVORCE AND THEN MY
EX KILLED HIMSELF.
PART OF HOW I'M LIVING NOW IS ON
SURVIVORS BENEFITS --
FROM HIM HAVING DONE THAT SO HE
ACTUALLY BENEFITED ME BY TAKING
HIS OWN LIFE BECAUSE HE WAS
MENTALLY ILL --
I DON'T KNOW IF HE REALIZES BUT
WHEN PEOPLE APPLY FOR SSI YOU
DON'T GET IT FOR AT LEAST SIX
MONTHS. TO THREE YEARS EVEN IF --
DISABLED --
I SET MYSELF UP A LOT WHILE I
WAS GETTING SOME STE.
YOU KNOW A TEMPORARY SPOUSAL
SUPPORT SO THAT I WAS KIND OF
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS SO THAT
HELPED ME.
BUT THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF PEOPLE
LIVING IN VIOLENT SITUATIONS
WHERE THEY'RE BEING ABUSE LIKE
WOMEN ARE STAYING LONGER LIVING
WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE HURTING
THEM BECAUSE IT BEATS LIVING ON
THE STREETS AS WE CAN SEE RIGHT.
AND IMAGINE IF YOU ARE HOMELESS
WHERE DO YOU GO TO THE BATHROOM
HOW DO YOU CHARGE YOUR PHONE AT
TO LOOK FOR JOBS OR ANYTHING
ELSE HOW DO YOU APPLY FOR FOOD
STAMPS.
AND HOW DO YOU CHARGE THAT PHONE
YEAH YOU CAN GET AN OBAMA PHONE
BUT HOW DO YOU CHARGE IT --
HOW DO YOU STAY WARM IF YOU OF
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT TO KEEP
YOURSELF ALIVE HOW DO YOU PLUG
THAT IN?
HOW DO YOU COOK FOOD HOW DO YOU
STORE FOOD HOW DO YOU KEEP YOUR
FOOD FRESH YES YOU CAN GET FOOD
STAMPS BUT HOW DO YOU KEEP THAT
FOOD FRESH?
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU CARRY IT
AROUND IF YOU'RE DISABLED HOW DO
YOU LOG STUFF AROUND.
YOU KNOW MY PARTNER THAT I'M
WITH ROMANTICALLY.
HAS BEEN HOMELESS ON AND OFF FOR
YEARS.
AND THE REASON HE'S NOT HOMELESS
NOW IS BECAUSE I HAVE MOVED HIM
AND THAT'S ALWAYS THAT'S
SOMETIMES A DIFFICULT SITUATION
BECAUSE HE HAS SOME ISSUES THAT
ARE DIFFICULT.
BUT IT'S LIKE I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE FOR PEOPLE TO BE HOMELESS I
KNOW PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
CULVERTS I KNOW PEOPLE THAT LIVE
IN.
AND STORAGE CONTAINERS I KNOW
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN TENTS I KNOW
QUITE A FEW OF THEM THEY'RE NOT
ALL ACCOUNTED IN THOSE HOMELESS
COUNTS.
I THINK THEY IN RICHMOND I
BELIEVE THAT THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOW HOMELESS
JUST IN THE LAST YEAR WHEN THAT
WERE SENIORS OR DISABLED WHEN UP
18% AND ONE YEAR.
HUGE AMOUNT.
THERE'S A JUST SOME ISSUES. TO
BRING UP GEN THANK YOU.
WELL I HAVE THE CELL GROUP A LOT
OF P. --
WHAT THAT PERSON JUST TO BE FOR
ME FEATHER PEOPLE ARE LIVING ON
THE STREET?
AT THEIR OWN IF THEY HAVE FUN.
WELL WE COULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE HOUSING COSTS OR MORE PEOPLE
GONNA BE ON IF IF --
ARE ON THE STREETS.
MAY I GREW WE NEED TO INCREASE
THE VOLUME OUT AT LEAST FOR THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IF NOT
MORE.
DID YOU LITTLE THEN THE TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE STATE
COURTS WAS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
DOLLARS NOW ONLY.
ONE SIXTY SEVENTY TWO ALL HUGE
CRACKED.
I WOULD EXPECT THE REPUBLICANS
DEMOCRATS.
SO LOVE DO YOU DO THE JOB AND DO
A MAKE.
INCREASE THE AMOUNT IF THE
FEDERAL FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
Q..
THANK YOU.
WRAP UP AND LISA COLEMAN CHALCO
Là AB WE JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE ARE.
SOME OF THE SMALLER AND SMALLER
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS FOR THE SS I
SS P. IN THE ASSISTED LIVING
ROOM AND SO THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT SEGMENT.
AND ALSO.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN NURSING HOMES TODAY
BECAUSE THE LACK OF A HOT MEAL
AND ACCESSIBILITY OF THE FOOD
STAMP PROGRAM SO.
THANK YOU FOR RESTORING MORE OF
THE SPOKE THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS TERRENCE
ENTRY ALMA HOPING JUSTICE
ADVOCATE FOR SAINT MERRI SENIOR.
RIGHT ELEMENT TRANSITION.
AND IS TAX IS NOT ENOUGH FOR ME
TO SAVE MONEY SO I CAN MOVE. TO
MY OWN PLACE SO THANK YOU AND
I'M THE WE NEED MORE MONEY TO
HELP OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
AND THERE.
MIGHT IS KILEY ME HOCKEY'S AND I
AM ON SSI RECIPIENT.
FROM BERKELEY AND I LAKE.
I'M DO REALLY WELL YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE A CLEAN FASCES SO --
BUT I DO THAT THERE IS A THERE
ARE SO MANY PEOPLE SO MANY OF US
WHO AREN'T --
BOB LINE AND BRAIN DAMAGE AND
THE SO MANY OF US I HAVE SOME
ADVOCATES THERE ARE SO MANY WHO
DON'T AND DO NEEDS TO BE STUFF
YOU ARE --
BUSINESSES FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE A VOICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GUYS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME HELLO I'M ANTHONY FABER
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
REALLY WANT YOU TO BRING THAT
SAYS I UP TO A 100% OF THE
POVERTY LINE.
LIKE MY BASIC JAM IS THAT.
AS AS I GOES UP ACCORDING TO THE
FEDERAL INFLATION RATE WHERE'S
MY RENT I HAVE A RENT CONTROLLED
APARTMENT.
BUT IT GOES UP WITH THE REGIONAL.
INFLATION RATE WHICH IS WHAT
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
INFLATION RATE SO BASICALLY OVER
THE TEN YEARS LIKE YOU KNOW IT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I WAS AT NINE
THIRTY FIVE IT WENT DOWN.
TO EIGHT THIRTY FIVE AND I'VE
BEEN GETTING THE FEDERAL
COALESCENCE THERE AND AND THEN A
FEW THINGS FROM THE STATE AND SO
NOW.
MY BENEFIT IS I JUST TWO OR
THREE DOLLARS LESS THAN WHAT I
WAS ME BUT WHEN I WAS GETTING IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND MY RENT
HAS BEEN GOING UP AND SO YOU
BASICALLY I HAVE TWENTY DOLLARS
MORE THAN MY RIGHT NOW.
IN MAY MY RENT GOES UP AND I
WILL HAVE.
MY BUT WILL BE HIGHER THAN WHAT
I GET FROM SSI.
AND SO IF YOU COULD INCREASE IT
SO THAT WORRY ABOUT.
IT THIS GAP YEAH I MEAN THAT THE
GUY WAS STILL GOING TO BE THERE
BECAUSE FEDERAL VERSUS WILL BE
JOURNAL BUT IT WILL BE IT'LL
GIVE ME SOME BREATHING ROOM.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS MY NAME IS
JENNY BECAUSE STEEL I'M AN
ORGANIZER FOR SAINT MARY'S
CENTER OUT OF WEST OAKLAND.
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT MOST
OF US CAME AND GOT UP AT SIX AND
GOT ON A BUS AT EIGHT IN THE
MORNING TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
SAW THE FACES.
OF THE FOLKS THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE HELPING IN JUNE WITH THE
FOOD STAMPS.
BUT YOUR WORK IS NOT DONE AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN YOUR
THINKING AND YOUR PLANNING BUT
IT'S TIME TO RAISE THE SSI
GRANTS.
IT'S TIME TO RAISE THEM NOT JUST
FOR THE FOLKS IN THE STORIES
THAT YOU HEARD HERE BUT FOR US
CALIFORNIANS WHO BELIEVE TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
IT WILL THE FLOOD OF MONEY INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES INTO OUR CITIES
WILL BENEFIT OUR COMMUNITY SO
IT'S NOT JUST.
A NEEDY POOR SITUATION IT REALLY
HELPS EVERYONE IN OUR CITY WITH
THE FLOOD OF MONEY THAT IS GOING
TO BE GOING TO THE HANDS OF OUR
SENIORS OF OUR DISABLED PEOPLE.
INTO OUR STORES AND SO IT'S JUST
THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH I KNOW IT IS
ALREADY DONE I'M CLAIMING THAT
IT IS ALREADY DONE.
LET'S PUT IT THERE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME IS OUR PAYMENT TO ONE ON
BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK.
WE ASK THAT YOU ENSURE THAT
SENIORS AND PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES IN OUR STATE ARE
ABLE TO LIVE A LIFE OF DIGNITY
BY RAISING THE GRANT LEVEL ON SS
I SS P..
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
A SIGNATURE VALLEY I'M FROM LAKE
COUNTY AND I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING SINCE THERE'S ONLY ONE
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE OR TO
MEMBERS OF THE BE THE THAT'S
HEARING WHAT WE'RE SAYING TODAY.
IS THE OTHER ONE'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR WHAT WE'RE SAYING
TODAY BY HAVING A PLAYED FOR A
MORE.
OR SOMETHING SO THEY CAN GET IT
LATER DOWN BECAUSE DOESN'T DO US
ANY GOOD TO TALK TO DO IT
BECAUSE IT TAKES ALL COMMITTEE
TO VOTED IN.
BUT I ALSO WANT YOU TO KNOW I
WAS BEEN HOMELESS ALL OF LAST
YEAR WITH MY FORTY TWO YEAR OLD
SON.
HE'S DISABLED MEN ONLY HE'S ON
SSI.
IF IT WASN'T FOR HIS CHECK.
MY CHECK THOSE PENSION.
I WORK THREE JOBS FULL TIME WITH
I A TEST US.
M. SIXTY FOUR AND I'M GETTING
OLD AND I DON'T WANT TO KEEP
WORKING THAT ART BUT RAISE IT
HIS SSI.
AND GIVING THEM FOOD STAMPS IS
GONNA MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
OUR LIVES.
AND WE FINALLY FOUND A HOME BUT
I LIVE IN LAKE COUNTY SO THE
ONLY HOME I COULD FIND WAS
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
SO WE'RE BARELY MAKING IT WE'RE
NOT MAKING ENDS MEET NOW THAT
WERE LIVING THERE BUT IT WAS
STILL BETTER THE MOTEL.
I SPENT TWENTY ONE HUNDRED MONTH.
SO I JUST BEG YOU.
PLEASE DON'T LISTEN TO THESE
PEOPLE ON THE STREET IS A THEY
DON'T NEED TO RAISE THEY GET
MONEY OFF THE STATE THEY'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING WITH IT ANYHOW
THAT'S A BUNCH OF BALONEY YES WE
DO NEED IT.
AND WE DO NEED THE FOOD STAMPS
THEY NEEDED THAT FOR A LONG LONG
TIME SO PLEASE GO FORWARD WITH
IT.
THANK YOU TELL YOUR OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TO SO JUST THE AYE AYE WE JUST
MENTION THAT --
THE I KNOW THAT THEIR THAT THEIR
OFFICES ARE DEFINITELY
MONITORING THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IN MY CONVERSATION WITH
THEM SO YOU ARE BEING YOU ARE
BEING LISTENED --
TO THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT I I TAKE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND I'M AT
HAPPY TO BE HERE PERSONALLY TO
HEAR EACH ONE OF YOU AS WELL
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO MY NAME IS
ANTOINETTE I'M FROM HUMBOLDT
COUNTY.
AND I MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE A JOB
WHEN I GET AND THE REALLY ANGRY
THAT I VOLUNTEERED TO COME UP
HERE VERSUS GOING THEY'RE MAKING
MONEY BUT THIS IS IMPORTANT.
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT I HAVE A
SECRET GOAL IN MY LIFE AND THAT
IS. TO NOT BE ON ANY MEDICATION
BY THE TIME I HIT SO SECURITY
AGE I'VE ONLY GOT EIGHT MORE
YEARS TO GO AND I ONLY TAKE AYE
DROPS.
BUT YOU KNOW SOME WOMEN THE
RIGHT A BOOK I'VE BEEN TAKING
CARE PEOPLE FOR OVER TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS.
AND THE BOOK TITLE IS GOING TO
BE WHICH MAKES ME THINK OF YOU
GUYS HERE.
AND I DON'T KNOW YOU GUYS BUT AS
IF I COULD ONLY SEEN THROUGH
YOUR EYES I WOULD TO TAKE CARE
OF YOU BETTER SORRY THAT I WAS
BLIND [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE SO OKAY BY ONE THANK
YOU EVERYONE --
FOR INTO --
TESTIFIED IN THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE I KNOW THAT
THE FOLKS WAITING FOR I JUST US
HAVE BEEN VERY PATIENT.
AND SO WE ARE GOING TO BE
LEAVING ON THEN --
TO TALKING ABOUT --
AND I TO ASSESS SO WILL YES.
SO WE CAN BRING UP THE MEMBERS
OF THE PHARMACIST SERVICES FOR
DISPERSION OF THIS PORTION OF
THE HEARING AND SO WE WILL BE
HEARING AN OVERVIEW.
HOW HIT THE HIGHLIGHTS AND THEN
WE HAVE --
SOME TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
MAINTENANCE OF F. FOLLOWED BY.
SEVEN NINE OKAY.
OKAY TO BUY A PC P. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW DATA
ANALYSIS AND THEN WE HAVE I
BELIEVE FIVE FIVE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS RELATED TO I JUST US
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ON ALL THOSE TOGETHER SO --
SO ACTUALLY SINCE THIS AGAIN OF
THE CATEGORY WOULD ASK EVERYONE
TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AGAIN
FOR THE RECORD I KNOW MANY OF
YOU.
HAVE INTRODUCED YOURSELF BEFORE
BUT JUST FOR THE RECORD FOR THIS
ITEM SO AGAIN DSS IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES START WITH
THERE.
ARE SUCH SERVICES.
DAVIES HELPS A DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ADULT PROGRAMS.
THE SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU.
FEATURING THE CHIEF DEPUTY AT
THE DEPARTMENT.
JACOB POOR FINANCE.
OF YEAH MY OWN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
YEAH ONLY DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
ACCURACY --
ELIA JEANNIE BELL LA O..
K. FINANCE CUT OFF TO THE JOB
HERE ALL RIGHT WELCOME ALL RIGHT
SO -- WHEN
WE GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH THE?
AN OVERVIEW OF AYE HSS IN THE
END MAINLY ABOUT HITTING VIA THE
HIGHLIGHTS WHICH HAVE BEEN VERY
GOOD ABOUT I THINK THERE'S SOME
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS WE HAD THAT
WE WERE PARTICULARLY INTERESTED
IN AS WELL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO THE POWER POINT TO STARTS
WITH THE BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT
THE PROGRAM ITSELF --
WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND CURRENT.
RECIPIENTS RECEIVING I AGES US --
AS THE ESTIMATED FOR A FISCAL
YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY ARE THE
BREAKDOWN OF THAT GIVES YOU BY
AGE THEIR SEASON SEE THAT A
LITTLE BIT --
THEN WE GO INTO SOME BUDGET
INFORMATION FOR YOU.
AND THEN SOME INFORMATION AGAIN
ABOUT THE GROWTH OF THE PROGRAM
AND RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS
OVER TIME.
WE'RE UP TO ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PROVIDERS AS WELL IN
THE PROGRAM.
GIVES YOU SOME DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION ABOUT BOTH THE
RECIPIENT SEVEN AM THE PROVIDERS
THAT YOU CAN.
TAKE A LOOK AT AND THEN IT GOES
INTO GIVING OUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SICK LEAVE
BENEFIT.
THAT OCCURRED THIS LAST JULY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO OUR EYES
HAS PROVIDERS ARE NOW ELIGIBLE.
FOR EIGHT HOURS --
ANNUALLY AND THAT WILL GO UP AS
THE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES. TO
SIXTEEN HOURS WHEN MINIMUM WAGES
THIRTEEN AND TWENTY FOUR I'M NOT
A FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR --
THE ELECTRONIC SERVICES PORTAL I
KNOW YOUR LITTLE BIT INTERESTED
AND THE ELECTRONIC TIME SHEETS
SO THAT IS FULLY OPERATIONAL
STATEWIDE AND HAS BEEN FOR A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR NOW I THINK.
AND WE HAVE A JUST OVER ABOUT
32% OF OUR PROVIDERS ARE IN
ROLES NOW IN THE PORTAL AND
USING ELECTRONIC TIME SHEETS --
AS A WAY OF SUBMITTING THEIR
TIME FOR PAYMENT --
THERE IS ALSO A LITTLE OVER 40%
OF PROVIDERS THAT ARE RECEIVING
THEIR PAYMENTS THROUGH A DIRECT
DEPOSIT --
OFF OPTION.
THEN IT GOES INTO OUR ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION --
AND I CAN I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT ME TO COVER YOUR QUESTION
NOW AS FAR AS ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION --
AS FAR YEAH UPDATE ON BASS.
PLEASE OKAY SO THE REQUIRE THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION SYSTEM FOR OUR
PROVIDERS --
ME BY.
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY WAS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT NOW.
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF FOR MORE
WITH ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS WE
HAVE TO PASS GOING WE HAVE THE
DESIGN AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SYSTEM ITSELF.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION PATH SO AS FAR AS
THE DESIGN AND DEVELOPMENT THERE
WILL BE TWO PRIMARY OPTIONS FOR
PROVIDERS TO UTILIZE IN.
IN DOING ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION EITHER ONLINE OR
THROUGH A TELEPHONE SOLUTION.
THE ONLINE SOLUTION WE DID AN
EXTENSIVE --
OUTSIDE.
THE STAKEHOLDER --
LAST FALL WE GOT --
TO VERY POSITIVE RESPONSE TO THE
EASE AND SIMPLICITY OF THAT SO
THAT PEACE IS.
FAIRLY WELL --
COMPLETED THE TELEPHONE SOLUTION
WE WILL BE DOING THOSE DEMOS
COMING UP NOW IN MARCH AND APRIL.
THAT WILL FOCUS PRIMARILY ON
WALKING INDIVIDUALS THROUGH THE
SCRIPTING PROCESS AND THE
PROMISE THAT THEY WOULD RECEIVE
TO ENTER THAT INFORMATION AND
THAT IN A TELEPHONE --
OPTION AND THE DE INTENT AND WE
ARE ON TRACK IS TO COMPLETE
THOSE BY JULY OF THIS YEAR JULY
OF NINETEEN AND HAVE IT READY.
TO MOVE INTO A PILOT PHASE AND
ROLLOUT OF THAT SYSTEM.
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLEMENTATION WE ARE WORKING ON
MATERIALS FOR OUTREACH AND
TRAINING WE'RE BEGINNING TO SEND
THOSE OUT TO OUR STAKEHOLDERS
THIS MONTH TO START LOOKING AT
THOSE AND GIVING US FEEDBACK ON
THEM BECAUSE WE WILL ALSO WANT.
TO HAVE THEM ALL TRANSLATED ONCE
THEY HAVE BEEN.
A WE'VE GOTTEN ALL THE
APPROPRIATE FEEDBACK AND HAVE
THEM READY TO BEGIN USING WITH --
WITH OUR PILOT FOLKS IN JULY --
THAT WE WILL ALSO BE TALKING
ABOUT HE STRATEGY FOR HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE ROLLING THAT OUT WE
HAVE MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS THAT WILL BE COMING UP
THE END OF MARCH --
THAT WE'LL BE DISCUSSING PLAN IS
TO START IMPLEMENTING IN JULY
AND IT WILL BE AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD TO BRING
US -- TO THE
END OF DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ON
THE IN ORDER TO MEET THE FEDERAL
TIMELINES WELL THAT'S A YEAR
PAST THE DATE.
THE STATE DOES INTEND TO APPLY
FOR THE ONE YEAR GOOD FAITH
EFFORT AT EXCEPTION FROM THE
PENALTY FOR ON THAT YEAR PERIOD.
AND SO THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT
WITH THAT PROCESS --
IN AND THEN AFTER THE ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION IT ALSO
INCLUDES --
INFORMATION ABOUT --
WE WILL BE --
STARTING TO INCLUDE --
SOME ADDITIONAL PROGRAM DATA
THAT'S GOING TO BE GOING UP ON
OUR WEBSITE WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW OF SHARING THAT WITH
OUR COUNTIES BECAUSE IT WILL BE
COUNTY LEVEL DATA AS WELL.
AND SO WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE THAT
UP THAT.
END OF MARCH BEGINNING OF APRIL.
BEFORE WITH THE COMMENTS FROM LA --
IN FINANCE --
JUST THE THE CLERK AND THE
SELECT TRONIC TIME SHEETS HAS IF
SO I THINK THE LAST.
TIME WE TALKED ABOUT LAST YEAR
WE WERE DOES THAT AT THE FEDERAL
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COME UP
WITH THERE'S ACTUAL REGULATIONS
AROUND THAT.
AROUND ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION YES THEY HAVE NOT
ISSUED REGULATIONS OKAY
NECESSARILY ANTICIPATE THEY'RE
GOING.
TO DO ANYTHING SIGNIFICANT WITH.
OKAY AND TO SOME DEGREE THAT OR
FLEXIBILITY AND CHECK TO DO IT
AND THE WAY THAT WORKS BEST FOR
GOOD.
WHAT OUR NEEDS ARE OKAY SO I I
THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DO SOME BACK AND FORTH
ABOUT BECAUSE --
SERVICE IN THE ABSENCE OF
INFORMATION WE OVERSHOOT RIGHT
AND RECOGNIZING THAT.
SO I THINK THERE WAS SOME
TENSION ABOUT WELL WHAT ARE THE
FEDS GOING TO PUT IN REGULATION
AND WHAT WE DO AND SO FORTH SO.
I JUST WANT TO FIND A WAY THE
FEDS WERE ON ON THE ON ON THEIR
RULES BUT THAT THEY WOULD BE
GOOD IF THEY GIVE US SOME SOME
FLEXIBILITY.
THAT THEY ARE --
ALLOWING FOR THAT FLEXIBILITY
AND ALLOWING US TO WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO DO WHAT OKAY
WORK FAST EXCELLENT EXCELLENT
AND THEN --
JUST ALSO.
DID IT AT THE PROVIDER BACK UP
SYSTEM FOR THE PAID SICK LEAVE --
TOBY IDIOT AND STAND THE THE
PAID SICKLY WORKGROUP IN A FIRE
BACK UP SYSTEM RECOGNIZING THAT.
YOU KNOW JUST HOW.
HOW THAT HOW IS THAT GOING?
SO WHAT WITH SICKLY BEING
IMPLEMENTED THERE WAS SOME
CONCERN ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT OF
THAT WOULD BE FOR INDIVIDUALS --
WHEN THEIR PROVIDER WAS OUT SICK
AND BEING ABLE TO RECEIVE THEIR
CARE SO WE ARE WORKING WITH
ABOUT TEN COUNTIES AND PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES INCLUDING LA COUNTY
WHICH IS ABOUT 40% OF OUR
CASELOAD? TO GATHER DATA ABOUT
WHAT IS OCCURRING --
AND WHAT KIND OF REQUEST THE
COUNTIES ARE GETTING --
FOR BACK UP DUE TO THE SICK
LEAVE IMPLEMENTATION AT OUR
FIRST MEETING AND FEBRUARY HAD
ABOUT A QUARTER ABOUT THREE
MONTHS WORTH OF DATA AT THAT
POINT IN TIME.
RIGHT NOW THE THE NUMBERS OF
REQUESTS ARE.
REAL FAIRLY REALLY FAIRLY LOW --
WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THEM TOGETHER AT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND LOOK AT THAT AND
THAT WOULD BE --
COMING BACK TO YOU AS A REPORT
IN SEPTEMBER OKAY RIGHT OKAY
COMES FROM OHIO.
WE'VE REVIEWED '
ASSUMPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN USED --
TO CALCULATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR I JUST SAYS AND REYES
NO MAJOR CONCERNS ONE THING WE
WOULD NOTE --
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES PROPOSED
TO CONTINUE FUNDING THE
RESTORATION OF THE 7% WHICH
UNDER CURRENT LAW WAS TIED TO
THE EXISTENCE OF THE MCO TAX --
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HOWEVER
DOES NOT IN THE NCO TAX
SCHEDULED TO EXPIRE AT THE END
OF THIS FISCAL YEAR --
BUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES
NOT INCLUDE ANY FORM OF A
RENEWAL OR SOMETHING OF THAT
SORT FOR THE MCO TAX BUT SO
GIVEN THAT IT'S THE INTENT FOR
THE RESTORATION OF I JUST SAYS.
OURS TO BE ONGOING IS STILL IN
EXISTENCE THAT LINKS IT TO THEM
SO TAX SO WE JUST RAISE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IF IT'S THE TRUE
INTENT.
AND IF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WANT THIS TO BE
ON GOING ON IN FUTURE YEARS THEN
CHANGING THE STATUTORY FLAG THAT
MAY BE NEEDED.
OKAY SO WE NEED TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS.
TO BUT ON WHICH ALL RIGHT
FINANCE COMMENTS.
SENATE HAMMER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS THE ELLIE --
HAS NOTED THE BUDGET DOES NOT
ASSUME EXTENSION OF THE MANAGED.
CARE ORGANIZATION TAX HOWEVER
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO RESTORE THE SOME PERCENT
THROUGH BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS THE COST
RESTORE THE 7% REDUCTION IS
ESTIMATED TO BE ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WE
HAVE ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS CONCERNING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FIRST
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
AND WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
TAKE THEIR CURRENT CONCERNS INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE GO INTO MAY
REVISION.
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND OKAY CAN
ACTUALLY TO STIR ON THE SAID THE
ELECTRONIC TIME SHEETS --
THE TERMS OF FIVE ERRORS --
THAT -- MAY
HAVE SHOWN UP --
TERMS OF AS IF YOU THE YET --
ARE --
BECAUSE OF THE THERE'S A SHOWED
UP ON THEIR TIME CARDS UNDER
FLSA.
SO I THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
VIOLATIONS WERE USEFUL ARE GOING
ABOVE THE WEEK RIGHT --
HOURS STRAIGHT SO.
SOMETHING'S WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION FOR YOU ON THAT
SORRY [inaudible] TO HAVE.
PUT IT AWAY WITH SOME OTHER
PAPER --
CAN'T OF NINETY FOUR YEAH.
SO.
IN THIS LAST --
FISCAL YEAR FROM JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH THROUGH DECEMBER OF
EIGHTEEN THERE WAS ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS THAT RECEIVED A
THIRD VIOLATION.
WHICH IS THE THREE MONTH --
SUSPENSION.
AND THE FOURTH VIOLATION THERE
WAS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
PEOPLE THAT RECEIVE THAT.
NOW THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE AT THOSE WITH
THE COUNTIES AS WELL AS IF THEY
LOSE THAT DISPUTE TO APPEAL THAT
TO THE STATE FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEWS --
ON THE THIRD VIOLATIONS WE DID
OVER TURNED THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX AT THE STATE LEVEL
OF THOSE VIOLATIONS AND ON THE
FOURTH WHEN WE OVERTURNED FORTY
SIX OF THOSE.
SO --
PROPORTIONALLY TO THE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS WE HAVE THESE ARE OUR
VERY SMALL NUMBERS ON BUT WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS DOES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
INDIVIDUALS SO WE CONTINUE.
TO OUR OUR OWN STAFF AT THE
STATE ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
LEVEL AS WELL AS WORKING WITH
COUNTY STAFF TO REALLY --
TO OUTREACH AND EDUCATION FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THESE --
ISSUES AND MAYBE MISS
UNDERSTANDING HOW THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE ON FILLING OUT
TIME SHEETS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WILL BE OCCURRING AND IS
ALREADY OCCURRING IN ELECTRONIC
TIME SHEETS AND THEN WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH EBV.
ON THE IS THAT THE SYSTEM ITSELF
WILL PROMPT PEOPLE AS THEY
COMPLETE THEIR TIME SHEET TO LET
THEM KNOW IF THEY'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE CLAIMING
HOURS THAT WILL LEAD TO A
VIOLATION.
SO IF PEOPLE ARE CHOOSING NOW TO
USE ELECTRONIC TIME SHEETS THEY
GET THOSE PROBLEMS AND SO ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'VE CONTINUED TO DO
IS ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO UTILIZE
THE SYSTEM TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT.
AND AS PEOPLE MOVE INTO EBV BOTH
ON THE TELEPHONE AND ON THE
ONLINE SYSTEM THEY WILL GET --
DOT SUPPORT AS WELL AS THE ON
GOING OUT REACH AND TRAINING
FROM THE COUNTIES AND THE STATE
LEVEL AND WHAT PROPORTION OF
PEOPLE ARE USING THE LIKE TRYING
TIME SHEETS NOW.
ABOUT 32% OF 32% AND HOW LONG
AND HISTORIC TRY TIME SHEETS
BEEN AROUND.
LITTLE OVER A YEAR.
YEAR AND A HALF ALMOST TWO GOING
ON TO JUST THINKING LIKE AT THE
32% I MEAN ARE YOU PROJECT IT'S
THIS.
THE IN THE LIKE THE ONLY A YEAR
EXPERIENCE USE IT YOU'RE
EXPECTING THIS TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
PART OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING IS
INITIALLY BECAUSE IT WAS
COMPLETELY.
OPTIONAL THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
PUSH -- IN
AND OUT REACH --
TO TRANSITION FOLKS AS WE'VE
MADE THE DETERMINATION TO USE
OUR ELECTRONIC TIME SHEETS
SYSTEM OUT SO --
OUR APPROACH TO COMPLIANCE WITH
EVEY VIA KNOWING THAT THAT WILL
BECOME A MANDATE WE'VE REALLY --
CHANGE THAT APPROACH AND NOW ARE
DOING MONTHLY TIME SHEETS
STAFFERS AND INFORMATION OUT TO
FOLKS WERE FINDING THAT WITH
THOSE STAFFERS WERE GETTING
ABOUT A 2% BUMP EACH TIME.
AND WE ALSO HAVE AN INITIATED A
LOT OF WORK WITH THE COUNTIES TO
DO SOME --
MORE OUTREACH AROUND THOSE
ACTIVITIES THAT WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THOUGHT WILL.
START GOING UP MORE AND MORE
OVER TIME.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE LAW WE GO THEN --
TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ISSUE
WHICH IS I. TO ASSESS
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT --
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND WE
HAVE --
GRAHAM KNAUSS FROM THEY CALPERS
THE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WELCOME --
TO GIVE US --
ACTUAR START WITH ELLEN HAVING A
START WITH LA OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
AT THE LA --
WE HAVE A WALK SO FIRST OF ALL
WE ARE HEAVILY OPENS GONNA WALK
THROUGH --
OUR GRAPHIC ABOUT NINE ONE
REALIGNMENT --
AND THEN THAT WE HAVE THE PART
OF FINANCE PROVIDE THERE A BRIEF
SUMMARY IF THEY'RE REPORT ON SB
NINETY NINETY ONE REALIGNMENTS
AND AND THE HAVE AND DISCUSS HOW
THE RECOMMENDATIONS REPORT
REFLECTED THE POSE POSE CHANGES
THAT MEANS OF EFFORT AND THEN
THE LA --
WILL RESPOND AND THEN WE'LL HAVE --
STRAUSS --
SPEAK AS WELL AND COMMENT SO --
IT'S ONE OF THE FOUR WE'VE DIED
INTO THIS IS THAT --
WELL CERTAINLY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AYE HSS ONE OF THINGS I
WANT TO SORT TOUCH ON IS NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT BECAUSE THAT
TYPE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THIS
IS FOR THIS YEAR I SHOULD SAY.
UP TO SEE EVERY YEAR WE RUN IT
WE TOUCH ON THIS --
THIS IS GONNA BE THE FIRST
PROGRAM.
THAT TOUCHED ON NIGHT ONE
REALIGNMENT WE WILL LATER ON
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT ACCOUNT
MANAGED CARE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
YEAH PUBLIC HEALTH COUNTY LEVEL
IT'S ADDRESS SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US THIS IN A FEW
MOMENTS.
GOING OVER WHAT NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT IS AND JUST --
IS AS BACKGROUND --%
AS BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS MORE
SPECIFICS ABOUT I JUST US AND
COUNTY FUNDING SO.
LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH LA JOH.
SO ON PAGE THIRTY FIVE OF THE
AGENDA YOU'LL FIND A FLOW CHART
THAT JUSTICE BLAZE HOW NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT IS
STRUCTURED.
AND WE WERE ASKED TO BROACH JUST
WALK THROUGH THIS.
SO IN GENERAL REALIGNMENT WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN IT PROVIDES
COUNTIES WITH DEDICATED REVENUES
TO PAY FOR PROGRAM COSTS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
SPECIFICALLY.
A NUMBER OF COSTA
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS WERE LARGELY
TRANSFERRED FROM THE STATE TO
THE COUNTIES.
SO WHEN YOU SEE IN THE CHART
IT'S BESET THE REVENUES THAT
THAN WERE PROVIDED TO COUNTIES
TO PAY FOR THESE NEW COST.
WAS BOTH A PORTION OF THE
VEHICLE LICENSE FEE AND A
PORTION OF SALES TAX AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN DOES TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE OF MAGNITUDE LF
REVENUE THAT FLOWED TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE REALIGNMENT WAS
AROUND. TWO BILLION DOLLARS AND
THE AMOUNT OF SALES TAX THAT
FLOWED TO REALIGNMENT WAS AROUND
THREE BILLION.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE CHART
REALIGNMENT IS MADE UP OF A
NUMBER OF ACCOUNTS AND THEY'RE
GENERALLY DEFINED BY PROGRAM
AREA SOCIAL SERVICES HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH.
NOW HOW THE REVENUES FLOW WITHIN
THE STRUCTURE THEY FOLLOW RANK
ORDER.
THE SOCIAL SERVICES ACCOUNT GETS
THE FIRST CALL ON THE DOLLAR.
AND THIS SUB ACCOUNT INCLUDES
COUNTY COST FOR I'D JUST US.
THEN THE REVENUES WOULD FLOW --
TO COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS WHICH IS A SMALL NUMBER
OF COUNTIES FOR THEIR HEALTH
PROGRAMS.
AND THEN LASTLY TO THE GENERAL
HEALTH ACCOUNT AND MENTAL HEALTH
ACCOUNTS AND YOU SEE YOU EVEN
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH ACCOUNTS THEY HAVE SUB
ACCOUNTS WITHIN THEM.
IN WHICH A PORTION OF THEIR
REVENUES THAT THEY GET GO TO
THESE ACCOUNTS TO ULTIMATELY
THAN OFFSET STATE CAL WORKS COST.
NOW THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT
GOES INTO EACH ACCOUNT IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR --
DEPENDS ON TWO FACTORS THE FIRST
BEING THAT EVERY ACCOUNT GETS
THE AMOUNT THAT THEY RECEIVED
FROM THE PRIOR YEAR AND THAT'S
REFERRED TO AS BASE FUNDING.
SO ONCE EACH ACCOUNT IN THE
ORDER THAT I JUST DESCRIBED GETS
THERE'S THEIR BASE FUNDING TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE ANY DâN
REALIGNMENT REVENUES LEFTOVER.
THAT'S AGAIN RE DISTRIBUTED
TEACH ACOUNT IN THE ORDER AND
THOSE ARE CALLED GROWTH FUNDS.
ON THE WAY BACK VLF GROWTH FUNDS
ARE DISTRIBUTED --
YOU'LL SEE THAT DAY FIRST GO TO
SEE HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH.
IT'S REALLY THE CONVERSATION
AROUND HOUSE SALES TAX GROWTH
DOLLARS ARE --
HOW DO THEY FLOW THROUGH THE
SYSTEM WHERE WE GET INTO THE
SITE JUST AS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THE SALES TAX GROWTH
FUNDS FIRST GO TO THE SOCIAL
SERVICES SUB ACCOUNT?
AND THE COSTS THAT THOSE GROWTH
DOLLARS ARE USED TO COVER
REFLECT YEAR TO YEAR GROWTH IN
THE PROGRAMS WITHIN THE SOCIAL
SERVICES ACCOUNT.
AND THOSE --
GROWTH IS ATTRIBUTED IN MOST
CASES TO JUST GROWTH IN CASELOAD.
NOW TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH GROWTH DOLLARS TO
COVER THOSE COST --
THEN THAT MEANS IN THAT
PARTICULAR YEAR SALES TAX GROWTH
DOLLARS DON'T FLOW TO HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND THAT CAN HAPPEN FOR AND
MULTIPLE YEARS BECAUSE THE WAY
THAT REALIGNMENT WORKS IS IF
THERE ANY IF THERE'S ANY ON MAC
COST WITHIN THE SOCIAL SERVICES
UP ACCOUNT FACTS TRACKED.
UNTIL IT'S PAID IN FULL WITH
FUTURE REVENUE SOURCES --
SO COULD BE A NUMBER OF YEARS
UNTIL HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
I'M SEIZE ANY FORM OF SALES TAX
GROWTH AND THAT'S THE SITUATION --
WE GOT OURSELVES IN IN THE
RECENT YEARS WITH THE CHANGES
THAT WERE MADE TO I JUST AS
COUNTY COST WERE UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
COUNTY COSTA --
WERE SO LARGE THAT REALIZE COVER
THEM SO WHAT THAT MEANT FOR HELP
HEALTH AND MENTAL IN THE CASE O
SALES TAXES THAT NO DOLLARS ARE
FLOWING TO THEIR TO THOSE
ACCOUNTS BUT ALSO.
BE A LEFT GROWTH FUNDS WERE
TEMPORALLY RE DIRECTED FROM
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH TO PAY
OFF -- I
JUST AS COST AND I'LL LET
FINANCE EXPLAIN SOME OF THEIR
CHANGES THAT UNDO SOME OF THESE
THINGS AND ALLOW ADDITIONAL
FUNDS ARE MORE FUNDS --
TO FLORIDA HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND THEN I'LL SHARE OUR
COMMENTS ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I THANK YOU FINANCE.
GREAT THANK YOU CITY TEHAMA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS YOU
MENTIONED MISTER CHAIR IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE REPORT WILL BE
DISCUSSED IN FUTURE HEARING SO
I'M HAPPY TO GIVE A VERY HIGH
LEVEL OF THE DEPARTMENT FINDS
ANNOUNCES NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT REPORT.
THE PRIMARY FINDING BASS OUR
ANALYSIS IS THAT THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE AVAILABLE UNDER NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT CANNOT
SUPPORT THE COST OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAMS FUNDED WITH REALIGNMENT.
THIS IS NOT DUE TO CONSTRUCT
CONSTRUCT OF THE ORIGINAL DESIGN
BUT IT'S MOSTLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO
CHANGES.
THAT HAVE BEEN INCORPORATED INTO
THE REALIGN PROGRAMS PRIMARILY I
HSS.
AND SOME OF THESE CHANGES ARE
THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
AND PAID OVERTIME.
THERE'S ALSO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED THE
INDIGENT HEALTH POPULATION AND
THE REDIRECTION OF FUNDS TO
SUPPORT CAO WORKS GRANT
INCREASES.
BASED ON THIS REPORTS FINANCE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
NUMBER CHANGES TO NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT THAT WILL
ACCOMPLISH THREE MAIN GOALS. FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE THE REST
ACCOUNTING IS OF HAVING TO USE
GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDS TO COVER
AYE HSS COSTS.
SECOND FREE OF NINETEEN NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT GROWTH REVENUES
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH AS
THE ELLIE --
HAD ALLUDED.
TO AND THIRD IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY FLEXITY IT
CURRENTLY ASSOCIATED WITH NINETY
NINE DO YOU WANT RELY MAC THINK
REALIGNMENTS PRETTY MUCH
SYNONYMOUS WITH COMPLEXITY. TO
ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS THE
BUDGET SPECIFICALLY PROPOSES TO
REDUCE THE STATE WHY COUNTY I
HSS MOE AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY FROM TWO BILLION TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FIVE SIX
BILLION.
A REDUCTION OF FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
THE REVISED IMHO YOU PROJECT
REFLECTS THE PROJECTED LEVEL
COUNTIES I HSS COSTS THAT CAN BE
FUNDED WITH IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
SECONDLY THE BUDGET PROPOSES TO
REDUCE THE ANNUAL MOE INFLATION
FACTOR FROM 7% 24% BEGINNING AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ELIMINATE THE GENERAL FUND
MITIGATION.
GOING FORWARD.
THIRDLYTHE BUDGET PROPOSES TO
STOP THE REDIRECTION THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
GROWTH FROM MENTAL HEALTH AND
HEALTH TWO HSS SO RE DIRECTED
BACK TO INITIALLY WHERE IT WAS
FLOWING.
TO THE PROBE THE BUDGET PROPOSES
TO TEMPORARILY ELIMINATE GROWTH
ALLOCATIONS TO THE COUNTY
MEDICAL SERVICES PROGRAM BOARD
BEGINNING AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY DUE TO THE BOARD
SIGNIFICANT OPERATING RESERVE.
THIS PROVIDES ADDITIONAL GROWTH
FUNDING FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
HEALTH.
AND LASTLY THE BUDGETS PROPOSING
TO STREAMLINE THE DISTRIBUTION
OF GENERAL GROWTH FUNDS BY
ESTABLISHING FIXED ALLOCATIONS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND CAL WORKS.
THE PROPOSAL TO REDUCE THE
COUNTY I HSS MOE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES GENERAL FUND COSTS
GOING FORWARD COMPARED TO
CURRENT LAW.
SAID BE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FORTY
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY GROWING TO FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
TWO TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY THREE WE KNOW THAT
THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT ELIMINATE
THE REST TO COUNTIES FROM THE
POTENTIAL REVENUE.
DECLINES THAT WE THOUGHT WERE
PART OF THE ORIGINAL NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT STRUCTURE.
HOWEVER THE SIGNIFICANT FUSION A
GENERAL FUND MEANS SUBSTANTIALLY
LESS FOR US TO COUNTIES WITH
USING GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDS TO
COVER I IT JUST AS PROGRAM COSTS.
THANK YA HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SELL FOR HERE BACK
FROM LA --
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE SOME
QUESTIONS FROM COUNSEL FINANCE
MENTIONED TO THEIR CHANGES MODE
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE I JUST
AS RELATED IN THOSE ARE THE BIG
SIGNIFICANT ONES THERE IS --
OTHER PROPOSES THAT WOULD AFFECT
HEALTH THE MENTAL HEALTH WHICH
WILL BE DISCUSSED IN FUTURE
BUDGET HEARINGS --
OUR OFFICE IN ANTICIPATION OF
FINANCE RELEASING THEIR REPORT
JANUARY WE DID --
OUR OWN ASSESSMENT OF NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT BACK IN
OCTOBER WHERE WE ARE GENERAL I
IDENTIFIED GENERAL PRINCIPLES.
IN WHICH YOU COULD USE TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OR A
VALUE IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT.
AND WE FOUND SOMEWHERE TO WHAT
FINANCE FOUND IN THEIR REPORT IS --
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE THERE WAS
A MISALIGNMENT WITH THOSE
PRINCIPLES --
FINANCES RECOMMEND RECOMMENDED
CHANGES TO I JUST SAYS
DEFINITELY MOVES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OF MEETING THE CORE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE IDENTIFIED
SPECIFICALLY THAT COST WITHIN --
BACK COUNTY COST REFLECT THEIR
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY CONTROL THE
PROGRAM.
FIVE REDUCING THE COUNTY ACOSTA
NITROUS AS WE THINK THAT THE TO
MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
BUT THEN ALSO THAT REVENUES
WITHIN REALIGNMENT COVER COST
OVER TIME IN THESE CHANGES
IMPROVE THAT PROBABILITY --
WE ALSO REYES --
SOME GENERAL BIG PICTURE
QUESTIONS --
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
ONE BEING THAT WHETHER
REALIGNMENT REVENUES WILL BE
SUFFICIENT TO COVER COUNTIES
COST IN THE LONG TERM REMAINS
UNCLEAR THAT'S JUST DUMB.
HOW REALIGNMENT WORKS SO
SOMETHING THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS REALIGNMENT REVENUES AND
IN ANY GIVEN YEAR --
ARE THEY GENERALLY COVERING
COUNTY COST.
AND THEN THE SECOND
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE HAD IS
WHY -- BY
REDUCING THE I JUST SIZE COUNTY
COSTS THAT THEN SHIFTS COSTS A
GREATER AMOUNT OF BY JUST AS
COST TO THE STATE AND WE FIND
THIS APPROPRIATE --
HOWEVER THIS DOES RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEN THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO CONTROL COSTS BUT
THEN ALSO --
LOOKING AT COST PRESSURES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE AGING
POPULATION THAT WE MAY SEE AND I
JUST US SO SUMMER TO THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAD EARLIER IN
THIS HEARING THIS CONVERSATION
ABOUT.
HOW DO WE PLAN FOR THE IMPACT OF
THE GROWING AGING POPULATION IN
THE STATE BUDGET --
FITS IN WITH US AS WELL
[inaudible]
DO YOU.
RIGHT SEC MR HOUSE.
I THANK YOU SENATOR PAN I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE A COUNTY PERSPECTIVE ON
THE GOVERNOR SITE TO ASSESS AND
WE PROPOSAL --
ITEM GRAND CANAL SOME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF C. SACK.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND WE REPRESENT ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
AND I'M GONNA PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTS RELATIVE.
TO WHAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS WHERE
WE SIT TODAY AND HOW WE SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND ALL ACTUALLY BEGIN WITH THE
PUNCH LINE WHICH IS REALLY THAT
WERE THANKFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE COMMITMENT OF
ADDITIONAL STATE GENERAL FUND --
TO STABILIZE A PROGRAM IN THE
STABILIZE THE OVERALL
REALIGNMENT.
AS AS COUNTIES WE ARE STEWARDS
OF A NUMBER OF STATE PROGRAMS
THAT'S CERTAINLY TRUE --
WITH -- WITH
AYE TO ASSESS --
WE'RE PROUD TO STAND WITH THE
STATE AS A PARTNER IN
ADMINISTERING THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM.
I'M TO MEET THE NEEDS OF MORE
THAN HALF A MILLION FOLKS AT
THAT ARE IN OUR COMMUNITY SUIT
TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN.
SAFELY REMAIN --
WITHIN THEIR HOMES.
WHEN WE THINK BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE WE
NEGOTIATED WITH THE LEGISLATURE
IN ADMINISTRATION.
I'M A COUNTY I JUST US AND WE
THAT -- THAT --
WHO HAD A TWO YEAR RE
EXAMINATION IN TERMS OF WHERE WE
WERE AT --
AND THAT PROVISION --
FOR US IS CRITICAL TO THAT AS WE
WERE GOING THROUGH A NEW MODEL
WITH A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
CHANGE.
THAT WE KEPT IN MIND.
THE RISK SHARING --
THAT EXISTED BETWEEN THE STATE
AND COUNTIES TO ENSURE THAT FROM
A LONG TERM PERSPECTIVE --
WE COULD HAVE SUSTAINABILITY OF
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE --
ACCESS TO DELIVER ON THEIR
BEHALF.
SO THIS.
THIS RE EXAMINATION WAS REALLY
FOCUSED ON THAT BALANCE POINT OF
INSURING --
APPROPRIATE SHARED RISK BETWEEN
THE STATE AND COUNTIES.
BUT AS WE WALKED IN --
220-001-71718 AT THE BEGINNING
THIS AM A WE WE HAD --
CONFIDENCE THAT IN THE FIRST
COUPLE OF YEARS WE COULD MANAGE
THROUGH WITH THE ANIMAL WE
WITHOUT I'M SEVERE DISRUPTION
RELATED TO PROGRAMS.
I'M NOT WITHSTANDING THE
REDIRECTION OF BOTH PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH RELATED
FUNDING WITHIN THE REALIGNMENT.
BUT WE ALSO KNEW THAT.
AS WE GOT TO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY AND BEYOND.
THAT THE COST WOULD INCREASE AT
A MUCH FASTER RATE THAN THE
REVENUES THAT WE WOULD RECEIVE --
TWO TO FUND THOSE COSTS AND SO
THIS IS WHERE --
WE ALONG WITH THE SO HAVE A VERY
SIMILAR ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF OF
WHERE THINGS WERE.
WE'RE GOING.
SINCE OUR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
COUNTIES HAVE.
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE TO IMPLEMENT --
THE ANIMAL WE I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF ELEMENTS
OF THE EMMA WE THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH --
THAT TO LEAD US UP --
TO TO THIS PROPOSAL.
THE FIRST IS THAT.
THE INCREASE COSTS THAT WERE
TRANSFERRED UP TO COUNTIES --
OCCURRED IN A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SO THERE'S
THOSE THINGS --
ATTRIBUTED TO REGULAR PROGRAM
CASE SLOW GROWTH IN THE PROGRAM
WHICH IS ABOUT 4% --
AND THEN --
CHANGES THAT OCCUR THAT WERE
OUTSIDE OF COUNTY CONTROL THAT
DEAL WITH --
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES AND
ALSO DEAL WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FEDERAL --
OVERTIME RELATED RULES BECAUSE
OF THOSE INCREASED COSTS --
BEING FAR HIGHER THAN THE
REVENUES AVAILABLE WITHIN THE
REALIGNMENT IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
M. A WE WORKABLE AND THIS IS
WHERE THAT REDIRECTION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH RELATED.
I'M REVENUE --
OCCURRED.
SO WE WE KNEW WE COULD WIN
THROUGH THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS BUT THAT THAT WAS NOT
SUSTAINABLE.
WHICH IS WHY I'M WITHOUT AS
SIGNIFICAN INTERVENTION WE'VE
KNOWN THAT WE'VE BEEN HEADED.
FOR THIS CLIP AS THE STATE
GENERAL FUND WAS OTHERWISE
SLATED TO DECREASE OVER TIME AS
OUR COSTS --
ACTUALLY WENT UP.
SO WITHIN THIS CONTEXT --
COUNTIES HAVE UTILIZED SOME OF
THE NEW COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
JURORS AND TOOLS THAT WERE PUT
IN PLACE --
TO MAKE SOME FOR PROGRESS
RELATIVE.
TO LABOR AGREEMENTS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- FOR
ARE I TO ASSESS --
PROVIDERS --
AND THAT'S PARTICULARLY TRUE
WITH THE UTILIZING OF THE WAGE
SUPPLEMENT AND ADDITIONAL STATE
SHARON AND I'M SO WE'VE MADE
SOME SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
WITH THIS --
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT REPORT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT'S
IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUT
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET.
I'M WERE ABLE TO BRING SOME
STABILITY TO NOT JUST A TO SAYS
BUT ALSO TO THE REALIGNMENT --
MORE BROADLY --
AND AS WAS HIGHLIGHTED BY BOTH
THE MINISTRATION ELIO --
STOP THE REDIRECTION OF REVENUE
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES --
TO ENSURE THAT CHEMICAL DISEASE
CONTROL --
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE
RELATED EFFORTS CAN CONTINUE TO
BE FUNDED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND SO I WANT.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE --
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
SO CLOSELY WITH US --
FOR BOTH HEARING OUR CONCERNS --
AND I'M PUTTING A PROPOSAL IN
THE BUDGET.
THAT --
STABILIZES --
HEIGHTS ASSESSES THE PROGRAM --
PROVIDES A SUSTAINABILITY IN
TERMS OF THE OVERALL REALIGNMENT --
CLEARLY AS A LA APPOINTED.
THIS IS STILL A SHARED RISK
MODEL AND SO THERE IS --
REMAINING RISK WITH ON THE
COUNTY SIDE JUST AS THERE IS ON
THE STATE SIDE.
AS WELL --
BUT WE SEE THIS PROPOSAL AS FAIR
AND BALANCED IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING THAT STABILITY I'M
RECOGNIZING THAT OF WHICH COSTS
CAN BE CONTROLLED AND BY WHOM.
AND AS A RESULT WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL AND WHEN
YOU CAN ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO MOVE IT FORWARD AS WELL.
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL.
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS --
I THINK THAT --
WHEN MY THINGS AS WE LOOK AT --
REALIGNMENT I APPRECIATE I THINK
I AGREE THAT --
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AB REALLY DOES COME DOWN TO THE
YOU KNOW WHO'S BEARING THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN.
WHO ACTUALLY HAS CONTROL OVER
THE COSTS LIKE THE WORST
SITUATION IS THAT YOU HAVE AN
EXPENSE THAT YOU CAN'T CONTROL
YOU DON'T HAVE THE AND THEN YOU
DON'T AND?
AND ALSO TIED TO A REVENUE
STREAM THAT YOU ACTUALLY CAN'T
MANAGE EITHER RIGHT SO --
FOR EXAMPLE --
WELL AND YOU CAN CORRECT ME OF
RALEIGH VLS IT'S NOT LIKE A
COUNTY CAN REYES STIR FEEL
LASSIE SEPARATELY FROM OTHER
COUNTIES RIGHT IF I DON'THAVE A
FEEL LEFT REVENUE ARE JUST
RAISED VEAL A FEW MY COUNTY
RIGHT.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT SAID IT STATE
RIGHT SO THAT VLF MONEY.
HOW MUCH YOU GONNA GET PART OF
IT'S A TEN OF COURSE ON HOW MANY
CARS YOU HOUSE RIGHT WHICH YOU
DON'T DECIDE EITHER YOU CAN'T
TAKE PEOPLE BUYER MORE OR LESS
CARS IN YOUR COUNTY OR OUR OWN
MORE OR LESS CARS AND CUT IT
SHOULD SAY BECAUSE PEOPLE MOVE?
IN THE PAPER.
BUT THEN ALSO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT WE SET THE FEET RIGHT SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE THAT SO THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER THAT
GREAT.
SALES TAX A LITTLE DIFFERENT
YOLO CONTROL YOU COULD YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU GO BACK TO YOUR
VOTERS AND SO FORTH PERSUADE
PEOPLE THAT THERE MIGHT BE A
LITTLE BIT.
SO -- SO I
MEAN AS WE LOOK AT THAT AND THEN
ALSO THINKING ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT TRADE OFFS RATES OF
FOR EXAMPLE I HSS WON THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE IS
THAT OUR INVESTMENT AYE HSS.
ALSO ALLOWS US TO ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY LOWER AND WE'VE DONE
STUDIES WHICH LOOKED AT THIS
LOWER SOME OF THE STATE SPENDING
ON INSTITUTIONS RIGHT WHICH IS
ACTUALLY COST US FOR BY THE
STATE NOT BY COUNTY SO --
SO IT'S GOOD THAT THE STATE HAS
DAVE BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE RE
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO THIS IT
MAKES SENSE FOR US BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY CAN REDUCE OUR COSTS IN
THE SIDE WHERE IS THE COUNTIES
LIKE WELL WE'LL WE CAN.
PUT MORE MONEY INTO IT AND SAVE
MONEY BUT WE DON'T SEE ANY OF
THAT SAVINGS RIGHT SO THINKING
ABOUT HOW THAT I REALIZE THESE
ARE MULTIPLE THREADS THAT RUN
THROUGH THINGS BUT NOW THAT THAT
IS WHAT IT IS WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS I KNOW THAT BACK IN.
WHEN WE WERE DISCUSSING THIS
COUPLE YEARS AGO AND A DEAL DID
COME TOGETHER?
KNIVES CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THESE
THINGS INTERPLAY AND WHERE'D
INCENTIVES BEING CUT RIGHT FOR
FOR THE DIFFERENT PARTIES THE
STATE THE COUNTIES AND SO FORTH
IN TERMS OF BEING SURE THAT.
YOU DON'T HAVE --
I GUESS --
YEAH.
WELL ATTENDED CONSEQUENCES ARE
MISALIGNED INCENTIVES RATE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO TO CHEAT THE
CHEMICALS MY CHIEF WITH WITH THE
PROGRAM.
AND SO I DO THINK THIS IS MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
I CLEARLY IT DOES PUT A GREATER
BURDEN ON YOU KNOW THE STATE
WHICH MEANS THAT I HAVE TO SAY
THE OKAY HOW WE GONNA FIGURE OUT
WE HAVE.
YOU HERE WE HAVE LOTS PROPOSALS
FOR THINGS PEOPLE WANT IT TO GET
FUNDED RIGHT OUT THERE AND AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING ON AN
ONGOING BASIS OF LARGE PORTION
OF THE AYE HSS RATE SO THAT
MEANS THAT ON STATE SIDE.
BARRING ADDITIONAL REVENUES THAT
PUTS MORE PRESSURE ON ANY OTHER
PROGRAM THE STATE FUNDS AS WELL --
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING COUNTIES AT
SQUEEZE OUT OTHER THINGS SO WE
HAD A HEARING ON PUBLIC HEALTH
AND WILL DELVE MORE DEBT LATER
WE HAVE HEARING ON MENTAL HEALTH
RIGHT.
AND SO WHEN THAT.
LATER LIVE OF A RUN DOWN THERE'S
NOBODY GOING THERE WELL WHAT'S
THAT SUPPOSED TO MEAN RIGHT SO --
SO I THINK THAT --
SO I DO APPRECIATE --
THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL I THINK AS WE CONTINUE
TO BEFORE WE NEED TO LOOK AT I
THINK IS MENTIONED EXACTLY.
WELLS WAS WAY [inaudible]
WE'RE FUNDING.
HSS BUT THE DEMAND FOR
RIGHTEOUSNESS IS NOT AT LEAST I
KNOW OF MAYBE SOMEONE DID MIKE
MACRO ECONOMIC ANALYSIS IS TIED
TO THE NUMBER OF CARS IN A
PARTICULAR LOCATION OR THE
AMOUNT OF RETAIL SALES THAT
HAPPENS IN IN A COUNTY RIGHT.
SO THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
FUNDING SOURCE AND THE AND
WHAT'S PAYING FOR IS NOT
NECESSARILY YOU YOU KNOW THAT
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY ALIGNED
THAT WAY AND THAT NOT.
SO -- WE
HAVE TO BE SURE THAT THE FUNDING
STREAM MAILED IS IS IS IS GOING
TO BE ADEQUATE ON AN ONGOING
BASIS OVER TIME SO WE NEED TO
CERTAINLY MONITOR THAT.
SHE LOKED OVER TIME AND
CERTAINLY THAT'S SOMETHING THE
STATE HAS TO LOOK AT AS WELL
WERE HIGHLY DEPENDENT ON INCOME
TAX REVENUE --
CAPITAL GAINS REVENUE SO WE HAVE
A MORE VOLATILE WE'RE TRYING --
TO AND I APPRECIATE GOVERNOR
BROWN THIS IS LEADERS AND
CERTAINLY STEPS WE'VE TAKEN THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO BE SURE WE
CAN -- LEVEL
OUT THE BULBS SAID TO THE DEGREE
WE CAN -- TO
BECAUSE RECOGNIZING WHAT WE
SPEND THINGS ON ACTUALLY FIRST
OF ALL GENERALLY TENDS TO BE
MORE CONSTANT IN A REVENUE
STREAM AND ALSO TENDS TO BE
SOMEWHAT COUNTER CYCLICALS WELL
SO THE DEMAND GOES UP WHEN OUR
REVENUES ARE DOWN.
SO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BALANCE ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT PIECES IS --
SOMETHING THAT --
WE WANT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO SURE WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND I APPRECIATE THE THE
THE THE GOVERNOR'S --
LEADERSHIP IN TRYING TO AT LEAST
I THINK MOVE THIS MIGHTY ONE
REALIGNMENT PORTION TO I THINK
WE'RE MOVING IN THE DIRECTION OF
MAKES MORE SENSE THAN THAN IT
DID BEFORE --
RECOGNIZING IT DOES MEAN MORE
BURDEN ON THE STATE --
OF A TERMS OF ITS US.
ALL RIGHT ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY SO I APPRECIATE THE
OVERVIEW IN THE COMMENTS --
ACTUALLY ANYTHING ELSE ON THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE HERE I
THINK.
SO CELLS LIKE EVERYONE SAYS OKAY
WE'RE WE'RE SEVEN RIGHT
DIRECTION I'M SURE WE COULD
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO TWEAK IT BUT
I THINK IT'S A SO FAR SO GOOD
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
LAST.
SO WITH THAT SAID --
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR HSS
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW AND DATA
ANALYSIS.
AND DOES HE TO DO WE HAVE TO SAY
ON THAT [inaudible]
THING.
OKAY OKAY SO AGENCY OKAY.
THANK YOU.
I SO THESE ARE TWO POSITIONS ONE
THAT WILL BE --
A SUPPORTING THIS STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEWS OF THE
VIOLATIONS THAT WAS THAT THAT'S
AN ONGOING ACTIVITY THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO PERFORM.
THAT HADN'T RECEIVED ANY
POSITIONS IN THE PAST SO WE HAVE
A LIMITED TERM POSITION OF THAT
WILL AND THIS YEAR.
THAT WE HAVE REDIRECTED TO
SUPPORT THAT ACTIVITY THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A PERMANENT.
FUNDING FOR AND THE OTHER WAS --
IN OUR DATA AND IN OUR DATA UNIT
WHERE WE DO ALL OF OUR DATA
ANALYSIS OF THE MANY MANY
ACTIVITIES GOING ON IN THE AYE
AGES US PROGRAM AGAINST TO
PERMANENT BECAUSE THAT'S AN
ONGOING ACTIVITY THAT'S SUPPORT
BY THE DEPARTMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU --
COMES FAMILIAL [inaudible]
FINANCE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO.
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
THEN WE HAVE --
FIVE PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS --
AND SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH --
NUMBER ONE IS COULD CUT
CODIFYING THE TRYING VISIT
VERIFICATION PROTECTIONS AND I
THINK TO USE THAT'S RIGHT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES FOR HSS.
AND EDIE W..
AS A USER I. ON HIS PRESENTING
ON THIS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE SHOULD HAVE ENOUGH CHAIRS UP
FRONT FOR YOU.
TO OKAY THERE YOU GO
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SEC.
SAID KNOWING JUST KEEP IN MIND
WE DO HAVE THREE MINUTES
CUMULATIVELY SO FIGURE OUT
DIVIDE UP THE TIME BETWEEN THE
THREE OF YOU.
AS I SAID YOU MAY HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SPEAK WHEN WE
ASK QUESTIONS BUT SO ACTUALLY
FORTY FIRST DECENT INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES AND OF COURSE DOES
NOT COUNT AGAINST YOUR TIME.
HI SENATOR PAN MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON WITH
YOU W. APPS ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY WE REPRESENT.
I JUST AS PROVIDERS IN TWENTY
ONE COUNTIES AND I'M HERE TO
INTRODUCE FLORENCE CROSSAN WHO
IS THE CHAIR OF DISTRICT FOR FOR
UT W. SHE IS AND I JUST AS
PROVIDER.
OKAY AND DOES HE ALSO SPEAKING
YEAH JUST AS CONSUMER FORMER
WORKER ARE THE CALIFORNIA
ALLSTATE COMMITTEE LOCAL AGENT
SAYS COMMITTEE AND MULTIPLE
OTHER COMMITTEES.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT WHICH COULD
BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
LIKE CRISTINA SAID MY NAME IS
FLORENCE PRESIDENT EMMA I JUST
AS PROVIDER.
FROM MERCED COUNTY I CARE FOR MY
MOM DOROTHY.
AND I'VE BEEN A PROVIDER FOR A
LIVING YEARS.
UNLIKE MOST CARE GIVERS MY DAYS
ARE HARD ENOUGH.
A LOT OF THE CARE THAT WE
PROVIDE IS PERSONAL.
AND WOULD NOT BE RIGHT TO SHARE
WITH ANYONE.
AND STOPPING OUR WORK TO REPORT
THESE DETAILS WOULD TAKE TIME
THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
WE DO WANT OUR PRIVACY WE DO NOT
WANT OUR PRIVACY TO BE INVADED
AND WE DON'T WANT THE PRIVACY OF
OUR CLIENTS TO BE INVADED EITHER.
AND THAT'S WHY WHEN I JUST AS
PROVIDERS FIRST HEARD ABOUT THE
V. V..
WE WERE LIKE REALLY WORRIED.
IT'S KIND OF CONCERNING.
I I KNOW THAT THE STATE IS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW TO
IMPLEMENT THE EBV BY JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I ALSO KNOW
THAT BECAUSE PROVIDERS AND
CLIENTS MADE OUR VOICES HEARD.
DSS HAS OUTLINED AND EBV PLAN
THAT IS MINIMALLY INVASIVE AND
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENTS LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATOR PASSED
VERY IMPORTANT PRTECTIONS.
SOME OF THESE ARE.
MANDATING STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
WHERE YOU W. IS AT THE TABLE TO
REPRESENT THE VOICES AND
CONCERNS OF OUR MEMBERS.
IMPLEMENTING ETV BY CD SS MUST
BE IN A WAY THAT IS NOT A BURDEN
TO I JUST AS PROVIDERS AND
CLIENTS.
NO GPS TRACKING NO VIOLATIONS
FOR PROVIDERS.
GUARANTEEING THAT PROVIDERS ARE
SUFFICIENTLY TRAINED ON THE
STATE'S NEW EBV SYSTEM.
COMMITMENT THAT HOMESTED RIGHTS
OF I'D JUST AS CLIENTS ARE NOT
INFRINGED UPON.
SO I ASK PLEASE PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF CARE GIVERS AND OUR
CLIENTS.
BY WRITING THE SAME EBV
PROTECTIONS INTO THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE SO THAT THEY
WILL BECOME PERMANENT.
THANK YOU.
I ACTUALLY HAVE TWO SUBJECTS
EVEY V. JUST BE WHATEVER MADE A
SPECIAL ROSY --
EBV WILL HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON
SENIORS BLIGHTED PEOPLE
DISABILITIES TAKING AWAY FROM
HAVING TO PAY FOR SYSTEM WILL
TAKE AWAY FROM THEIR ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT TIME SHEETS.
IN SOME CASES AND CURRENT FIVE
SYSTEM HAS A LOT TO BE FIXED
WHEN IT COMES TO USING IT FOR
EBV.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE TAKING AWAY
THE PAPER TIME SHEETS RECIPIENTS
AND THE PROVIDER WILL STILL HAVE
AN ABILITY TO PRINT.
PAST TIME SHEETS AND THEIR
RECORDS BELIEVE IT OR NOT CDSS
HAS MADE.
A MESS MOST OF THE REQUEST
REGARDING CATION A SENIORS AND
OTHERS WHO ARE AFRAID OF
COMPUTERS IS GREATLY NEEDED.
HOW HOW CAN THIS BE STRESSED
THAT IT PAYS MORE THAN STE THE
STAFF IN THE OFFICE BUT FOR
STAFF THAT GOES OUT IN THE FIELD
OF WORKS WITH THE CONSUMERS AND
THE PROVIDERS?
SAID THE EEVEE IS PUT IN PLACE.
OUTRAGE IS DONE IN A WAY IT WILL
IMPACT A LOT OF HIGHLY VVV IS
IMPLEMENTED OVERALL AND HAVING A
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES FOR
RECIPIENTS CENTER PROVIDERS.
THERE ARE STILL MANY ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE JOINTLY WORKED OUT
WITH ON CONSUMER GROUPS AND WITH
PROVIDERS.
I WOULD HOPE CSS WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THOSE WHO WERE
IMPACTED BY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE V..
I ALSO WANTED TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE 87% ARE YOU WANT TO
HANG ON THERE WHEN WE GET TO
THAT PANEL JUST IF YOU DON'T
MIND I WISH YOU CAN JUST STAY
RIGHT THERE WHEN WE GET THAT
PANEL YOU WOULD HAVE YOU SPEAK
ON THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY ALL RIGHT. FOR
YOU GO.
COMING FROM THE THE PARTIAL
SERVICES.
VERY BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIR WE
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND IN THEIR
HAND OUT THAT MY COLLEAGUE WENT
THROUGH FOR YOU ON PAGE NINETEEN
LAYS OUT THE POLICY PRINCIPLES
WHICH THEY BOTH DISCUSSED.
WE DON'T PARTICULARLY HAVE AN
OBJECTION TO THOSE BEING
CODIFIED WE'VE BEEN CLEAR IN ALL
OF OUR MEETINGS --
CONSULTATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IS CRITICAL IT'S MANDATED BY
FEDERAL LAW THE FEDERAL LAW ALSO
MANDATES TO BE MINIMALLY
BURDENSOME OR INVASIVE --
TO USE THE TERM PROTECTING THE
ONSTAD RIGHTS AS LONG BEEN A
PRINCIPAL IN THE PROGRAM SO WE
WOULD HAVE NO OBJECTION.
OKAY.
LA -- ANY
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT FINANCE.
NO ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL CERTAINLY THOSE OUR
BEST PRACTICES WITH I WANT YOU
TO STAY THERE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE WHAT I DO ANOTHER PANEL
THAT WE GET TO YOUR SECOND ONE
SO IF YOU'RE COMFORTABLE THERE.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE HANG OUT WITH US ALL
RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE NEXT
ITEM IS THE ACTUAL STUDY FOR LTE
ASSESS FINANCING SERVICE OPTIONS.
SO WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA AGING
AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE WELCOME
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY SO --
WHEN YOU ALL GET UP HERE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD AND EACH OF THE FORTY A
YEAR HI INTERVIEW OF YOUR TIME?
OKAY SO FIRST LET'S DO
INTRODUCTIONS.
BUDGET HAND INDUCTOR PUBLIC
POLICY LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA.
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M PRETTY WILL FIND THE
STATEWIDE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
REPRESENT THE AGES AS PROVIDERS
AND THE OTHER.
AT THIRTY SEVEN COMPANIES.
I WANT TO BEGIN.
GREAT THANK YOU A DOCTOR PAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE AGAIN MY NAME IS TO
ENHANCE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA.
LEADING IS CALIFORNIA IS THE
STATE'S LEADING ADVOCATE FOR
QUALITY AND NOT FOR PROFIT
SENIOR LIVING IN CARE.
OUR ASSOCIATIONS MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDE PROVIDERS OF
SENIOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY.
CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES AND SKILLED NURSING
CARE.
OUR MEMBERS REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND SENIORS --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BUDGET ITEM --
WE ARE ALSO A NUMBER OF KATO THE
CALIFORNIA AGING DISABILITY
ALLIANCE WHICH IS TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT --
SHARING THAT SHARE A COMMON
INTEREST AND COMMITMENT TO
CREATING AFFORDABLE HERE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND AND CONTEXT --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE HA
WHEN CAR CONGRESS FORMALLY
REPEALED THE COMMUNITY LIVING
ASSISTANCE SERVICE IN SPORTS OR
THE CLASS ACT.
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS RETIRED
TIRELESSLY TO FIND NEW WAYS ON
HOW WE CAN.
PAY FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
IN THE MIDDLE CLASS.
IN LATE --
TWENTY THIRTEEN OUR NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION LEADING AGE
PARTNERED WITH A. R. P. IN THE
SKIN FOUNDATION TO JOINTLY FUND
AND ECONOMIC AN ACTUARIAL
ANALYSIS WITH THE URBAN
INSTITUTE --
AN ORGANIZATION WHICH EMPLOYS
OVER FIVE HUNDRED SOCIAL
SCIENTISTS ECONOMISTS
MATHEMATICIANS DEMOGRAPHERS AND
DATA SCIENTISTS.
AND WITH MIDDLEMAN AN ACTUARIAL
FIRM. TO MODEL THE IMPACT OF
DIFFERENT LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FINANCING DESIGNS.
BOB WALTER LEIGH THE MODELING
RESULT RESULTS SHOWED THAT THERE
WERE NO PERFECT FINANCING
SOLUTIONS.
IT DID PROVIDE CRITICAL AND
VALUABLE INSIGHT ON WHAT
FEATURES TO MAKE A FINANCING
MECHANISM MORE IMPACTFUL --
INCLUDING ELEMENTS SUCH AS COST
AND COVERAGE OPTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE AS WE
ANOTHER CONVERSATION OF HOW WE
PAY FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORT --
HAS NOT BEEN PRIORITIZE AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
I RECENTLY OTHER STATES SUCH AS
HAWAII TEN IN MAINE.
HAD BEGUN TO TAKE INITIATIVE TO
WORK ON THEIR OWN STATEWIDE
SOLUTIONS TO FINDING A
SUSTAINABLE FINANCING MECHANISM.
TO ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FACING
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES IN CARING
FOR THEIR AGING LOVED ONES.
I WE LEAVE NOW THE TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MOVE FOR WITH
DEVELOPING OUR OWN SUSTAINABLE
FINANCING MECHANISM. TO MEET
THIS GROWING NEED --
JUST FOR CONTEXT CALIFORNIA HAS
ALMOST EIGHT MILLION PERSONS WHO
ARE EITHER A OLDER ADULTS
PERSONS WITH MOBILITY SENSORY
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL AND
OR MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
MANY OF WHOM STRUGGLE TO FOR THE
SERVICES.
AND SUPPORTS THE NEED TO LIVE
WITH DIGNITY AND INDEPENDENCE.
I NGUYEN INFORMAL NETWORKS OF
CARE NOT AVAILABLE INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES PAY OUT OF POCKET
FOR LONG TERM SERVICES FOR SELF
FILL THE GAP.
BUT THESE SERVICES BRING HIGH
COSTS NOT ONLY TO THE
INDIVIDUALS DIRECTLY INVOLVED
BUT ALSO TO THE TAXPAYERS IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
AS MORE INDIVIDUALS ARE FORCED
TO SPEND DOWN ASSETS TO QUALIFY
FOR AN ALREADY OVERBURDENED
ACCOUNT SYSTEM.
I'M SURE MOST INDIVIDUALS AWARE
THAT MEDICARE DOES NOT COVER --
ADEQUATELY --
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FINANCING HOURS ON COMPUTERS AND
SUPPORTS.
AND AS AS THIS HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT TODAY WE
KNOW THAT LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE --
BY AND LARGE IS RELATIVELY ON
AFFORDABLE.
OKAY I THINK YOU JUST USE THAT
ALL THE TIME --
WELL THEN I WILL OUT PASSED ON
TO TO MY CALL IS THAT OKAY.
ALSO BE TALK HERE SO --
OUR ORGANIZATION IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET REQUEST
FOR THE VARIOUS REASONS EXPRESS
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE KNOW ALL TOO
WELL THE SORT OF FISCAL CRUNCH
ON THE AYE HSS PROGRAM.
FAR TOO OFTEN WHEN INDIVIDUALS
REACH THE AGE WHERE THEY NEED
LONG TERM CARE --
THEY'RE FORCED TO SPEND DOWN
INTO POVERTY TO QUALIFY FOR THE
AGE OF SUCH PROGRAMS.
AND IT IS AS IT STANDS NOW THE
CURRENT FUNDING STRUCTURE FOR
AYE HSS IS NOT.
SUSTAINABLE --
WITH THE GROWING SENIOR
POPULATION --
AND WE ALSO REFUSED TO BELIEVE
THAT IT'S THE VISION OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE OUR SENIORS
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
IMPOVERISH THEMSELVES --
SIMPLY IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE CARE THAT THEY NEED
IN THEIR CITING OF CHOICE WHICH
IS OUR HOME.
SO IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
CALIFORNIA FIND OF OF
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION TO THESE
CHALLENGES FOR MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES WHO ARE CARING FOR
THEMSELVES OR THEIR AGING AND
DISABLED LOVED ONES.
AND IT'S OUR POSITION AT LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN UNNECESSARY FIRST.
MISTER CHAIR BOTH --
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
AND AS A MEMBER OF CARE THAT WE
SUPPORT THE REQUEST I JUST WANNA
MAKE ONE QUICK POINT ON TOP OF
THE THOROUGH DISCUSSION OF MY
COLLEAGUES --
AND IS A PROGRAM I THINK YOU'RE
BEGINNING TO KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
A LITTLE BETTER A KEY COMPONENT
FOR THE US AND WHAT WE THINK
WILL BE HAVING THE ACTUARIAL
STUDY -- TO
WILL SHOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IS --
REQUIRE --
THAT ANY PLAN THAT GOES FORWARD
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE HOMESTEAD
ACT AND INSURING THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING INDIVIDUALIZED PERSON
CENTERED CARE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH -- ANY
COMMENTS FROM DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
NO WE WE BEEN APPROACHED
INVOLVED IN SOME INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
IN LIGHT OF WHAT YOU HEARD IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE MASTER PLAN
CONVERSATION --
THERE MAY BE ROOM TO MAKE THAT A
PRIORITY IN THE BUDGET OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT HELLO
COMMENTS.
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT --
SO NO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL I'D MAKE NOTE THAT I
THINK I MONITORING YOUR
COMPANION LEGISLATION --
AND BECAUSE WE NEED YEAH WE NEED
TO FIGURE THIS OUT RIGHT AND
WOULD --
DOES IT TO ME PLEASE SAID
EARLIER IT'S IT'S A HARD NUT TO
CRACK I MEAN YOU MENTIONED THAT
THERE WERE SOME DEL URBAN
INSTITUTE LOOKED AT WE HAVE
PEOPLE LOOKING AT AND I KNOW
THERE'S EVER PERFECT SOLUTION
CERTAINLY WE THE FACT THAT.
OUR MAIN APPROACH TO OUR MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES HERE WHO CLEARLY
THEY ARE UNABLE TO AFFORD TO
SORT OF CARE TO START WITH IS TO
TELL THEM THAT WELL YOU JUST
HAVE TO TRY YOUR FAMILY THE
POVERTY AND THEN THE STATE WILL
STEP IN IS.
NOT THE RIGHT SOLUTION SO WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT SOME OTHER
OPTIONS AND I APPRECIATE --
YOU CHAMPING THIS I APPRECIATE
THE INTEREST APARTMENT SCIAL
SERVICES AND I THINK THAT THAT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT STUDY THAT
NEEDS TO BEFORE SO THANKS FOR
MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
RIGHT --
PRODUCTOR SERRATION AND 7% CUT
TONIGHT IS A SERVICE HOURS OKAY
WHO'S COMING UP WE I KNOW OF ONE
MY SPEECHES READY UP HERE.
COME ON UP [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY SO EVERYONE CAN INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD AND I
KNOW YOU'RE READY UP HERE BUT
WHICH HAVE EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL.
ANYONE WITH A CA YOU CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
BUT THE SURVEY LESS THE PROGRAM
OF THE WHOLE SUPPER.
THANK YOU --
ERIC BUT IT IS WITH THE ACLU
TWENTY FIFTEEN OKAY THANK YOU.
MICHELLE ROSY CALIFORNIA OF SAID
I HSS LOCAL ALAMEDA COUNTY TANK
YOU OKAY NOW.
IT CAN FIGURE OUT THE AT THE
TIME.
THESE ALL IN THE LAST WEEK OKAY
THANK YOU RIGHT WHICH COULD
BEGIN.
IF ANYONE WOULD --
AS HERE YOU CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
TO PRESENT THE PROPOSAL --
TO RESEND CERTAIN SEC RESEND
CERTAIN SIR TO MAKE IT A
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THE 7%
I HAVE ONE OF OUR MEMBERS HERE
WITH ME --
AS WELL AS OF SOMEONE THAT WILL
BE TRANSLATING FOR HER WELL WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE BUDGET --
PROPOSES THAT IT WOULD BE DONE
IN A BUDGET BILL THAT'S SIMPLY
NOT A PERMANENT RESTORATION
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
THANK YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU A LITTLE EXTRA
TIME SINCE YOU HAVE THE CHANCE
AND ATTRIBUTING HERE.
THE SHEET THAT.
TAKING SENATE EVEN GO THEN CONDO
THAT YOU OWN ALL.
IS A BIT OF A LOT OF THEM WITH
ANOTHER MISSING NO WE LEARNED ON
ME HOPEFUL SO THEN IN.
THAT THE NSA LITTLE POLICY.
HELLO CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BUT THE
SALE NAY LASS.
I'M A MEMBER OF SCA YOU TWENTY
FIFTEEN FROM YOLO COUNTY.
I A. EMMA HOME CARE PROVIDER FOR
MY SON HOLD SWAY WHO HAS
CEREBRAL.
PALSY.
ABRAMOV ANKLE SUPPORT PROPORTION
UP WITH OTHER BE TIGHT BUT I
LEFT FOR SOME AS WELL AS MEN MAY
HAVE YES.
BUT SOME OF MY UNITS ARE CAUSING
GET ESOS BUT SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE BEST GONNA CASF THE FAMILY.
IS THE MOST ARE YOU THAT WE NEED
INDEPENDENT THE ECONOMY THAT YES
OF THE THAT A LEVY THAT THE
LITERACY PAN FISCAL MOMMY WHO IS
BUT WITHOUT ESTáN WHEN YOU'LL.
THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM PROVIDES VITAL CARE TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
LOW INCOME SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
SO THEY MAY LIVE INDEPENDENTLY
AS POSSIBLE AND WITH DIGNITY IN
THEIR OWN HOMES A TEMPORARY OR
ANNUAL RESTORATION OF THE 7% CUT.
CREATES INSTABILITY IN THE LIVES
OF CARE RECIPIENTS LIKE MY SON
AND THEIR CARE PROVIDERS LIKE ME.
NO SORT OF NSA CONFIDENCE AT THE
PERCENT ON THE WHOLE THING OKAY
I'M GUESSING IF YOU GOT THE NEW
JUNGLE BUT A MONTH AND THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND EAGLE DO YOU
MUST BUY LIST.
AND THIS IS BUS BECAUSE THEY
WILL KNOW THAT.
THIS IS WHAT I WAS BORN IN ONE
OPPOSES YOUR NAME ESTABLISH A
SINGLE IT OUT.
RESTAURANT OPEN.
IF THE BUSH HIMSELF.
THE COURT THEN THEY INCOME
SUPPORT KNOW THAT I WANT TO
STUDY THAT WE LOVE THEM AND SEE
DON'T YAK A LOT GOING ON AND
THAT'S NOT THE BILL FROM YOU
THOUGHT HE PROBABLY THOUGHT.
NOT ONLY DOES A 7% CUT THREATEN
MY SON'S CARE BUT IT ALSO MEANS
I AM STRUGGLING TO KEEP A ROOF
OVER OUR HEADS AND COVER BILLS
OF OUR MOST BASIC NEEDS.
A CUT TO HIS HOURS PUTS US IN A
UNSTABLE POSITION TO BOTH
CONSUMERS LIVES.
AND THE CARE BEING PROVIDED.
ME YOU CALL NO.
BUDGET.
BUSINESSES SODAS I THINK YOUR
LET'S BE LOOK ABOUT HOW WATER HI
BUT YOU NEVER EVER THOUGHT OF
HIM FOR A MINUTE.
GET THE POSSIBLE GRASS YES.
MY SON SHOULD NEVER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT WHETHER HE WILL HAVE
ENOUGH HOURS OF CARE SO TODAY I
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT A TRUE PER
MINUTE RESTORATION OF THE 7% CUT
THANK YOU.
THIS IS A I SHALL ROSY OF
EVERYONE REPEAT WHAT THEY SAID
LOT OF WHAT I WAS CONVINCED HER
TO SAY TODAY OF WOULD BE REPEAT
WHAT THEY HAD TO SAY.
BUT I WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD WEAR
CARD WITH A PROPOSED A UNIQUE
WAYS FOR MAKING SURE AYE HSS
SERVICES ARE SUSTAINABLE AND TO
THE FUTURE FOR THOSE WHO NEED A
IT JUST SAYS.
THERE'S NOT AN ALTERNATIVE TO
USING AYE HSS THERE'S NOT A
BETTER PROGRAM IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT HELPS KEEP SENIORS THE
BLIND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
MAINTAINED IN THE COMMUNITY.
AS WITH THE SUPPORTS THEY NEED.
I'M GLAD THE GOVERNOR SAYS HE
FULLY SUPPORTS HIGH SHE SAYS BUT
A ONE YEAR RESTORATION OF 7% CUT
USING.
GENERAL FRIENDS IS NOT ENOUGH WE
NEED TO FIND A PERMANENT
SOLUTION.
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE'VE WE'VE COME
BACK.
IT IS FOR IT OF SUN BECAUSE WHEN
I HAD THOSE CUTS IMPLEMENTED FOR
ANY.
OF I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THING ON
THE LIST OF MY THINGS TO DO THAT.
THAT THAT I WOULD HAVE TO CUT
OUT WITH THOSE CUTS AND I DON'T
EVER LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND SO YOU AS OUR OUR PEOPLE IN
OFFICE NEED TO FIND A SOLUTION
IS NOT AN OPTION ANYMORE TO GO
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
WE HAVE TO FIND A SOLUTION FOR
THE 7% CUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH --
ANY COMMENTS FROM.
THE FARM SOCIAL SERVICES.
OKAY -- LA --
ONCE FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANY
TALENT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE. THREE
HUNDRED FOR A TWO POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO RESTORE
THE 7% IN IS THE INTENT OF THE
AMOUNT ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
RESTORATION TO BE ONGOING.
WE HEAR THE CONCERNS WERE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE ENGAGING
CONVERSATIONS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO WE WILL
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I'M
HAPPY TO KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION LEASES.
PROPOSING IN SPIRITS AND IN
NUMBERS TO DO THAT BUT I ALSO
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
WE SHOULD HAVE OUR OUR CODE
ACTUALLY REFLECT OR INTENT AS
WELL OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY NEXT ITEM.
IS -- IS THE
PUBLIC AUTHORITY FOR MINISTRY TO
FUNDING SO I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES --
I CARE YOU ARE OKAY WILL COME
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR
THE RECORD FOR BEING Q. MISTER
TERRIBLY BC AND HAS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR AGENDA USING THIS ISSUE --
WE FIRST WANT TO START BY
EXPRESSING OUR APPRECIATION.
FOR THE ON GOING DIALOGUE WE'VE
BEEN HAVING WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
REGARDING WHAT WE BELIEVE TO BE
A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT IN
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL FOR PA
ADMIN FUNDING --
WE ARE HOPEFULLY OPTIMISTIC THAT
AT THE END OF THE DAY THOSE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WILL PROVE
FRUITFUL AND WILL COME TO A
SHARED UNDERSTANDING ABOUT.
THE NEED TO FULLY FUND PA ADMIN
ON JUST TWO EXAMPLES I WANT TO
GET OF OFTHE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY THAT WE BELIEVE HAS
PROVEN FAULTY.
IN DETERMINING --
PA ADMIN FUNDING FOR THIS
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR --
FIRST OF ALL PLEASE PROVIDE A
WIDE VARIETY OF FUNCTIONS --
INCLUDING YOU KNOW REGISTRIES
REFERRAL SERVICES BACKGROUND
CHECKS AT CETERA.
SO AS IT RELATES TO BACKGROUND
CHECK OLOGY FOR DETERMINING THE
NUMBER OF FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
ALLOCATED FOR PERFORMING
BACKGROUND CHECKS WAS BASED ON
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND BACKGROUND
CHECKS BEING DONE ANNUALLY --
THERE'S A REALLY LARGE TURNOVER
RATE IN HSS ABOUT 30% SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DOJ BACKGROUND
CHECKS THAT WERE DONE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE NUMBER WAS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
SO THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE THE
R. FREIGHT --
AND SO THAT RELATED THAT VERSE
THE RESULT OF IT --
BEING BASED ON FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND WOULD RESULT IN ABOUT
ONE AFTER HE FOR EVERY NINETY
FIVE HUNDRED BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND ONLY FOUR POINT.
SEVEN FOUR FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE TO DO THAT
WHICH IS INSUFFICIENT THE SECOND
EXAMPLE HAS TO DO WITH THE
PROVIDER REGISTRY THAT WAS BASED
ON ONLY. 8% OF THE CONSUMER
CASELOAD WHICH WOULD HAVE
RESULTED IN ONLY THIRTY SIX
POINT SIXTY THREE OF T. E.'S
ACROSS THE STATE AS WE HAVE
FIFTY SIX PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE THAT'S NOT EVEN ENOUGH
FOR ONE PER SO WE AGAIN ARE VERY
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
DO OUR DUE DILIGENCE TO CONVINCE.
EVERYBODY THAT WE NEED MORE
MONEY THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU --
COMES FROM THE FARM SOCIAL
SERVICES.
OKAY NO THAT'S RIGHT RIGHT LA --
FINANCE ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL THANKS VERY MUCH AND
STANDARDS ON GOING DISCUSSIONS
SO HOPEFULLY THOSE SKETCHES OF
PROVE FRUITFUL BY --
MAY.
EXCELLENT.
FINALLY WE HAVE THE TO LINK I
JUST AS COUNTY ELOISE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING --
SO.
YOU W. SEIU WELCOME --
SO I KNOW YOU'VE BOTH BEEN UP
HERE BEFORE BUT LET'S INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD FOR
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM THANK YOU.
IF ANYONE KNOWS THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA.
HI CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON YOU
W. ASKS ME [inaudible]
SO -- SO I'D
BE GOING BEGIN THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR --
YOU W. REPRESENTS TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES THE OF AYE HSS
PROVIDERS I DISTRIBUTED TO THE
COMMITTEE A GRAPH IT SHOULD BE
THAT SHOWS YOU COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING STATUS IN OUR TWENTY
ONE COUNTIES.
SO WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TODAY GIVING ATTENTION TO THE
LONG TERM CARE CRISIS.
I BELIEVE WHAT ARE PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES IS ANOTHER LINK IN
THAT CHAIN WHICH IS PROVIDER PAY.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU CANNOT
RECRUIT AND WORK WHEN ALL YOU DO
IS PAY THE MINIMUM WAGE.
THEY CAN GO WORK ANY OTHER JOB
THAT IS SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
STRESSFUL AND LESS DIFFICULT.
AND PROBABLY GET PAID MORE AND
PROBABLY HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
BENEFITS.
I JUST AS PROVIDERS AS YOU CAN
SEE IN THE IN THE COUNTIES
HIGHLIGHTED IN GREEN.
WE ONLY HAVE SIX COUNTIES
CURRENTLY OUT OF TWENTY ONE THAT
PAY OVER MINIMUM WAGE.
THE COUNTIES HIGHLIGHTED IN
YELLOW ARE COUNTIES THAT DO NOT
HAVE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE.
AND SO YOU CAN SEE OUT OF
THERE'S SIX ONLY SIX COUNTIES
OUT OF TWENTY ONE HAVE
AGREEMENTS CURRENTLY IN PLACE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
CALL AND YOU CAN SEE THE AVERAGE
TIME SINKS SINCE THAT AGREEMENT
HAS BEEN EXPIRED IS ALMOST THREE
YEARS.
AND THE AVERAGE AMOUNT OF TIME
SINCE EIGHTY NEGOTIATED WAGE
INCREASE OCCURRED IS CLOSEST TO
FOR YEARS I WANT TO POINT OUT
BECAUSE I REALIZE THIS AFTER I I
PUT THE CHART TOGETHER.
THAT.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE FACT
THAT MOST OF THOSE WAGE
INCREASES THAT HAPPENS SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THE COLUMN IN THE MIDDLE
THAT SAYS LASTING INCREASE.
MOST OF THOSE INCREASES WERE
PURELY THE TRANSFER OF THE
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT WERE
SPENT ON HEALTH BENEFITS.
BEING PUT TOWARD WAGES SO THAT
THERE WAS NO ACTUAL COST TO THAT
AND THE REASON WHY THAT HAPPENED
WAS THAT WAS WHEN THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT PASSED.
AND MEDICAID EXPANSION HAPPENED
WHICH MEANT WHICH MEANT THAT
MOST OF THOSE WORKERS WERE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET ON TO MEDIC
HAL.
SO THE ONLY WAY THAT WE GOT
THOSE INCREASES WAS BY TAKING
MONEY OUT OF HEALTH BENEFITS.
THE REASON I SPEAK SO
PASSIONATELY ABOUT THIS IS
BECAUSEWE HAVE TRIED OVER AND
OVER IN THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
INCENTIVIZE MOVEMENT.
BY THE COUNTIES WHO WE BARGAIN
COLLECTIVELY WITH AND SO THIS
ISN'T TARGETING THE COUNTIES WHO
HAVE DONE THE RIGHT THING THIS
IS TARGETING THE COUNTIES THAT
ARE RECALCITRANT AND REFUSE. TO
DO WHAT'S RIGHT BY THESE WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY DON'T
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
AND I'M GONNA GO BACK TO TWENTY
TWELVE WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THE STATE TO GET THE COMMITTEE
FIRST CHOICE OPTION WHICH WAS
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL DOLLARS.
THAT WAS APPLIED RETROACTIVELY
WHICH MEANT THAT EVERY COUNTY
GOT A CHECK FOR THE AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS THAT WAS REFUNDED BACK
TO THEM WE BAG AT THE TIME FOR
THOSE DOLLARS TO BE PUT RIGHT
BACK INTO THE PROGRAM IN THE
FORM OF WAGES AND BENEFITS AND
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
THE I. AGES AS MOE WHICH HAS
BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED IN STARTING IN
TWENTY TWELVE MEANT THAT THE
COUNTIES WERE NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR ANY SPENDING IN THE PROGRAM.
EXCEPT FOR THREE AND A HALF
PERCENT GROWTH FACTOR.
I DIDN'T RESULT IN ANY WAGE
INCREASES I'M SORRY MR TRACK IS
BIG ON THIS FOR A VERY LONG TIME
BUT LET ME PASS IT ON TO MY
COLLEAGUE IN TO SAY THAT WHAT
WE'RE ASKING.
FOR IS A COMMITMENT THAT THE
SAVINGS THAT THEY WILL
EXPERIENCE.
WE'LL GO BACK INTO THE POCKET
BOOKS OF THESE PROVIDERS THANK
YOU.
YOUR PASSION LAUGHTER WITH NO
TIME BY LETTERS GO HEAD TO HEAD.
BECAUSE TO BRIEFLY.
ANYWAY IN WITH US THE ARE YOU
THIRTY SEVEN COUNTIES CURRENTLY
WE HAVE TWENTY THREE OF OUR
THIRTY SEVEN COUNTIES WITHOUT A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO RECOURSE --
OUR PROVIDERS CANNOT STRIKE
SIMILAR TO PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS THERE'S NO BINDING
ARBITRATION SO AT COUNTY CAN
DECIDE THAT THEY JUST DON'T WANT
TO DO IT AND AND BACHELORS OKAY
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN IN OTHER
PROFESSIONS STATE EMPLOYEES TO
HAVE A CONTRACT.
THERE WOULD BE CONCERNED IF
HOSPITALS DON'T HAVE A CONTRACT
THERE WOULD BE CONCERN THE FACT
THAT ARE AYE AGES AS PROVIDERS
COULD NOT HAVE A CONTRACT FOR
UPWARDS OF TEN YEARS.
IS IS NOT OKAY AND THERE SHOULD
BE CONCERNED IT EVERYBODY SHOULD
BE GRAVELY CONCERNED --
WITH THIS CURRENT STATE WE HAVE
ONE COUNTY AS LASSEN THEY HAVE
NEVER HAD A CONTRACT THEY WENT
TO MANDATORY MEDIATION AND IN
MEDIATION IT WAS FOUND IN.
FAVOR OF THE UNION AND THEY HAVE
DISMISSED EVERYTHING SO NOT
HAVING A CV EIGHT IS BASICALLY A
DISMISSAL OF AYE AGE OF THOSE
PROVIDERS IT'S A DISMISSAL OF
THEIR CLIENTS IN A DISMISSAL OF
THE PROGRAM AND ITS ENTIRETY.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THIS PROPOSAL
IS BEFORE YOU TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH
CLEARLY A BIG PROBLEM.
YEAH OF COMMENTS FROM THE PARTS
OF SERVICE.
NO I THINK THE PROBLEM THAT
YOU'RE HEARING IS NOT A NEW --
ONE WE COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S BEEN HISTORICAL
UNCERTAINTY ON ON REGARDING
WHETHER A BARGAINING WOULD BE
MOVED TO THE STATE LEVEL --
AS WAS PROPOSED UNDER THE
COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE
INCREASES IN MINIMUM WAGE --
HAVE BEEN A FACTOR AND ALSO JUST
THE GENERAL CONVERSATION AROUND
THE AMMO IN FISCAL COMMITMENTS
IN THE PROGRAM WE'RE NOT GOING
CONCERNED AS CLEARLY COMPLICATED
THE ABILITY TO REACH AGREEMENTS --
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY AND CARE
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE ALL HERE.
FOR IS HIGHLY CORRELATED WITH
THE HAVING A STABLE WORKFORCE
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT KNOWN IN
CERTAIN COMPENSATION FOR THAT
WORK FORCE IS THEREFORE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT HEALTH
CARE AND SAFETY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LA --
ANY COMMENTS.
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WELL WE'RE GOING TO NOW
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
AYE ON THIS PORTION OF AYE HSS
SO WE WILL BE THEY'LL COVER THE
OVERVIEW THE MAN IS FIVE FIRSTS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO THE B.
C. P..
FOR THE MISTER VIEW DATA AND THE
FIVE PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF ITEMS --
BUT ALSO LOTS BEEN SAID ABOUT
THEM READY NOT THAT MARKET COULD
BE BUT I'M GOING TO ASK IF YOU
COULD SEE --
THESE AGAIN KEEP YOUR REMARKS TO
A MINUTE BE TO USE WORK I AGREE
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER AGREED
WITH PEOPLE TESTIFIED WORKS --
TO SO THANK YOU AND Là.
WELCOME.
AFTER PAN IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CONNIE ARNOLD HERE
AGAIN.
A DISABILITY RIGHTSADVOCATE FOR
THIRTY PLUS YEARS.
FIRST I AM HERE TO SAY THAT THE
I JUST AS PROGRAM IS NO LONGER
SERVING THE INTERESTS OF THOSE.
OF US WITH SEVERE DISABILITIES
TO SAY LIVING.
AT IN OUR OWN HOMES IN THE
COMMUNITY --
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM NOBODY
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT THE I
JUST SAYS.
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES ARE IN
EFFECTIVELY USELESS AND HELPING
RECIPIENTS. TO FIND COMMUNITY
CARE PROVIDERS BECAUSE AND WHAT
I'M SAYING SPECIFICALLY MAY
INVOLVE OTHER MULTIPLE COUNTIES
BECAUSE I HEAR FROM A LOT OF
PEOPLE. ONE THEY RECYCLED NAMES
ON LISTS TWO THEY GIVE OUT VERY
FEW PROVIDER NAMES TO CALL WHEN
THERE'S RECIPIENT.
CALLS IN FOR A LIST SOMETIMES
FAR AWAY. THREE POTENTIAL
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS DON'T WANT
TO WORK FRIDAY JUST AS
RECIPIENTS WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES ONE WAGES ARE LEVEL.
LOWER THAN MCDONALD'S OR OTHER
LOW WAGE JOBS --
WITH THE LAST TWO SPEAKERS --
NEW PROVIDER ENROLLMENT IS TOO
SLOW AND REQUIRES A GOING
THROUGH ITS LOW BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS.
I AGES SAYS TIME SHEETS ARE
GIVEN OUT FOR WEEKS TO MONTHS
FOR NEW PROVIDERS TO BE PAID.
PAYMENT CAN BE DELAYED FOR
MONTHS.
ARE THERE IS NO LOW PAY
DIFFERENTIAL FOR PROVIDERS
WILLING TO WORK FOR PERSONS
DEFINED IN LAW IS HAVING.
A SEVERE DISABILITY WHERE THE
AYE HSS RECIPIENT HAS TWO OR
MORE.
I IT JUST SAYS PROVIDERS WERE AT
LEAST ONE IS A NON FAMILY MEMBER
CARE PROVIDER OR MORE.
THERE SHOULD BE ANNUAL PAY
INCREASE INCENTIVES SMALL REYES
FOR THOSE PROVIDERS WILLING TO
WORK.
AND PROVIDE CARE TO AYE HSS
RECIPIENTS DESIGNATED AS HAVING
A SEVERE DISABILITY.
THIS DESIGNATION IS BASED ON
LEVEL OF ASSESSED AYE HSS HOURS
UNDER THE WELFARE INSTITUTIONS
COAT. EIGHT CDSS AYE HSS AND
RECONCILED ADVANCE PAY I'M AND I
HSS ADVANCE PAY RECIPIENTS.
THERE OVER PAYMENT PROCESS IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
HAS THE STATE AND COUNTY IS
FAILING TO GET ONLY TIMELY PAPER
TIME SHEETS.
THEN TURN AROUND AND DEMAND A
REFUND OF THE MONIES FOR
ATTENDANT CARE THAT THE PERSON
PAID OUT. TO THEIR PROVIDERS --
FROM THOSE OF US WITH THE MOST
SEVERE DISABILITIES CURRENTLY
THAT SITUATIONS GOING ON WITH A
FRIEND IN LA.
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS A FRIEND OF
MINE WHO RUNS A NONPROFIT WHO IS
A QUADRIPLEGIC IN.
SANTA CRUZ CAN'T GET TIME SHEETS
EVEN THOUGH HE'S CALLED THE HELP
DESK CALL THESE.
SOCIAL WORKER CALLED THE COUNTY
THEY WON'T SEND HIM OR THE
PROVIDER THE TIME SHEETS AND
THEY'VE HAD HIM ALREADY PAID
BACK MONEY [inaudible]
AND AND NOW HE'S FACING IT A
SECOND TIME HE CAN'T GET THE
TIME SHEETS THAT'S WRONG THAT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE.
CDS AS PROPOSED DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PARAMEDICAL SERVICES
PROPOSED.
CHANGES THAT WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER FOR AYE AGES SAYS
RECIPIENTS WHICH IS ABILITY TO
GET PARAMEDICAL SERVICES.
AND THEY'RE MAKING THE SYSTEM
MORE PER YEAR CRADDICK.
SO IF YOU NEED HER MEDICAL
SERVICES THEY WANT YOU TO HAVE
TO GO TO A LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. TO GET TWO FORMS
FILLED OUT NOW AND GET TRAINING
AND SIGN OFF ON IT FOR WHAT.
THE PROVIDER CAN BE PAID TO
PROVIDE A CATHETER CHANGE A
FEEDING --
TO RANGE OF MOTION THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS.
AND THE PRIORITY NEEDS TO SHIP
TO THE THIRTY PER 2% OF US THAT
NEED.
A COMMUNITY PROVIDERS WE REALLY
THOSE COMMUNITY PROVIDERS ARE
NOT BENEFITING FROM THE OVER
TIME.
AND WE APPRECIATE ALL THAT IS
BEING DONE FOR THE FAMILY MEMBER
PROVIDERS BUT WHEN WE CAN'T FIND
IT.
WERE THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO
END UP IT'S OUR DEBT I KNOW
WHERE I'M GOING.
I HAVE A HOUSE AND I KNOW I'M
GOING TO END UP IN A NURSING
HOME THE WAIT THE SYSTEM IS.
SET UP IN A FIGHT.
IF THAT IS THE CASE I'M GOING TO
GO DROWN MYSELF IN THE OCEAN
BECAUSE I AM NOT GOING TO ONE OF
THOSE PLACES.
OKAY AND I'M GONNA HAVE TO ASK
YOU TO I WANT TO WRAP THIS UP
FOR YOU YES ACTUALLY IF YOU HAVE
SOME WRITTEN MATERIAL WE HAVE%
SOME WRITTEN MATERIAL AND THERE
ARE SOME.
ADDITIONAL THINGS GET WORSE
POSTED ON THE BERKELEY DISABLED
LIST SERVE.
BY A GROUP OF US WERE ASKING TO
STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS SO WE
CAN FIND CARE GIVERS AND REVERSE
THE BACKGROUND CHECK.
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
WE FEEL THAT.
AND I FEEL IN A IT'S BEING
TALKED ABOUT BY RECIPIENTS YOU
COULD SAY FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
BY GETTING RID OF THE AYE AGES
AT PUBLIC AUTHORITY SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT'S NOT WORKING AND WE
CAN'T FIND CARE GIVERS AND WE
HAD A BETTER TIME.
FINING CARE GIVERS BEFORE THERE
WAS SUCH AS A OUR CHANGE.
OKAY LENGTHY PROCESS TO GO EIGHT
SEVEN FIFTEEN WHICH IS GONNA BE
HEARD.
ABOUT RAISING THEIR AGED AND
DISABLED.
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL 210038%
APPRECIATE THE YOU HAD A LOT TO
SAY -- AND I
DID CALL YOUR STAFF BUT THEY
NEVER CALLED ME BACK --
WELCOME BACK YEAH AND I WANTED
TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES OKAY AND I EVEN
EMAILED THEM BUT I DIDN'T HEAR
BACK FROM YOU KNOW OKAY WHILE
CHECK IN WITH THEM ON THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO COME SEE YOU
AGAIN.
SHE ATE ALL YOU'RE DOING IN YOUR
INTEREST IN THISBILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND I KNOW YOU HAD A
LOT THE VERY IMPORTANT THINGS TO
SAY SO I TRIED TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE MORE TIME BUT I ALSO NEED
TO I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WAITING.
YEARS WELL SO [inaudible]
THIS THING [inaudible]
EVERY TIME.
THAT SHE WAS GETTING INFORMATION
FROM THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
ABOUT THE URGENT CARE AND
THEY'RE VERY SMALL USAGE.
A LOT OF THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
DON'T EVEN ADVERTISE OR TELL YOU
THE PHONE NUMBER TO WEAR TO GET
URGENT CARE SERVICES.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY LIMITS YOU TO
THREE TIMES FOUR HOURS YOU CAN'T
EVEN MAKE IT THROUGH A FRIDAY TO
ON MONDAY.
ON URGENT CARE SERVICESTO THE
COUNTY.
SO I GUESS YOU'RE JUST NOT
SUPPOSED TO EAT OR GO TO THE
BATHROOM OR GET UP AND GO TO BED.
YOU KNOW SO THANK YOU I THINK
YOU'RE AND I DON'T THINK WHEN
THEY'VE ASKED TALK TO BLAME BACK
WITH -- SAID
TO CALL EASY DOES IT DOWN AND
BERKELEY FOR HAVING TO STAY IN
BED AND HAVING TO GET URGENCY
SERVICES AS HE'S BEEN UNABLE TO
FIND A CARE GIVER.
AND HE'S ON A VENTILATOR FOR
SEVEN WEEKS HE'S TRIED FOR YEARS
TO FIND A CARE GIVER
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK THANK YOU AND DAVID
[inaudible]
WAR BUT OKAY WELCOME HELLO
ALLEN O'CONNELL.
DOG FIVE CHAIR.
DISABILITY ORGANIZING GROUP FOR
INITIATING TOLL EQUALITY AND
HAVE A KID [inaudible] TWO WE
SUPPORT THE 7% REYES AND MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S PERMANENT.
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
TO GO THROUGH ALL THIS PAPERWORK
AGAIN
AND I AM ALSO THAT I AGES AS
CONSUMER [inaudible]
AND A LOT OF WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
GOING TO DO WITH THE EEVEE V.
AND STUFF.
IS VERY CONFUSING FREE FOR ME
AND I TRY TO STAY UP ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MARIA GROW HALL BONE WEST
SACRAMENTO YOLO COUNTY.
I AM.
THE MOTHER OF A THIRTY ONE YEAR
OLD SON WHO HAS ASPERGER'S AND
SCHIZO AFFECTIVE DISORDER. FOR
THOSE OF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
SCHIZOAFFECTIVE IF THAT'S
ANOTHER NICE WORD FOR
SCHIZOPHRENIA --
MY SON HAVE A LOT OF RAGE INSIDE
HIM.
HAVE NO IDEA WHERE HE COMES FROM
FOR COME FROM BUT HE REQUIRES
SUPERVISORY CARE.
IT'S WHAT IT'S CALLED.
AND I'M STORE THAT 77% BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY IN THE PUBLIC'S
INTEREST THAT MY SON STAY HOME.
WHEN HE BECAME QUALIFY WHEN HE
BECAME ELIGIBLE FOR HSS I
COULDN'T FIND A PROVIDER LUCKY
FOR ME I FOUND A WOMAN THAT'S
BEEN A PROVIDER FOR TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS AND SHE WAS NOT SCARED OF
HIM?
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS SCARED OF HIM.
BECAUSE I COULDN'T FIND A
PROVIDER I AM OF A STATE OUT I
RETIRED FROM THE STATE BECAUSE I
HAVE A BAD BACK AND I HAVE I
RECEIVE SOCIAL SECURITY
DISABILITY.
I HAVE TO CLEAN THOSE HOURS I
HAD TO BECOME A PROVIDER AND
THEN SO SECURITY DISABILITY TOOK
MY CHECK AWAY AND SO ANYWAYS
THANK GOODNESS I FOUND A
PROVIDER.
WE ALREADY HAVE ON ALL TURN OUT
ON ELECTRONIC CHECK IN SYSTEM WE
DON'T NEED TO BE OUT.
OF MICRO MANAGED AND WE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU DO BUT PLEASE IT'S IN THE
INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC.
TO KEEP MY SON AT HOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GOT IT.
OKAY.
ALLOW ME BY WELCOME.
LET ME KNOW MAYES MAN I LIKE
THEM SO I PRO WITHOUT I THINK WE
DON'T CRY SAM THEY'VE GONE
THOUGH THIS STUDY LAOS DROP FOR
YOUR PROPOSED AT THE LITTLE SEED
IN THIS FOR SO THAT MONTH ANY
MENTAL.
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN THOSE CALL MORE
MEAL.
GET THE IN AN ACQUITTAL SIGNAL
NAY ALSO ASKS EUNICE QUALITY OF
US.
IF THE MINISTRY.
NONE OF MY SKIN --
SIMPLE CAMELS.
IN RECORD PLEASE SEE NóI AND
LIKELY THAT IF EITHER.
THEY MISTRUST EQUALS DANIELS.
BEYOND A PORTABLE.
WHAT THREE HOLES?
THE LIST.
IS YOU'RE NOT.
GOING. TO MEET.
WHAT IMPACT DOES HOW DOES IT
MAKE YOUR?
WHAT THREE THINGS THAT?
WELL I'M NOT A CONSPIRACY THIS
CALL MAYBE.
IT ALSO DOES THE YEAR OR MODEL
NUMBER TWO GUY YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
WELL.
AND SO OFTEN GONE DOMINOES OKAY.
YOU SEE ON BUT THOSE COURSES CAN
BE SAN.
MY NAME IS ON MY LIKE I FOUND.
AND I AM AN H. SINCE HOME CARE
PROVIDER.
FROM STANISLAUS COUNTY.
I SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO REDUCE
THE COUNTY I'M ONLY ONLY AND
COUNTIES LIKE MINE.
THAT HAVE A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS IN PLACE.
THIS IS A BERMAN I FOUND.
THIS IS RAMON IS THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD.
HE IS ONE OF FOUR CHILDREN.
MY OTHER THREE CHILDREN ARE
PROFESSIONALS.
MY SON IT HURTS ME HE SUFFERS.
IT HURTS ME TO SEE HIM HE
UNDERSTANDS.
AND WHEN HE HEARS ABOUT CUTS. TO
THE AGENTS THIS PROGRAM HE
WORRIES.
AND IT HURTS HIM AND IT HURTS ME.
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO TALK --
BUT WANT WHAT WE WANT I HOPE
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND.
THAT AS A PARENT PROVIDER.
THAT THIS IS NOT JUST THE FOCUS
FOCUS SHOULD NOT BE ON ME AS A
PROVIDER BUT IT SHOULD BE ON THE
NEEDS OF MY SON.
AND THOSE LIKE MYSELF.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE'VE WE'RE
FORTUNATELY WE ARE NOT PROPOSING
TO CUT THE PROGRAM AT THE MOMENT
THAT THANK YOU THANKS MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR HAND TEMAS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS RUSSELL RAWLINGS I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
WE REPRESENT --
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
THROUGHOUT SACRAMENTO AND YOLO
COUNTY AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO I CAN REFLECT UPON THE
IMPORTANT WORK BEING DONE HERE.
IN THIS --
PARTICULAR ITEM I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE LOTS OF MOVING PIECES
FOR ONE WE FULLY SUPPORT --
KEEPING HOLE THE 7% REDUCTIONS --
PLEASE --
MAKE THAT PERMANENT SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION.
A SECOND I JUST WANT TO TIE THIS
CONGRESS YOUR CONVERSATIONS THAT
WERE BEING HELD.
AS WE LOOK TOWARD A FUTURE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT A
PROGRAM LIKE I TRUST US AND THE
FOUNDATION OF THE PROGRAM IN
WHICH IT WAS.
A STRONG COMMITMENT FROM
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS.
OF MANY VERY DISABILITIES AND
SITUATIONS TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY SETTING OF THEIR
CHOICE.
ADDITIONALLY IT'S ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE CARE GIVERS
THOSE WHO PROVIDE THE CARE.
ARE BEING TREATED WITH DIGNITY
AND RECEIVE A LOVELY LIVABLE
WAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI WELCOME EN CHAPTER TO GEAR.
IN SUPPORT WHAT'S YOU NEED TO DO
AT THE SAME TIME I WILL OFFER.
IS DEALING WITH THE ELECTRONIC
VISIBLE YOUR CATION IS BASED
UPON THE PAYROLL SYSTEM AND SO
FAR ALREADY I'VE HEARD THIS YEAR
ALONE.
THAT IS HAVING TO BE REBOOTED TO
REBUILD IT SO I WILL INVITE YOU
TO PLEASE DETERMINE WHERE ARE
THE ISSUES AND THE PROBLEMS.
AS OUR SUPPORT THIS BUT ALSO SAY
TO YOU THERE'S MUCH THAT NEEDS
TO BE WORKED ON I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI DOCTOR PAN I'M SORRY MY NAME
IS KATHY BAR HAMMER NINE FROM
PLASTER COUNTY.
BY.
WHICH DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
IN PLACE.
FOR FOR US FOR THE PROVIDERS.
SO I SUPPORT YOU W. FOR PROPOSAL
TO REDUCE THE COUNTY MO WE ONLY
AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
IN PLACE IN AND THEY SHOULD.
CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR COUNTIES
LIKE MINE TO REACH CONTRACT
AGREEMENTS WITH US.
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS
LIKE A STATEWIDE FOREST FIRE IN
AND BREAKS WON'T HELP.
SO WE NEED TO PUT THE FIRE OUT
AND I SAID TRUMP THING.
IS BY THE WAY.
ISSUED IN READING --
HERE EVER HEAR THAT --
ONE AND THAT PUT THE FIRE OUT
WITH MORE FUNDING.
AND IT'S BEEN HAPPENING THERE
WERE ALWAYS ON THE BOTTOM LINE
WHEN IT COMES. TO FUNDING.
BUT ON THE TOP RUNG WHEN IT
COMES TO CUTS.
AND SO THIS 7% CUT I'D LIKE TO
SEE BE PERMANENTLY REMOVED.
FROM BUDGET TALKS.
AND SO.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S ALL I
HAD TO SAY SO IF YOU DON'T MIND
I'D LIKE TO BE A SECOND PERSON
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO LEAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF HER CLIENT.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LIFE
THREATENING.
A PROBLEM THAT SHE HAD FOR HER
WITH HER CLIENT BECAUSE OF THE
7% -- CAUGHT.
DO YOU MIND IF I READ THAT THE
IT VERY BRIEFLY TO STEVEN I
THANK YOU YES.
OKAY SO --
HE WAS SHE WAS NOT I WAS NOT DUE
TO GO TO MY RECIPIENTS HOUSE
THIS DAY BECAUSE OF THE 7% CUT.
BUT I HAD NOT TALKED TO HER ALL
DAY AND THIS WAS VERY UNUSUAL IT
WAS A VERY HOT DAY.
I DECIDED TO STOP BY WHEN I
ARRIVED AT THE FRONT DOOR IT WAS
LOCKED AND I HAD NOTICED THAT
HER LITTLE DAUGHTER BEEN
SCRATCHING AT THE DOOR AND
JUMPING UP ON THE WINDOW.
I DIDN'T LIVE FAR AND RAN HOME
AND GRABBED THE KEYS AND RAN
BACK TO HER HOUSE AND WHEN I GOT
INSIDE A YOUNG FOR HER.
FINALLY FOUND HER IN THE BATH
TUB HER OXYGEN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
A DAY.
WHEN I FOUND HER OXYGEN --
I PUT IT ARMENIAN WE PUT IT ON
HER HER LIPS HAD ALREADY TURNED
BLUE.
I CALLED NINE ONE ONE WHEN I
ARRIVED AT THE HOSPITAL THE
DOCTOR TOLD ME SHE WAS EXTREMELY
DEHYDRATED ANOTHER HOUR.
OR SO AND SHE WOULD HAVE EXPIRED.
ALL OF THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED IF THAT 7% WAS NOT IN
PLACE AND I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO PERMANENTLY
RESTORE THE 7% TO OUR RECIPIENT
HOURS.
THANK YOU I I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE --
THAT.
WE'RE NOT NO ONE'S PROPOSING A
7% CUTS --
SO WE I UNDERSTAND PROPOSAL THAT
WERE GOING TO REMOVE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE STATUTE NAY
ANDERSON HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS --
BUT I THINK ALSO WE JUST.
THAT'S WHY BE CLEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS NOW PROPOSED AND
STARS I KNOW WE'RE NOT LOOKING
AT LEGISLATURE A DOING A 7% CUT
FACT INTENT IS. TO RESTORE 27%
NOW ONLY FOR ONE YEAR BUT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AND I I I I DON'T.
AS SITES WILL BE SURE THAT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO DO BUT I ALSO
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
THAT WE ALSO TAKE IT OUT THE
STATUTES OF THE REAL FACT IS NOT
GOING TO BE A CUTS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO.
PROPOSED ACTUAL FINANCIAL CUT
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED TO
TRY TO TAKE CARE OF THE LANGUAGE
IN THE STATUTE WHICH IS THERE --
SO AND WAS NOT BEEN PROPOSED TO
BE REMOVED YET SO SAYING THAT --
THERE'S A PROPOSAL 47% CUT
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE CERTAINLY
CERTAINLY CONSIDERING SO.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR MONICA MILLER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY ALAMEDA AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
JUSTIN YOU'RE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES --
GRAHAM IS ALREADY OUTLINED --
HOW COUNTIES ARE PROUD TO
MINUTES OF THIS PROGRAM IN OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S ROSE I'M JUST GONNA
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO SOME OF
THE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS?
ON THE PUBLIC AUTHORITY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING OR
SUPPORT OF THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN CAP AND
CITIES HAS TO ENSURE THE
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF FUNDING IS
PROVIDED.
AND THEN ON THE PROPOSAL TO LINK
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TO THE AYE
AYE REDUCE I'VE SESSIONS LATER --
YOU KNOW WE'VE PARTNERED WITH
SCA UNITY W. TO CREATE NEW
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TOOLS BACK
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE SEEN THEM
WORK IN A NUMBER OF COUNTIES AND
WE THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH --
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS ON THIS
ISSUE SO WERE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO I'M HAVING A COUNTY NOT BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE THAT REDUCE
INFLATION FACTOR 24% LESS TO
COLLECT BARGAINING AGREEMENT IS
IN PLACE.
THE PROPOSED AMOUNT ABOUT STATE
MINIMUM WAGE AS BOTH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NELLY I OUTLINED THE
INTENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS --
TO KEEP THAT COUNTY ISIS COSTS
WITHIN WHAT IT CAN BE HANDLED
WITHIN REALIGNMENT AND THERE'S
RECOGNITION THAT --
THERE ARE COSTS THAT WERE
OUTSIDE OF COUNTY CONTROL AND
HAPPENED PROP PREVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE IN IMPLEMENTATION OF
FEDERAL OVERTIME RULES.
AND SO IF THE INFLUENCE IF THE
INFLATION FACTOR IS ABOUT CUTS
IN NEGATIVE IMPACTS THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT OCCURRING TO OUR
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS THAT COUNTIES ALSO
ADMINISTER ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSE AND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THE AYE HSS MOE AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU.
ABOUT US AND WHY ON BEHALF THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S AYE HSS I'M
AWAY PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S HSS EMILY
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI I THINK BASKET WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION --
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S I JUST ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT BOTH IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND ON AN ONGOING BASIS IN
THE I JUST AS PROGRAM.
AND TO HELP KEEP THE PROGRAM
SUSTAINABLE WITHIN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT REVENUES --
SO WE THANK YOU FOR THAT --
WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE SEX
COMMON ON THE PROPOSAL TO LINK
THE MO WE TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
REGARDING EBV IMPLEMENTATION --
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION COUNTY WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS TO ENSURE THE
ADEQUACY OF THAT FUNDING AS THE
PLAN FOR IMPLEMENTATION
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE --
AND WE ARE ALSO SUPPORT OF OF
THE WORK GOING ON AROUND THE
PUBLIC AUTHORITY ADMINISTRATIVE
BUDGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
KELLY BUCKS I'M HERE THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE REAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF COUNTY
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION.
AND THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA SANTA
CRUZ VENTURA AND COLUSA --
THAT THOSE ALL OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND COUNTIES ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S I JUST LAST EMILY
TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL --
WE WANT TO THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
WE THINK IT'S A REALLY FAIR
PROPOSAL TO ABOUT IT THAT BETTER
ALIGNS REVENUES.
AND PROGRAM COSTS AND JUST ONE
UNDERSCORE FOR YOU HOW IMPORTANT
THAT HEALTH FUNDING IS COUNTIES
ARE USING IT AS A MATCH FOR MEDI
CAL AND THEY USE IT --
ON PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND I KNOWYOU KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS GIVEN THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING YOU HAD
LAST WEEK --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WELCOME BARBARA GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. TO REALIGN MENTAL
HEALTH GROWTH RESTORATION FUNDS
THESE FUNDS --
WILL NOW BECOME AVAILABLE FOR
COUNTIES AND IT WILL HELP WITH
THOSE HOSPITALS THAT PROVIDE
INPATIENT PSYCIATRIC CARE AND I
AM DE SERVICES AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME AND GET THE
NAME IS THE CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT
THAT REPRESENT MOE AND THE ADMIT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS
THEY HAVE ARE WE ARE 40% OF THE
CASELOAD STATEWIDE --
SO THAT IS A A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME TO BE CENTERS
ON THE OVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WANT TO
REGISTER OUR SUPPORT. FOR THE
AYE HSS MOE THE PERMANENT REPEAL
OF THE 7% CUT AND THE
CODIFICATION OF THE EEVEE V.
PROTECTIONS FROM LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HI CARL JONES PLASTER COUNTY I
TO ASSESS.
PROVIDER AND THE RING TO LONG --
PLACER COUNTY HIATUSES RECIPIENT --
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S 7% RESTORATION AND ON
A PERSONAL NOTE.
I NEVER PLANNED ON BEING A FULL
TIME CAREGIVER AND LORRAINE.
NEVER PLANNED ON HAVING A STROKE
AND BECOMING DISABLED THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A LIFELINE AND
A LIFE SAVER AND WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR FINDING THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI IS A DOCTOR FRIEND MY NAME IS
DOLLY KI MANDATE FROM THE BAY
AREA SOME FRIENDS HE'S CALL.
I BELONG TO A IS THE I USED TO
INDEED BE.
FIFTEEN AND I TAKE CARE OF MY
SISTER --
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
INTELLECTUALLY CHALLENGE.
I HAVE A QUESTION DO YOU PLEASE
AND I'D LIKE TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING.
I OF ZEUS SO THAT THE REST OF US
WOULD UNDERSTAND IT ONCE AND FOR
ALL AND CLEARLY.
IT IS ABOUT THIS 7%.
IT IS JUST A PROPOSED SON BUT WE
ARE REQUESTING YOU'LL WE HAD A
QUESTING OUR POLITICIANS AND
GOVERNOR NEW SOME TO HAVE BEEN
HIT BERMAN AND NOT ON A YEAR TO
YEAR BASIS.
IT'S LIKE A SHINING STAR THE
MOST LET'S IN OUR NECK.
IT IS YOU.
AND DOES ALL PLEASE CLOUDED BY
TO US AND BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED.
IS ACTUALLY --
FIGHTING IT IS AND AND THE
BUDGET FINANCIALLY IS ACTUALLY.
SUSTAINING THE ITIS US PROGRAM
SO THERE'S NO 7% CUT RIGHT.
NOW SO ALSO THE REQUESTS WHICH
BUT THEN THAT PROPOSAL SO THEY
HAVE OUR BUDGETING MONEY THEY'RE
PROPOSING MONEY TO BE SURE THERE
IS A 7% CUT.
CERTAINLY THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
I WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVEN'T WE
HAVEN'T VOTED ON ANYTHING BUT
CERTAINLY THAT'S A AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WE WOULD AGREE --
THE PAT WHICH I ALSO UNDERSTAND
IS A PROPOSAL FROM.
AS HERE YOU ASKED ME IS THAT
WHAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL BUT THEY DIDN'T DO AND
THE OF WHICH IT IS ACTUALLY
REMOVED THE CUT OF THE LANGUAGE
IN THE CODE IN THE LOCK CODE.
WHICH OF COURSE IS WHAT'S BEING
REQUESTED AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE CONSIDERED YELL
CONSIDERING AND I THINK IT.
AND I'VE POINTED OUT ACTUALLY IN
OUR DISCUSSION WHEN THAT
PROPOSAL SUGGESTED ICE OR LOOKED
AT FINANCE AND SAID WELL WE
SHOULD PUT IN CODE WHAT WE'RE
OUR INTENTIONS ARE EIGHT SO --
AND SO AS YOU CAN PROBABLY TELL
BY ASKING THAT I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
BUDGETING THE MONEY. TO BE SURE
THERE IS A 7% CUT SO THAT'S
WHAT'S WILL BE CLEAR FOR TO
CLARIFY THAT THERE ISN'T A
PROPOSAL FOR A 7% CUT FOR HSS
FOR EITHER THIS YEAR OR EVEN
NEXT YEAR NOW I CAN'T SAY WHAT
HAPPENS IN RECESSION TWENTY
YEARS TO NAIL.
THAT WHATEVER THAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN BUT THERE'S NO IMMEDIATE
PROPOSAL OR INTENTION TO TO CUT
HI TO ASSESS BY 7% THIS YEAR.
YOU KNOW AND IT'S UP TO KILEY
OBVIOUSLY EACH YEAR WE DO WANT
BUDGET YEAR BUT THAT BUT THAT
PROPOSALS FOR AN ON GOING
FUNDING SO THAT THERE'S NO 7%
CUT AND I JUST WANNA BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
YEAH.
I REALLY GOING TO RECEIVE SOME
KINDA ALL.
RIGHT BEING STATING THAT WELL
THAT THAT ACTUALLY THAT WOULD BE
IN THE BUDGET WHEN WE PASS IT IN --
JUNE SO AND WITH THE GOVERNOR
SIDES BEFORE JULY THAT WOULD BE
THE BEST FIRM WAY OF SENDING
THAT MAKE MAKING THAT STATEMENT
VERY CLEAR.
YES SO THING IN WRITING.
ALL WHO WE HAD THESE 7%.
IT'S A PROPOSAL THAT THERE IS NO
CRAP.
HERE EXACTLY AND THEN YOUR UNION
IS AB APPROPRIATELY ADVOCATING
THAT WE ALSO BE SURE THAT ARE
LAYING ARE THAT THE LAW ALSO
REFLECTS THAT EXACTLY AS WELL AS
THE BUDGET SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE THAT THAT'S A
PROPOSAL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE YEAR TO YEAR.
SO THE DICE A SAID THE PROPOSALS
FOR ON GOING SO THERE'S NO IT'S
NOT LIKE TING TO ENSURE THERE
WILL NOT BE A 7% CUT.
I CANNOT PROMISE.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN OF FUTURE
LEGISLATURE FUTURE GOVERNOR IN
THE FUTURE RECESSION BUT THE
INTENTION RIGHT NOW IS TO BE
SURE WE HAVE ADEQUATE FUNDING SO
THERE WILL NOT BE A 7% CUT THIS
YEAR NEXT YEAR I'M GOING?
OKAY SO WE'LL HAVE THAT IN
WRITING WELL THAT WILL BE IN THE
BUDGET AND THAT WILL DEFINITELY
BE IN WRITING.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR SIGNS IT?
NO YOU'RE WELCOME I JUST I JUST
WANT TO BE SURE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME THING YOU KNOW
SOMEONE A KNOWLEDGE THAT YEAH WE
NEED TO FIX THE CODE PARDON THAT
WAS NOT IN THE ORIGINAL
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT THE FUND
MONEY IS THERE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME AND ALSO IT BY THE WAY
THE LEGISLATURE THAT DOES
COMPOSE THE BUDGET SO WE HAVE TO
BE SHOULD WE WILL BE SURE WE
WILL WORK ON IT TO BE SURE
THAT'S IN THERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU WELCOME [inaudible]
HELLO EVERYBODY.
HELLO EVERYBODY OKAY I SPEAK
FRENCH SO MY ACTION GOING TO BE
A LITTLE BIT FRENCH.
BITES -- MY
NAME IS DOUG GOT IT.
AND I'M MORE WAS MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT ELECTRONIC VISITING.
BECAUSE ALL AS A PARENT OF
SPECIAL NEUTRON.
IS KIND OF FLORA DIFFICULT I
KNOW THAT TWO DAYS FEDERAL LAW.
AT SIX I WE LOVED THE STATE TO
TRY TO I GUESS FOR US BECAUSE AS
A SINGLE MOTHER.
MY SON IS ONLY FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD BY THE STARLIGHT AND THE
FESTIVAL IS STRONGER THAN ME.
YEP IT USUALLY.
IS NOT AVAILABLE YOU HAVE ALL
THE D..
ANY UP WHAT IS IT.
THERE ARE SOME DAYS YOU CANNOT
EVEN SLEEP.
SO AS A MOTHER.
MY HEART IS MORE CONCERNED.
ABOUT.
MY SON'S.
FIFTY N. CONTROL EVERY AREA
WHERE IT NEEDS WHEN IS.
AS NAY OKAY.
IF I HAVE [inaudible]
TO CLICK [inaudible]
WITH ELECTRONIC.
HOW IS GOING TO WALK BECAUSE?
WHO DID NOT TELL US THAT THE
IMPLICATION OF ELECTRONIC
VISITING OR NOT WE DO WE DON'T
KNOW?
WHAT THE DETAILS ARE ALL WHY THE --
I WOULD YOU CALL THE NINETY TWO
ARE.%
WITH MY SON PROBLEM.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT BECAUSE
THERE ARE SOME THESE VERY VERY
HOT.
AND I WON'T HAVE A MIND TO GO TO
CLICK.
ON MY PHONE NO ELECT I WILL NOT
BE MINE BECAUSE I HAVE TO
PROTECT MY SON AFTER TAKE OFF IT.
WHEN HE'S STILL HYPER?
BLACK MICHAEL WALKER HE'LL.
SHE WENT DEAD AND SHE'S SO MY
SON.
WHEN IT WAS TOO DIFFICULT FOR
ALL OF US TO DO WE FOR THE BOY
SO WHEN YOU FINISH WE'VE THAT'S
YOUR TIRED WHEN I'M DONE THE JOB?
AND YOU WOULD COME. TO CLICK.
IT WOULD FOR THAT.
AND YOU WILL NOT BE PENALTY.
SO HOW DOES THE GOING TO WALK
WITH.
THANK YOU --
I THINK --
CERTAINLY PEOPLE CAN FOLLOW UP I
JUST AND AGAIN NUMBER ONE BE
SURE WE I WOULD JUST ALSO DANGER
I'D SAY THAT I'M SURE DID THE
AGENT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
KNOW THE AGENCY HAS TO WORK WITH
THIS IS THAT SOME OFTHIS MONEY
COMES FROM THE FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT SO WE ARE TRYING WE
WORKED TO TRY TO MINIMIZE --
BUT AGAIN I HAVE ASKED THAT --
IT'S REALLY UNDERSTAND I MEAN I
THIS FEATURE SHOULD TAKE A LOT
OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL --
CONCERNS AND AT THE END WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY YOU CAN WASHER
THANK YOU.
JUST JUST TO FOR CLARIFICATION I
KNOW THAT ORIGINALLY PEOPLE HAD
A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT ARE WE
GONNA HAVE TO CHECK IN AND CHECK
OUT EVERY DAY.
THAT IS NOT THE WAY THE SYSTEM
IS BEING DESIGNED YOU COULD YOU
CAN DO IT AT THE END OF THE PAY
PERIOD JUST LIKE YOU DO YOUR
TIME SHEET TODAY.
YOU CAN DO IT AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE THERE ISN'T GOING TO
BE A CHECK IN AND CHECK OUT --
TYPE REQUIREMENT FOR THE SYSTEM
WE'VE DESIGNED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOD BLESS YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT ABLE THIS
CONFIRM FOR YOLO COUNTY AND THEM --
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER VOLUNTEER.
IN ON BECAUSE A FOUR FOOT BY TWO
SAYS PROVIDED CONSUMERS.
THANK YOU FOR PERMANENTLY
RESTORATION 47%.
AND FUTURE CUTS AND THE US EVEY
VIA OF FOR A LAKE UP FLEXIBILITY
FOR CONSUMERS PROTECTION. FOR
PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER PAN.
BEEN A LONG DAY OF FIRST THING I
WANT TO DO IS EXPRESSED SUPPORT.
FOR THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS.
ARE IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT AND I
JUST SAYS.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT ON THE FIRST OF A NUMBER OF
REPRESENTATIVES OF ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE HERE. TO COMPLEMENT TO
AND TO ENCOURAGE.
THOUGHT THE INVESTMENT OF THE
STATE AND THE MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST TO FUND UP APPROPRIATE.
RESEARCH ON THE COSTS ON THE
INCIDENTS IN THE THEIR X. THE
DEGREE OF NEED.
OF FOR A LONG NEW LONG TERM CARE
BENEFIT FOR CALIFORNIA.
WELL I THINK I THINK WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT LONG TERM CARE.
COSTS HAVE GROWN TO EXCEED THE
ABILITY OF MOST FAMILIES
INCLUDING MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
TO PAY FOR AND WE'VE GOT TO
DEVELOP A NEW --
A REALLY NEW APPROACH AND WANT
ONE THAT IS SUSTAINABLE AND I
BUT I BELIEVE THAT MILLION
DOLLARS WILL ALLOW US TO
PURCHASE.
THE SERVICES OF A QUALIFIED.
OF ENTITY EIGHT OUTSIDE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO COME IN AND DO
WHAT'S CALLED AN ACTUARIAL STUDY.
TO LOOK AT WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR CERTAIN BENEFITS WHO WOULD
RECEIVE THEM --
AND WHAT KINDS OF BENEFITS.
I URGE YOU TO INCLUDE THAT IN
THE BUDGET AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHOKE ASIDE
FROM THE STATE INDEPENDENT
LIVING COUNCIL --
OUR AGENCY IS ONE OF THE QUE TO
MEMBERS AND WE SUPPORT THE HELL
TSS ACTUARIAL STUDY.
WITHIN SENATE BILL --
FIVE TWELVE THAT'S JUST IN A
VERY INITIAL START BUT AN
IMPORTANT START TO LOOK AT THE
HUGE PROBLEM.
OF LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS --
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE I. H.
YOURSELF PROPOSALS ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT ARE GOING TO BENEFIT
THE CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING PROPECIA.
OF EXCUSE ME AND DEPARTMENT
FINANCE SORRY YANG --
MY NAME IS KRISTEN HIM AND I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR ADULT DAY SERVICES KATZ IS
BEEN ADVOCATING AND PROVIDING
ADULT DAY SERVICES SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WE AS A
MEMBER OF THE CATO ORGANIZATION --
WE ARE ALSO --
IN SUPPORT OF THE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET AUGMENTATION
REQUEST --
FOR AN ACTUARIAL STUDY AND WE
ALSO AT CHAIRMAN PAN FOR
AUTHORING THAT BUILT THE
COMPANION PIECE THE COMPANION
BILL -- AT
THAT IS --
ALSO IN RELATION TO THIS STUDY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
IT'S IN HI MY NAME IS ROB
WEIDEMANN AARP VOLUNTEER FROM
WHAT SACRAMENTO.
AND WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE A
A RP.
BUDGET PRIORITY BUDGET REQUEST
FOR THE L. T. S. P.'S ABILITY
STUDY.
A A RP IS ALSO ARE PARTNERS WITH
OUR BILLY ALLIANCE FOR THE AGING
AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE
[inaudible]
SO.
SINCE WANT ONE WOMAN HERE FROM
AMONG THE THREE FROM MY NOTES
FOR A SECOND HERE.
OKAY A OUR PS THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NEAR MOST OF ALL I
MEMBERS DO NEED SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS.
FROM LONG TERM SERVICES.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL 1100% FOR THE EIGHT TO
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS IN THE CITY I MEAN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IT SHOWS THAT THE HIGH WE DID A
STUDY IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SHOWS THAT THE THE HIGH COST OF
OF PARK HERE.
IS BEYOND WHAT MOST FAMILIES CAN
AFFORD EVEN IF THEY ARE IN THE
UPPER MIDDLE CLASS SOMETIMES IF
THEY HAVE TO ONE OF THESE
CATASTROPHIC EXPENSES COME UP.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD IT.
AND SO WE WANT TO PROTECT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH HIS
PROGRAM BUT THE ONLY WAY TO STOP
THIS PROGRAM EFFECTIVELY WE HAVE
TO DO A THOROUGH STUDY.
A MASS WHAT THIS PROGRAM IS
ABOUT THE L. T. SS FEASIBILITY
STUDY PROGRAM WE HAVE TO KNOW
HOW WOULD ONE IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM HOW MUCH IS GOING TO
COST.
WHO IS GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE?
HOW MUCH?
WE'RE GOING TO PAY FOR THEM AND
ALSO HOW LONG WILL THEY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
SO WITH A A RP IS SUPPORTING
THIS PROGRAM FOR THE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO THE FEASIBILITY
STUDY FOR THE L. TSS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY KINDLY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME --
DAVID FEINBERG ARE A R. P.
VOLUNTEER.
ALL I AM HERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST IN
THE BUDGET ITEM IN JUST A SHORT
PERSONAL FACE ON THE ISSUE I
HAVE A NINETY SEVEN YEAR OLD
MOTHER WHO LIVES IN A FACILITY
CARING.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL
NEEDS THE COST OF THAT CARE.
CLOSER TO TWELVE AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH WHILE
HOSPICE AND HER INCOME WILL PAY
SEVEN THOUSAND OF THAT.
THROUGH MANY FIVE THOUSAND HAVE
TO COME FROM SOME PLACE SHE'S
ALREADY USED UP ALL OF HER OWN.
BENEFITS IT COMES OUT OF HER
FAMILY TO PAY FOR THAT CARE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY WHAT THAT DOES
IS REDUCE OUR ABILITY TO CARE
FOR OUR OWN RETIREMENT SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON LISA
COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
WE STAND IN SUPPORT --
AS PRIDE MEMBERS OF CARE.
ALL DAY I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HOW YOU DON'T NEED TO REINVENT
THE WHEEL.
I TAKE THE EXCEPTION KEITA IS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE DATA
THAT WE NEED TO BE.
INNOVATIVE IN CREATING LONG TERM
SERVICE PORTS FOR PEOPLE AND I'M
ALSO THE ASSOCIATION IS IN
SUPPORT AS I TO SASS AND ALL
THAT IT DOES THANK YOU FOR TO
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT WELCOME.
CAROL SUE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING WERE ALSO
PART OF THE CATER GROUP AND ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
FOR THE ACTUARIES STUDY THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR KIMBERLY
ELEVATING OUT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION.
OUR MEMBERS CARE WHAT FOR WHAT
WE BELIEVE ARE THE MOST VALUABLE
RESOURCES ARE SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
AND WE'RE PART OF THE CATA
COALITION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF THE BUDGET REQUEST FOR
MILLION DOLLARS ACTUARY STUDY TO
SUPPORT THE EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AND HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE STRUGGLING EVERYDAY. TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES AND GIVE THEM DIGNITY WHICH
THEY DESERVE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN OF FEAR
PATIENTS TODAY JORDAN LINSEY
WITH THE ARCHIPELAGO ANY
REPRESENT INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
IF YOU VERY QUICK COMMENTS --
ONE AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY FROM
RECIPIENTS AND THERE IS A CRISIS
OF PEOPLE NOT BEING ABLE TO
RECEIVE.
THE SUPPORT THE SERVICES THEY
NEED AND THAT COMES DOWN TO WHAT
IS HAPPENING NOW THE INABILITY
TO FIND PROVIDERS BECAUSE THEY
ARE GOING TO BE EMPLOYED
SOMEWHERE ELSE RIGHT NOW --
MANY THOSE AYE HSS PROVIDERS ARE
ALSO DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS IN THE D. SYSTEM
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
CALIFORNIA WAGES HAVE INCREASED
ABOUT THREE AND A HALF PERCENT
PER YEAR OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
IT'S INCREASED 6% PER YEAR.
AND AS THERE ARE COMMON SO OFTEN
WHEN BIG CORPORATIONS RECEIVE
BIG PROFITS THAT THAT MONEY
SHOULD BE GOING BACK TO WORKERS
CERTAINLY LAST COUPLE YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS A HAS HAD A HAD A
WINDFALL.
AND FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS I JUST
SAYS THAT THE STATE SUPPORTS.
THAT SHOULD BE GOING BACK TO THE
WORKERS SO THAT THERE IS NOT A
CRISIS OF BEING ABLE TO PUT TO
FIND PROVIDERS.
A SECOND COMMENT JUST IN GENERAL
ABOUT THE RECENT --
MOVES FOR ONE TIME INVESTMENT
FOR ASIAN AND PERMANENT
INVESTMENTS --
UNDERSTAND THAT ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS ARE DEFINITELY MUCH
BETTER THAN NO INVESTMENTS AT
ALL.
HOWEVER IT'S SIMPLY SHIFTING
RISK ON TO COMMUNITIES AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE STATE.
INDIVIDUALS WERE TRYING TO PLAN
BEYOND ONE IN TWO YEARS AND
THIRD QUICKLY SUPPORT THE
REQUESTS FOR THE ACTUARIAL STUDY
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON TENER
CONTROLLERS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS.
WE PROVIDE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
TO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
WE ARE MEMBER OF KATO.
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE ACTUAL STUDY BUDGET REQUESTS
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO -- MY
NAME IS THERESA STRECKER FROM
DENMARK CARE ME THIS IS KEVIN.
THANK YOU HEY.
HELLO -- A
OPPOSE THE EBV.
DUE TO HIS CONDITIONS IT'S
MARTIN NEC THING WITH HIS
SEIZURES AND HIS DEVELOPMENT HE
NOT BEING VERY VOCAL --
GENNEM BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S SUPPORT ON OUR
BEHALF AND OUR CLIENTS BEHALF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME WELCOME HI MY NAME IS
BILL THIS FROM DEL MAR COUNTY I
AM WITH THAT HERE YOU TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND ALSO A HOME CARE
WORKER MYSELF TAKING CARE OF MY
SPECIAL NEEDS BROTHER --
I LIKE TO SAY WE ARE VERY HAPPY
AS SOMEONE WHO SUFFERED FROM
THAT SAM'S AND GOT TO HEAR THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE GETTING THAT BACK.
DOWNS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ED VETO RODRIGUEZ AND I TOO
AM FROM DOWN OUR COUNTY WE DO
HAVE A NEGOTIATION.
OF A CONTRACT --
AND I'M HERE BECAUSE OF TWO
REASONS I TAKE CARE OF ONE AT
THE HOME AND I ALSO HAVE TO GO
OUT WORD.
AND I DID --
MEET MY SIXTY SIX YEAR TO GO FOR
MY FULL BENEFITS.
IS -- GOT A
SURE OF COST OF THREE THOUSAND
FIVE DOLLARS.
AND I ONLY BRING HOME WITHIN
MYSELF ONLY FOURTEEN HUNDRED SO
WHAT I AM IN NEED OF IT IS TO
SUPPORT THE TRAILER BILL IN ITS
LANGUAGE.
THEN I AM NOT IN FAVOR OF THE E.
V. V. AND THE REASON WHY IS
BECAUSE MY CLIENTS THAT I
PRESENTLY HAVE I HAVE TO HAVE.
THREE IN ORDER TO SURVIVE I ALSO
OWN MY HOME AND MY HOME BIRD SO
I'M ALSO.
HOMELESS SO I'M GOING TO YOUR
ONES THAT'S WORKING THAT'S GOT
SOCIAL SECURITY THAT COULD
AFFORD A PLACE BUT I ALSO HAVE
THE INSURANCE IT'S TERRIBLE WAY.
AND THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO FIND
ME A HOME THAT I CAN LIVE IN.
SO THEREFORE --
BECAUSE OF ECONOMICS AND BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO MAKE A BUCK LIKE
ANYTHING ELSE AND OF COURSE I
PAID INTO IT FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS.
OF MY HOME THEY'RE NOT PROVIDING
ME WHAT I NEED WITHIN THE MARKET
VALUE OF MY HOME RENTAL.
OKAY THAT I OWN.
SO.
I AM ALSO HERE.
THERE'S NO WAY I'M GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AND MY CLIENTS
AREN'T.
HOW DO I SAY COMPETENT ENOUGH TO
USE THE TELEPHONE TO SAY YES OR
NO OR COMPANY ENOUGH TO EVEN
HAVE A COMPUTER TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HIGHER PATRICK CROSS FROM FROM --
HUMBOLDT COUNTY --
I DO NOT FAVOR FOR THE V. DEL I
MEAN THE EEVEE VILLE I MEAN THE
EEVEE V..
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR TRYING TO CHANGE THE TRAIL --
OF THE TO THAT THE TRAIN --
BILLS TO THE THAT DID THAT THE
LANGUAGE TO CHANGE THE SAYS
STATUE AND THE CODE --
FOR THE SOMERSET ON GOING SO
THAT'S IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
VICKI FERGUSON.
HUMBOLDT COUNTY --
I'M ON OR BARGAINING TEAM.
AND WE'RE GOING ON LIKE ALMOST
THREE YEARS OF NOT HAVING A
CONTRACT YET OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CAN GIVE THEMSELVES
A RAISE.
BUT THEY CAN'T GIVE US A RAISE.
THEY DON'T THINK THAT OUR WORK
IS.
YOU KNOW WE CAN WE CAN AFFORD
MINIMUM WAGE.
MY MOM PASSED AWAY AND I WASN'T
ABLE I COULDN'T.
STAY DOWN IN ORANGE COUNTY
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A LIVABLE
WAGE.
IN ORDER TO GO ANYWHERE.
SO BUT I DO SUPPORT THE NEW
LANGUAGE.
AND I SUPPORT THE EEVEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHAT WAS AFTERNOON OR EVENING BY
NOW BUT I WANT TO SAY HELLO TO
EVERYONE FIRST OF ALL MY NAME IS
MARYLAND SMITH?
I'M ORGANIZER FOR THE NC I YOU
AS WELL AS A CALL HERE HOME CARE
PROVIDER SORRY.
ME PERSONALLY SPEAKING WE COULD
DO MORE WORK MORE WITH OUR MONEY
THEN PRINTED UP ON EASY V. BUCKS
WHICH IS ELECTRONIC VERIFICATION
BOX.
AND THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE
WE'RE MAKING STILL UNDER MINIMUM
WAGES HOME CARE PROVIDERS THAT
MONEY COULD GO TO PAIN THAT'S A
SALARY.
THAT MONEY CAN GO TO SOMETHING
MORE GREATER THAN WHAT I
CONSIDER DISCRIMINATION.
AND MICROMANAGEMENT.
NOBODY WANTS ON ANY JOB TO BE
MICROMANAGE NOBODY ON ANY DOT
WANTS TO FEEL THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BECAUSE
WE'RE HOME CARE PROVIDERS.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
TAKING OUR LANGUAGE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT DOMESTIC WORKERS WE
ARE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE
SERVICES IS VERY WELL NEEDED.
THINK ABOUT IT.
I'M SURE MOST EVERYBODY UP HERE
ON OUR PANEL HELP SENIOR
CITIZENS IN THEIR HOMES FAMILY
CARE FAMILY MOTHERS FATHERS
AUNTS UNCLES OR GRANDPARENTS
EXCEPT.
THE POINT OF IT IS WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PUT MORE MONEY
INTO THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
DOING THE WORK.
THE WORK IS NOT ESY IT'S HARD
TAKING CARE OF SOMEONE ELSE WHEN
YOU'VE TAKEN OUT OF ALL YOUR
LIFE TO GIVE TO OTHERS WHAT WE
YOU GUYS HAVE JUST A NIGHT AT
THE PENSION.
I'VE BEEN DOING HOME CARE WORKS
IS.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WE DON'T
HAVE A PENSION.
WHO IS THE LEFT TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR PEOPLE ARE FAMILIES?
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE
CAN DO MORE WITH THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE USING FOR THE EVE EVE V..
THAT'S GOING TO HELP SUSTAIN US
PEOPLE THOSE DOING THE WORK ON
AND SUSTAINABLE LIVING WAGE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW 1-250- IS NOT
A SUSTAINABLE LIVING WAGE.
PERIOD.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
LATE WAVE RAISE THEIR WAGE TO
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR WE'RE
STILL UNDER THAT SO WITH THE
HELP OF GAVIN NEWSOM.
GOD BLESS HIS SOUL THAT WE CAN
MOVE BEYOND THIS BECAUSE IT'S
STILL WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS CALL
MODERN DAY SLAVERY WE'RE STILL
KEEPING PEOPLE IN BOXES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS TO MURATSUCHI
CANELA.
I AM IN AYE HSS PROVIDER FOR MY
SON BACARDI BELL IN THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA --
I'M ALSO AN EXECUTIVE BOARD
MEMBER WITH SEIU LOCAL --
TWENTY FIFTEEN I WENT I WENT --
TO I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT I
MEAN AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
INCLUDING THE TRAILER BILL THAT
WILL --
PERMANENTLY YOU STORE THE 7% CUT --
I WENT YOU COULD YOU TO KNOW
THAT I AM TO IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION --
IT WORRIES ME BECAUSE MY SON IS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD AND HE HAS
AUTISM SEVERE AUTISM SO HE WAS
BORN IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
THERE ARE A GREAT NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT WERE BORN IN OUR
STATE IN THAT YEAR WHO ARE NOW
ADULTS.
WHO ARE UTILIZING SSI AND HOT
AND AND IN NEED OF AYE CHICEST
SERVICES --
I MY SON REQUIRES PROTECTIVE
SUPERVISION BECAUSE HE'S UNABLE
INTELLECTUALLY TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
SAFELY OR BE IN THE HOME SAFELY
I DO NOT WANT ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION.
TO PREVENT ANY OF OUR DISABLED
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE FROM THE
THEIR ABILITY TO MOVE THROUGHTHE COMMUNITY SAFELY IF THEY
REQUIRE PROTECTIVE SUPERVISION --
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
BARGAINING COMMITTEE FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND IT --
AND HOME CARE WORKERS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY WERE STUCK AT AT TWELVE
FIFTY AN HOUR FOR FOUR YEARS AND
IT TOOK US A YEAR.
OVER I THINK THIRTEEN TO
FOURTEEN MONTHS AND WE JUST ARE
REYES WAS JUST --
IMPLEMENTED THIS MONTH --
SO I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI I'M SORRY THAT ME COMBOS THE
B. WING A CONDO IS SAN FRANCISCO.
MY NAME IS DONE MAY COMPASS AND
I AM FROM SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY.
EIGHT OKAY GET ALL THIS SEAT IS
THE IS MORE IMPORTANT THEY THEN
THAT IS COOL MORE.
BUT ALL THOSE GOING TO BE LOS
KOMODO HOW LOTUS EQUAL VIENNA.
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME IS.
OKAY GEAR THIS SEAT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THEY BUT I TOLD US
COMO INDIVIDUALS WILL MADRE
HUDDLED REYES COMMERCIALS HERE
THE COMICAL VIETNAM.
IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR EVERYBODY
AS INDIVIDUALS AS A SOCIETY AND
AS A GOVERNMENT.
THE EMMY COMPANION I COULD PLAY
THAT THAT'LL SEE LOCATED IS
PRETTY DOPE BUT I SEAT IN IS
THAT THAT.
AM I ASKED MY FELLOW UNION
MEMBER -- TO
INTERPRET WHAT I WANNA SAY THAT.
OKAY BUT SHE ASKED ME TO JUST GO
AHEAD AND READ --
I SUPPORT THE SEVEN PERSON SENT
PERMANENT RESTORATION BECAUSE WE
CAN NO LONGER SPEND TIME AND
INSTABILITY.
PERMANENT RESTORATION EQUATES TO
ECONOMIC AND EMOTIONAL STABILITY
FOR PROVIDERS AND THOSE LIKE
THEY CARE.
FOR PSYCHOLOGICALLY PERMANENT
RESTER UNTIL AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH FOR ALL WHO BENEFIT FROM
AYE HSS.
THIS RESULTS IN PERSONAL GROWTH
AND BETTER QUALITY CARE AS WELL.
THIS IS CONVENIENT FOR SOCIETY
AND CONVENIENT FOR GOVERNMENT SO
PERMANENT RESTORATION EQUAL
STABILITY STABILITY EQUALS
BETTER MENTAL HEALTH BETTER
MENTAL HEALTH EQUALS HEALTHY AND
STABLE BENEFICIARIES AND
PROVIDERS.
AND YOU AS OUR GOVERNMENT ONE
HEALTHIER WORKERS RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ISN'T THERE A LION AND THEN DEAL.
THANK YOU VERYMUCH AND I HOPE
YOU UNDERSTAND OKAY.
GARCIA SCRATCHES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR PANDA BROUGHT DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA ECHO WHAT
OTHER SAID ABOUT CODIFYING THE
E. V. V. PROTECTIONS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE 7% IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU ALSO FAVOR A
CODIFICATION AND JUST TO CLARIFY.
CODIFYING THE RESTORATION OF
THAT CARD IS NOT THE SAME AS
CODIFYING THE EEVEE V.
PROTECTIONS.
THE CARD EXIST IN STATUTE IT IS
IN CURRENT LAW AND IF NOTHING
HAPPENS IT STAYS THERE AND
THAT'S WHY ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE SO SCARED AND THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE GONE TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
REASSURE THEM.
IT WILL NOT BENECESSARY TO
REASSURE THEM ABOUT THAT IF YOU
SIMPLY REPEAL THE STATUTE.
I AT THE LEVY THAT FIVE POINTED
OUT SO YES.
BUT I SENATOR MIKE YOU HAD AND
THERE WERE NO LORD.
MY NAME'S KATRINA VEHICLE I LIVE
IN THE HIGH CALIFORNIA I'M WITH
AT U. D. W.. THIRTY NINE THIRTY
OUT OF RESPECT JOHNNY.
I TAKE FOR MY BROTHER RIGHT M.
HIS NAME LOUDEST RACONTE RANDY.
THERE THERE'S IT'S ALMOST SEVEN
LIVES I'VE BEEN CARE GET RESERVE
SOME SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD.
I'M NOT EMBARRASSED MY AGE I
JUST TURNED.
FIFTY SEVEN I DON'T LOOK AT AND
I DID.
WHERE THEY ARE THE D. V. D. NEAR
THE?
MY BROTHER CAN'T HE DON'T KNOW
DIFFERENCE FOR ME RIGHT OR WRONG.
SO HE CAN'T JUST PUSH A BUTTON
MIGHT YES OR NO WHATEVER CRITICS
DON'T UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
AND WE CANNOT.
PLEASE DON'T DON'T [inaudible]
PLEASE DON'T [inaudible]
AB [inaudible]
SACRAMENTO.
IF WE IF WE HAVE TO START DOING
[inaudible]
IN OUT.
HE WOULD GET.
AGITATED.
AND WHEN HE GETS AGITATED HE
GETS.
OUT OF CONTROL.
WHEN HE WAS YOUNGER HE HAD A BAD
SEIZURE?
AND HE HIT HIS HEAD.
ON SCENE BACK PLATTER MEANS
THEY'LL.
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY CAN'T TALK
AND ALSO DAMAGED BRAIN.
WHEN OUR OWN PASSED AWAY?
ALL THOSE KIDS PROMISED.
PROMISED HER.
FAVORITE NUMBER ONE ALL.
I'M THE YOUNGEST OF NINE I THINK
I'M THE ONLY.
ONE IT'S BEEN ABLE --
TO TO TAKE CARE I GET HIM TO
CALL THE DOCTOR.
I MAKE SURE HE'S ON THE C. PAP.
MAKE SURE TAKES ALL THE
MEDICINES.
THE DAYS START HE'LL FIGHT ME
INTO TO TAKE ON I WITH COURAGE
HIM TAKEN PRISONERS BETTER FOR
HIM.
THE NEXT DAY HE'S OKAY. TWENTY
MINUTES LATER.
TICKETS ARE CONTROL SO IT'S NOT
EASY TAKING CARE SOMEBODY.
THAT HAS A MENTAL.
ARE YOU FISCAL [inaudible]
IT'S IF YOU COULD DO IT IN DO
WHAT WE DO. FOR TWENTY FOUR
HOURS.
IT WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO IT
[inaudible]
THE I'M.
ALWAYS SAY I CAN'T TAKE IT NO
MORE MOTHER.
MARY JANE B. HE KNOWS AND HE
HE'LL CALM DOWN.
AND I CAN TELL WHEN HE'S UPSET
ON A LOT OF THINGS BECAUSE HE
DON'T CRY LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
DOES HIS EYES GET RE READ.
AND IN LIGHT COURT COURSE YOU
GUYS BASS PRO.
MARY KAY AND HE'S FIFTIES WHEN
I'M SORRY I'M.
JUST.
HE SIXTY ONE SB SIX JUNE MAY.
WHATEVER HE WANTS I TRIED TO GET.
IT WILL REALLY HAVE.
IT'S NOT SAFE FOR HIM FOR A BIKE.
THEIR FAME BECAUSE TWENTY FIVE
ZONE.
THE SPEAKER LIKE IRATE
[inaudible]
BACK [inaudible]
AND POR FAVOR LAMB OR DON'T CARE
EITHER SO [inaudible]
AREA [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE A SISTER COMING DOWN AND
THAT NOT NEXT WEEKEND FOR A
BIRTHDAY. TWENTY A SURPRISE
PARTY FOR HER.
BECAUSE SHE'S IN FEDERAL WAY
WASHINGTON.
AND SHE'S PROGRESS HERE NO THE
TERRORIST AT ALL.
SO THIS HER DAUGHTER.
MAKE SURE TO BE A SURPRISE.
I THINK THAT PLEASE DON'T.
BECAUSE LIKE ACIDITY CONFUSED WE
CONFUSE HIM.
MY WORD IT CONFUSES ME.
NEAR FAN ALL MADE I'M COMPUTER
SMART.
IT WAS MY KNEES.
OKAY.
HELP IN ALL RIGHT NOW THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SHARING [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
BEFORE MOVEON AND I KNOW YOU
SAID IT BEFORE --
I I JUST WANNA BE SURE WE'RE
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE WE DO WHAT.
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL IS TO CODIFY
AND DIED --
THE FIGHT I ALSO HEAR THERE'S
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT YOU V. V.
THAT ARE NOT AT LEAST REFLECTED
UP WHAT THE EEVEE IS NOW.
AND CERTAINLY IF PEOPLE DON'T
WANT ANY VV I UNDERSTAND THAT'S
ALSO POSITION TO TAKE --
BUT I'M HEARING SOME.
ASPECTS OF TV THAT'S NOT WHAT'S.
DVD CURRENTLY IS IN FACT WHAT
THE PROPOSAL IS TO CODIFY THE
KIND OF PRINCIPLES AND CHANGES.
THAT THE THE PART SOCIAL
SERVICES ACT DOING SO --
IF I MAY ASK THE PART JUST BEGAN.
TWO WEEKS TO HELP OF BE SURE
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE ABOUT
WHAT IS.
EVEY EXPECTING PEOPLE TO DO --
A HEARING THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE HAVING SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT CHECKING IN
CHECKING OUT OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS THAT HAVE TO DO. FOR THEM
IN ORDER TO BE SURE THAT THEY
GET THEIR BENEFITS.
SO THE IN THE DESIGNED THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE.
FOR THE V. V. THERE IS NO CHECK
IN OR CHECK OUT REQUIREMENTS
THIS THE FEDERAL STATUTE
REQUIRES US TO COLLECT
INFORMATION OF START TIME IN AND
TIME.
SO WHEN THE TIME SHEET IS
COMPLETED.
YOU'LL FILL OUT YOUR START TIME
IN AND TIME YOU'RE NOT CHECKING
IN AND CHECKING OUT IN REAL TIME.
SO AT THE END OF THE PAY PERIOD
OR AT WHATEVER.
INTERVALS YOU CHOOSE TO FILL OUT --
THE INFORMATION OR PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION IS YOU'RE GETTING
GIVE THOSE ADDITIONAL PIECES OF
INFORMATION BUT YOU'RE NOT
STOPPING OR STARTING AS YOU AS
YOU ACTUALLY DO THE CHECK IN OR
CHECK OUT --
FROM THE WORK THAT'S NOT THE
CASE I'VE ALSO HEARD A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS AROUND --
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE ABLE --
TO DO THAT TYPE OF ACTIVITY
SIMILAR TO I WOULD IMAGINE TODAY
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO SIGN TIME
SHEETS PERHAPS --
IF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
RECIPIENTS ARE IN THOSE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS THEN IT JUST LIKE
TODAY.
A CONSERVATIVE OR A GUARDIAN
APPARENT.
AN AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVE CAN
DO THAT ACTIVITY ON THEIR BEHALF
ELECTRONICALLY THE SAME AS THEY
WOULD IN PAPER TODAY.
THE CLEAR FIVE BECAUSE I THINK
MANY OF THEM ARE FAMILY CARE
GIVERS WHAT HAPPENS IS THEIR
GUARDIAN IS ALSO IN THE IHS AS
CARE GIVERS CAN THEY SIGN OFF ON
THAT OR NOT I MEAN.
SO IF THEY HAVE LEGAL
AUTHORITIES OF THEIR THE
CONSERVATOR THE PARENT OF A
MINOR.
THEN THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DO THAT ON THEIR BEHALF EVEN IF
THEY ARE THE PROVIDER ALSO JUST
LIKE THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT WITH THE TIME SHE TODAY.
OKAY SO I JUST WANNA BE SURE
WERE YOU CAN ADD A CERTAINLY
UNDERSTANDS SOMEONE SAYS BOOK I
STILL DON'T LIKE IT I OPPOSE --
BUT I JUST WANNA BE SURE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME.
BUT TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE
TALKING WHAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING
AND AND THE PROPOSAL IS ACTUALLY
TO CODIFY.
THESE PRINCIPLES SO THAT WE
DON'T GO TO X. I KNOW THERE WAS
A PREVIOUS PROPOSAL THE I THINK
IT WAS A YEAR A YEAR AGO OR SO
THAT BORDER WAS IN THE CHECK IN
CHECK OUT WHICH WE REJECTED.
AND SO THAT'S NOT THE DIRECTION
WE'RE GOING IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I JUST WANNA BE
SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
ABOUT WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON SO.
OKAY I THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT GOOD AFTERNOON --
SENATOR PAN SUSAN TO MORRIS
REPRESENTING THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS TODAY
AND LISTENING TO A HOST OF
ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO THE
TWO POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
WHO ARE AFFECTED BY ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE QUEDA ONE MILLION
DOLLAR ACTUARIAL STUDY --
BUDGET ITEM IN THE THESE IS
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE THAN THE MEDIAN
HOME PRICE IN SACRAMENTO.
WE URGE YOU IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS WEEK
THIS MODEST REQUEST TO ADD TO
EXPLORE AFFORDABILITY OPTIONS.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE AT GREAT RISK
OF SPENDING DOWN TO MEDI CAL --
OR WHO HAVE NO RESOURCES
OTHERWISE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
TRANSPONDERS AN AGING HER IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF THE ARE YOU
JUST AS PROPOSALS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO MAKE --
SEIU -- I AM
HOME CARE WORKER ALSO I HAVE A
ISSUE WITH THE EVP --
IS THIS IT SEEMS LIKE IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO WRITE --
WHEN YOU HAVE BEEN A CLIENT THAT
NEEDS YOUR SPECIAL ATTENTION I
UNDERSTAND YOU SAID OTHER PEOPLE
CONFINEMENT BUT ON TOP OF THAT
WE HAVE ANOTHER CLIENT WHEN IT
DOESN'T LIKE TO USE?
ELECTRONICALLY.
WELL THEN WHAT YOU DO.
YOU YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING RIGHT
IT WAS SO DO YOU GET PENALIZED.
WHAT HAPPENS I'M ON TOP OF THAT --
WITH THE I SUPPORT THE I DO
SUPPORT.
THE 7%.
BUT I WANT TO SEE A PERMANENT
STATUS BEFORE I SAY AT COULD
SUPPORT IT FULLY.
AS BEST SET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI KATIE COVENTRY
HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
YEARS AGO --
I GAVE UP A FULL TIME TEACHING
JOB TWO FRIENDS OF MINE.
WERE BECAME DISABLED ONE WAS A
TEACHER ONE WAS A DISABLED
VETERANS --
THEY WERE UNABLE TO FIND ANYBODY
THROUGH THE REGISTRY THEY ARE --
ON THE VERGE OF BEING PUTTING
NURSING PUTTING. ONE IN A LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY I GAVE UP MY
FULL TIME JOB SO I COULD ALLOW
THOSE PEOPLE TO STAY IN THEIR
HOMES STAY IN THE COMMUNITY.
BY STATE BY BEING ABLE TO STAY
IN THEIR HOMES THEY'RE ABLE TO
VOLUNTEER AND GIVE BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY. FIVE ALSO BECAUSE
YEARS AGO OF THE 7% CUT I HAD TO
TAKE ON ANOTHER JOB.
AND I CONTINUE JUST TO KEEP THAT
JOB BECAUSE FROM YEAR TO YEAR WE
DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THAT
7% WAS GONNA.
HAPPEN SO I URGE YOU. TO TO MAKE
THE RIGHT CHANGES AND CONTINUE
THIS AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO TAKE
CARE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
WERE ALL EITHER GOING TO BE
GIVING CARE.
GETTING CARE OR NEED THE CARE SO
IF ALL OF US.
WE NEED TO DO THE RIGHT THING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S AYE HSS AMMO WE
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
I'M ON A STRAIGHTER AND I MET IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICE PROVIDER
FOR NON FAMILY MEMBERS AND I
ALSO -- THEM
AND MEMBER OF THE ACLU LOCAL --
TWENTY FIFTEEN I WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED THAT
THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT WHEN YOU
ASKED SENATOR THE WHAT IS THE
COST OF NOT DOING ANYTHING WHAT
IS THAT COST.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD KNOW THAT
I THINK THAT THAT WOULD SHOCK US
ALL.
ON THE COST OF NOT RESTORING THE
7% PERMANENTLY IT IS A SMALL
FRACTION OF ALL OF THE OTHER
CUTS THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING AND
TO GETTING A MASTER PLAN.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE A MASTER
PLAN EVERY DAY DIETITIAN A
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDER I DO
ACCOUNTING I DO.
BOOK WORK CLEANING I DO THE
BATTLE AND BLADDER TREATMENTS
ALL THOSE THINGS WE DO.
AND IT IS IT IS VERY GRATIFYING
JOB TO DO FOR THOSE THAT CAN'T
DO FOR THEMSELVES BUT WE NEED
YOUR HELP.
AND WE NEED THE THE RESTORATION
OF THAT WE DON'T NEED TO BE
MONITORED FULLY.
THAT I UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO
REPLACE THE WHITE HOUSE IN ORDER
TO GET THAT PART FIXED BUT IN
THE MEANTIME WE'LL GO WITH WHAT
YOU'VE GOT PROPOSED.
SO THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT --
THERE ARE MANY OF US OUT THERE
THAT DO THIS JOB NOT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T GET A JOB ELSEWHERE I WORK
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS WE CAN.
BECAUSE WE FEEL THIS IS A NEAT
AND WE FEEL COMPELLED TO DO THAT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY I COULD
DO THAT AND MAKE A LIVING WAGE
CURRENTLY I CAN'T I'D LIKE TO
SAY I DO THAT AND I SEE BENEFITS
CURRENTLY I DON'T.
SO PLEASE MAKE ALL THOSE CHANGES
THAT YOU CAN AND WITH THE COST
OF WHAT DOING NOTHING WOULD DO
TO US AS A STATE AS A COMMUNITY
AS PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
PETER HAD SO WHAT CARAPACE --
CALPERS REPRESENTS THE TWELVE
PROGRAMS OF ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY --
OUR MEMBERS PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE CARE AND SERVICES
TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD BE A NURSING
HOMES --
HERE STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THE
PERMIT RESTORATION OF THE HSS
HOURS AND ALSO STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE ACTUARIAL STUDY
FUNDING OF VERY MODEST AND
REASONABLE FIRST UP AND REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU.
LOCAL MARTY EMOTO CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY YOU COMING ACTION
NETWORK --
CITY CAN FAMILY MEMBER FIRST
WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF ALSO
THE AGENCY --
STAFF AT THE TABLE FOR LISTENING
TO US BECAUSE IT'S NOT ALWAYS
EASY.
AND SENATOR PAM PRE SHEET YOU
TAKING THE TIME TO HAVE THE V. --
AND ALSO ABOUT THE 7% REDUCTION
ON THE V. V. ISSUES JUST HARD
FOR PEOPLE.
TO TRUST GOVERNMENT BECAUSE ALL
ALL THE YEARS OF REDUCTION SO
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT --
ALSO PREACH --
STRONGLY SUPPORT ALL THE
INVESTMENT PROPOSES PICK CREEK
THE CATER PROPOSAL EVEY V. 7%
REDUCTION A 7% ALMOST A
REDUCTION.
AND ALSO THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROPOSAL LASTLY WANT
TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT FOR
WORKING WITH ALL OF US STILL
DOES REALLY CONTROVERSY OF THE
ISSUE OF VVV BUT YOU I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN REALLY
SENSITIVE.
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS OF FOR THE
PAST YEAR OR TWO YEARS WHENEVER
SPENT AND THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI I'M DAPHNE DONE STEIN AND I
AM ON A MOTHER OF TWO SPECIAL
NEED BOYS.
ON SENATOR BEN.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HEARING OUR VOICES.
I UNDERSTAND ABOUT THEM YOUR
VIEW ABOUT DENNIS I'M NOT
CUTTING OUT WHERE --
7% -- I IT'S
JUST HOURS.
I FULLY --
GOT TO YOU.
AND I DO I TELLING US THAT.
YOU THERE'S NO CUT YES I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND HOPEFULLY I
WILL NOT BE COMING BECAUSE LAST
YEAR I WAS HERE BEGGING FORTIES --
I ACCEPT 7% BERMAN ENTERS
SERRATION BY IT SAYS SAYS I AM I
WANTED PERMANENT AND I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA DO WITH THAT.
I AND I I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA DO
THAT DOCTOR BàN.
AND THE SECOND THE EASY THE
HAWAII WE ARE WORRIED SPECIALLY
ME I HAD TO SPECIAL NEEDS VOICE
THERE THEY HAVE --
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY INTELLECT
TOLD THE LADY AND AUTISM.
WHEN YOU GUYS ARE SAYING THAT --
WE HAD TO CHECK IN AND OUT I
JUST COULD NOT.
UNDERSTAND HOW I WILL DO IT WHEN
I HAVE.
TO SEE --
BUT I'M HOPING THAT YOU YOU WILL
BE WORKING WITH US AND SEE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO US A PARENT I'M A
PARENT PARENT PROVIDER.
AND YOU KNOW --
IT'S IT'S REALLY HARD I EVEN
LOST MY I HAVE TO I IT SAYS IS
PROVIDER AND I LOST IT WE HAD.
A RESPITE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO MY NAME'S LUCIA
LITTLE I WORK FOR THEM.
I HSS AND I'M MEMBER OF SEIU
LOCAL.
TWENTY FIFTEEN I TAKE CARE OF A
FAMILY MEMBER AND A NON FAMILY
MEMBER AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR X. HAVING THAT EXPLAINED
ABOUT THE EBV THAT MAKES IT.
THE VERY MUCH.
SIMPLER --
IT WAS VERY.
WHERE IT WAS GOING TO BE VERY
HARD ON EVERYONE BECAUSE YOU'VE
ALREADY LOST TEXAS OHIO AND IOWA?
BECAUSE OF THE EVD SO --
ALSO I AM.
I WANT TO THANK YOU --
FOR HOPEFULLY WE GET TO GET THAT
RESTORATION OF THAT 7%.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADRIN CHILDREN WITH THE
STEINBERG A CITY WERE HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
AYE HSS MOE PROPOSAL AND THINK
THAT THE COMMITTEE OF
ADMINISTRATION AND THE COUNTIES
FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK ON THIS
THANKS VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MONA STATUS ME NUMBER A
SETTLEMENT ESSENTIALLY THIS
EVENING WITH A LOOK ON THE OTHER
THAN NAPA.
AND BAD LOOK AT EVERYTHING TO
KNOW.
KING SEN.
BANK THERE.
ARE.
STORY PUT AWAY THE ORDER.
IN THEIR ME HACKETT CAN
ACCORDING FATAL SINO SO THERE
KNOWS THE CHORUS.
EPILEPSY WITHOUT US ONE TIME
[inaudible]
A OUR WAR FOR A NUMBER OF A LOT
OF IT WE HAVE A MIDDLE GROUND.
HE BE THE OKAY.
CORD USUALLY CAN LESS.
PER PIXIE ONUS A NATIVE DV
[inaudible]
AND EBV.
RIGHT ACROSS FROM ME THE ORDER
SEE.
IT COULD BE TOTALLY YOUR
CHOLESTEROL CHEST GUESTS AND
SAMPRAS AND THAT'LL.
HE DRESSES SO THEY ALSO STANNIS
GAY.
NO SIGN ARE YOU THAT'LL YEARS
SPENT ALMOST QUE AND NAY STATE
PARKS OKAY.
NO THEY HAVE A SAID HER OWN WILL
THE SERIAL.
BORDER AROUND.
THE DAY I LOVE WRESTLING YEAH MY
DALY WHO'S DE SAC AC IT HONESTLY.
GUITAR.
THE PLACENTAL TRAVIS HE LARA
ASSISTED A RELIC THROWN
ACCORDING TO MY NECK A LITTLE
KID IN THE SAN.
ANTONIO SAYS.
A EUROPEAN SO OKAY AS WHO STOCK
IN MOST SUPPORTING.
BEIRA CLINTON WIDER.
ASEAN THOUGH IT CUIDADO THE
KILEY THAT.
BYRON WAS TO SEE HEAT.
IS A CRISIS ACTORS AND YOUR
PREFERRED A QUICKLY OR
PROTECTIONS OF CONSUMER PRIVACY.
I HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE V. V. N.
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS.
TRAINING AND THE FLEXIBILITY
OFFERED FOR PROVIDERS --
AND JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
HAVE BEEN COMING HERE FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS --
VISITING AND LOBBYING DIFFERENT
POLITICIANS --
FOR FOR JUSTICE AND FOR WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR CONSUMERS OF THIS
PROGRAM SO.
THANK YOU EXTRA CLASSES THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BENITA MANUALS AND
I'M FROM CINEMA COUNTY I DROVE
UP HERE.
I LEFT MY HOME AT FOUR FOUR IN
THE MORNING TO PICK UP ALL.
ALL OUR MEMBERS TO COME TO THE
CAPITAL AND WE GOT HERE AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING SO WE HAD
A LONG DAY YES BUT I AS I
SUPPORT.
THE TRAILER BILL FOR THE 7%.
AND I ALSO SUPPORT THE WAY THAT
THE AV THE IS GOING TO BE ROLLED
OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
V. BUT I'M STILL FROM CLEAR LIKE.
MY NAME IS THE WORK YOUR BELLY
AND I'VE BEEN PROVIDER FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU SAY YOU'RE GONNA SUPPORT THE
7% AND BECOME --
APARTMENT THINK OF THE BUDGET.
I HOPE YOUR CO WORKERS FEEL THE
SAME WAY YOUR OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND IF THEY DON'T THAT
YOU TALK REAL LONG AND HARD --
TO SO THEY DO.
BECAUSE WE DEFINITELY NEED THAT
PUT IN THE BUDGET.
PERMANENTLY.
THE OTHER THING IS IS THE YOU
REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU THE
CONSUMER PROVIDERS IN WHERE.
I GET THAT YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE OUR DEATH THIS CAME FROM
THE FEDS THE ONLY WAY TO GET RID
OF IT.
GET RID OF LOSE THEIR AND WE
WILL IN TWENTY TWENTY TRUST ME.
BUT I FEEL THAT TIME I HOPE THAT
IF YOU KNOW ANYBODY THAT'S ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT YOU TALK
TO THEIR EAR AND TELLING HOW
STUPID.
THIS IS BECAUSE TO ME IT'S JUST
ANOTHER WAY OF THEM TRYING TO
SAY THAT I'M NOT TRUSTWORTHY AND
THAT'S WHAT AT WHAT THAT'SHOW I
FEEL WHETHER THAT'S WHAT THEY
MEANT BY IT OR NOT I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT I ALREADY DO A TIME CARD
EVERY MONTH --
I TRY NOT TO GO OVER MY HOURS.
I DON'T NEED TO BE CHECK IT IS
OK AT THAT TO ME THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS SAY ONE
MORE TIME WE'RE NOT TRUSTWORTHY.
WELL.
WE ARE.
THE GUYS IT IS IN WASHINGTON DC
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
TRUSTWORTHY THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT SHOULD WE DO WITH THE CVV
THINK.
BUT WE CAN'T DO THAT SO WELL
THIS DID ABOUT OFFICE IN TWENTY
TWENTY THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR HELPING US ON
THE 7%.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SHERRY
BILLION SIGNED WITH THE S. YEAH
YOU TWENTY FIFTEEN I'VE BEEN A
MEMBER FOR THREE YEARS.
APPROXIMATELY I'VE BEEN TAKING
CARE OF MY MOTHER AND I AND I DO
SUPPORT THE TRAILER BILL AND I
ALSO SUPPORT ETV YOU'VE COME A
LONG WAY AND IMPLEMENTING.
A WAY OF HOW REPORT Q. M. ARE
HOURS ARE SEVEN I APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG
ROAD FOR ALL OF ITS INDIVIDUALLY
MAYBE WE CAN GET RID OF IT ALL
THANK YOU.
OKAY WELCOME THANK YOU I NEED IT --
MY NAME IS A SELLOUT A AND I AM
A U. D. W. MEMBER LIVING IN
MADERA COUNTY.
WITH -- WHOM
AS YOU D. W. MEMBERS --
WE HAVE NOT HAD A CONTRACT FOR
ALMOST FIVE YEARS THAT'S FIFTY
ONE MONTHS TO BE EXACT --
MY FATHER IS EIGHTY YEARS OLD --
HE IS LOSING HIS HEARING HIS
LOSING HER FIGHT AND AS A FALL
RISK -- AND
CURRENTLY WE ARE WAITING TO HEAR
IF HE'S GOING TO HAVE A
DIAGNOSIS OF CANCER.
MY MOM IS SEVENTY EIGHT YEARS
OLD -- SHE
IS DIABETIC OF FAR RISK AND IS
ALSO -- I
HAD ALSO RECOVERED FROM A FORM
OF MELANOMA CANCER.
THIS IS MY FUTURE --
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY I'LL NEED
I HSS I'M CURRENTLY FIFTY YEARS
OLD.
I SUPPORT YOU DW'S PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE THE COUNTY MOE ONLY AND
COUNTIES THAT HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS IN PLACE.
THIS WILL CREATE AN INCENTIVE
FOR COUNTIES LIKE MINE TO REACH
CONTRACT AGREEMENTS WITH THEIR
I. HSS PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CHRIS
BREEDER HOME CARE PROVIDER FOR
SACRAMENTO.
AND I'VE BEEN COMING HERE OFF
AND ON FOR MANY YEARS ABOUT THE
7%.
LET'S JUST RESTORE IT
PERMANENTLY SO I CAN STOP COMING.
OKAY.
ALL THIS YEAR.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
EXPLAINING YOU BE BE OVER AND
OVER -- I
ALSO WANT TO SAY AYE OPPOSED VVV
THANK YOU.
RIGHT WELCOME IS CHAIRMAN AND
OTHER MEMBERS POLLY --
SCHNEIDER INTO YET --
HERE TODAY TO THANK THE NEWS OF
ADMINISTRATION AND INCLUDING THE
STAFF FOR THE AGES SYSTEM --
WE PROPOSAL I'M DOING THIS TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARDS TO RISE
IN MENDOCINO PLASTER SAN JOAQUIN
FRESNO KERN IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
COMPARE MEMBERS JIM GROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF CONTRA
COSTA MARIN IN SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT OF THE EMILY PROPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WELL SAYING NO ONE
ELSE AT THE MICROPHONE I WANT TO
THANK.
ALL OF THE PEOPLE CAME TO GIVE
PUBLIC KAMADHENU MANY I KNOW
MANY OF YOU TRAVELED A LONG WAY
IN CAME EARLY THIS MORNING AND
IT'S NOW ALMOST FIVE O'CLOCK SO
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN.
WAITING FOR A LONG TIME. TO TO
SPEAK AS WELL SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND STORIES IN YOUR
CONCERNS --
I WANT TO BE SURE WE ALSO GAVE
SOME PPORTUNITY.
TO ANSWER SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS
AS WELL SAID JUST HAVING YOU
TALK AND NOT.
RESPONDING --
I WENT I GUESS I DO HAVE ONE
QUICK QUESTION --
FOR DEPART SOCIAL SERVICES --
IN TERMS OF FOR HSS ONE THINGS
WE RE HEARING.
IS IS THAT AT LEAST --
WELL -- IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO GET
SUFFICIENT.
PEOPLE WERE WILLING TO PROVIDE
SERVICE PARTICULARLY FOR FOR
CLIENTS TO MAYBE MORE --
CHALLENGING.
BUT SEVERE DISABILITIES --
ETCETERA ARE WE THE MAN A WOLF
OF FINDING SOMEONE TO IS TO
SERVE UP A DEGREE PEOPLE
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES --
SECT OF BEHAVIORAL ISSUES SUCH
AS THEIR ANSWER TRACKING GOING
ON OF THAT.
SO CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE A
METHOD FOR TRACKING.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN PARTICULAR
WITH PEOPLE.
HAVING PROVIDER TURNOVER HAVING
DIFFICULTY IN GETTING PROVIDERS --
WE ARE.
DEFINITELY WORKING AND TALKING
TO RECIPIENTS COUNTIES AND
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES ABOUT WAYS.
TO EXPEDITE PROCESSES AND ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE DEFINITELY LE
INTENDING TO DO.
IS -- AS A
PART OF OUR PORTAL AFTER WE GET.
KIND OF THROUGH OUR ETV PIECE IS --
TO I HAVE THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE
TO SELF --
ADDED PROVIDERS IN THE PORTAL SO
THAT THAT COULDN'T BE ANOTHER
WAY OF EXPEDITING THINGS --
SO OKAY BUT IT'S IT'S ONLY HERE
EXPEDITING HELPS BUT THE
CHALLENGES ON CAN'T FIND IN THE
FIRST PLACE THEY'RE NOT HAVING
THE EXPEDITE SO.
I'M HOPING THAT MAYBE WE CAN AT
LEAST GET SOME --
THE IS THE SO.
I THINK THAT'S ONE THING AND
THEN I GUESS THE OTHER PART
pABOUT -- YOU
KNOW EVEY WE HAD NO IS A
DISCUSSION BUT SOME PEOPLE SAID
WELL LOOK YOU KNOW MY HOUSE
BURNED DOWN AS IN THE FIRE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ELECTRICITY.
IS THERE'S THAT IS SO IF YOU
DON'T HAVE GOOD BROADBAND
INTERNET WHATEVER TO CONNECT IS
THEIR DUTY I WOULD PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVES SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY STILL GET IN THERE AND
THEIR INFORMATION SO.
PHONE LANDLINE OR CELL PHONE
YOUR AVAILABLE --
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE THINGS WE
HEARD -- A
LOT OF FEEDBACK ON WHEN WE HAD
ALL OF THE TRAGIC FIRES GOING ON
AND YOU COUNTY YES WAS THAT
PROVIDERS WERE.
ASKING.
WANTING TO GET ON THE PORTAL.
YEAH BECAUSE IT WAS THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO GET TO THEIR COUNTY
OFFICE TO GET COPIES OF TIME
SHEETS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO GET MALES.
TO GET DIRECT DIRECT DEPOSIT
CHECKS AND SO THAT IT WAS
ACTUALLY FOR IT FOR THAT
SITUATION.
IT CREATED A BENEFIT TO HAVE THE
OPTION TO DO THAT BY.
ONLINE OR PHONE SO TRACK OKAY
BUT IT ACTUALLY LEAD TO PEOPLE
REALIZING SOME OF THE BENEFITS
OF HAVING THAT OPTION --
I A YES STILL OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
SOMETIMES IT WORKS BETTER --
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU DON'T AND
SOMETIMES SEVEN ALSO HEARING
SOME PEOPLE THAT.
DEPENDING ON WHAT'S THE
SITUATION.
SO THAT THE ERRORS.
THAT THERE ARE SOME OTHER
OPTIONS I MEAN THERE MAYBE THIS
MAY BE IN THE BEING THE PRIMARY
OPTION BUT IF YOU HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE --
D. E. YOU HAVE MORE CHALLENGES
WITH OTHERS PHONE LINES OR
WHATEVER ELSE THAT.
THE DEAD PEOPLE OF SOME
ALTERNATE ALTERNATIVE STAR
USABLE THAT.
SO IT'S ONE KEEP THAT IN THE
BACK YOU KNOW THINKING ABOUT
THIS WERE ROLLING OUT YES
ABSOLUTELY OKAY NO THANK YOU --
SIDE SO I JUST WANT FIRST OF ALL --
I WANT TO THANK OUR DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES WE HAD A LOT OF
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT HERE
TODAY THAT WERE I KNOW WAS THE
RESULT Là HARD WORK GOOD VERY
POSITIVE --
GOING YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO YOU
KNOW WE'RE GETTING POWER THE
ACCOUNT FOR US.
FOR PEOPLE WHO --
ON SS I SS P. ANY IDEAS
PROPOSALS.
TO FUND --
ILL AT LEAST FINANCIALLY WE'RE
GONNA WORK ON THAT CODE LANGUAGE
BUT YOU KNOW THE INTENT IS TO BE
SURE THAT WE A RESTORED A 7%
PERMANENTLY --
A FEW SHEET THAT --
THE THE THE WHAT HOW HOW SO
SERVICES HAS HAS HAS WORKED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AROUND THE V. V. AS
I KNOW --
WHEN IT WAS FIRST PROPOSED IN
WHAT WAS FIRST PROPOSED I WAS
THERE AND I SAID NO THIS IS NOT
GOING TO WORK RIGHT YOU KNOW THE
CHECK AND THE --
THE PRIVACY ISSUES AND SO FORTH
THAT RAISES CONCERNS IT'S VERY
COMMITTEE AND I APPRECIATE THE
ONE HEARING NOW IS THAT YOU'RE
RESPONDING TO THOSE CONCERNS AND
THAT YOU ARE --
MAKING TRY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE THAT WORK SO I I REALLY DO
WANT TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO THE DEPARTMENT --
FOR IT'S FOR THE FACT THAT --
SOUNDS LIKE --
FOR CERTAINLY FOR THIS HEARING
YOU LISTEN TO THE CONCERNS WOULD
RAISE CENTER PASSED HEARING IN
AND ARE WORKING WITH VARIOUS
PEOPLE TO MAKE THINGS WORK SO I
AM I NEEDED I WANT A KNOWLEDGE
THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT --
SO WITH THAT I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY WE ARE GOING AND SO ON
THE ITEMS FOR SOCIAL SERVICES WE
HAVE -- THE
S..
THE S. S. A. B. C. P. UPDATE IS --
IS -- SO
AFTER THIS TO HOLD THAT WE'RE
HOLDING OPEN --
THE ISSUE FOR WHICH IS THE CAL
FRESH EXPANSION B. C. P. --
ISSUE FIVE THE H. STAFF IS BEING
HELD OPEN --
ISSUE SIX WHICH IS THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE COLA FOR SS PEAS HELD
OPEN.
AS YOU CAN TELL WE'RE NOT WE'RE
HOLDING LAST WE HOPE FOR HOLDING
EVERYTHING OPEN AT THIS MOMENT
AND THEN --
INCOME SUPPORT SERVICES --
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORTS TVO WE'RE
HOLDING OPEN.
ISSUE --
NINE THE PCP FOR THE
ADMINISTRATOR FOR FALLS OFF FIVE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT WERE
HOLDING OPEN THEY COVER
EVERYTHING.
OKAY SO THOSE ARE ALL OFFICIALLY
HELD OPEN FOR NOW AND WITH THAT
I WANT THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE -- THIS
HEARING AS THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU